ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS BELL.
BRADFORD BY ADAM. DODD THE RAZA
GOD. YEAH GLAZER GONZALEZ HER.
HELLO HUESO HURTADO JACKSON
LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL. MONNING
NIELSEN. PAN PORTANTINO ROB.
RUBIO SKINNER STERN NUMBER WHY
CASTING WIENER. BATES. YOU KNOW
TAKING A- FACE. YEAH I MEAN
HERE PRESIDENT BATES PRESENT.
THANKS JUST PORGES. PRESIDENT
SAY THE NAME CITY NAME SENATOR.
OR JUST PRESENT. CHIANG.
PRESENT MELINDA'S. WHEN DOES
PRESENT MORLOCK. WHAT MR
PRESIDENT MORLOCK PRESENT.
MORALE. MERLE HERE. WELK. WILL
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WHAT OUR MEMBERS AND
OUR GUESTS BEYOND THE REAL.
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
NELSON AFTER WHICH WE'RE GOING
TO ASK YOU TO REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR MITCHELL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE PLEASE BOW
YOUR HEADS. AND JOIN ME IN
PRAYER TO START OUR SESSION.
THE LORD WE THANK YOU FOR THE
WISDOM THAT YOU AND YOU AND
EACH OF US. WE'VE BEEN A
TRUSTED BY THE FOLKS THAT WE
REPRESENT. THE SPEAKER MIND
HERE AND TO REPRESENT THEM WELL.
BUT YOU GIVE US THE WISDOM OF
SOLOMON REQUESTED FATHER AS WE
MAKE THESE DECISIONS IN THESE
TROUBLED IN CHALLENGING TIMES.
MANY OF YOUR PEACE WHICH PASSES
ALL UNDERSTANDING GUARD OUR
HEARTS AND MINDS THROUGH CHRIST
JESUS YOUR SON. BLASTOCYST DAY
WE PRAY IN JESUS NAME AMEN. AND
CALLING PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE
PLEDGE TO OUR FLAG AND OUR
COMMITMENT TO JUSTICE FOR ALL I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. HERE THANKS.
ILLEGAL WORKERS THIS CALL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS WERE GOING TO
HAVE A FULL DAY SO WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO KEEP THINGS MOVING THE
DAY WILL HAVE MEMBERS SENATORS-
BAIT FORGES JIANG DOLLY ROLLED
JONES MELINDA'S MORLOCK MORALE
AND WOKE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
GOOD MORNING SENATORS. WE'RE
MOVING NOW ONTO PRIVILEGES OF
THE FLOOR. I WANT TO RECOGNIZE
PRESIDENT PRO TEM SENATOR
ATKINS FOR GEORGE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND ORDINARILY WE
MIGHT DO- THIS UNDER
ADJOURNMENTS BUT IT'S GOING TO
BE A LONG DAY AND I FELT LIKE
IT WAS IMPORTANT FOR US TO
START. WITH AN ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
BECAUSE OUR EYES SENATE FAMILY
HAS LOST ONE OF OUR OWN. WE
LEARNED YESTERDAY AND I WANT TO
THANK OUR FORMER COLLEAGUE
SENATOR ANTHONY CANNELLA FOR
REACHING OUT AND LET ME KNOW
THAT WE HAD LOST SENATOR TOM
BERRYHILL. AND I KNOW THAT A
COUPLE OF OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES ARE GONNA ARE GONNA
COMMENT. AND WHILE WE ARE BUSY
TODAY. YOU KNOW I OFTEN THINK
THAT WHEN WE LOSE SOMEONE THE
WORLD SHOULD PAUSE FOR A MOMENT
WE SHOULD TAKE A MINUTE. AND
REFLECT ON THE LIFE OF SOMEONE
THAT MEANT A GREAT DEAL TO- TO
US PERSONALLY AND TO ON THE
SENATE FAMILY. TIME SERVED
TWELVE YEARS IN THE LEGISLATURE
HE IS A FORMER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND HE WAS OUR RECENT COLLEAGUE
HERE IN THE SENATE. A
REPUBLICAN HE REPRESENTED
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE
FROM TWO THOUSAND SIX TO TWENTY
TEN. AND THE EIGHTH SENATE
DISTRICT FROM TWENTY TEN
THROUGH TWENTY EIGHTEEN. ALL
THIS AFTER HAVING UNDERGONE A
HEART TRANSPLANT BUT FOR THOSE
OF US WHO KNEW TOM HE KNEW HE
HAD A HEART FOR CALIFORNIA AND
ITS PEOPLE. EVEN AFTER LEAVING
THE SENATE HE CONTINUED IN
PUBLIC SERVICE REPRESENTING
CONSTITUENTS AT THE STANISLAUS
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DESPITE
HAVING ALSO BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
PARKINSON'S DISEASE. HE WAS A
FARMER A BUSINESSMAN A DEVOTED
LEGISLATOR. HE WAS A DECENT
HUMAN BEING AND SOMEONE THAT WE
ALL LIKE TO WORK WITH A CIVIL
MANNER A GENTLEMAN. I ENJOYED
VERY MUCH SERVING ON RULES WITH
HIM AND EVEN AS SPEAKER OF THE
ASSEMBLY WHEN WE HAD TO
COMMUNICATE AMONGST MEMBERS I
AM BOTH HOUSES I ALWAYS FOUND
HIM TO BE ONE OF THE MOST
DILIGENT AND THOUGHTFUL.
INDIVIDUALS IN REPRESENTING NOT
ONLY HIS CONSTITUENTS BUT BE A
PART OF THIS BODY HE LOVED THE
LEGISLATURE HE HAD A GREAT
RESPECT. FOR IT AND SO I KNOW
THAT EVERYONE HERE WILL EXTEND
OUR DEEPEST SYMPATHIES TO HIS
WIFE LORETTA. HIS DAUGHTERS
JESSICA AND SAMANTHA HIS
BROTHER IN OUR OTHER FORMER
COLLEAGUES. IN THE ASSEMBLY
BILL BERRY HILL BUT ALSO TO THE
ENTIRE FAMILY AND- SO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE MR PRESIDENT WE TURN
IT OVER. TO OUR REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES TO ALSO MAKE A FEW
COMMENTS ABOUT OUR COLLEAGUE
SENATOR BURIAL. SINNER GIRL.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT.
THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND IT IS-
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT WE
STAND HERE TODAY AND WE TALK
ABOUT OUR COLLEAGUE AND OUR
FRIEND I'M TOM BERRY HILL YOU
KNOW WE WEREIN THE MIDDLE OF
THE FLOOR SESSION YESTERDAY
WHEN WE GOT THE NOTIFICATION
THAT HE HAD PASSED AWAY AND
GONE TO HEAVEN. AND I THINK
ABOUT HIS LEGACY IN WHAT HE
LEAVES BEHIND AND NOT ONLY AS A
LEGISLATOR BUT AS A FATHER IN
THAT IN A HUSBAND AND A FAMILY
MAN AD- CALIBER TO SUPERVISOR
AND OBVIOUSLY A STATEMENT IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE IT
IS I'M VERY SAD THAT WE- HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION TODAY BUT IT
IS IMPORTANT THAT WE HONOR
SENATOR BERRY HILL YOU KNOW I
MET SENATOR BERRY HILL WHEN I
WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY. BECAUSE HE
PERSONALLY CAME OVER AND ASKED
ME TO PARTICIPATE IN HIS FROG
JUMPING CONTEST NEW YORK STREET
EVERY YEAR IN I THANK YOU AGAIN
WHEN I FIRST CAME INTO THE
ASSEMBLY I WAS NOT INTERESTED
IN A FROG JUMPING CONTEST
BECAUSE WE WERE YOU KNOW TWENTY
MILLION TWENTY IT SAYS A
SEVERAL BILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT
IT WAS JUST IT WAS ATROCIOUS
WHEN WE FIRST CAME IN IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN. AND HE SAID
COME ON GROVE THIS IS WHERE YOU
GUYS CAN GET TO KNOW EACH OTHER
AND THAT BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
AND ALL YOU GOTTA DO IS GO OUT
NAME OF FROG AND HOPEFULLY YOUR
FRONT WILL WIN AND SO I TOOK
HIM UP ON IT AND I JUST
APPRECIATE THAT HE HAD THAT
ATTITUDE THAT WE CAN ALL HAVE
DIFFERENCES IN POLICY WE CAN
ALL DISAGREE ON WHAT WE- THINK
IS BEST FOR CALIFORNIA- BUT AT
THE END OF THE DAY SENATOR
BERRY HILL WANTED TO MAKE SURE
THAT RELATIONSHIPS WERE
STRONGER THAN THE POLICY
DISAGREEMENTS. AND IT SAID IT'S
WITH GREAT SADNESS THAT WE
STAND HERE TODAY BUT- ALSO
REJOICING IN THE FACT THAT I
KNEW HE WAS A STRONG BELIEVER
IN CHRIST AND THAT HE'S IN
HEAVEN AND THAT ALL THE
ILLNESSES THAT HE HAVEN'T BEEN
COMPLETELY HEALED AND SO LET'S
JUST KEEP HIS FAMILY AND HIS
WIFE AND IN IN HIS ENTIRE
FAMILY IN PRAYER SO. THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO SHARE A FEW
WORDS. THANK YOU SENATOR BREAUX.
NEXT UP SO. KNOWS. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE. NOT ONLY
DID THE BERRY HILL BROTHERS
SERVE HERE IN OUR STATE
LEGISLATURE BUT THEIR FATHER
CLAIRE DID AS WELL. SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND THEN THE LAST
FOUR YEARS AS A STATE SENATOR.
SO IT'S KIND OF A FAMILY
TRADITION CLLR BERRY HILL WAS
AS WELL DURING THE DAY BEIJING
YEARS THE SECRETARY OF
AGRICULTURE OF CALIFORNIA
MANIFESTING THAT LONG HISTORY
OF THE BURIAL FAMILY BEING
INTEGRAL FORCES. IN CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. AND TOM FACED HUGE
CHALLENGE A HEART TRANSPLANT IS
A BIG DEAL. WELL AFTER THE
TRANSPLANT TOM BERRYHILL DID
NOT JUST SIT AROUND AND REST
ALL OF THE TIME HE GOT BACK
INTO THE ARENA. AND THE LORD
BLESSED HIM WITH MANY MORE
YEARS YET TO SERVE US. AND
SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT HE
REPRESENTED IN HIS DISTRICT.
THEY DID IT WELL ALL THE WAY
THROUGH. SO WE WILL CERTAINLY
MISS HIM HE WAS A GREAT
ADDITION TO THE INSTITUTION.
AND CONTRIBUTED MIGHTILY TO THE
CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA. TOM
BERRY HILL WILL BE MISSED.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON. NEXT
WE HAVE SENATOR BORJAS. MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF. I AM
THANKFUL THAT WE'RE ABLE TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF CHARLES
BURIAL A MENTOR A FRIEND AND A
COLLEAGUE. TOM WAS BORN ON
AUGUST TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN
FIFTY THREE IN THE TOWN OF
SIRIUS JUST OUTSIDE MODESTO HE
ATTENDED SERVICE HIGH SCHOOL
MODESTO JUNIOR COLLEGE AND
LATER CALIFORNIA POLYTECHNIC
UNIVERSITY IN SAN LUIS OBISPO.
THE FORMER IN SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER TOM REPRESENT THE TWENTY
FIFTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT IN THE
EIGHTH SENATE DISTRICT HIS
BROTHER BILL WASN'T AS WE'VE
HEARD AS WAS ELECTED TO THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE NEIGHBORING
TWENTY SIXTH DISTRICT. THE
BURIALS WERE THE FIRST BROTHERS
EARLY TO SERVE CONCURRENTLY IN
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWO DECADES.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW TOM HAD A
PASSION FOR WINE AND WAS A
FRIEND AND CHAMPION DRIVER
CULTURED SMALL BUSINESS. HE WAS
ALSO A FRIEND TO MANY ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE WHERE HE
WORKED TIRELESSLY ON BEHALF OF
HIS CONSTITUENTS TO GET THINGS
DONE. DESPITE A HEART
TRANSPLANT IN TWO THOUSAND ONE
HE CONTINUED TO SERVE AND FIGHT
FOR HIS COMMUNITY. TOM BURIAL
LET A DEDICATED LIFE IN SERVICE
TO HIS COMMUNITY BOTH IN THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE. AND ON
THE STANISLAUS COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. BEFORE YOU EVEN
BUY CAMPAIGNING FOR STATE
SENATE. TOM TAUGHT ME MANY
VALUABLE LESSONS HI HE WAS US
HE WAS A MENTOR.
HE VALUED
RESPECT INCIVILITY. IF YOU HELP
ME. RUN TO BEAT HIS SUCCESSOR
SO. FOR MANY YEARS WE HAD-
REGULAR REGULAR CONTACT WHEN HE
WAS THE CENTER FOR- BUT THE TWO
TERMS AND THEN OF COURSE HE
HELPED ME- AND I'M ACTUALLY IN
HIS APARTMENT RIGHT NOW SO
WHICH IS WHERE I LIVE. BUT I'LL
NEVER FORGET THAT. HOME TOLD ME.
YOU'RE GOING TO DISAGREE WITH A
LOT OF FOLKS IN SACRAMENTO WHEN
YOU BECOME A SENATOR IN FACT
YOU'LL PROBABLY DISAGREE WITH
YOUR OWN CAUCUS A LOT OF TIMES
FOR YOUR JOB. IS GOING TO
ALWAYS BE LOOKING FOR THAT
COMMON GROUND. WHERE IS THAT
COMMON DENOMINATOR IT'S A PLAN
THAT. THAT YOU BUILT BECAUSE
ISSUES WILL COME AND GO. AND
ABOUT YESTERDAY IS SOMETHING IN
THE PAST BUT MOVING FORWARD
EVERY DAY WHERE IS THE COMMON
DENOMINATOR WHERE CAN YOU BUILD
AND FIND THAT COMMON GROUND I
ACTUALLY THAT'S THAT'S A LESSON
ON THAT. I HOLD DEAR AND- AS WE
ADJOURN TODAY- I THINK HIS
LEGACY IS THAT. HE BROUGHT.
RESPECT AND CIVILITY AND
COLLEGIALITY INTO OUR ENATE
TRADITIONS AND WITH THAT HE
WILL ALWAYS BE REMEMBERED OUR
HEARTS AND PRAYERS GO OUT TO
LORETTA AND THEIR TWO
DAUGHTERS- THEY LIVE IN TWAIN
HARTE AND- WE'RE SENDING THEM
OUR PRAYERS DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU THANK YOU
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS WHO RECOGNIZED SENATOR
BERRY HILL AND IT WAS TRULY AN
HONOR. FOR ME TO SERVE IN BOTH
HOUSES WITH HIM AND- TOM
REPRESENTED. WHAT A TRUE
STATEMENT LOOKS LIKE. AND
REPRESENT THE BEST IN
BIPARTISANSHIP SO WE'LL HAVE A
MOMENT OF SILENCE IN
REMEMBRANCE OF SENATOR TOM
BERRYHILL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
AND NOW TOM WOULD WANT US TO
GET TO WORK SHOW MOVING ONTO
OUR AGENDA OF MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEAN READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WOULD BE MEETING WILL BE TEAM
READ. REPORTS FROM COMMITTEE
WILL BE DEAN READ. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES THERE
ARE NINE. NOW MOVING TO
CONSIDERATION OF DAILY FILE.
FOR SECOND READING FILE WE HAVE
A LOT OF LOVE AND ITEMS MEANT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILLS. EIGHTY SIX ONE OH SEVEN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FOUR EIGHTEEN
SIXTY FIVE EIGHTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX EIGHTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AND ASSEMBLY BILL.
THIRTY THREE THIRTY. THANK YOU
MOVING TO UNFINISHED BUSINESS.
WE HAVE SEVERAL ITEMS FIRST UP
IS FALL ITEM TWELVE. FILE I'M
TWELVE SENATOR MITCHELL ARE YOU
PREPARED I SEE SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE FIFTY FIVE BY SENATOR
MITCHELL AN ACT RELATING TO
DETENTION FACILITIES SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MY BEST TO THE BERRY HILL
FAMILY AND IF NONE OF YOU HAD
THE UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
BERRY HILL AND CANNELLA IN ONE
OF THEIR GIGGLING FITS- THEY
BOTH WERE PRANKSTERS IN WITH
PRANK EACH OTHER REGULARLY YOU
CAN WALK IN ON THEM GIGGLING
AND NOT KNOW WHAT HAPPENED AND
FIND YOURSELF LAUGHING. HE HAD
A LIGHT IN HIS EYE AND HE AND
CAMILLA COULD JUST REALLY SET
EACH OTHER OFF SO I WANTED TO
GIVE THE LIGHT PERSPECTIVE OF
MR BEER HILL HE KNEW HOW TO
HAVE FUN TOO IN ADDITION TO HIS
FROGS. OUR COLLEAGUE SENATE
BILL FIVE FIVE FIVE IS BACK
BEFORE YOU FOR CONCURRENCE THE
BILL WILL REDUCE THE COSTS OF
COMMUNICATION SERVICES AND
COMMISSARY ITEMS SOLD IN COUNTY
JAILS THAT ARE PAID FOR BY THE
INCARCERATED PEOPLE AND THEIR
FAMILIES THIS BILL IS
INCREDIBLY TIMELY RIGHT NOW
WITH SUSPENSION OF VISITATION
IN PRISONS AND JAILS TO THE
CALL THAT NINETEEN. YOU KNOW IN
COUNTY JAILS YOU CAN'T EARN
MONEY BY WORKING TO PUT MONEY
ON THE BOOKS YOURSELF YOU RELY
ON YOUR FAMILY TO BRING MONEY
IN AND IF THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO COME IN THAT COMPLICATE
YOUR ABILITY TO GET FOOD AND
NECESSARY ITEMS FROM THE
COMMISSARY. WHEN THE CARS READY
PERSON CANNOT VISIT WITH A
LAWYER FAMILY MEMBERS AND LOVED
ONES AT THE SAME TIME THEY
CANNOT WORK TO EARN MONEY WE
CANNOT CONDONE FIFTEEN DOLLAR
PHONE CALLS FOR JUST A FEW
MINUTES OR COMMISSARY ITEMS ARE
NOT AFFORDABLE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR ON THIS
ITEM I SEE WE HAVE SOME REMOTE
MEMBERS. SENATOR GROVER
RECOGNIZE IF YOU MR PRESIDENT
YOU KNOW WHEN THE AUTHOR FIRST
BROUGHT THIS BILL FORWARD I WAS
SUPPORTED ON THE FLOOR IN A
COMMITTEE BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHAT YOU JUST SAID MAKES
PERFECT SENSE THAT YOU KNOW
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
INCARCERATED SHOULD BE ABLE TO
REACH OUT AND HAVE- DISCUSSIONS
WITH THEIR ATTORNEY OR THEIR
FAMILY MEMBERS BUT SINCE THAT
HAS HAPPENED I'VE BEEN
CONTACTED BY MY LOCAL HERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT AND- IN ALL THE
COUNTIES THAT I REPRESENT. AND
THEY'VE ASSURED ME THAT- THIS
WILL TAKE A ROUGHLY ABOUT TWO
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OUT
OF THE KERN COUNTY SHERIFF'S
BUDGET WHICH WILL GO AND COME
FROM OTHER PROGRAMS OTHER
PRGRAMS LIKE SUBSTANCE ABUSE
PROGRAMS EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THAT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
INCARCERATED STILL GET THOSE
BENEFITS BUT THE- DOLLAR WILL.
WE'RE HAVING A LITTLE TECHNICAL
DISK. DIFFICULTIES CENTER GROVE
IT WAS A MOMENT. OTHER PROGRAMS
SO I HAVE TO RESPECTFULLY- I
CHANGE MY VOTE AND- AND- VOTE
NO BECAUSE I'M VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT OTHER PROGRAMS THAT WOULD
BE CUT BECAUSE OF THIS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO FUNDING. BUT AGAIN I
SUPPORT BE- I SUPPORT THE
POSITION YOU KNOW PEOPLE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO MAKE PHONE CALLS BUT
IT DEFINITELY HAS TO BE FUNDED
OR ELSE OUR COUNTY JAILS ARE
GOING TO HAVE. HUGE ISSUES WITH
OTHER PROGRAMS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR UMBERG THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
IN SUPPORT- IT IF WE'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND IF WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT
RECIDIVISM THERE'S NO BETTER
TOOL TO PREVENT RECIDIVISM THAN
A CLOSE FAMILY CONNECTION AND
THERE'S NO BETTER TOOL TO
CONTINUE THAT FAMILY CONNECTION
THAN PHONE CALLS IN CHARGING
EXORBITANT RATES TO PRECLUDE
FOLKS FROM CONNECTING WITH
THEIR FAMILIES. IS A PUBLIC
SAFETY HAZARD I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES SENATOR MITCHELL
YOU MAKE CALLS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I APPRECIATE THE
PERSPECTIVE SHARED BUT I- BY MY
COLLEAGUE- FROM THE VALLEY- BUT
LET ME JUST SAY. THE MARKUP ON
COMMISSARY ITEMS IN THE
CONTRACT THAT THE SHARES HAVE
NEGOTIATED FOR CELL PHONE RATES
AND- VIDEO CONFERENCING. THEY
AREN'T CONTRACT THAT ANY OF US
WOULD SIGN FOR OUR OWN PERSONAL
USE THE PROFIT MARGIN IS WHAT
IS MOST OFFENSIVE- FOR EXAMPLE
AND SO SHE TALKED ABOUT THE
CONCERN ABOUT THE INMATE
WELFARE FUND. THE WAY IT WAS
ORIGINALLY SET UP THESE FUNDS
WERE SUPPOSED TO GO INTO THE
INMATE WELFARE FUND TO PAY FOR
THOSE SERVICES. ON THE FUNDS
HAVE NOT BEEN USED TO PAY FOR
REQUIRED COUNTY. IN MANY
INSTANCES THEY HAVE BEEN THE
SUBJECT OF GRAND JURY INQUIRE
RESULT CROSS THE STATE TOO MANY
HERE TO MENTION TOO MANY
COUNTING STEPHEN. REFERENCE AND
SO WHAT WE'VE DONE IS BASICALLY
PLACE THE CAT WE'VE NOT SEEN
THE PHONE CALLS ARE FREE BUT
THE COMMISSARY ITEMS ARE FREE
WE'VE- TRY TO PROVIDE SOME
DIRECTION TO THE SHERIFFS AND
SOLD THE PROFIT MARGIN. ISN'T
SO EXCESSIVE THE KIND OF
PROGRAMMING THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT THAT'S WHAT GOVERNMENT
BUDGETS ARE FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED. WE IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AT THE STATE PRISON
LEVEL ALLOCATE FUNDS FOR-
TRAINING AND ALL KIND OF THINGS
TO AVOID RECIDIVISM SO IT
SHOULD BE BALANCED ON THE
BACKS. OF LOW INCOME FAMILIES
WHO ARE TRYING TO STAY
CONNECTED TO THEIR FAMILY
MEMBERS- AGAIN IT'S A CAP IT'S
NOT ZERO CALLS WE'VE GOT TO
TAKE THE PROFIT OUT OF THIS
THESE CONTRACTS AND. FOR ALL
THOSE REASONS I ASK FOR NOVEL.
THANK YOU. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
TWELVE SP. FIVE FIVE FIVE. ALAN
FIVE ARCHULETA I AT KINS. WELL
HI BRADFORD I HAVE A ZERO I DON.
I TORONTO I GOT JOHNNY HI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERZ BERG.
HI HELLO FIVE WITH SO. HER TADO
HI JACKSON I LLEVA. I REQUIRE
FIVE MITCHELL HI MY NAME. HI
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE TINO I.
ROSS FIVE RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER
STERN. NUMBER FIVE Y. CASKEY
FIVE WINNER HI. NO REMOVING TO
OUR REMOTE VOTERS MA'AM SECTOR.
MEMBERS WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY
YOU'RE VOTING ON FILE ITEM
TWELVE SP. FIVE FIVE FIVE.
BABYFACE SP FIVE FIVE FIVE NO
BABIES NO PORGES. WE'RE JUST SP
FIVE FIVE FIVE ABSTAIN. CHANG
THANK SP FIVE FIVE FIVE HI JANE
HI DALLY. GOLLY S. B. FIVE BY
FIVE NO DALLY NO GROWTH. GREAT
SP FIVE FIVE FIVE NO GROVE NO
MELINDA'S. BELINDA'S SP FIVE
FIVE FIVE NO MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. WE'RE LIKE SP FIVE FIVE
FIVE HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. L.
AST FIVE FIVE FIVE NO MORALE NO
WILKE. I WILL S. P. FIVE FIVE
FIVE I WILL HI. SENATOR
MITCHELL MOVES A CALL. NEXT UP
THIS FALL ITEM THIRTEEN S. B.
EIGHT FIVE FIVE SENATOR WIENER
YOU PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM I
SEE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE BY SENATOR WIENER AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH COVERAGE IN
WINTER THE FLOOR'S YOURS I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT CALLING
ON SENATE BILL EIGHT FIVE FIVE
IS BACK FROM THIS AMERICAN
CURRENTS AS YOU REMEMBER THIS
BILL WILL EXPAND ACCESS TO
MENTAL HEALTH AND ADDICTION
CARE. BY REQUIRING INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO COVER ALL
MEDICALLY NECESSARY- MENTAL
HEALTH AND ADDICTION CARE
NACHOS CRISIS CARE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN IN THE ASSEMBLY EXCEPT
THE WORD TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTH CARE. AND DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE INCLUDING CLARIFYING
TECHNICAL DEFINITIONS REFINING
THE OUT OF NETWORK PROVISION TO
ENSURE IT WILL NOT THIS
INCENTIVIZE PROVIDERS ARE
JOINING NETWORKS. BROADENING
THE DEFINITION OF MEDICAL
NECESSITY AND CREATING EQUITY
AMONG ALL PROFESSIONALS
PROVIDING MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER TREATMENT AS PROMISED
WE CONTINUE TO WORK WITH OUR-
AGENCIES AND KEY STAKEHOLDERS
IN THE ASSEMBLY- TO IMPROVE
THIS BILL- I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOVELS. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. CENA MICROPHONES UP
ON THE FLOOR CENA AND REMOTELY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI I. ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS. BELL FIVE BRADFORD HI
BY ADAM I DON. HI THE RUSSELL.
I GOT JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HURTS BERG. HI
HELLO FIVE LISTEN. HER TADO
FIVE JACKSON I LLEVA. I REQUIRE
I MITCHELL. MONEY FIVE NIELSEN.
NO HAN FIVE PERSON TINA. I.
ROSS HI RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN.
NUMBER HI FIVE WACO CITY FIVE
WINNER HI. MMHM SECTOR NOW
PLEASE CALL OUR REMOTE VOTERS.
YES WE'RE VOTING ON FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN S. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE.
BAYTEX SP EIGHT FIVE FIVE NO
PLEASE NO OR JUST. WE'RE JUST
SUPPOSED TO BE EIGHT FIVE FIVE
NOW FOR JUST NO CHANG. J. S. V.
EIGHT FIVE FIVE I'D CHANG HI
DOLLY. L. E. S. B. EIGHT FIVE
FIVE NO DALLY NO. GROSS READ
THE SP EIGHT FIVE FIVE NO
GROWTH NO. MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
SP EIGHT FIVE FIVE NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. S. P.
EIGHTY FIVE FIVE ABSTAIN.
MORALE. S. V. EIGHT FIVE FIVE
NO. MORALE NO WELL. I WILL S.
T. EIGHT FIVE FIVE FIVE WILKE
HI WINTER MOVES A CALL. MORNING
ALL MEMBERS NOW THROUGH FILE
ITEM. FOURTEEN S. P. NINE SEVEN
TWO SENATOR SKIN ARE YOU
PREPARED I SHE SHE ES MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE SENATE
BILL NINE SEVENTY TWO BY
SENATOR SKINNER AN ACT RELATING
TO TAXATION CENTER SPINNER.
THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
SP NINE SEVEN TWO IS BACK FOR-
CONCURRENCE IT HAD MINOR
AMENDMENTS BUT WHAT IS
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THE
INFORMATION IS NO LONGER GOING
TO BE POSTED ON A WEBSITE SO
THERE IS AS OPPONENTS HAVE
CLAIMED SOME ISSUE ABOUT PUBLIC
SHAMING THAT WILL NOT BE THE
CASE. AND IT ALSO ALLOWS FOR.
WELL THAT WAS THE MAIN ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENT. AND WITH THAT I.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR SCENE NINE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE REMOTELY.
C. NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PUBLISHED CALLED TH WORLD
CHURCH SYNERGEN WOULD YOUR
CLOSER- THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT EVEN.
THANK YOU TO. I'M SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. AT KINS I FELL.
BRADFORD FIVE BY. FIVE DODD. HI
TORONTO I GOT JOHNNY FIVE LASER.
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG. HI HELLO
HI WITH SOME. HER TADO FIVE
JACKSON. FIVE LLEVA. I REQUIRE
HI MITCHELL. I MOANING. I
NIELSEN NO PAN I FORTUNE TINO
FIVE ROSS HI RUBIO. FIVE
SKINNER FIVE STERN. AMBERG HI
WHITE HOUSE E. FIVE WINNER. HI.
ARCHULETA I'D- NOW WE'RE MOVING
TO A REMOTE SENATORS WERE
FALLING ON FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
S. B. NINE SEVEN TWO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL REMOTE
VOTERS. FATE SP SEVEN NINETY
TWO NO. NINE SEVEN TWO SENATOR
BATES YOUR VOTE IN A THREE NINE
SEVEN TWO. I THOUGHT I SAID
THAT NINE SEVEN TWO NO. SENATOR
BATES SAID NO. BASE NO.
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS S. B. NINE
SEVEN TWO NOW FOR JUST NO CHANG
A. AS HE NINE SEVEN TWO NOW
CHANG NO DALLY. SALLY S. B.
NINE SEVEN TWO NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. AND ROWTH SP NINE
SEVEN TWO NOW GROWS NO
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S SP NINE
SEVEN TWO NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. THIS SIXTEEN OR MORE LIKE
WE CARRY. MY APOLOGIES MISTER
PRESIDENT MORE LOCKING THEIR
SPEED NINE SEVEN TWO NO MORE
LOCK NO. MORALE YES V. NINE
SEVEN TO MORALE VOTING NO
MORALE NO WILKE. IF WILK SP
NINE SEVEN TWO NO WELL NOW.
SINNERS CAN REMOVE THE CALL.
MOVING ON NOW MEMBERS FILE ITEM
FIFTEEN BY SENATOR JACKSON ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
SENATE BILL NINE SEVENTY THREE
BY SENATOR JACKSON AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT
INTERJECTION GOOD MORNING MR
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES SP
NINE SEVENTY THREE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS IS A BILL THAT
FIGHTS GENDER AND RACE BASED
PAY DISPARITIES. WITH DATA AND
REQUIRES LARGE COMPANIES TO
SUBMIT REPORTS ANNUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING OUTLINING THE
COMPENSATION AND HOURS WORKED
OF ITS EPLOYEES BY GENDER RACE
ETHNICITY AND JOB CATEGORY
RECENT AMENDMENTS REQUESTED BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OUTLINED
SOME ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
NEEDED BY COMPANIES. AND
RELATED TO COMPANIES- THE TWO
COMPANY ADDRESSES EXCUSE ME
THAT THEY NEED IN ORDER TO
COMPLETE THEIR WORK AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NOT VOTE ON AMENDMENTS ON
CONCURRENCE. IS DESCRIPTION-
VERY WE'RE RECOGNIZING SENATOR
GIRL. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND YOU KNOW I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL I SPOKE
AGAINST IT WHEN IT LEFT OUR
FLOOR. AND NOW WITH THE KOBE
SITUATION IT EVEN SEEMS MORE
DETRIMENTAL AND NOT ONLY
BECAUSE OF THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD ON BUSINESSES BECAUSE
OF- THE KOBE SITUATION THEY
FIND THEMSELVES IN- ADAPTING TO
REVOKE IT WORKING REMOTELY. BUT
MY MAIN OBJECTION IS THAT AS AN
EMPLOYER AND IN THE REAL WORLD
I GUESS YOU WOULD SAY- AS AN
EMPLOYER IT'S ILLEGAL FOR US TO
ASK FOR THIS INFORMATION YOU
CAN'T AS FOR IT ON AN
APPLICATION. YOU CANNOT- ASKED
FOR THE INFORMATION TO BE
PROVIDED- AT YOU CAN MAKE
ASSUMPTIONS BUT SUPPOSE YOU
MAKE THE WRONG EXTENSION A
REPORT THE WRONG DATA. THERE
IS- IT'S ILLEGAL IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FOR US AS
EMPLOYERS TO ASK ETHNICITY
QUESTIONS- GENDER QUESTIONS ANY
OF THESE QUESTIONS THAT ARE
BEING REQUESTED FOR US TO
GATHER INFORMATION ON. AND THEN
SUBMIT TO DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OR
DEPARTMENT OF LABOR STANDARDS
ENFORCEMENT IS ILLEGAL FOR US
TO DO THIS WE CAN'T GARNER THAT
INFORMATION SO. A QUESTION OF
THE AUTHOR. SYNERGY WOULD YOU
TAKE QUESTIONS CERTAINLY. IN
RIVER SO COULD YOU PROVIDE I
MEAN YOU ARE AN ATTORNEY AND
COULD YOU PROVIDE ANY ADVICE TO
EMPLOYERS ON HOW THEY WOULD
OBTAIN THIS INFORMATION. OUT
BASED ON THE BILL- BECAUSE IT
IS ILLEGAL FOR US TO OBTAIN OR
ASK THOSE QUESTIONS WHEN WE
INTERVIEW. OR IN PLACE SOMEBODY
IT'S ALL VOLUNTARY. THERE'S I
BEG YOUR PARDON. PROVIDING THE
INFORMATION IS ALL VOLUNTARY. I
UNDERSTAND IT'S ALL VOLUNTARY
ACCORDING TO THE BILL BUT WE AS
EMPLOYERS UNDER THIS BILL WOULD
BE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT OR
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING. HOW DO WE OBTAIN
THE INFORMATION WHAT IF THE
EMPLOYEES DON'T PROVIDE IT WE
CAN ONLY ASK FOR IT SO THEY ARE
THEY GOING TO PROVIDE IT ON
THEIR OWN. YOU WANT ME TO
RESPOND I'M SORRY WOULD HAVE A
LITTLE TROUBLE WITH THIS-
REMOTE THING HERE. IT THIS IS
ALL AND TERRY THE BILL DOES NOT
CALL UPON ANYBODY TO VIOLATE
ANY LAWS. I CAN I JUST ASK IF
YOU WOULD THROUGH THE CHAIR TO
CLARIFY THE QUESTION IT'S
VOLUNTARY FOR THE EMPLOYERS TO
PARTICIPATE OR VOLUNTARY FOR
THE EMPLOYEES IDENTIFIED THE
INFORMATION IS VOLUNTARY FOR
THE EMPLOYEES TO PROVIDE THE
INFORMATION IF YOU NOTE IN
EVERY INSTANCE WHERE. THERE IS
A BREAKDOWN IN DEMOGRAPHICS AND
GENDER AND ETHNICITY THERE'S
ALWAYS A CATEGORY CALLED OTHER.
WHICH ALLOWS PEOPLE WHO DO NOT
WANT TO PARTICIPATE NOT TO HAVE
TO DO SO THAT MAKES IT A
VOLUNTARY PROCESS FOR THE
EMPLOYEE. SO I GUESS- MINE-
ADDED A QUESTION THAT I THINK
THAT I WOULD ASK YOU TO ADDRESS
IN YOUR CLOTHES AND I DON'T
NEED TO HAVE- CONTINUOUS BACK
AND FORTH BUT IF YOU WOULD
ADDRESS IN YOUR CLOTHES. AGAIN
IT'S ILLEGAL FOR THE EMPLOYERS
TO ASK FOR THIS INFORMATION SO
HOW DO YOU ASK FOR THE
INFORMATION TO HAVE THE
EMPLOYEES EITHER VOLUNTARILY.
ADD NOT COMPLIED OR- COMPLY IF
THEY CHOOSE TO. BECAUSE WE AS
EMPLOYERS CANNOT ASK ANYBODY
ABOUT ANY OF THE SUBJECT
MATTERS THAT ARE IN THIS
PARTICULAR BILL. SO I WOULD ASK
FOR A NO VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE ON THIS I DON'T.
HEARING SEEN NINE SENATOR
JACKSON YOU MAY CLOSE VERY
BRIEFLY WHAT'S DETRIMENTAL IS
THE FACT THAT THE
DISCRIMINATION THAT TAKES PLACE
AGAINST PEOPLE BASED UPON THEIR
GENDER OR THE COLOR OF THEIR
SKIN THEIR ETHNICITY HAS
CREATED A SCHISM THAT. MEANS
THAT PEOPLE ARE NOT PAID
EQUALLY FOR COMPARABLE WORK WE
PASS THAT LEGISLATION IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN. IT IS NOW THE LAW OF
CALIFORNIA THAT PEOPLE ARE TO
BE PAID EQUALLY REGARDLESS OF
THE COLOR OF THEIR SKIN OR
THEIR GENDER BUT BASED ON THE
QUALITY OF THEIR WORK THIS IS A
MEASURE OF THE PAY DATA BILL
WHICH- BASICALLY EXPANDS THE
EEO ONE- FORM THAT HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR DECADES. TO ALSO
INCLUDE CATEGORIES OF
EMPLOYMENT OR COMPENSATION SO
THAT COMPANIES CAN TAKE A LOOK
IN THE MIRROR AND SEE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE IN FACT A
DISCRIMINATING OFTEN
INADVERTENTLY- BUT TO
CERTAINLY- BY PUTTING PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND WOMEN IN LOWER PAYING
CATEGORIES- SO THAT THEY CAN
CORRECT THEMSELVES WHEN IT
COMES TO HIRING. RETENTION AND
PROMOTION OF EMPLOYEES THIS HAS
BEEN THE PROCESS HAS BEEN IN
PLACE FOR DECADES AND WE ARE
VERY CONFIDENT- THAT EMPLOYEES
WILL CONTINUE TO PARTICIPATE T
IS REALLY THEIR RIGHT TO DO SO
OR NOT. AND THIS BILL SIMPLY
ALLOWS THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THIS IN HOPES THE COMPANIES
WILL COMPLY VOLUNTARILY WHICH
IS THE FIRST STEP OF THIS BILL
AND IF NOT THAT THE D. F. E.
AGE CAN POINT OUT TO THEM THAT
THEY ARE NOT COMPLYING WITH THE
LAW. ND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU. THE BEST DESCRIPTION
OBEYED HANSON'S HASN'T SEIZED
AT MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE
AT KINS FIVE WELL. BRADFORD.
FIVE ZERO FIVE DOT. FIVE
TORONTO I GOT JOHNNY I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I HURTS BERG. I TELL.
I WAS SO. HER TADO HI JACKSON
FIVE LLEVA I REQUIRE I MITCHELL.
FIVE MORNING. FIVE NIELSEN. NO
HAN HI FORTUNE TINO FIVE ROTH.
HI RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER FIVE
STERN. NUMBER FIVE Y. CASKEY HI
WINNER I. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO A
REMOTE SENATORS WERE VOTING ON
FALL I DON'T FIFTEEN SP NINE
SEVEN THREE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE REMOTE VOTERS.
FACE. THE BATES I BELIEVE
YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE. S. B.
NINE SEVEN THREE BIG SNOW.
SPACE NOW FOR JUST FORGES SP
NINE SEVEN THREE NOW. GORGEOUS
NO CHANGE THANK S. THE NINE
SEVEN THREE ABSTAINED. DALLY
VALLEY SP NINE SEVEN THREE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH THE SP NINE
SEVEN THREE NO. GROVE NO
MELINDA'S WINDOWS XP NINE SEVEN
THREE NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. WELL I GUESS WE NINE
SEVEN THREE NO. MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. YES V. NINE SEVEN THREE
NO MORALE NO WELL. WILK SP NINE
SEVEN THREE ABSTAIN. THANK YOU
SENATOR JACKSON MOVED TO CALL.
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN S. V. TEN FORTY FOUR
FINALITY PREPARED. I SEE THE
IDEAS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. SENATE BILL TEN FORTY
FOUR BY SENATOR ALLEN AN ACT
RELATING TO FIRE PROTECTION
CINDERELLA. MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS TO REMIND EVERYONE THIS
IS THE BILL THAT PROHIBITS THE
MANUFACTURE SALE AND USE OF
CERTAIN FIREFIGHTING FOAM THAT
CONTAINS THE CHEMICALS OF P.
FUSS. NOW IF YOU FOLKS REMEMBER
WE HAD A VERY GOOD DEBATE HERE
ON THIS FLOOR WE TALKED ABOUT
THE CHALLENGES THAT THIS
DANGEROUS CHEMICAL- BEGINS TO
BOTH OUR ENVIRONMENT BUT ALSO
TO OUR FIREFIGHTERS AND THE
FACT THE FIREFIGHTERS WERE
WORKING SO HARD ON GETTING THIS
BILL ACROSS THE FINISH LINE WE
RAISED WE HEARD CONCERNS FROM
FOLKS IN THE IN THE IN THE OIL
INDUSTRY AND OTHERS. AND WE
WORKED REALLY HARD TO GET THE
ISSUE SETTLED MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN FIGHT FIRES REFINERIES
AND STILL MAINTAIN THE
INTEGRITY THE BELL AND I'M VERY
PLEASED TO SAY THAT WE HAVE
STRUCK THE DEAL I WE HAD A
SEVENTY TWO TO ZERO VOTE OVER
THE SIMPLY SIDE. AND WE'RE NOW
BACK ON CONCURRENCE HERE IN
THE- IN THE SENTENCE I'M VERY
PLEASED TO ANNOUNCE THE CHANGES
THAT WERE MADE WE BASICALLY
ALLOWED OIL REFINERIES AND
TERMINALS TO USE THE PHONE FOR
CERTAIN TYPES OF STORAGE TANKS
AND FUEL INDEPTH BUYERS UNTIL
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT WE THEN PUT
IN A WAIVER PROCESS THAT GOES
OUT TO TWENTY THIRTY TWO FOR
OIL REFINERIES AND TERMINALS
THAT BASICALLY MEANS THAT THE
FIRE MARSHAL HAS TO COME IN AND
CERTIFY THAT THERE IS NO VIABLE
ALTERNATIVE- TYPIFIES IF THEY
WANT TO CONTINUE USING THE P.
FAST. AND WE PROVIDED A THREE
YEAR DELAY FOR PEOPLE'S PHONE
PHASE OUT FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND WE ALSO PROVIDED AIRPORTS
WITH SOME ADDITIONAL ONE
ADDITIONAL YEAR FOR TRANITION
TIME SO THAT'S WHAT WE DID WE
ARE WE ARE VERY PLEASED TO HAVE
REACHED THIS DEAL THAT WILL
HELP TO PROTECT THE LIVES OF
FIREFIGHTERS BOTH WHY THEY
FIGHT FIRES IN AS THEY FIGHT
THE POTENTIAL OF GETTING CANCER
OR OTHER TYPES OF DANGEROUS A
DANGEROUS AILMENTS DUE TO THEIR
CLOSE PROXIMITY. TO THIS
CARCINOGEN. AND WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER TO HAVE A-
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR SCENE NINE
WE HAVE SOME REMOTE MEMBERS I
THINK WE HAVE SENATOR DONNELLY
AND THE Q. CENTRE DOLLAR. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- I JUST WANT
TO. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR REALLY
HAVE YOU LEFT HERE AND DOING A
GREAT JOB AS FAR AS BRINGING
EVERYBODY TO THE TABLE- AND
GETTING IT AN AGREEMENT THAT I
THINK IS A VERY SOLID GREEMENT
I'M SUPPORT THE BILL. I JUST
WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD
WORK OF THE COMMITTEE. AT HOLE
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. IN AN
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
MR JONES JANUARY JONES. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD MORNING-
FIRST OF ALL I JUST WANT TO
SAY- GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY I'M
FEELING PRETTY GOOD- AND THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE FOLKS THAT HAVE
REACHED OUT AND CHECKED UP ON
ME I APPRECIATE THAT REGARDING
THE BILL I WANT TO THANK AS
CENTRE ALAN- FOR WORKING ON IT
AS HARD AS HE HAS I KNOW HE'S
COMMITTED TO SOLVING. A
CHALLENGE WITHOUT CREATING
ADDITIONAL CHALLENGES ITHINK
HE'S DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB ON
THIS AND I APPRECIATE HIM AND
HIS CREATIVITY IN IMPROVING AS
BILL AS IT COMES BACK TO THE
SENATE. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE URGENCY NINE CENTER ALAN
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU JIM TO MY COLLEAGUE THANK
YOU TO MY STAFF ON THIS BILL
AND THANKS TO THE FIREFIGHTERS-
I RESPECT FASHIONABLE. THANK
YOU. HOME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I FELT. BRADFORD FIVE
CABRERA I DON. I TORONTO. FIVE
KALYANI. GLAZER GONZALEZ FIVE
HERZ BERG HI HILL HI WESTERN.
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LLEVA I
REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL FIVE
MINING. HI NIELSEN. I CAN. FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS. HI RUBIO.
HI SKINNER I STERN. NUMBER FIVE
Y. CASKEY HI WINNER HI. NOW
WE'RE MOVING TO OUR REMOTE
SENATORS WERE VOTING ON S. B.
TEN FOR FOUR SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FAKES BAKES SP TEN
FORTY FOUR HI BABES FIVE BARGES.
WE'RE JUST- B. TEN FOUR FOUR
ONLINE FOR JUST HI CHANG. THANK
YOU AS THE TEN FOUR FOUR I'D
CHANGE HI DALLY. SALLY IT'S
USUALLY GALLEY SP TEN FOUR FOUR
HI DALLY FIVE GROWTH. BRUCE SP
TEN FORTY FOUR- WE DON'T WE
OKAY NOW KOREA. GROSS S. C. CAN
FOR I. GROVE HI MELINDA'S.
BELINDA'S SP TEN FOUR FOUR HI
MELINDA'S I MORE LOCK. SP TEN
FOUR FOUR HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. S. V. TEN FOUR FOUR HI
MORALE I WILL LOOK. WELL S. P.
TEN FORTY FOUR HI WILKE HI.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN MOVES A
CALL. MOVING ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM. SEVENTEEN S. B. TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN. SENATOR RAZA ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM I
SEE YOU ARE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE THREE. SENATE BILL
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
DORADO AND AFTER LEADING TO
EMPLOYMENT. CENTER FOR GEORGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN WOULD ELIMINATE THE
EXCLUSION OF PRIVATELY PAID
HOUSEHOLD DOMESTIC SERVICE
EMPLOYEES FROM CALIFORNIA'S
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
ACT CAL OSHA. ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS NARROW TO BUILD TO
PRIVATELY PAID DOMESTIC WORKERS
AND ALSO DELAYS IMPLEMENTATION
FOR TWO YEARS TO ALLOW CAL
OSHA. TO CREATE AN ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF VEHICLE PARTS
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES TO
ADDRESS WHAT AND IF. INDUSTRY
SPECIFIC REGULATORY GUIDANCE IS
NEEDED ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ALSO
CLARIFIED THAT ANY
INVESTIGATION OF A VIOLATION OF
THESE PROTECTIONS MUST BE
CONDUCTED IN A MANNER THAT
AVOIDS AN UNWARRANTED INVASION
OF PERSONAL PRIVACY. THE
MEASURE HAS NO ORGANIZATION
OPPOSITION AND RECEIVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY. BUT NOW MORE THAN
EVER THE HEALTH THESE DOMESTIC
WORKERS DEPENDS ON- THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY PROTECTIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
GREAT ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
AND DEBATE I'M RECOGNIZING
SENATOR GIRL AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I AM
GLAD THAT THE AUTHOR TOOK
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
FOURTH AMENDMENT RIGHTS THAT
WOULD BE VIOLATED UNDER THIS
PARTICULAR BILL- AND I BUT I DO
TAKE- OBJECTION TO THE FACT
THAT- WHEN SHE SAYS NO
OPPOSITION IS REGISTERED BY
ORGANIZATIONS. IT'S BECAUSE
ORGANIZATIONS WERE ABLE TO GET
OUT OF THIS BILL SO BASICALLY
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE I. HSS
REGIONAL CENTERS THINGS LIKE
THAT WHERE PEOPLE ARE PAID BY
THE GOVERNMENT TO GO INTO
PRIVATE HOMES THEY WOULD NOT BE
UNDER THIS REGULATORY PROCESS
THEY WOULD NOT HAVE TO. AND IT
HERE TO THIS BUT IF YOU'RE A
PRIVATE BUSINESS IF YOUR
PRIVATE HOMEOWNER AND YOU HAVE
SOMEBODY THAT COMES IN AND
CLEAN YOUR HOUSE EVERY TWO
WEEKS OR WHATEVER THAT MAY BE
OR COMES IN AND TAKES CARE OF
YOUR ELDERLY FAMILY BECAUSE
YOU'RE PAYING FOR THAT PERSON
TO COME AND THEN YOU WOULD BE
SUBJECT AS AN INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNER. SHOULD THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
SO I GUESS WHEN YOU MAKE
SPEECHES OR FLOOR SPEECHES ARE
YOU SAYING YOU NEED THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT'S TO PROTECT ALL OF
THESE WORKERS THEN WHY IS IT
NOT TO PROTECT ALL WORKERS IN
JEST- THE ONES THAT ARE
BASICALLY NOT UNIONIZED OR THAT
HAVE AT AT. THAT OR NOT THEY'RE
IN INDIVIDUAL HOMES SO- I DO
STILL TAKE OBJECTION TO THIS
BILL I DO APPLAUD THE AUTHOR
FOR AT LEAST AT AT MINIMUM
SIXTEEN THE FOURTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS WHICH VIOLATED THE
CONSTITUTION IS THE BILL WENT
OFF THE SENATE FLOOR IT WAS
AMENDED IN THE S. IN THIS
SIMPLY SO I DO I THANK GOD FOR
THAT. BUT WE STILL HAVE A HUGE
ISSUE THAT- IF THIS BILL IS TO
PROTECT EMPLOYEES IT'S NOT
PROTECTING EMPLOYEES IT'S NOT
PROTECTING ALL EMPLOYEES AND IT
IS STILL AN INVASION INTO- AN
INDIVIDUAL'S PRIVATE HOME. AND
SO I WOULD STILL. ABSOLUTELY
REQUESTED NO VOTE. THANK YOU
FURTHER THE- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. EARN SCENE
NINE SENATOR RAZA WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA
HI ATKINS I FELL. BRADFORD I
HAVE A I DON. FIVE TERRAZZO. HI
CAROL CHANNING HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG HI
HELLO I WAS SO. HURTADO HI
JACKSON I LIVE IN. HI WIRE. THE
CHOIR. I MITCHELL. MITCHELL HI
MY NAME I NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH. FIVE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI STERN. HI
NUMBER HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
WINNER HI. MEMSIC THREE PLEASE
CALL THE SENATOR'S VOTING
REMOTELY ON S. U. V. TWELVE
FIFTY SEVEN. BASE BATES S. V.
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN NO BATES NO
BORJAS. FORGES THE BEST B.
TWELVE FIVE SEVEN NOW PORES NO
CHANG. THANK S. B. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN NO CHANG NO DALLY. KELLY
SP TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN NO DALLY
NO GROWTH. S. C. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN NO GROVE NO MELINDA'S.
BLENDERS SP TWELVE FIVE SEVEN
NO MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. MORE
LIKE A SPEECH WILL FIFTY SEVEN
NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. YOUR
LSP TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN NO
MORALE NO WELL. WE'LL S. B.
TWELVE FIFTY SEVEN NO WELL NO.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALSO MOVES A
CALL NOW MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTEEN SENATOR WAY SO ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM. HE'S
NOT AT HIS DESK MOVING ON WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWENTY.
SENATOR CAFIERO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FOURTEEN OH NINE BY
SENATOR KERR BIO AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION AND
RECOVER YOU'RE ON THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT SP FOURTEEN OH
NINE WHICH IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS
DELETED THE LANGUAGE THAT
REQUIRED THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD TO ISSUE A PLAN FOR A NO
RETURN TAX FILING PILOT PROGRAM
TO INCREASE THE CLAIMS OF
CALLIE ITC AND INSTEAD GAVE
THEM A LITTLE BIT MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO STUDY AN ISSUE A
PLAN. THAT WOULD INCREASE AGAIN
INCREASED CAL EITC CLAIMS AS
WELL AS FEDERAL EITC CLAIMS IN
THESE TOUGH ECONOMIC TIMES HARD
WORKING FAMILIES NEED ECONOMIC
SUPPORT DELIVERED AS
EFFICIENTLY AND RAPIDLY AS
POSSIBLE THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
ALTERNATIVES TO DELIVER A
CRITICAL SAFETY NET PROGRAMS TO
THE NEEDIEST FAMILIES THE BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR C. NINE.
REMOTELY SANE NINE. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL GIRL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS
FIVE WELL. BRADFORD FIVE BY
ADAM I DON. I TORONTO. I GOT
JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. HI HILL FIVE WITH
SO. HER TADO HI JACKSON HI
LLEVA. I REQUIRE HI MITCHELL.
FIVE MINING HI NIELSEN. PAM
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER HI STERN FIVE AMBERG HI
BY CAL SKI HI WINNER HI.
NIELSEN I. NOW WE'RE MOVING TO
OUR REMOTE SENATORS WERE ON. S.
P. FOURTEEN OH NINE I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THOSE
SENATORS VOTING REMOTELY.
BASICS EIGHT SB FOURTEEN OH
NINE BY BATES HI FORGES. WE'RE
JUST S. B. FORTINO NINE HI OR
JUST BY SAYING. SAYING SB
FOURTEEN OH NINE I CHANGED HI
DALLY. GALLEY SP FOURTEEN OH
NINE BY DELHI FIVE GROWTH
GROWTH SP FOURTEEN OH NINE HI
GROVE HI MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
SP FOURTEEN OH NINE I MELINDA'S
HI MORE LOCK. HIS FEET ONE FOUR
ZERO NINE ABSTAIN. MORALE. WELL
S. B. ONLINE HIGH MORALE I WILL.
WILK SP FOURTEEN OH NINE HI
WELL I. SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES A
CALL NO REMOVE BACK TO FALL
ITEM NINETEEN. S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY CENTER STARNES PREPARED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN TWENTY BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING
TO CLIMATE CHANGE FORMER STERN.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS-
THIS THIS MEASURES BACK ON
CONCURRENCE I APPRECIATE THE
SUPPORT NOT JUST FROM.
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY WHO
WANTS US TO HAVE A CLEAR
PICTURE OF THE CLIMATE COSTS
THEY COME OUT OF NOWHERE BUT
ALSO FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
OTHERS WHO WORRY ABOUT OUR LONG
TERM BUDGETARY HEALTH. IF WE
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE SURPRISES
THAT WE GET EVERY YEAR WHEN
THESE WILDFIRES BREAK OUT A
RATHER BIG CLIMATE DISASTERS-
WE NEED AN ACCURATE ASSESSMENT
OF WHAT THIS COST IS REALLY
GOING TO BE THIS BILL IS NO
OPPOSITION ISAAC IS A GOOD
MEASURE TO GETTING US SOME
TRANSPARENCY IN THE RISKS WE
TRULY FACES STATE- I THINK WILL
BE A SCARY PICTURE. WE ACTUALLY
DO- FULLY UNDERSTAND IT BUT WE
HAVE TO BE HONEST WITH
OURSELVES ABOUT THE TRUE SCOPE
IN THIS RESPECT AFTER I'VE-
THANK YOU. AND FOR THE
DESCRIPTION OF THE VAN ON THE
SIDE OF THE MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR SHE NINE REMOTELY. SAYING
NINE. MONTHS AGO TERRY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI ACTIONS I FELL.
BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE DODD.
FIVE THE RUSSELL. HI GALE
JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER. GONZALEZ
FIVE HERTZBERG HI HELLO HI WAY
SO. HURTADO. HI JACKSON. I
LLEVA. I REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL
FIVE MONEY HI NIELSEN. HI PAM
FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH.
FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER HI STERN
HI NUMBER FIVE WACO SKI I
WINNER HI. NO REMOVING TO OUR
SENATORS VOTING REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON S. B. FOURTEEN ALL. NINE I'M
SORRY THIRTEEN TWENTY S. V.
EIGHT THREE THIRTEEN TWENTY.
FAITH IT'S S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY ALLY BATES HI GORGEOUS.
BORJAS SP THIRTEEN TWENTY HI
PORGES HI CHANG THEY ISSUED
THIRTEEN TWENTY I'D CHANGE HI
SALLY. DELHI SP THIRTEEN TWENTY
NO DALLY NO GROWTH. THE SP
THIRTEEN TWENTY NO GROWTH NO
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S SP THIRTEEN
TWENTY NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. WELL I GUESS WE THIRTEEN
TWENTY ABSTAIN. MORALE. S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY NO MORALE NO
WILL. THIS WILL WORK S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY HI WELL I.
SENATOR STERN MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO FALL ITEM. FIFTY
FOUR EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY BY
SENATOR ALAN. GENERALLY
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN EIGHTY
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACTUALLY DID A SOLID WASTE.
SENATOR ALAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS- MISTER PRESIDENT YOU
CALL THESE ARE THIS IS A
COMPANION BILLS SB FIFTY FOUR
THAT WE PASSED LAST YEAR OUT OF
THE SENATE AND WHEN WE PASSED
IT THERE I MADE A STRONG
COMMITMENT TO ALL OF YOU. THAT
WE WOULD WORK TO YOU WELL
ADDRESS THE VARIOUS CONCERNS
THE REAL CONCERNS OF
STAKEHOLDERS HAD ABOUT OUR BILL
AT THAT SEEKS TO ADDRESS AN
ENORMOUS CRISIS BOTH
ENVIRONMENTAL AND FINANCIAL.
DOT RELATING TO PLASTIC WASTE I
TOOK THAT COMMITMENT
EXTRAORDINARILY SERVICE
SERIOUSLY I WORK WE WORKED
TIRELESSLY SINCE JUNE LAST JUNE
TO SOLVE EVERY ISSUE THAT WAS
SOLVABLE. HAVING COUNTLESS
CONVERSATIONS WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. HI THIS BILL-
IMPRINT KNOWLEDGE WHICH IS
IDENTICAL TO SB FIFTY FOUR
REFLECTS ALL THE CHANGES THAT
WERE MADE BASED ON THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THE FEEDBACK THAT
WE RECEIVED FROM SO MANY OF YOU
AND FROM OUR COLLEAGUES OVER
THE SOMEBODY. SOME HERE SOME
HIGH LEVEL CHANGES THAT WE'VE
MADE WE'VE NARROWED THE BILLS
ONLY TO COVER PLASTIC YOU'LL
REMEMBER LAST YEAR ALL MATERIAL
TYPES WERE COVERED INCLUDING
GLASS AND ALUMINUM. WE PUSH
BACK COMPLIANCE DATES FOR
PRODUCERS BY TWO YEARS FROM
TWENTY THIRTY TO TWENTY THIRTY
TWO AND AT LENGTH IN SOME OF
THE TIME LINES FOR POWER CYCLES
ACTIONS. WE HEARD FROM ALL OF
YOU LOUD AND CLEAR THAT WE
NEEDED TO REDUCE CALORIES
CYCLES ROLLS AND WORKLOAD AND
SO WE GOT RID OF THE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN NOW WE HAVE
CAL RECYCLE CONDUCT OUTREACH TO
DEVELOP GUIDANCE TO HELP
PRODUCERS COMPLY. TO A ROBUST
REGULATORY PROCESS THAT ENGAGES
BUSINESS AND PRODUCERS THE BILL
GIVES MORE STATUTORY GUIDANCE
TO REDUCE THE DEPARTMENT'S
DISCRETION AND OFFER PRODUCERS
CERTAINTY PARTICULARLY ON
REPORTING AND DATA REQUIREMENTS
AND COMPLIANCE OPTIONS. RECENT
EVENTS ALS CLARIFIED THAT THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR CHEATING THE
TARGETS IN THE BILL FALLS TO
THE PRODUCER. ARE THEY WILL BE
THE ONES TO DETERMINE HOW TO
BEST COMPLY WITH NECESSARY
OVERSIGHT ENFORCEMENT TO
PREVENT ANYONE FROM GAMING THE
SYSTEM BUT ULTIMATELY PUTTING
THEM IN THE DECISION MAKING.
DRIVER SEAT. NOW LET ME TELL
YOU ABOUT THE WORK WE DO
MISTAKE. THIS PAST YEAR WE TOOK
HIM FOR THE EXAM FARMERS THAT
TACK YEAH THAT PACKAGE ON THEIR
FARM. ODD THAT THESE GUYS ARE
CONSUMERS OF THE PACKAGING
THEY'RE NOT THE PRODUCERS SO WE
EXEMPTED THEM. WE TELL. OUR
CYCLE TO CONSIDER FOOD WASTE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE
RAISED BY OUR FRIENDS IN
WESTERN GROWERS- THAT WAS A AN
ACT ASPIN THE BAG LETTUCE AND
CARROT FOLKS. LIKE OUR CYCLES
DASH TO BE SURE THAT THE
PROGRAM DOESN'T CONFLICT WITH
FEDERAL FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
MINTS AND WE ADDED TO FOOD
PACKAGING REPRESENTATIVE
ADVISORY PANEL. WE ALSO ADDED A
CLAUSE EXEMPTING SMALL
PACKAGING COMPONENTS SUCH AS
COURTS AND TAPES- TAPE AND
LABELS. AND CONVERT THE
MINIMUS. ISSUE ASSOCIATED. WITH
WINE ESPECIALLY. THE ROLE THE
RETAILERS AND WHOLESALERS HAS
ALSO BEEN CLARIFIED IN THE BILL
WE GIVE THEM CERTAINTY TO AVOID
BEING. PULLED INTO THE PROGRAM
ALTOGETHER FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
FOR EXAMPLE WE STATUTORILY
EXEMPT RETAILERS AND
WHOLESALERS. MAKING LESS THAN A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR. WE
LOWER THE PENALTIES FOR SMALLER
PRODUCERS YOU FALL OUT OF
COMPLIANCE. ON COMPLIANCE FOR
PRODUCERS NOT MEETING THE RATES
BEYOND THE FLEXIBILITY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TO ADJUST THE
RATES IN CASE OF AN UNFORESEEN
MARKET ISSUE LIKE CODE FOR
EXAMPLE. WE ALSO ALLOW
PRODUCERS TO AVOID PENALTIES BY
DEVELOPING A CORRECTIVE ACTION
PLAN THAT LAYS. OUT HOW THEY'LL
COME INTO COMPLIANCE. THE NEW
AMENDMENTS MAKE THAT PRODUCERS
ARE. KERR ACTION DON'T ACCRUE
PENALTIES THAT'S ANOTHER
IMPORTANT THING. THAT WE
DISCUSSED IN OUR CONVERSATION
WITH BUSINESS OUR GOAL HERE IS
NOT TO BE PUNITIVE. BUT TO GET
COMPLIANCE IT'S TO PRODUCE PUSH
PRODUCERS TO GET TO THE
RECYCLING RATES. STAKEHOLDERS
ALSO WANT TO SEE GREATER
PARTICIPATION ON ADVISORY PANEL
WE ADDED SEVERAL SEATS TO
ENSURE THE RECYCLERS AND-
COMPOSTERS WERE REPRESENTED
ALONG WITH THE NEW FOOD.
PACKAGING FOLKS WE HAD A C. TO
ENSURE THAT A FINAL JUSTICE
GROUPS WERE INVOLVED. AND NOW
LET'S TALK ABOUT STEWARDSHIP
ORGANIZATION THE BILL INCLUDES
STANDARDS AND GUIDELINES FOR
PRODUCERS CHOOSING TO FORM A
STEWARDSHIP ORGANIZATION WE
LEARNED A LOT FROM OUR MATTRESS
IN OUR BATTERIES PROGRAMS AND-
ALL THE CHALLENGES THATTHEY'VE
GOT. AND WE DESIGNED OUR OPTION
HERE SPECIFICALLY TO AVOID
PREVIOUS PITFALLS THE BILL ALSO
MAKES CLEAR THAT NO ENTITY CAN
BE REQUIRED. TO JOIN A STORAGE
OF ORGANIZATION IS ENTIRELY
VOLUNTARY ACTS. BY THE PRODUCER.
WE ALSO HAD A LANGUAGE
CAREFULLY BALANCING THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE HAULERS
WITH THOSE OF THE PRODUCERS TO
ENSURE THE FRANCHISE CONTRACTS
ARE PROTECTED. WHILE PRODUCERS
PARTICULARLY THOSE FORMING
STORAGE OF ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
MAXIMUM FLEXIBILITY. TO REACH
THE RATES. SO THERE THERE I'M
HAPPY TO GET INTO MORE DETAILS-
BUT I KNOW THAT WE HAVE A LOT
OF WORK TO DO. THIS IS
SOMETHING THE PUBLIC IS ASKING
FOR- YOU KNOW THE POLLS. OVER
AND OVER AGAIN THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE SHOW THAT PEOPLE WANT US
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS. AND LET
ME JUST SAY THAT THE CHALLENGE
HERE ULTIMATELY IS FALLING ON
OUR TAXPAYERS ARE REPAIRS IN
OUR CITY COUNCILS I JUST HAD A
CHAT WITH ONE OF MY LOCAL CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS WHO WAS
SHOCKED. BY THE RATES THAT ARE
BEING BROUGHT TO HER BY THE
WASTE MANAGEMENT FOLKS- BECAUSE
HOW HIGH THOSE RATES ARE ABOUT
TO BE JACK. THERE'S BOTTOMS
FALLING ON THE RECYCLING
MARKET- AND WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE IS REINVIGORATE THAT
MARKET. AND THE HOPE HERE IS
THE PLAN HERE IS IN THE END WE
HAVE A KIND OF ECONOMIC STUDIES
IS TO SEEK TO SHOW THIS. THE
DAY AFTER THIS BILL PASSES
THERE WILL BE AN INFUSION OF
INVESTMENT. INTO THE SORT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL BE
NECESSARY TO MEET THE GOALS OF
THIS STUFF. RECYCLING AND
SUSTAINABLE PACKAGING
MANUFACTURING. WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ON THE
FLOOR SHEENA CINCINNATI METRO
I'M SORRY. MY SISTER PRESIDENT
JUST A QUICK QUESTION OF THE-
JACKIE PUT THE FLOOR MANAGER
PLEASE ENTER ONLY TO QUESTION
YES SIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
THAT SUMMARY OF THE WORK THAT
YOU ALL DID OVER THE YEAR IT
WAS A BUSY YEAR YOU TALKED
ABOUT- THE EXEMPTION OF. ARMED
GROUPS UNDER A MILLION DOLLARS
I WONDER IF THAT INCLUDED
RESTAURANTS BECAUSE I'M JUST
HEARING I'VE MY OFFICE HAS BEEN
FLOODED BY. VERTICALLY NOW POST
COLD RESTAURANTS IN MY DISTRICT
THAT ARE HAVE BEEN A POLL FOR
THIS BILL AND SOMEONE IN IT
THAT EXEMPTION IF- BUSINESSES
UNDER A MILLION A YEAR WOULD
APPLY TO THEM. WELL IT'S FOR
THE RETAILERS AND WHOLESALERS I
WILL SAY THAT- INTO THE FUTURE
SINCE THE SEASON. ON EITHER END
OF THE DAY DATE THE THEY'RE NOT
THE RESTAURANTS ARE THE
PRODUCERS RIGHT THEY'RE NOT
PRODUCERS SELLING. SO WHEN THIS
BILL GETS THROUGH. THERE WILL
BE NEW PRODUCTS ONLINE FOR THEM
TO PURCHASE. THAT WILL BE
COMPLIANT WITH THIS BILL. SO I
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE STRUGGLING
INTERNALLY THIS IS GOT TO BE
FULLY LIMIT IS NOT IMPLEMENTED
TWENTY THIRTY TWO LONG AFTER
COVET. SO I KNOW THEY'RE
NERVOUS I UNDERSTAND THAT AND
WE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH THEM.
BUT THIS IS ULTIMATELY ABOUT.
THERE WILL BE A WHOLE NEW SET
OF PRODUCTS THAT WILL BE
COMPLIANT THAT THEY CAN
PURCHASE AND CAN USE IT AND I
GUESS THE QUESTION WOULD BE
PRODUCTS EVERYTHING AFFORDABLE
BECAUSE GIVEN THE FINANCIAL.
STRAINS THAT THEY'RE
EXPERIENCING THAT. IT WILL PUT
ADDED BURDEN TO THEM.
ABSOLUTELY AND YES ABSOLUTELY.
THE ALL I PUT ON THAT SO TO
LOOK AT WHAT WE DID WHEN WE PUT
IN PLACE RULES. THAT INCREASE
THE- THAT THE POLLUTION.
REQUIREMENTS ON OUR CARS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW KIDS IN LA
WERE GROWN UP WITH HALF OF THE
LUNG CAPACITY. THE KIDS IN
OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE OF ALL THE SMOG. YEAH
PEOPLE SAID WELL THIS IS GOING
TO MAKE IT TO THE CAR'S NOT
GONNA AFFORDABLE KNOWN TO BE
ABLE TO DRIVE ANYMORE. WE PUT
THE RULES IN. BUSINESS STEPPED
UP THE MARKET WORKS. AND NOW WE
HAVE MUCH CLEANER BURNING CARS
WE GOT DOUBLE THAT OUR PEOPLE
IN LA A LOT MORE TRAFFIC BUT
MUCH CLEANER AIR. AND SO THE
MARKET WORKS IN THE MEDIA THAT
WE KNOW THE TECHNOLOGY THERE WE
KNOW WE KNOW THE
INFRASTRUCTURES THERE WE NEED
INVESTMENT IN THAT NEW
TECHNOLOGY INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
THAT'S HOW. YOU END UP DRIVING
DOWN PRICES AND MAKING IT WORK
FOR EVERYBODY. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU- MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I STAND
AS A PROD CO AUTHOR OF THE-
IDENTICAL BILL AND I DO WANT TO
THANK ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS FOR
WORKING SO HARD AND I WANT TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT
HAVE BEEN RAISED OUR SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES. YOU WILL
DEFINATELY RAISE THE
RESTAURANTS CONCERTS- BUT OUR-
THE JOCKEY MENTIONED THE COST
OF TO THE WASTE HAULERS. AND OF
COURSE OUR RESTAURANTS ALL OF
OUR SMALL BUSINESSES AS WELL AS
OUR INDIVIDUAL RESIDENTS PAY
FOR THEIR GARBAGE AND RECYCLING
PICK UP. AND BECAUSE OF THE
COLLAPSE IN THE RECYCLING
MARKET THOSE FEES ARE GOING UP
SO HIGH THAT ANY POTENTIAL COST
INCREASE OF A PRODUCT WOULD
FART WILL EASE I MEAN THE- IF
THIS BILL AND IT'S DESIGNED TO
DO SO. CAN REDUCE THOSE
PRODUCTS FOR WHICH THE- HOLLER
WEST TO PICK UP MATERIALS
HASN'T NO WORK NOTHING TO DO
WITH THEM AND BASICALLY IT'S
JUST PRODUCT THAT CANNOT BE
RECYCLED PRODUCT THAT CANNOT.
BE DISPOSED OF ANYTHING OTHER
THAN A LANDFILL- THEN OUR FEES
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO GO UP
THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THAT'S WHERE YOU SEE MANY
OF OUR- WASTE HAULERS- AND
THERE ARE THE UNIONS WHO
REPRESENT. THE HOLLERS ALL IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL SO WHILE
MANY OF US APPROACH THIS FROM
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LANDS MANY
MANY OTHERS ARE APPROACHING
THIS VERY MUCH FROM THE
ECONOMIC LENS BECAUSE WE'RE IN
A SITUATION NOW. WHERE WE
PROMISED PEOPLE RECYCLING AND
YET WE DON'T HAVE THE ABILITY
TO RECYCLE THESE PRODUCTS SO
WITH THAT IT'S A GOOD BILL AND
I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. SENATOR
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- AND WHAT I THINK THE
SENATOR FROM SANTA MONICA FOR
ALL THE DETAILS RIGHT- WAS
LOOKING TRUCK WITH ONE COMMENT
AND THAT IS A AN INFUSION OF
INVESTMENT WHICH MEANS AUSTIN
AND I'M SORT OF CONCERNED WITH
OUR KIND OF ME BEING IN SHAPE
IT IS ALTHOUGH THERE BEEN
DELAYS IN IMPLEMENTATION- I
STILL THINK THAT WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL I HAVE AS WE WORK WITH
INDUSTRY IN THIS REGARD. CAL
RECYCLE CERTAINLY NEEDS A WHOLE
NEW BUSINESS PLAN I'M NOT SURE
THIS IS IT- BUT- I WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR HARD
WORK BUT THE LIST OF THOSE THAT
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL IS
STILL RATHER LENGTHY UNLESS MY
COMMENTARY IS OUTDATED SO. I
WILL BE A NO VOTE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE ON
THE FLOO IT'S SEEN NINE
REMOTELY. SENATOR ALAN WHICH
OUGHT TO CLOSE MEMBERS I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME ATTENTION
I MY STAFF ACTUALLY CLARIFIED
FOR MY GOOD FRIEND FROM LOS
ANGELES- CENTER MITCH I THEY'VE
ACTUALLY WROTE- RESTAURANTS
INTO THE DEFINITION OF
RETAILERS FOR UNDER A MILLION
SO THAT SO THE READ THE SMALL
RESTAURANTS ARE ACTUALLY
EXEMPTED UNDER THE BILL. SO I
WANT TO GET THAT CLARIFIED THEY
ARE TAKEN CARE OF I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT IT HAPPENS ON
THAT'S FANTASTIC THANK YOU TINA
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE LET'S DO THIS
FOR OUR CITIES FOR REPAIRS FOR
TAXPAYERS FAR ENVIRONMENT FOR
CHILDREN. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA.
ATKINS I FELL BRADFORD. CABRERO
DODD FIVE THE RISER. HI KALYANI.
GLAZER GONZALEZ BY HERTZ BERG
HI HELLO HI WITH SO. HER TADO.
JACKSON FIVE LABOR I REQUIRE.
MITCHELL HI MY NAME HI NIELSEN.
PAN. FOUR TWENTY NINE. FIVE
ROSS. HI RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE
STERN FIVE NUMBER FIVE WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER HI.
NIELSEN NO. MMHM SECTOR PLEASE
NOW CALL OUR SENATORS ARE
VOTING REMOTELY ON IT A. B. TEN
EIGHTY. FACE BABY BABY TEN
EIGHTY NO BASS NOW BORJAS.
WE'RE JUST EIGHT B. TEN EIGHTY
EIGHT NOW FOR JUST NO CHANG. K.
A. V. TEN EIGHTY AT THE SAME.
DALLY. KELLY AT TEN EIGHTY OF
ST. GROWTH GROSS EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY NO GROVE NO MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AB TEN EIGHTY NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. YOU'RE
LOGGED EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. ABC TEN
EIGHTY NO MORALE. NO WILKE.
WE'LL LOOK AT. TEN EIGHTY NO
WELL NO. HELLO. RALPH I DON'T
KNOW. SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
THERE IS NO WE'RE MOVING TO
FALL ITEM TWENTY FIVE. S. ABC
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN
CINNAMON WATER. ON THE FLOOR.
ROUTE NINE IT IS DOES. YES
THIRD ROWS ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
FALL ITEM THIRTY TWO. S. AV.
THIRTY THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN. SHE
S. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
OR MUNISH PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT. SEVEN
ZERO ZERO THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THIS BILL CREATES A
RIGHT OF RECALL AND RETENTION
FOR WORKERS EMPLOYED AT LARGE
HOTELS AIRPORTS CONVENTION
CENTERS AND IN JANITORIAL
SERVICES. THESE INDUSTRIES HAVE
LAID OFF THOUSANDS OF WORKERS
WHO HAVE NO IDEA IF OR WHEN
THEY CAN RETURN TO WORK. THE
BILL INITIALLY FEATURED ROBUST
PAID LEAVE AN EXPANSION OF THE
CFRA PROVISIONS BUT IT HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY PARED DOWN TO ONE
FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE. THE RIGHT TO
GO BACK TO THE JOB YOU HAD
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC. BOOKERS
WITH DECADES AT THE SAME BUT
WITH THE SAME EMPLOYER WORKED
THEIR WAY UP. MAY LOSE THEIR
JOBS TO NEWER LOWER PAID
WORKERS. THIS BILL IS MODELED
AFTER SEVERAL ORDINANCES PASSED
ALREADY. IN CITIES AND COUNTIES
AROUND THE STATE LONG BEACH LOS
ANGELES CITY LOS ANGELES COUNTY
GLENDALE SANTA MONICA OAKLAND
SAN FRANCISCO CITY AND AIRPORT
SAN JOSE CITY AND AIRPORT JUST
TO NAME A FEW. THAT IS THAT
WHEN THESE LARGE COMPANIES DO
EVENTUALLY WE OPEN THE
EMPLOYERS SHOULD EXTEND THE
INITIAL OFFER OF EMPLOYMENT
BACK TO THE PERSON WHO HAD THE
JOB BEFORE THEY WERE LAID OFF.
THIS ENSURES THAT OLDER WORKERS
WITH YEARS OF SERVICE HAVE A
SHOT AT GETTING THEIR JOBS
BACK. IT ALSO ALLOW EMPLOYER IT
ALLOWS EMPLOYERS TO RETURN TO
FULL PRODUCTIVITY IMMEDIATELY
WITHOUT HAVING TO TRAIN NEW
EMPLOYEES SEVERAL AMENDMENTS
HAVE BEEN MADE INCLUDING THE
REMOVAL OF THE RIGHT PRIVATE
RIGHT OF ACTION. IT IS OUR HOPE
THAT THE BILL FACILITATES THE
QUICK AND EFFICIENT RE HIRING
OF WORKERS WHO LOST THEIR JOBS
DUE TO NO FAULT OF THEIR OWN.
THE GOAL HERE IS FOR THE
WORKERS TO GET THE JOB BACK GET
BUSINESSES TO RE OPEN AND BE
FULLY OPERATIONAL AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE. PROVIDE RECALL ONLY
APPLIES TO WORKERS LAID OFF DUE
TO A STATE OF EMERGENCY SUCH.
AS THE COLD WITH PANDEMIC. S. I
WILL. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. THREE NINE SENATOR
BREAUX I'M SORRY SINNERS
SENATOR RUBIO OVER IN THE
CORNER SENATOR RUBIO. I GOT YOU.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
ATHLETE ISN'T IN A MINUTE THE
SENATE I JUST WANT TO RISE AND
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE I THINK THIS IS REALLY
IPORTANT TIMES OF FIVE
EMERGENCIES LIKE NOW THAT SO
MANY WORKERS ARE LOSING THEIR
JOBS I THINK THIS IS JUST A
SIMPLE MEASURE TO GET PEOPLE
BACK ON THEIR FEET ESPECIALLY
OUR OLDER CALIFORNIANS WHO WHO
NEED TO GO BACK TO WORK SO I
STRONGLY URGE AND I BOTH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR GIRL. I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I- I
AGREE THAT WE NEED TO GET
WORKERS BACK TO WORK AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE ESPECIALLY BECAUSE IT
WASN'T THEIR FAULT AND THAT
THEIR BUSINESS OR THE JOB THAT
THEY HAD WAS SHUT DOWN AND IT
DEFINITELY WASN'T THE BUSINESS
OWNER. OR THE- THE PROPRIETOR
OF THAT BUSINESS. IT WASN'T
THEIR FAULT THAT- THEY'VE LOST
ALL THIS REVENUE AND HAD TO
CLOSE THEIR DOORS. I DO HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR
REGARDING THE SALE AND TRANSFER
OF BUSINESSES IF SHE WOULD TAKE
A QUESTION. THROUGH THE RISERS
MANAGER WE TOOK A QUESTION. AND
I'LL RESPOND AT THE END SHE SHE
WILL QUESTION INTERVALS THANK
YOU OKAY WELL I DO HOPE YOU DO
RESPOND BECAUSE IT IS A
QUESTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
ANSWERED SO FOR INSTANCE LET'S
USE A REAL LIFE EXAMPLE WE ALL
GOT NOTIFICATION OR YOU SHOULD
HAVE GOTTEN NOTIFICATION THAT
AMBROSIA A VERY WELL KNOWN AND
WELL LIKED AND CAFE IS CLOSING
ITS DOORS FOR GOOD. AND THEY
WERE ABLE TO MAKE IT THROUGH
THE PANDEMIC WITH ALL THE
REQUIREMENTS- IT HAD TO BE MET
IN ORDER TO SURVIVE IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY. SO THOSE
EMPLOYEES I WILL NOT HAVE A JOB
TO GO BACK TO YOU AND TO THE
CURRENT OWNER EVAN BROSIUS. IF
AMBROSIA OPENS AT AM AND OUR
NEW OWNERSHIP MY QUESTION IS
THAT WITH THE NEW OWNER REQUIRE
BE REQUIRED TO HIRE THE
EMPLOYEES THAT WERE LET GO FROM
THE PREVIOUS OWNER OF THAT
BUSINESS- SO THAT WOULD APPLY
TO ALL BUSINESSES STATEWIDE AND
I WOULD JUST LIKE A RESPONSE ON
THAT. ON MY OWN TIME AGAIN I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY THAT-
THERE IS AN EXEMPTION THERE IS
AN EXEMPTION THAT REQUIRES THE
STILL- THAT THAT IS IN THIS
BILL FOR EXISTING UNION
CONTRACTS- DEALING WITH
RETENTION AND SO I GUESS MY BIG
BEEF WITH ALL OF THIS IS THAT.
I'M NOT ONLY DO I THINK IT'S
VERY. ON BUSY IS JUST WITH A
TRANSFERS. IF THAT'S THE CASE
AND BUT IT IS ALSO EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO SUPPORT A BILL
THAT. YOU SAY THAT YOU WANT TO
PROTECT WORKERS BUT WE DON'T
SERVE PROTECT THOSE UNDER
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING AGREEMENT
AND AGAIN AS I MENTIONED A
COUPLE OF DAYS AGO IN MY
COMMENTS. SEVERAL OF THESE FARM
PACKING HOUSES THAT ARE UNDER
UNION AGREEMENT WITH THE U. S.
W. HAVE LOST. AND YOU KNOW
SEVERAL PEOPLE TO FATALITIES.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T NEGOTIATE A
CONTRACT- OR THEY CAN'T GET THE
CONTRACT- INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
IN CHARGE OF THE CONTRACT TO BE
ABLE TO. PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SAFETY OR DO ADDITIONAL THINGS
THAT NEED TO BE DONE THAT ARE
RESTRICTIVE ON ANOTHER EMPLOYER
THAT WOULD HAVE TO BEABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE THINGS. BECAUSE
EVERY EMPLOYER WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THEIR EMPLOYEES ARE SAFE.
BUT THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO DO THAT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO CONTRACT
TO PROVE WHEN THINGS FIRST. SO
GOING BACK TO THIS PARTICULAR
BILL. I GUESS I HAVE A HUGE
CONCERN THAT IT DOESN'T COVER
ALL EMPLOYEES. BUT MOSTLY I
NEED SOME ANSWERS ON THE- THE
TRANSFER OR SALE OF THE
BUSINESS WOULD THAT BE A
REQUIREMENT FOR THE NEW OWNER
TO BRING BACK THE EMPLOYEES
UNDER THE PREVIOUS OWNERSHIP.
IF YOU COULD ANSWER THAT THAT
WOULD BE GREAT AND- THANK YOU
SENATOR NELSON YOU'RE FINE.
THANK YOU MOVING ON TO SENATOR
MELINDA'S. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I ALSO HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR BRING TO
THE TIME PERIOD IT'S OUTLINED
IN THIS BILL- THIS. IS IN PLACE
FOR A DETERRENT FOR THE EXTENT
OF A STATE OF EMERGENCY BUT WE
HAVE. SEVERAL STATE EMERGENCIES
IN FACT SEVENTY ACCORDING TO MY
NOTES ON THAT WERE ONGOING SO
SAVE EMERGENCY CAN GO ON FOR A
LONG PERIOD OF TIME. AMONG
DECEMBER TWENTY THIRD JUST OF
LAST YEAR GOVERNOR NEESON
TERMINATED MORE THAN SEVENTY
ONGOING STATE OF EMERGENCY THAT
HAD BEEN DECLARED AT VARIOUS
TIMES IF SOMEONE IS DATED BACK
TO THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN. SO IT DOESN'T APPEAR
THAT THIS BILL IS LIMITED TO
JUST THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
RELATING TO KIND OF ADD ON
MEGAN WE DON'T KNOW WHEN THE
GOVERNOR WILL DECLARE AN END TO
THIS DATA THAT EMERGENCY. SO I
THINK WE CAN UNDERSTAND HOW
THAT COULD BE PROBLEMATIC FOR
SOME OF THESE BUSINESSES IF
THIS GOES ON FOR YEARS LIKE
SOME OF THE STATE OR MERGING
TEAMS HAVE GONE. ON TO I WONDER
IF YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT
PLEASE. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. HEARING C. NINE SENATOR
RAZA WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES AGAIN THE GOAL OF THIS IS
FOR THOSE EMPLOYEES TO KNOW
THAT THEY CAN GO BACK TO THEIR
JOB THAT'S THE FUNDAMENTAL FACT
THE FUNDAMENTAL ISSUE HERE- IF
THERE IS A NEW EMPLOYER THAT
EMPLOYER WILL ALSO HAVE TO HIRE
THOSE WORKERS BACK. FOR AT
LEAST NINETY DAYS AND THEN BE
ABLE TO EVALUATE THEM BUT
THERE'S NO REASON IF IT
CONTINUES TO BE A RESTAURANT
WHY THE SUCCESSOR EMPLOYER
SHOULD NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE THEM
BACK- I'M NOT QUITE SURE ABOUT
THE ISSUE OF THE EMERGENCY
OTHER THAN. IF THERE'S AN
EMERGENCY THAT'S WHEN THE
SUPPLIES I'M SORRY DON'T KNOW
MORE DETAILS THAN THAT I JUST
WANT TO END IF I CAN MR WOULD
JUST IF I MAY READ TWO
SENTENCES FOR MACHINERY. THANK
YOU ON THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
WROTE AN ARTICLE THEN IT WAS
ABOUT THE SAID SEVEN YEARS AGO
A SINGLE MOTHER BACK AND WAS
HIRED AT A HOTEL IN BEVERLY
HILLS LUXURY HOTEL CATERING TO
SAUDI PRINCESSES JAPANESE
INDUSTRIALS AND EUROPEAN
MODELS. THERE SHE WORKED HER
WAY UP FROM A MINIMUM WAGE BED
MAKING JOB TO POSITION AS ON-
SEVENTEEN DOLLARS. AN HOUR MINI
BAR ATTENDANT. LATER SHE PICKED
UP HER FINAL CHECK SHE WAS TOLD
HER TERMINATIONWAS FINAL AND
IF THE HOTEL RECOVERED IN THE
FUTURE SHE COULD RE APPLY AS A
NEW EMPLOYEE WE WOULD HAVE NO
SENIORITY. COLLEAGUES THAT'S
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
AVOID HERE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR LIBEL. SHEEN NO FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF THE BAIT. MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD HI CABRERO HI
DOT. NO DURAZO. I GOT JOHNNY.
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI HERZ BERG.
HI HELLO HI WITH SO. HURTADO HI
JACKSON. FIVE LLEVA. I REQUIRE
I MITCHELL. FIVE MINING. FIVE
NIELSEN NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. FIVE ROTH HI RUBIO. FIVE
SKINNER. STERN BY AMBER. BY
WACO SKI FIVE WINNER. HI. M.
SIX ARE NOW LET'S MOVE TO OUR
SENATORS WHO ARE VOTING
REMOTELY. ON A. B. THIRTY TWO
SIXTEEN. BASICS EIGHT X. EIGHT
B. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN DOLLAR
BASE NO BORJAS. WE'RE JUST
EIGHTY THIRTY TO SIXTEEN NOW OR
JUST NO CHANGE. TANG AB THERE
TWO NO CHANG NO DALLY. KELLY AT
THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. READ THE EIGHTY THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN NO GROVE NO.
MELINDA'S BELINDA'S AB THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. A. B. THREE TWO ONE
SIX NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. A.
B. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN NOW
MORALE NO WILKE. WILL AT THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN NO WELCOME NO.
SENATOR RAZA MOVED TO CALL.
MEMBERS NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
FALL ITEM THIRTY THREE SENATOR
WARNER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR A
B. THIRTY SEVENTY. MADAM
SECRETARY PATRICK HAS
TEMPORARILY A PAST EMPLOYER
LIKE OKAY WE SURELY WILL. ALL
RIGHT. MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR RAZA ARE
YOU PREPARED FOR FALL ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN. AV. ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. SHARES OR SHE'S GETTING
READY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
ROUTE. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GIPSON AN ACT RELATING TO
OFFICERS. TAKE A TURN WHEN
YOU'RE READY TO ROCK SENATOR
ALSO. OKAY YOU MAY BEGIN OKAY
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON I
RISE TO PRESENT A B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX IT WILL BAN LAW
ENFORCEMENT FROM USING TOLL
CALLS AND CAROTID RACE
RESTRAINTS AND CREATE A UNIFORM
POLICY UNTIL COLD STATE LINE.
ALTHOUGH THESE TACTICS ARE NOT
NEW. TO OUR COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD WATCHED AS GEORGE FLOYD.
SLOWLY DIED AT THE HANDS OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT THIS MESSAGE
METHOD ALSO KNOWN AS A SLEEPER
HOLD INVOLVES APPLYING PRESSURE
TO THE SITES OF THE NECK WITH
AN ARMOR KNEE IN THE CASE OF
GEORGE FLOYD. IT QUICKLY BLOCKS
BLOOD FLOW IN THE CROWD CAROTID
ARTERIES AND RENDER SOMEONE
UNCONSCIOUS IT CAN CAUSE
SERIOUS INJURY OR DEATH IF THE
BLOOD FLOW IS RESTRICTED TO
LONG. SIMPLY MAINTAINING
RESTRICTED BLOOD FLOW FOR ONE
MINUTE AFTER THE SUSPECT IS
RENDERED UNCONSCIOUS CAN CAUSE
PERMANENT BRAIN DAMAGE. FIFTY
THOUSAND SEVENTY THREE PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA HAVE DIED BY
ASPHYXIATION AND BEING
RESTRAINED 53% FOR BLACKS AND
LATINOS. AFTER A CONVERSATION
WITH SEVERAL LAWYERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THE AG WE WANT
TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT OFFICERS
MAINTAIN THEIR RIGHT TO SELF
DEFENSE. THIS IS ABOUT TAKING
AWAY A DANGEROUS TECHNIQUE THAT
CAN AND HAS EASILY GONE WRONG.
THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND SUPPORT FROM
GOVERNOR NEWSOM THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL MEMBERS OF THE BLACK
LATINO API WOMEN'S LGBTQ AND
JEWISH CARCASSES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR ABLE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR NELSON. THIS
PRESENT LATER IN JAIL IN THE
SENATE I WILL JUST CONTINUE TO
ASK FOR A NO VOTE. FOR
FORTUNATE THERE ARE CRITICAL
MOMENTS THAT I GUESS MOST OF
THE PUBLIC ARE NOT AWARE OF.
AND WHEN THAT PROGRAM OFFICER
NOT THIS BECAUSE OUR KNEE JERK
BUT BECAUSE YOU'RE TRAINED
THOROUGHLY TRYING. PLUS THEY
HAVE DEVELOPED GOOD INSTINCTS
OUT ON THE LINE IN THE COURSE
OF THEIR CAREER. AND WHEN THEY
AND THEIR LIFE OR A THREAT.
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO RESPOND.
FULLY WITH THE BEST RESOURCE IS
AVAILABLE. AND NOT ONLY TO
THEIR OWN WELL BEING. BUT ALSO
QUITE OFTEN TO THE CITIZENS
AROUND. SO I BELIEVE THAT THIS.
BUSH TOO FAR. AND I DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THESE TERRIBLE
INCIDENCES WHICH INCIDENT THAT
BECAME SO HIGH PROFILE. ARE
COMMONPLACE DEGREE JUST
BEHAVIOR. THE PERPETRATOR WILL
PAY A PRICE I'M QUITE SURE AND
OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM. WE FIND
COMFORT IN THAT JUSTICE WILL BE
DONE. THE TECH ABOUT YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS WHO
DAY AFTER DAY. BUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE. AND THOSE CRITICAL
SECONDS. THE RIVER BETWEEN THEM.
IN DEATH OR SERIOUS INJURY.
THEY ARE TRAINED TO RESPOND AND
I WILL ARGUE. THEY ARE VERY
RESPONSIBLE. AND THEY ARE
SAVING OUR LIVES IN OUR
PROPERTY. AND WE NEED TO PUT.
HANDCUFFS ON THE CRIMINALS NOT
ON OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS. SENATOR PAT. HE
WAS A FRESHMAN SENATORS ISAH
STAND IN SUPPORT OF- THE SPELL
I KNOW THE- FLOOR MANAGER HAS
SPOKEN TO SOME OF THE
PHYSIOLOGICAL EFFECTS OF
CHOKEHOLDS AND CROWDED.
PRESSURE AS WELL AND AS A
PHYSICIAN I JUST WANT TO STAND
AND SAY. THAT THESE ARE HIGHLY
DANGEROUS MANEUVERS AND WHILE I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE MY GOOD
FRIEND FROM TAYLOR TALKING
ABOUT HOW SKILLED OFFICERS ARE
WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THE
RISKS SO WHATEVER THE
INTENTIONS OF THE OFFICER. THEY
ARE ENGAGED IN A WITH THESE
MANEUVERS AND SOMETHING THAT
CAN LEAD TO. THE PERMANENT
INJURY OR DEATH OF THE PERSON
THEY ARE TRYING TO RESTRAIN.
AND I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
GIVEN HOW DANGEROUS THESE ARE
THAT WE BAN THIS TYPE OF-
RESTRAINT AND THAT THIS
CERTAINLY I ARE HIGHLY SKILLED
OFFICERS WOULD- TODAY FIND
ALTERNATIVE MEANS OF- TRYING
TO. PROTECT THEMSELVES AS WELL
BUT- I THINK THIS IS WAY TOO
DANGEROUS AND I ASKED FOR AN
ITEM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL. SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT- I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY- HOW MANY PEOPLE HAVE
BEEN KILLED IT WASN'T JUST ONE
INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED TO BE
THE MOST RECENT INCIDENT THAT
WENT VIRAL THAT. EVERYONE SAW
BUT IN CALIFORNIA HOW MANY HAVE
BEEN KILLED SINCE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTY THREE PEOPLE KILLED BY
THIS FIXATION. WE HAVE NO IDEA
THOSE PEOPLE WERE CRIMINALS ARE
NOT THOSE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAPPEN
TO HAVE AN ENCOUNTER WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT HOW MANY PEOPLE
HAVE ENCOUNTERS WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT. WHO ARE LET GO NOT
ARRESTED OR FOUND NOT GUILTY WE
WON'T KNOW ABOUT THOSE SEVENTY
THREE BECAUSE THEY'RE DEAD. MY
COLLEAGUE SAID YOU KNOW LET'S
NOT PUT THE HANDCUFFS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS PUT ON THE
CRIMINALS WE'RE NOT QUITE THIS
BUILDING QUESTION HANDCUFFS.
THIS BILL QUESTIONS A- TITULAR
HOLD AROUND SOMEONE'S NECK.
THAT OUR POSITION ON THE FLOOR
AND MANY OTHERS HAVE SAID. ARE
INAPPROPRIATE AND UNSAFE. AND A
NUMBER OF POLICE DEPARTMENTS
HAVE ALREADY BANNEDTHEM SAN
FRANCISCO SANTA CRUZ
WATSONVILLE OCEANSIDE CORONADO
SAN DIEGO LONG BEACH SACRAMENTO.
AND MANY MANY OTHERS. WOLONG
FORSMAN STILL HAVE MATH METHODS
IN USE AND TOOLS THAT CAN YOU
USE TO- CONTROL A POTENTIAL
ASSAILANT YES THEY STILL HAVE
PEPPER SPRAY TASERS AND OTHER
WAYS OF TAKING SOMEONE DOWN AND
DE ESCALATE SITUATIONS WITHOUT
USING FORCE. WE DON'T BELIEVE
THE PASSES A BABY ELEVEN NINETY
SIX INAPPROPRIATELY HAMPERS
TRAINED SKILLED LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM DOING THEIR JOB. JUST
DON'T CHOKE ME TO DEATH I'LL BE
SUPPORTING MAYBE ELEVEN NINETY
SIX. THANK YOU SENATOR- ICE WE
HAVE SENATOR BARGES REMOTELY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- IF I
MAY- MERRY POSE A QUESTION TO
THE FLOOR MANAGER. SENATOR RAZA
WOULD YOU ACCEPT QUESTIONS.
I'LL TRY AND I'LL DO IT AT THE
END SHE WILL ADDRESS IT IN OUR
IN OUR CLOTHES WELL IT'S A IT'S
A FACTUAL QUESTION WHICH. MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE IS
A DISTINCTION OR IS THERE A
DISTINCTION BETWEEN. THE
PROHIBITION ON CHOKEHOLDS. WHEN
IT COMES TO SUBDUING ASPECTS OF
DOING A SUBJECT. VERSUS SELF
DEFENSE. IS I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THE BED UNDER THESE
CIRCUMSTANCES- PUBLIC POLICY
COULD VERY WELL BE PUT FORWARD-
THAT DISALLOWS OF CHOKEHOLDS
WINDY IN A SUBJECT IS SUBDUED.
BUT TO DISALLOW. IT WHEN THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS LIFE
IS IN DANGER IN HERE SHE IS
DEFENDING THEMSELVES I THINK
WOULD BE. OF A STRETCH AND WE
SHOULD NOT. ALLOW FOR A
PROBATION TO BE APPLIED IN A
SELF DEFENSE CONTACTS SO IF YOU
COULD PLEASE ADDRESS THAT
SPECIFIC DISTINCTION TELL ME
WHETHER NOT THAT EXIST IN YOUR
CLOTHES I'D APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SHINO
MIKE SUCKS YOU KNOW HAND
REMOTELY SENATOR RATHER YOU
MAKE CALLS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS MY COLLEAGUE SAID EARLIER
LAW ENFORCEMENT STILL HAS OTHER
OPTIONS. PEPPER SPRAY TASERS
AND OTHER WAYS OF TAKING ANYONE
DOWN AND RESTRAINING THEM. YOU
CAN DE ESCALATE WITHOUT HAVING
TO USE THIS PARTICULAR METHOD.
COLLEAGUES I ASK FOR YOUR IDOL.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AV.
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. ALAN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I BELL I
BRADFORD I HAVE I EVER. I DON.
HI THE RUSSELL. HI CAROL
CHANNING I GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG HI HELLO HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON HI
LLEVA I REQUIRE BY MITCHELL.
FIVE MINING HI NIELSEN NO PAN
FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH. HI
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. STERN HI
AMBERG HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WINNER. FIVE NOW LET'S GO TO
OUR REMOTE VOTING SENATORS ON
A. B. A LOVE IN NINETY SIX.
FAITH BAKES AB ELEVEN NINETY
SIX ABSTAIN. FOR JUST. BORJAS
AB ELEVEN NINE SIX ABSTAINED.
CHANG THANK EIGHTY ELEVEN NINE
SIX HI JANE HI DALLY. DALAI AB.
ELEVEN NINE SIX UPSTATE. GROVE
AT ABC ELEVEN NINE SIX HI GROVE
HI MELINDA'S. BELINDA'S ELEVEN
EIGHT AB ELEVEN NINETY SIX
ABSTAIN. MORLOCK A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY SIX HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. A. B. ELEVEN NINETY SIX
ABSTAIN. TESTING WELL. WE'LL
LOOK AT ELEVEN NINETY SIX HI
WILL HI. SIX ZERO THE MOVES THE
CALL. NOW MOVING ON MEMBERS TO
FALL ITEM. THIRTY EIGHT.
SENATOR DODD ARE YOU PREPARED
FOR A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. HE IS MOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY AN ACT
RELATING TO HORSE RACING AND
MAKING AN APPROPRIATION
THEREFORE. YOU CATCHER WHEN YOU
MAY BEGIN SOONER DIED THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR MAKES
VARIOUS CHANGES TO THE HORSE
RACING LAW BY IMPOSING NEW AND
ADDITIONAL HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS TO BE ENFORCED BY
THE BOARD AND CODIFIES A NUMBER
OF EXISTING HORSE RACING HEALTH
AND SAFETY REGULATIONS THE BILL
IS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IN
BOTH HOUSES OF THE LEGISLATURE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVALS.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM I SEE NO MIKE'S UP ON THE
FLOOR SHE NO HANDS REMOTELY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA HI
AT KENS FIVE BELL HI BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM. I DOT HI YOUR
BROWSER. BY GOT YANNI FIVE
GLAZER I CONSOLIDATES BYE
HERTZBERG FIVE HILL BY WAY SO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON I LIVE
IN. I REQUIRE I MITCHELL HI MY
NAME. BY NIELSEN. HI PAM FIVE
FOUR TO TINA. BYE ROTH I REVERE.
FIVE SKINNER. I STERN HI AMBER
I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER HI.
NOW WE'LL MOVE TO OUR SENATORS
VOTING REMOTELY ON AV NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR MOUNT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THOSE REMOTE VOTING
CENTERS. BASICS BATES AB IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR ALL RIGHT
BAIT HI GORGEOUS. ORDERS AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I.
GORGEOUS HIGH CHANG TANG AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I CHANG
HI DALLY. DAWALY AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR HI DELHI BY GROWTH
BROKE EIGHTY NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR I DROVE HI MELINDA'S. OOPS.
THERE WE GO MELINDA'S AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR I
MELINDA'S FIVE MORE LOCK OR
LARGE GABY NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
WELL. EIGHTY NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HI MOREOVER I WILL. WILK
AB NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR HI
WILKE HI. YES PRICE THIRTY NINE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WHEN I TAKE A BRIEF FALLS FOR
THE CALL.
IN ORDER TO ROUTE FOR
WHAT PURPOSE. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WAS TO PRESENT
PLEASE PROCEED. MR PRESIDENT
SENATOR JACKSON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS A RESOLUTION AT
THE DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION
TO SPEND JOINT RULE TEN POINT
FIVE FOR ASSEMBLY BILLS THE V.
SIX FIFTY NINE. EIGHTY NINE
THIRTEEN AND A. B. KAREEM ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT A REPEAT A. B. SIX
FIFTY NINE. EIGHTY NINE
THIRTEEN AND EIGHTY THREE OH
EIGHT EIGHT. THESE REQUESTS
HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE I URGE ADOPTION OF
THE RESOLUTION. THANK YOU.
SERRANO SENT. THIS PRESENT I
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON THIS
WAIVER. THANK YOU. I'M SURE
MA'AM SECTOR PLEASE RE READ A
RESOLUTION. RESOLVED AT THAT
JOINT RULE TEN POINT FIVE BE
DISPENSED WITH AS REQUESTED.
PERSONER HERTZBERG'S ASKING FOR
OUR VOTES SENATOR NELSON'S
ACTIONS FOR NOBLEMEN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI I
ARCHULETA FIVE ACTIONS I FELL.
FIVE BRADFORD I COULD BUY A- HI
TODD. HI TORONTO. YOUR BROWSER.
I GOT JOHNNY. FIVE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ BY HERTZ BERG FIVE
HILL. HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO
HI JACKSON. FIVE LLEVA I
REQUIRE I MITCHELL. HI MORNING
FIVE NIELSEN NO PAN HI FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS. HI RUBIO FIVE
SKINNER I STERN. FIVE NUMBER
FIVE Y. CASKEY HI WINNER. FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE MEMBERS VOTING
REMOTELY ON SUSPENSION OF JOINT
RULES. ONE MOMENT SIR OKAY.
CREATE SUSPENSION OF JOINT
RULES AND NO.
MEMBER CENTER
WILL RESUME THE ROLL CALL OF
OUR REMOTE VOTING SENATORS. ALL
THE BASICS. BABES JOIN RIVAL NO
BASE NO GORGEOUS. WE'RE JUST
RULE SUSPENSION NOW GORGEOUS NO
CHANG. TANGLE SUSPENSION NOW
CHANG NO DALLY DALLYING RULES
SUSPENSION NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
ROADS WILL SUSPENSION NO GROVE
NO MELINDA'S. WINDOWS RULES TO
SUSPENSION NOW MELINDA'S NO
MORE LOCK. MORE LIKE REAL
SUSPENSION NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. WELL AND SUSPENSION OF
JOINT RULES NO. MORALE NO WILKE.
WE'LL SUSPENSION OF JOINT RULES
NO WELL NO. MEMBERSHIP ON MARCH
TWENTY NINE KNOWS TEN JOINT
RULES ARE SUSPENDED. CENTERS
FOR YEARS AT A COUPLE MORE.
MEMBERS I MOVE TO SUSPEND
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE TEN
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE TEN AS
IT RELATES TO MEASURES THAT
HAVE BEEN REALLY FOR UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS ROLE IN THE
SENATE BILLS RETURNED FROM THE
ASSEMBLY OR CONCURRENCE CASTRO
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR JONES.
THANK. THANK YOU MR. SIR JOHN
KERRY. THANK U. S. PRESIDENT
JUST WANT DAD CHECK TO THIS AND
ASK FOR A ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
MEMBERS ARE THERE CLOSER
JUNCTION OBJECTION I'M SORRY TO
USE IN A PREVIOUS ROLE CALL.
SENATOR JONES. GENERAL JONES NO
I GET THAT PREVIOUS ROLE
BECAUSE MINE OKAY. HIGHS TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN SENATE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. SEARCH FOR THANK YOU
AN EMOTIONAL RESOLUTIONS TO
PRESIDENT NUMBER THERE IS A
LETTER AT THE DESK REQUESTING
WITHDRAWAL OF THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES. SENATE BILLS. EIGHTY
SIX SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY EIGHT
SENATE BILL. SENATE BILL SIX
EIGHTY FOUR AND SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE IN ADDITION
ASSEMBLY BILLS. NINE THIRTEEN.
SIMPLY BILL NINE NINE FIVE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN FIFTY
NINE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ZERO
EIGHT EIGHT. AN ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWO THIRTY FOUR FROM
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THOSE
MEASURES TO THE TO THE THIRD
READING FILE AN UNFINISHED
BUSINESS FILE. AS FOR NOVEL.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I ALSO OBJECT TO
THESE MOTIONS AND WOULD SUPPORT
THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL OKAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL USE THE PREVIOUS
ROLL CALL ALL AYES TWENTY NINE
KNOWS TEN. JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. THE MEASURES ARE
WITH STRONG MARKET. SENATOR
MELINDA US. YES THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- ISLANDERS ARE
PERCENT RULE TWENTY EIGHT I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION TO
HAVE S. C. R. NINETY THREE
REMOVED FROM THE ROLLS COMEDIAN
BROUGHT TO THE SENATE FLOOR FOR
DEBATE IN ABOUT. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. NOBLE. MOTION TO
WITHDRAW CENTERED TOWARDS
ASKING FOR NO VOTE AND SENATOR
MELINDA IS AWESOME. MR
PRESIDENT PLEASE CALL ON
SENATOR JONES. SENATOR JONES
I'M SORRY. I'M SORRY MR THAT
WAS JUST I RAISE MY HAND TO
AGREE WITH THE MOTION AND ALSO
SUPPORT AND I BOTH. GOT IT. ALL
RIGHT SYNERGY PROJECTION FOR NO
VOTE SOONER JONES AND MELINDA'S
ASKING FOR OUR VOTE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
OUR MOTION TO WITHDRAW. ALAN NO
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BELL NO
BRADFORD NO BY ADAM NO DODD. NO
THEY'RE AWESOME. THEY'RE ALSO.
NO ONE GOT JOHNNY. NOAH GLASER
NO GONZALEZ NO HERTZBERG. NO
HELLO. HELLO NO WAY SO. NO
HURTADO NO JACKSON. NOS LLEVA
NO MCGUIRE. NO MITCHELL. NO
MINING. NO NIELSEN. I CAN. NO
PORTS AND TINA. FORTUNE TINO.
YEAH ACCORDING TO NO NO ROTH.
NO RUBIO. THE VIDEO NO SKINNER.
NO STERN. NO BURKE NO WHITE
HOUSE SKI. NO WINNER. NO
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUR
SENATORS VOTING REMOTELY. ON
MOTION TO WITHDRAW FAITH. WHO
SHOULD YOU WITHDRAW DATES HI
BABES HI GORGEOUS. OR JUST
MOTION TO WITHDRAW BY GORGEOUS
HIGH CHANG GETTING MOTION TO
WITHDRAW IT STAYED. DALLY OUR
MOTION WITHDRAW HI SALLY HI
GROWTH RINGS MOTION TO
WITHDRAW- SO WE CAN HAVE A
VIGOROUS DEBATE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND
THE EMERGENCY- HIGH GROWTH HI
MELINDA'S. THE WINDOWS ON THE
MOTION TO WITHDRAW ON AND THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY HI.
MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. MORE
LARGE MOTION TO WITHDRAW HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. YES LORI
ALL MOTION TO WITHDRAW HIGH
MORALE HIGH WILL. HE WILL
MOTION TO WITHDRAW HI. WILKE HI.
MEMBERS ALL EYES NINE NOS
TWENTY NINE THE MOTION TO
WITHDRAW FILLS. SURE THE
RUSSELL FORD PURPOSE. YES MR
PRESIDENT- I MOVED MAKE A
MOTION TO MOVE AB FOUR EIGHTEEN
ITEM THIRTY FIVE TO THE
INACTIVE FILE. REALLY NOTICE
THAT WILL BE THE. MEMBERSHIP
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A SLIGHT BREAK
FOR LUNCH FROM NOON TO GET
QUICK RECESS AND WE'RE ASKING
EVERYONE TO BE BACK ON THE
FLOOR AT YOUR DESK AT ALL
THIRTY WE'LL BE IN RECESS THANK
YOU.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA GET
BACK TO BUSINESS. AND WE'RE
GONNA START OFF WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SIX AV TWO SEVENTY
FIVE. SYNERGY BURGER YOU
PREPARED I AM INDEED THANK YOU
MUCH MR PRESIDENT OF THE TERROR
MONSTER COURSE PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO SEVENTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATING TO NATIVE AMERICAN
CULTURAL HERITAGE THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH TWO
DECADES AGO THE STATE ENACTED
THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE AMERICAN
GRAVES PROTECTION. AND
PREPARATION ACT BOMB WHICH
SEEKS SEEKING REPARATIONS WERE
NATIVE AMERICAN COMMUNITY WAS
SEEKING REPARATIONS FOR THEIR
HUMAN REMAINS. UNFORTUNATELY
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS LATER AS WE
STAND HERE TODAY THIS LAW AS IT
WAS INTENDED HAS NOT COME TO
FRUITION THIS BILL UPDATES THIS
MEASURE WITH RESPECT TO THE
POSSESSION OF HUMAN REMAINS AND
ITEMS BY REQUIRING TRIBAL
TRADITIONAL KNOWLEDGE THREE
FACTOR INTO REPARATION PROCESS.
I ASKED FOR AND I VOTE. THANK
pDEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEN ON
THE FLOOR SHE NINE REMOTELY.
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON TV. TWO SEVEN FIVE.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI AT KINS.
BELL. BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I
DON. HI THE RUSSELL. HI CAL
JOHNNY. HI LATER GONZALEZ I
HEARD SPURRED. HI HELLO HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO FIVE JACKSON I
LIVE IN. I REQUIRE FIVE
MITCHELL. FIVE MINING HI
NIELSEN. PAM I FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER STERN.
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY. FIVE WINNER
HI. RUBIO. FIVE MMHM SIX THIRD
LET'S CALL OUR MEMBERS WERE NOW
VOTING REMOTELY ON AV. TWO
SEVEN FIVE. BASICS. SURVEYS WE
DID NOT HAVE YOU YOU MIGHT
MIGHT'VE BEEN MUTED. LESS.
EIGHT EIGHTY TWO SEVEN FIVE HI
BABES HI FORGES FORGES THE B.
TWO SEVEN FIVE FIVE. FOR JUST
FIVE JANE J. A. B. TWO SEVEN
FIVE HI CHANG HI DALLY. DALLY
AB. TWO SEVEN FIVE FIVE DALLY
HIGH GROWTH. A. B. TWO SEVEN
FIVE I WROTE BY MELINDA'S.
MELINDA IS A B. TWO SEVEN FIVE
I MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. OR LIKE
A B. TWO SEVEN FIVE HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORAL. WELL AID TWO SEVEN
FIVE HIGH MORALE HIGH WILL LOOK.
EIGHTY TWO SEVEN FIVE WE'LL
LOOK AT TWO SEVEN FIVE HI WILKE
HI. MA'AM SIX THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE MISSING WELL.
GLAZER NIELSEN SKINNER STERN.
CENTERED FOR MOVES A CALL NEXT
UP THIS FALL I'M. FIFTY FIVE.
THE V. THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT.
MA'AM SEARCHER. FIVE FIFTY FIVE
PHYLUM FIFTY FIVE A. B. THIRTY
THREE OH EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT BY
DECEMBER SOME REMEMBER GABRIEL
AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING.
SENATOR FLOOR GEORGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THIS MEASURE WILL
HELP INCENTIVIZE. THE CLEAN
NEEDED AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR
OUR TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES BY ADDING NEEDED
CLARIFICATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHER HOUSING ACT MOST
IMPORTANTLY CLARIFIES HOW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS UTILIZE THE
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
TO BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING-
FOR THE LOW INCOME STAFF ASKED
FOR AND I BOTH. ANY FURTHER
DESCRIPTION OF THE RAID ON THIS
ITEM SEEN NONE ON THE FLOOR.
SHE NINE REMOTELY MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW
I DON. HI THE RISER. I CALLED
JOHNNY HI GLAZER GONZALEZ HI
HERZ BERG. HI HELLO. HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON HI LLEVA.
FIVE REQUIRE I MITCHELL. FIVE
MINING I NIELSEN NO PAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS FIVE
RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. STERN
NUMBER HI BY CAL SKI FIVE
WINNER HI. MMHM SECTOR PLEASE
CALL OUR MEMBERS WERE VOTING
REMOTELY. ON THE FILE ITEM.
FIFTY FIVE EIGHTY V. THIRTY
THREE OH EIGHT. BASICS H. A. B.
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT HI BABES
HI GORGEOUS. FORGERS AB THREE
THREE ZERO EIGHT FIVE FOUR JUST
HI CHANG. THE ABC THIRTY THREE
OH EIGHT HI JAMES HI THE ALLEY.
ALI A. B. THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT
ABSTAIN. GROWTH A GROUP AT
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT I GROVE
HI MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S AT
THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT I'M
STAYING. MORLOCK GAVE ME THREE
THREE ZERO EIGHT BYE MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. MORELLA AB THREE
THREE ZERO EIGHT NO. MORALE NO
WELL. EIGHTY THREE THREE OH
EIGHT HI WELL I MEAN. NO IT'S A
NO. MORALE CAN YOU STATE YOUR
VOTE ONE MORE TIME ON AB THREE
THREE OH EIGHT. YES I CAN ARE
YOU READY. MORALE A. B. THREE
THREE ZERO EIGHT WELL. THANK
YOU WHAT. SIR MOVES A CALL
NEXUS FALL I AM SIXTY. AV SIXTY
NINE. MADAM SECRETARY WHEN
YOU'RE READY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE. THE
NEW FLOOR GEORGE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT CHUN. WE'VE
GOT HAS THE GOVERNOR TALKED
ABOUT IN HIS STATE OF THE
STATE. THIS ISSUE OF HOUSING
AND HOMELESSNESS AND THAT WE
ALL KNOW IN OUR DISTRICTS- AS
WEARE TRYING TO FIND WAYS FOR
FAMILIES TO PUT MORE MONEY IN
THEIR POCKETS ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS A SAFE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IS EIGHTY
YOU EFFORT THAT HAS BEEN IN
THIS LEGISLATURE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS AND LED BY. VERY
IMPORTANT MEMBERS OF THIS
HOUSE- IN ORDER TO CHANGE THE
LAW TO ALLOW EIGHTY USUALLY
COMMUNITIES THAT I REPRESENT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA. LITERALLY
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF HOMEOWNERS
HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
BUT THERE'S A CHALLENGE IN
TRYING TO GET THIS HOUSING
WHERE THE FINANCING IS SUCH
THAT OUR BANKS GO TO GO TO A
HOME OWNERS AS WELL- HOMEOWNER
WE YOU HAVE- PLENTY OF EQUITY
BUT HOW DO YOU TEND TO PAY THE
LOAN IS STILL OF COURSE I'M
GONNA RENT THE UNIT OUT THEY
SAY WELL YOU EED TO YOUR RENT
ROLL. TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT AND
SO THIS PROVIDESA MECHANISM
TO- THE COUCH A FAIT FOLKS. TO
ALLOW WE THINK UP TO FIFTY
THOUSAND UNITS POTENTIALLY OF.
AND ON THE OTHER HAND ALSO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITY FOR FOLKS
IN COMMUNITIES AND PUT PEOPLE
TO WORK THIS IS PART OF OUR
LARGER ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PACKAGE- I ASKED FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. EIGHTEEN NO HANDS HERE IN
THE CHAMBER SENIOR HANDS
REMOTELY. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I ACTON'S I FELL.
BRADFORD I KERR BY ADAM I DON.
HI DURAZO I GOT JOHNNY FIVE
GLAZER GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG
HI HILL HI WAY SO. FIVE HER
TADO HI JACKSON I LLEVA I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. I MORNING.
I NIELSEN. NO PAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. FIVE ROSS FIVE RUBIO HI
SKINNER STERN. NUMBER FIVE WHAT
KIND OF SKI HI WINNER HI. I'M
THIRTY PLEASE CALL OUR REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS ON AV SIXTY
NINE. BASICS. EIGHT AB SIXTY
NINE HOMES. BASICS NO. GORGEOUS
OR JUST EIGHTY SIX NINE
ABSTAINED. CHANG. A. B. SIXTY
NINE I'D CHANG HI SALLY. ALI A.
B. SIX NINE NO DALLY NO. GROVE
ROAD EIGHTY SIX NINE NO GROVE
NO MELINDA'S MELINDA'S EIGHTY
SIX NINE NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. EIGHTY SIX NINE BY
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. L. A. B.
SIX NINE NO R. L. NO WELK SHE-
WILL AB SIXTY NINE NO WILKE NO.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL NUMBER
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM SIXTY
EIGHT. A. B. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SIX THIRTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO WORKPLACE SAFETY
CENTER FOR GEORGE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR THE- THIS IS ALSO
PART OF OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
PACKAGE IT'S BEEN DISCUSSED
BETWEEN THE TWO HOUSES. THIS
MEASURE REQUIRES HOSPITALS TO
PROVIDE AN INSURER EMPLOYEES
USE THEIR PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT OR AS WE CALL IT PP
THERE'S NO DOUBT AS WE ALL
KNOW. THAT WE HAVE HEARD
STORIES FROM OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES REPRESENT ABOUT
SHOCKING LACK OF PP SUPPLIES IN
LOCAL HOSPITALS THIS BILL.
REQUIRES THESE EMPLOYEES TO
MAINTAIN EMPLOYERS EXCUSE ME TO
MAINTAIN MISTER PRESIDENT A
THREE MONTH STOCKPILE OF NEW AN
INVENTORY TO CAL OSHA UPON
REQUEST- THIS IS FOR THE FRONT
HELPING FRONTLINE WORKERS. THAT
HAVE JUST FACED EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGES ASPIRIN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SEEN ON HAND HERE IN
THE CHAMBER. SENIOR HANDS
REMOTELY MADAM SECRETARY WELL
HERE WE GO WE HAVE. ZERO
SENATOR GIRLS AROUND ROOM.
THANK YOU AND THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I HAVE A QUESTION THE
AUTHOR. WITH THE ORDER TAKER
QUESTION CERTAINLY THE NUMBER
OF KOREA THANK YOU AND SO
BASICALLY WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE
LEGISLATION THAT SPECIFIES A
VIOLATION OF NOT HAVING TO
STOCKPILE MANDATE- WHICH-
BECAUSE A TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS CIVIL PENALTY- DURING
THIS CODE RAMP THAT. I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF HOSPITALS- NOT
JUST IN MY DISTRICT BUT ALL
OVER WERE HAVING DIFFICULTY
EVEN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND THE GOVERNOR COULD NOT
SECURE MASK- AND- WITH A
BILLION DOLLAR DEAL THAT FELL
THROUGH. AS COMPETING AS A
NATION STATE AS HE SAID AGAINST
OTHER STATES AND OTHER NATIONS
TRYING TO SECURE THESE ITEMS SO
I GUESS IF THE PRODUCT
INFORMATION THE PRODUCT THAT
FOR THE P. P. IS NOT AVAILABLE
I'M IN THE MARKET PLACE. AND
YOU'RE GONNA PINA BELIEVE
PUNISH HOSPITALS AND OTHER
FRONTLINE ORGANIZATIONS FOR NOT
HAVING- NOT HAVING THIS P. P.
R. HOW HOW DO YOU GO ABOUT
GETTING IT IF. IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE ON THE MARKET. THANK
VERY MUCH SENATOR THE YOU GOOD
INTENT CALL YOUR ATTENTION TO
PAGE OF FIVE OF THE MEASURE.
AND IF YOU START AT LINE SEVEN
AND GO THROUGH LINE TWENTY.
WHAT IT SAYS FIRST OF ALL IT'S
UP TO TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND NOT
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND COURTS
HAVE DISCRETION. BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY THE POINT THAT YOU
WOULD ACTUALLY RAISE EXACTLY
WHAT'S ADDRESSED HERE IN THE
AMENDMENTS. IT INDICATES THAT
YOU HAVE FOUGHT FINES UNLESS
I'M READING FROM THE MEASURE.
THE DEPARTMENT DETERMINES THAT
THE EMPLOYER COULD NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS TO THE ISSUES
BEYOND OUR CONTROL SUCH AS THE
PARK AND DEMONSTRATE. THAT
EQUIPMENT NEEDED TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS SECTION
HAS BEEN ORDERED FROM THE
MANUFACTURER DISTRIBUTOR OR NOT
BUT FAILED. OR IT'S BEEN
DAMAGED OR STOLEN. OKAY SO
BASICALLY IT DOES PROVIDE FOR
THAT FLEXIBILITY OF COURSE I
HOPE THAT ANSWERS THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU. M. I'M MY OWN TIME I
STILL AM OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
ALTHOUGH I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S RESPONSE. ON THOSE
QUESTIONS- MY GREAT CONCERN IS
NUMBER ONE IF THE INFORMATION
IS OR IF THE PRODUCT THE. PP
PER PERSON PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
IS NOT AVAILABLE. AND I UNDER.
THAT THEY WOULD HAVE TO PROVE
THAT THEY'VE ALREADY PLACED THE
ORDER- BUT EVEN. IF YOU LOOK
BACK AT THEM THE BILLION DOLLAR
MASS STILL PER SE JUST FOR AN
EXAMPLE. WE LOST RESOURCES ON
THAT PARTICULAR BILL BECAUSE WE
HAD TO PUT A DEPOSIT AT FRIENDS
AND THERE WERE SOME OTHER
THINGS THAT WE HAD TO DO. AND
ALTHOUGH I THINK THE GOVERNOR
DID EVERYTHING HE COULD TO MAKE
SURE THE MONEY WAS SECURED
USING THE RIGHT ATTORNEYS AND
STAFF THERE WAS STILL. REVENUES
THAT WERE TAX REVENUES TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA CITIZENS
THAT LOST- ON THAT. PARTICULAR
BILL. SO IJUST THINK THAT-
MANDATING I THINK THAT EVERY
EMPLOYER SHOULD DO EVERYTHING
THEY CAN BASED ON WHAT WE
LEARNED IN THIS PANDEMIC TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE. PROPER
PP TO MAKE SURE OUR FRONTLINE
WORKERS ARE TAKING CARE OF. BUT
IF YOU NEED TO REALLY PUNISH
ONE- FOR NOT SECURING. I
BELIEVE IT WAS A THREE MINUTES
OF EARTH. AS THREE MONTHS
SUPPLY. AND A THREE MONTH
SUPPLY. OF I THINK THAT'S JUST
NOT SOMETHING THAT THAT WE CAN
PUT ON OUR EMPLOYERS AT. THIS
TIME BECAUSE LIKE I SAID. IN
THE PAN IN THE BEGINNING MANY
PEOPLE WERE. FOR THE PPP ITEMS.
THE PRICES WERE SKYROCKETING
THERE WAS NO CONTROL WE WERE
GETTING EVERYTHING OUT OF
CHINA. BECAUSE WE'VE DRIVEN ALL
MANUFACTURING- YOU KNOW
ESPECIALLY WITH THE HIGH COST
OF DOING BUSINESS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. A LOT OF THAT
MANUFACTURING GOES TO OTHER
STATES OR OTHER COUNTRIES.
PRIMARILY CHINA. AND I JUST
THINK THAT TO HAVE US RELY ON
CHINA TO PROVIDE IS FOR PP. AT
AN ADEQUATE COST AND HAVE OUR
EMPLOYERS PUNISHED IF THEY
CAN'T SECURE IT. IS NOT GOOD
LEGISLATION BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR THIS COURSE IS A
BIT ON THE SIDE- DOCTOR PAN.
THANK YOU. THE PRESIDENT-
CENTERS- I ACTUALLY STAND AND
SUPPORT I APPRECIATE THE-
ISSUES BROUGHT UP BY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD IN
FACT THAT- IN. NOT ONLY WORKING
THIS BILL BUT A NOTHER BILL
THAT- MYSELF AND- SUR LEYVA.
ARE WORKING ON- WE DID TRY TO
ADDRESS THIS VERY ISSUE ABOUT
NOT HAVING- HEALTHCARE
FACILITIES LIKE HOSPITALS
HAVING TO STOCKPILE PP DURING A
STORAGE PERIOD IT ADDED. I KNOW
THAT THERE WERE TALKS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AS WELL AND-
AND ENSURING THAT THAT
SITUATION WOULD NOT HAPPEN. BUT
I THINK MORE IMPORTANTLY. A
STUDY FROM UC BERKELEY SHOWS
WHAT THE COST. IT WAS IN BOTH
MONEY AND LIVES TO CALIFORNIA
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE A LAW LIKE
THIS IN PLACE PRIOR TO COPE AT
NINETEEN. AND CERTAINLY WE
WOULD NOT WANT TO HAVE THAT
SITUATION GOING TO FEATURE. SO
I WOULD ASK THAT WE SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. HEARING
TINA SOONER TURBOCHARGED CLOSE
I DON'T PLACE FROM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON IT A.
B. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN.
ALAN I ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS.
BY BELL. BRADFORD ON FIVE BY
ADAM I DON. HI OSEM I GOT
JOHNNY. GLAZER GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG I HELLO. HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON. FIVE
LLEVA. I REQUIRE. MITCHELL FIVE
MINING HI NIELSEN. PAM FIVE
FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH HI RUBIO
FIVE SKINNER. STERN NUMBER FIVE
QUAKE OWSKI FIVE WINNER HI.
SECRETARY NOW LET'S GO TO OUR
REMOTE VOTING SENATORS ON. ABC.
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN. FAITH.
EIGHT ABC TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO. EIGHT NOW FOR JUST.
OR JUST A B. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN ABSTAINED. CHANG HANG AT
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN HI
CHANG HI SALLY. KELLY AT TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NO. DALLY NO
GROWTH AT TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN GROWTH NO GROVE NO
MELINDA'S. THE WINDOWS AT
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK OR A B.
TWELVE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. WELL.
EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN
NOW MARLA MORALE NO WELL. WE
LOOK AT TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN NO WELL NO. SENATOR MOVES
A CALL NEXT UP IS FOLLOW ITEM
EIGHTY SIX AV. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE CENTER YOU'RE
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM. YES
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MAIN SHINE AND ACTUALLY NEED TO
CONTACT CONTRACTS IN FLOORS OR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
LAST I WOULD SAY AT LEAST THREE
DECADES. THIS GOVERNMENT HAS
WORKED VERY HARD IN MANY
CONTEXTS OF CONSUMER PROTECTION
TO PROTECT SENIORS FROM BEING
RIPPED OFF IN ONE FORM OR
ANOTHER- THIS MEASURE PROVIDES
PREVENTATIVE PROTECTIONS FOR
SENIORS BY STATUTORILY
EXTENDING THE RIGHT TO CANCEL
THAT WE PUT INTO LEGISLATION A
FEW YEARS AGO. FROM THREE
BUSINESS DAYS TO FIVE BUSINESS
DAYS FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
CONTRACTS LAST YEAR I BOTH. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
FROM OUR REMOTELY PARTICIPATING
CENTERS SHINO HANDS UP MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE- ABC. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE. ALAN HI ARCHULETA
HI AT KINS I FELL. BRADFORD I
KERR BY ADAM I THOUGHT. HI THE
RUSSELL HI CAROL CHANNING HI
BLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HURTS BERG
HI HELLO HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO HI JACKSON I LLEVA HI WIRE
HI MITCHELL HI MONEY HI NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO FIVE SKINNER STERN
NUMBER HI BY CAL SKI. FIVE
WINNERS. FIVE SECRETARY NOW
LET'S MOVE TO A REMOTE VOTING
SENATORS ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SIX ABC. TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
ONE. FAITH ABC TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE HI BASED ON BOARD
JUST WORD IS A B. TWO TWO FOUR
SEVEN ONE NINE FOUR JUST BY
CHANG TANG AB TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
WHEN I CHANG HI SALLY. KELLY AT
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE HI
SALLY HIGH GROWTH. GROWTH AT
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE I DROVE
BY MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY ONE I
MELINDA'S HI WARLOCK. AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY ONE HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. WELL EIGHTY TWENTY
OR SEVENTY ONE HIGH MORALE HIGH
WILL. WILL AT. TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE HI WILKE HI. THANK
YOU SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES A
CALL NOW IS FINAL ITEM. FILE
ITEM ONE ON NINE AV. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE. MADAM SECRETARY
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER OR
BACK IN AFTER LEADING TO
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY VERA TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. YOUR
GEORGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THIS
MEASURE IS ALSO A PRODUCT OF
THE EFFORT THE BALL BOTH HOUSES
WITH RESPECT TO. ON THE- ON
ECONOMIC RECOVERY PACKAGE AND
THE AUTHOR WAS A VERY DILIGENT-
PARTICIPANT IN THAT PROCESS. IN
THIS MEASURE- HER BILL SEEKS TO
STREAMLINE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS FOR EDT WORK SHARE
PROGRAMS. TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF EMPLOYERS
PARTICIPATING IN THAT PROGRAM
AS WE KNOW. BRIEFLY THE WORK
SHARE PROGRAM IS A FORM OF
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE IT GIVES
EMPLOYERS THE OPTION OF
REDUCING EMPLOYEES HOURS
INSTEAD OF CUTTING THEIR
WORKFORCE. DURING AN ECONOMIC.
DOWNTURN FOR EXAMPLE A BUSINESS
MAY DETERMINE IT NEEDS TO
REDUCE PERSONNEL COSTS BY
LAYING OFF FIVE EMPLOYEES.
UNTIL BUSINESS CONDITIONS
IMPROVE UNDER THE WORKSHOP
PROGRAM THE EMPLOYER INSTEAD
CAN REDUCE THE HOURS OF TWENTY
FIVE EMPLOYEES. BY 25% AND
THOSE WORKERS RECEIVE A PRO
RATA U. I. PAYMENT FOR THE ONE
DAY PER WEEK OF AN EMPLOYMENT
WHILE MAINTAINING. ANY EXISTING
HEALTH AND RETIREMENT BENEFITS.
WHARTON MEASURE ASTEROID WILL.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. SHINO
MIKE'S UP LOOKING REMOTELY
SCENE NO YES WE DO. WE HAVE
THIS IS SENATOR GROVE. SENATOR
DID YOU WANT TO BE ON THE SIDE
OF. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
QUESTIONED THE AUTHOR. WITH ALL
THE THIRD QUESTION I WILL DO
THAT YOUR SISTER WE ALL KNOW
THAT THE UNEMPLOYMENT THE YOU I
TRUST FUND IS COMPLETELY
UNDERFUNDED AND- THE LAST TIME
THAT THIS HAPPENED EMPLOYERS IN
THE STATE WHERE WERE
ADDITIONALLY CAPPED AT. A TAX
FOR THE TAX REDUCTION CREDIT-
NOW WE HAVE THE PLAYERS IN A
DIFFERENT SITUATION WHEN IT
WASN'T THERE REESE IT WASN'T
THEIR FAULT THAT- THE ECONOMIC
SHUTDOWN TO PLACES WAS DIRECTED
FROM THE GOVERNOR. SO THESE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE OPERATING
AT DIMINISHED CAPACITY OR
MINIMAL CAPACITY AND- IT'S MORE
THAN LIKELY THAT THEY WILL-
THAT THEY WILL HAVE TO TAKE ON
THE BURDEN AND THE AND THE
UNINSURED AND EMPLOYMENT. TRUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL THIS
MONEY IS PAID OUT. AND REFUNDED
AND THAT WILL HAPPEN FOR. I'M
ASSUMING TEN TO TWELVE YEARS IN
THE FUTURE SO I GUESS MY AND MY
QUESTION IS THAT THERE WAS AN
AMENDMENT THAT WAS TAKEN. IN
THE ASSEMBLY WHICH ELIMINATED-
YEAH THE ELIMINATED THE ABILITY
TO- AD DOLLARS INTO THE U. I.
TRIES TO ELIMINATE SOME OF THE
STRAIN IT'S GOING TO BE
HAPPENING ON FUTURE. IN THE
FUTURE ON ALL OF OUR BUSINESSES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA HE
TELL ME WHY THAT A MINIMALISTIC
SEPT. IT AND WHY WE WOULD EVEN
TRY TO. BIRD BUSINESS THAT ARE
EMPLOYERS ANYMORE THAN THEY
ALREADY ARE. HAPPY TO. BE
CHALLENGED AT ALL OF US FACED
IN THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY PLAN
HERE WAS TO TRY TO REDUCE AS
MUCH BURDEN AS POSSIBLE ON THE
GENERAL FUND. THE FRAMEWORK WAS
HOW DO WE KEEP PEOPLE WORKING
CREATE THE MOST AMOUNT OF
ECONOMIC IMPACT FOR FOLKS. THE
MONEY YOU TALK ABOUT IS A IT IS
AT THIS POINT A NO INTEREST
LOAN. BUT TO THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S LIKE A LINE OF
CREDIT. SO HERE WE ARE HAVING
THE BENEFIT OF THESE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS OF COURSE
IT WILL ULTIMATELY BE A BURDEN
ON EMPLOYERS BUT IT'S A NO
INTEREST LOAN THAT BASICALLY
TAKES CARE OF PEOPLE ALLOWS
PEOPLE TO BUY FOOD PAY THE RENT
AND THE LIKE. SO BY ORDERS OF
MAGNITUDE WHEN THE SITUATION
THAT IS QUITE CHALLENGING THAT
YOU'RE CORRECT IS NO ONE'S
FAULT. WHAT'S HAPPENED HERE IN
WHAT WHY I THINK THIS MEASURE
SO ELEGANT IT'S BECAUSE ON THE
ONE HAND. ARM WE CAN'T AFFORD
TO KEEP PUTTING A HUGE BURDEN
ON THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA'S
GENERAL FUND THAT WOULD BE
PROBLEMATIC. WE HAVE A NO
INTEREST LOAN FOR A PERIOD OF
TIME NOW FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. AND THEN ALSO WE
HAVE THIS ODD SITUATION WITH
THIS WORK SHARE PROGRAM WHERE
PEOPLE WANT TO WORK IF YOU'RE
AN EMPLOYER YOU WILL BE GOT A
REALLY GOOD EMPLOYEE YOU DON'T
WANT TO JUST BE A SITUATION ARE
INCENTIVIZED TO GO ON AN
EMPLOYMENT. AND THIS MEETS A
REALLY ELEGANT BALANCE IN THAT
REGARD GIVEN ALL OF THESE VERY
SERIOUS CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING IN THE ECONOMY GOING
FORWARD. AND WE DON'T KNOW FOR
THE BEGINNING MIDDLE OR END OF
THE CIRCUMSTANCES WE ARE SO. IT
IS CHALLENGING BUT IT IS AND IT
WILL HAVE PROBLEMS IN THE
FUTURE THERE'S NO QUESTION
THEY'LL BE CHALLENGES AS WE GO
FORWARD. BUT RIGHT NOW WE'VE
GOT TO KEEP FOOD ON THE TABLE
KEEP KIND PLAYERS- HAVING-
THEIR EMPLOYEES WORKING AND
HAVING THEIR BENEFITS SO I
THINK IT'S. A PRETTY THOUGHTFUL
APPROACH BY THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU FOR THE RESPONSE I WOULD
ADAM ACTUALLY URGE A NO VOTE
FOR THE PREVIOUS REASONS I
THINK THAT- I DO AGREE THAT
IT'S LIKE A NO INTEREST LOAN
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
BUT LAST TIME THIS HAPPENED
WHEN WE HAD AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DEFAULTED ON THAT ON
LOAN AND NEVER PAID A DIME-
BACK FROM THE GENERAL FUND- SO
THE- EMPLOYERS WERE TAXED. AT A
GREATER AMOUNT AND IF THE TAX
REDUCTION CREDIT WHICH WAS
ELIMINATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FAILED TO PAY THAT
LOAN BACK. SO IT'S STILL ON THE
BACKS OF EVERY JOB CREATOR. AS
SOME BUSINESSES WENT OUT OF
BUSINESS BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH AN
EXTRAORDINARY BURDEN. AT TO
MAINTAIN I BELIEVE FOR SIX
YEARS AND- WE DID ESTIMATE TO
SHOW THAT THIS WILL PROBABLY
LAST LONGER TAN FIFTEEN YEARS.
I DO KNOW THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF THE PEOPLE IN THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY GATHER SUPPORTING
THIS BILL BECAUSE- IT IS.
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TO OFFER IT TO SEE IF OTHER
EMPLOYEES WOULD BE WILLING TO.
YOU KNOW SHARE THE BURDEN OF
SOMEBODY LOSING THEIR JOB. I'M
SO I SEE THE IMPACT THAT I JUST
DON'T SEE. THAT YOU CAN- DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS AND NOT
ADDRESS THE SEVERE. GET THIS
SEVERE- REJECTION IN THAT YOU I
TRUST FUND. BECAUSE THAT'S
GOING TO BE A SIGNIFICANT.
SHORTFALL THAT'S GOING TO HAVE
TO BE MADE AT. AT SO AGAIN I
WOULD AS ABSOLUTELY ASK FREE
AND NO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
RIGHT. YOU KNOW GET THE IDEA
BEHIND THIS BILL I LAKE THE
PROBLEM IS IT THE APPROVAL OF
THESE PLANS- GO TO THE DIRECTOR
B. D. D. AND WE KNOW THAT EDIE
D. HAS HAD A NUMBER OF PROBLEMS
KEEPING UP WITH THEIR WORKLOAD
RECENTLY TO THE POINT WHERE THE
MOST RECENT ARTICLE I SAW SAID
THAT EDT WISE NOT ANSWERING 60%
OF THE CALLS THAT THEY WERE
RECEIVING. SO I HAVE SOME
CONCERNS ABOUT JUST THEM BEING
ABLE TO TAKE ON MORE TASKS- I
WONDER IF THE AUTHOR OR THE
FLOOR MANAGER COULD- ADDRESS
THAT PLEASE. I'LL JUST MY
CLOTHES. HE WILL ADDRESS IT IN
CLOSER- MELINDA'S. ZERO DOLLARS.
THANK YOU THE BUT MR PRESIDENT
THAT REAL QUICK I JUST WANNA
MAKE A COMMENT I HAPPEN TO BE
ONE OF THOSE EMPLOYERS THAT
ACTUALLY. ADD TO PAY BACK IN
THE UNDER THE LAST RECESSION WE
HAD AND IT WAS IT WAS FROM THE
TWO THOUSAND A RECESSION. THAT
WE'VE ALL THE MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT JUST LIKE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT- THE
JOCKEY THIS BILL AND YOU KNOW
THOSE EMPLOYERS HAD TO PAY THAT
BACK WE JUST GOT IT PAID OFF- I
THINK IT WAS LIKE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN. OR SEVENTEEN AND NOW
HERE WE ARE AGAIN GOING RIGHT
BACK TO THE SAME PROCESS I LIKE
THIS BILL A LOT I ACTUALLY WANT
TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL AND IT
WAS. IN GOOD SHAPE UNTIL IT
CAME BACK WITH THE- PUTTING
THEM AREN'T OWNERS ON
BUSINESSES. ARE ALREADY.
STRUGGLING UNDER THIS CODE. IS
SHUT DOWN OUR BUSINESSES ARE
FAILING OUR OUR CLIENTELE IS
GONE. AND THERE'S A LOT OF
REASONS THAT IS MAKING IT VERY
DIFFICULT IF YOU HAVE NO
BUSINESS YOU HAVE NO EMPLOYEES.
WHICH MEANS THEY HAVE NO JOB.
THE IDEA OF DOING A PARTIAL IS
GREAT BUT WHEN IT GOES BACK ON
TO THE EMPLOYER- I CAN'T
SUPPORT THAT AND- IT'S- JUST
AMAZING TO ME THAT WE CAN
NEVER. LOOK OUT FOR THE
BUSINESS OWNER THAT ACTUALLY
SUPPLIES THE JOB AS PRIVATE
INDUSTRY JOBS. THE GREAT THE
TAX DOLLARS FOR THE GENERAL
FUND WE'RE WE'RE SECRETLY
TRYING TO TAKE CARE OF SO. FOR
THOSE REASONS I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
SIDE OF. HERE IN CHINO IN
SOONER TO REGAIN MAY CLOSE THEM
VERY BRIEFLY I YOU KNOW I THINK
THE AUTHOR IS SENSITIVE TO THE
ISSUES THAT WERE RAISED. THIS
GOVERNMENT TO GET IT CORRECT
TAKE TEN YEARS ROM TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO PAY OFF THE LAST
SUM OF MONEY. I THINK THAT I
THINK THAT THERE'S A
POSSIBILITY GOING FORWARD AND
CERTAINLY HAS US IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO PRIORITIZE WITH
RESPECT TO PARTICULAR SMALL
BUSINESSES. TO BE ABLE TO MAYBE
HAVE THE STATE STEP UP OR THERE
COULD BE SOME OTHER ADAPTIVE
APPROACHES BUT RIGHT NOW IN
TERMS OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY
REMAINS VERY DIFFICULT
CHALLENGE. WE DON'T WANT TO
INCENTIVIZE PEOPLE TO SAY OH
I'M GOING TO JUST STAND ON
UNEMPLOYMENT IT HELPS BOTH THE
EMPLOYEE IT HELPS FOR BENEFITS
AND HELPS EMPLOYERS TO KEEP
THEIR PEOPLE IT'S SMART. I
AGREE THAT THERE MIGHT BE
CHALLENGED IN THE FUTURE. WE
ARE IN A DIFFICULT SITUATION
THIS SOLVES THAT ISSUE IN THE
NEAR TERM. AND WE LEAVE OPEN
FOR DEBATE GOING FORWARD IF WE
WANT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE SOME
SUBSIDY FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND IMPACT THOSE QUESTIONS AS
WE MOVE FORWARD. TO ANALYZE
WHAT RESOURCES THE STATES HAVE
WHAT PRIORITY THE STATE HAS SO
IT'S IMPORTANT POINT BUT I
THINK RIGHT NOW THIS IS PART OF
A VERY URGENT SITUATION AND
IT'S A VERY WELL THOUGHT
THROUGH BILL LAST YEAR I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU ALL DISCUSSION DEBATE
HAS SEIZED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
FIVE ARCHULETA I AT KINS. WELL
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT I HAVE A- I
DON. HI TORONTO HI CAL JOHNNY
FIVE GLAZER GONZALEZ HI HURTS
BERG HI HILL I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO HI JACKSON HI LLEVA I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. I MONEY I
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE FORTUNE
TINO. I. ROSS. HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. STERN NUMBER I WAKE
OWSKI HI WINNER HI. ZURCHER CAN
RETURN ON TOUR REMOTE LINK
VOTING SENATORS ON THE ITEM ONE
ON NINE AV SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE. FAITH BATES A B. SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE NO BABIES NO PORGES.
FORTY EIGHT B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY
ONE ABSTAIN. CHANG THE EIGHTY
SEVENTY THIRTY ONE I. CHANG HI
SALLY. L. AB THIRTEEN AT
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE NO DALLY
NO GROWTH WELL THE AP SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE NO GROWTH NO
MELINDA'S. WINDOWS EIGHTY
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. D. A.
B. SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE NO MORE
LOCK NO MORE AROUND. TOMORROW
YOUR MUTE. OKAY MORALE AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE WELL
MORALE NO WELL. AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY ONE NO WELCOME NO. THANK
YOU SENATOR TO REMOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS ARE RETURNING TO FALL
ITEM THIRTY NINE. BY SENATOR
ASSEMBLYWOMAN- WHEN PRESENTED
BY SENATOR RUBIO AV. THIRTY TO
FORTY TWO. ARE YOU PREPARED.
SHE HAS OUT OF SURGERY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
IRWIN AN ACT RELATING TO MENTAL
HEALTH CENTER ROOF FLOOR GEORGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO. AB THIRTY
TWO FORTY TWO CLARIFIES THAT
COUNTIES CAN UTILIZE TELEHEALTH
TO CONDUCT FIFTY ONE FIFTIES
AND FIFTY ONE FIFTY ONE
INVOLUNTARY HOLD EVALUATIONS
DESPITE SUCCESSFUL DEPLOYMENT
OF THESE TELEHEALTH EVALUATIONS
DURING AND BEFORE THE PANDEMIC
THIS PRACTICE IS NOT CURRENTLY
CODIFIED IN LAW. THIS BILL
PASSED THE ASSEMBLYWITH
OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND WAS PASSED IN THE SENATE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WITH ZERO NO
VOTES IT'S SPONSORED BY BOTH
THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND NAMI CALIFORNIA
AND SUPPORTED BY A LARGE
COALITION OF HEALTH
ORGANIZATIONS RECENT AMENDMENTS
WERE TAKEN THIS WEEK TAKEN TO
INCLUDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU. PRINT QUEUE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SHINO
RAZOR MIKE'S HERE SEE NINE.
REMOTELY MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. BELL
BRADFORD FIVE CABRERA I DON. HI
THE RISER. I GOT JOHNNY FIVE
GLAZER. GONZALES HI HURTS BERG.
HELLO I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON. FIVE LLEVA I REQUIRE.
HI MITCHELL. I MONEY. I NIELSEN.
HI TEN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI
ROTH FIVE RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
STERN AMBERG I Y. CASKEY HI
WINNER. THANK. I WILL GO TO OUR
REMOTE VOTING. MEMBERSHIP ON
FOLLOWING FALL ITEM THIRTY NINE
THE V. THIRTY TO FORTY TWO
MONTHS AFTER PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BASICS MAYBE THIRTY TO
FORTY TWO HI BETH HI GORGEOUS.
URGES EIGHTY THREE TO FOUR TO
FIVE OR JUST HI CHANG. TANG AB
THIRTY TWO FORTY TWO R. CHANG
HI DALLI DALLI AB. THIRTY TWO
FORTY TWO HI SALLY BY. GROWTH.
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY TWO FORTY TWO
I GROW BY BELINDA'S WINDOWS
EIGHTY THIRTY TO FORTY TWO I
MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. OR MAYBE
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO A PRODUCT.
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE WELL A. B.
THIRTY TWO FORTY TWO HI MORALE
HI. WELCOME. WILL IT BE THIRTY
TO FORTY TWO HI WELL HI.
SENATOR SENATOR RUBIO MOVES A
CALL. NEXT UP IS FALL ITEM.
FORTY EVITA. ONE TWELVE CENTER
TARA ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THAT.
MEASURE. I BELIEVE SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY YOU MAY READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWELVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ALMOST AN ACT
RELATING TO SUICIDE PREVENTION.
INTERTIDAL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT A
B. TWO ONE ONE TWO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON BOTH A. B.
TWO ONE ONE TWO ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CORBETT NINETEEN HAS HAD A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON COMMUNITY
MENTAL HEALTH DUE TO ANXIETY
CAUSED BY MANY FACTORS SUCH AS
ISOLATION GRIEF OVER THE LOSS
OF FRIENDS AND FAMILY WE NEED
TO PREPARE NOW FOR INCREASED
PRESSURE FROM BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SYSTEMS NOT ONLY DURING THIS
CRISIS BUT- FOR ITS AFTERMATH
IN THE COMING YEARS. A. B. TWO
ONE ONE TWO TOOK THE FIRST STEP
AND ADDRESSING THE CURRENT
CRISIS OF SUICIDE. BY CREATING
A STATEWIDE OFFICE OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION WITH END OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AT
THIS OFFICE WILL CENTRALISE
STATE RESOURCES MARSHALL
EXPERTISE AND BUILD ON THE
VITAL WORK OF STAKE HOLDERS
LIKE THOSE WHO ARE HERE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIGHT BOAT.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION IN THE VERY CENTER
ROOM. BEST THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I'M PROUD TO BE A CO
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL I REALLY
JUST WANT TO CONVEY THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS MEASURE P
EVEN BEFORE CORBETT NINETEEN
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH REPORTED THAT
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG TEENS AND
YOUNG ADULTS BETWEEN FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY FOUR YEARS OF AGE OF
COURSE WITH THE PANDEMIC THIS
CRISIS HAS BECOME EVEN MORE-
URGENT SO I ALSO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I WANT
TO ALSO- SUPPORT AT TWENTY ONE
TWELVE- BRIEFLY SENATORS
SUICIDE IS AN ISSUE THAT
CROSSES ALL DEMOGRAPHICS AND-
CAN TRAGICALLY AFFECT ANY
FAMILY- INCLUDING MY OWN AND SO
I APPRECIATE THE EFFORTS OF THE
BILL'S AUTHOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ALMOST AFTER CARRYING THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND I WOULD ASK
YOU TO VOTE I PLEASE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SENATOR DOLLAR.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- MEMBERS
I ALSO HAVE LOST. TO FRIENDS
SINCE COVERT ACTUALLY TAKING
THEIR LIVES TO SUICIDE AND SO I
THINK THIS IS A GREAT STEP
THERE WAS A MEETING THAT TO. A
SENATOR FROM TO HEMA SIMPLY
WOMAN- THE FIRST HISTORY AGAIN
AT A SEVEN MEMBER FROM THE
THIRD DISTRICT HAD WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT HELD
PUBLIC HEALTH'S NEW DIRECTOR.
AND QUITE FRANKLY ASKED HER YOU
KNOW WE TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
SUICIDE CHILD ABUSE MENTAL
HEALTH ALL THESE THINGS THAT
HAVE CREATE BEEN A HEIGHTENED
BECAUSE OF BECAUSE OF IT AND-
THEY HAD NOT AT THAT POINT- HAD
GET YOU NEEDING ANY INFORMATION
BUT I CAN TELL YOU- JUST- WITH
MY OWN EXPERIENCE WITH MY
DAUGHTER BEING HOME- THAT HER
HER HEALTH MENTAL HEALTH I
DON'T BELIEVE IT'S GREAT
BECAUSE SAID SHE NEEDS TO BE
WITH OUR FRIENDS AT SCHOOL SO.
I FULLY SUPPORT THIS BILL LIKE
I APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD I THINK IT'S A
MOOD AS A MOVE IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION I ALSO THINK WE
SHOULD BE TAKING A LOOK AT
THOSE OTHER HEALTH IMPACT
HELMET- AND PLANO'S INPUT UP
ALL THE HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA
NOT JUST. A SITE SPECIFIC TO
COLBERT THANK YOU MR. CHAIRMAN
MISTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU. SO
GROVE. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
TO RAISE AND SUPPORT OF- THIS
BILL AB TWO WHEN TWO- YOU KNOW
WHEN WE WERE ALL ON LOCKDOWN
AND THE STATE WAS- BASICALLY
NOT OPERATING AT ALL INCLUDING
OUR SCHOOLS AND BUSINESSES AND
PEOPLE WERE SHELTERING IN
PLACE- THE WEEKLY CALLS THAT I
HAD WITH MY HOSPITAL
ADMINISTRATORS AND THE WEEKLY
CALLS I HAVE WITH LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN SHED A HUGE
LIGHT ON NOT ONLY THE SUICIDE
RATE THAT HAD. GONE UP
DRASTICALLY IT IMPACTED MANY
MANY FAMILIES BUT ALSO CHILD
ABUSE DOMESTIC VIOLENCE- ALL OF
THESE HORRIFIC AFTER- AFTER
SHOCKS I GUESS YOU WOULD SAY-
THE- AFFECTION THAT ARE
AFFECTED BY TOBIN IN THE
LOCKDOWN AND I WOULD HOPE THAT-
AS THIS NEW INFORMATION COMES
OUT WITH CDC GUIDELINE OR CDC
THAT IS SAYING THAT YOU KNOW
THE FATALITY RATE IS OERSTATED
BASICALLY BECAUSE- PEOPLE THAT
DIED WITH CO MOBILITIES AND
DIED- WITH KELVIN VERSES FROM
KOBE THAT REPORT JUST CAME OUT
TODAY I WOULD HOPE THAT THE
FATALITY RATE WOULD BE ADJUSTED
AND WE WOULD TAKE A MORE
REASONABLE APPROACH. ABOUT
HANDLING AND THIS PARTICULAR
VIRUS A MOVING FORWARD AND AS
WE- AS WE- SENT THE FATALITY
RATE THAT THIS THIS VIRUS IS
ACTUALLY CAUSED BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT WHAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH ON THIS PARTICULAR PIECE
OF LEGISLATION AND THE
AFOREMENTIONED THINGS THAT
DEPRESSION WITH OUR CHILDREN
AND WANTING TO GO BACK TO
SCHOOL A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS
THAT ARE TAKING PLACE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE SUICIDE- LIKE THIS
STILL WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT- WE ADDRESS. THESE ISSUES
AND MOVE FORWARD BUT WE ALSO
NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT AND WE
LOOK AT THIS- THIS SOLUTIONS
THAT WE OFFER ABOUT SHUTTING
DOWN POSITIONING DOWN SCHOOLS-
IN ORDER TO A VERTICAL BIT OR
FATALITIES IN CO BUT IN
POSITIVE CASES THAT TIME WE
SHOULD LOOK AT THE NEW CDC
INFORMATION THAT. SHOWS THAT IT
MAYBE IS NOT AS FATAL AS WHAT
EVERYBODY FIRST SAW. AND AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WE SHOULD ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE AS WELL BUT I FULLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU
SENATOR BATES. THANK YOU I RISE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE US
MANY OF US I DON'T EVER THINK
IT WILL TOUCH US PERHAPS THAT
IT TOUCHED MY FAMILY ARE
BECAUSE OF PTSD OF MY BROTHER
LAW WHO TOOK HIS LIFE AND THAT
OF MY SISTER AND I DO BELIEVE
THAT MORE RESOURCES WERE
AVAILABLE AT THAT TIME WELL
THAT MIGHT NOT HAPPEN SO THIS
IS THIS IS LONG OVERDUE AND I'M
I'M VERY SUPPORTIVE OF IT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MELINDA. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I SUPPORT THIS BILL
I'M I'M- REALLY PROUD OF THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS KOREAN
SHED A LIGHT ON THIS ISSUE AND
I THINK A NUMBER OF MY
COLLEAGUES SPOKE ABOUT THE FACT
THAT THIS IS DOESN'T SEEM TO BE
GOING AWAY ANYTIME SOON BECAUSE
OF COURSE WE ARE STILL IN MY
STATE OF LOCKED DOWN IN THIS
STATE AND I'M ACROSS A NUMBER
OF SECTORS INCLUDING OUR
SCHOOLS AND IS HAVING A
TERRIBLE EFFECT. ON PEOPLE'S
LIVES AND THEIR MENTAL HEALTH-
WE DO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ENDITEM IF WE CHOOSE TO RISE A
BODY BY- BRINGING A BILL
FORWARD TO END THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY. BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE HAVING
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS IF WE
DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
WE DON'T STEP FORWARD AND IN
STANDING UNITY AND- TRYING TO
GET EVERYBODY'S LIKE SCREWED
BACK TOGETHER AND WE CAN DO SO
SAFELY OF COURSE- BUT- THIS. IS
CERTAINLY A BILL- THAT I. I
THINK IT IS LONG PAST DUE AND I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING ABOUT I HOPE THAT MY
COLLEAGUES RECOGNIZE THAT.
WHICH EXTENDS BEYOND- THOSE WHO
ARE IDENTIFIED IN THE BILL IT
REALLY IS AFFECTING EVERYONE IN
OUR COMMUNITY AND I HOPE THAT
WE CAN COME TOGETHER AND DO
SOMETHING FOR THEM AS WELL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. SENATOR
JANG. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I
WANTED TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT AS A CO AUTHOR I'VE
ACTUALLY HEARD FROM MANY
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT KOBE IT'S
IMPACT ON MENTAL HEALTH
PARTICULARLY ON DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE- A CHILD ABUSE
DEPRESSION AND SUICIDE SO- I AM
VERY- OF VERY PROUD OF THAT THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL AND I URGE
YOU TO VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WERE SO. THANK YOU I WANNA RIDE
SAID ON TO THIS BECAUSE ALSO-
AS MANY MEMBERS HAVE MENTIONED
THIS IS HAD A PROFESSIONAL
IMPACT MY LIFE IN PARTICULAR
AND HAVING LOST TO A
GODDAUGHTER ENDED NEPHEW TO
SUICIDE AND HAVING BEEN
INFORMED RECENTLY THAT ANOTHER
YOUNG PERSON A SIXTEEN YEAR
OLD. JUST ENDED HIS LIFE OFF
THE CORONADO BRIDGE AND MANY OF
YOU KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON- BRITTANY'S SUICIDE FROM THE
CORONADO BRIDGE AND HOW THAT
EFFORT IS EXPANDING BUT AGAIN
WE LOST ANOTHER YOUNG PERSON TO
GRIEF AND WHATEVER HE WAS GOING
THROUGH. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE A
PROGRAM TO START TO REALLY.
ANALYZES THIS THIS PHENOMENAL
PHENOMENON ESPECIALLY WITH THE
INCREASE IN SUICIDES AND MORE
RECENTLY THIS YEAR. AND START
TO WORK ON A- PROGRAM TO TRY TO
PREVENT THIS AND TRY TO BRING
AN END TO END PRODUCT PROBABLY
FIND SOME RECOMMENDATIONS. ON
HOW THE STATE. AND DIFFERENT OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ALREADY WORK
TO ADDRESS MENTAL ILLNESS.
HEALTH PROBLEMS. I'LL START
WORKING ON PROVIDING ASSISTANCE
TO PEOPLE THAT ARE GOING TO
REALLY DIFFICULT TIMES. THIS IS
A WONDERFUL BILL AND I JUST
WANT TO ADD ON TO IT AND-
EXPRESS MY- SUPPORT HOW
IMPORTANT. THIS BILL IS AND HOW
IT'S GOING TO MAKE AN IMPACT IN
SO MANY PEOPLE'S LIVES WHEN
SOMEBODY COMMITS SUICIDE. THEY
DON'T ONLY AND THEIR LIFE BUT
THEY- REALLY- CONTRIBUTE TO
THE- THE END END END OF THE
HOPES AND DREAMS OF PARENTS
AND- AND OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE
ATTACHED TO THEM IN IN A WAY
THAT IS INEXTRICABLE SO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OF THE VEIN ON THE
SIDE OF. SENATOR RUBIO. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT HI YOU KNOW AS
A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CLARIFY HOW IMPORTANT THIS
ISSUE IS AND I DO APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS OF MY COLLEAGUES
ON SALEM HOWEVER THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S BEEN PLAGUING OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR A WHOLE
LIFETIME IT'S GOING TO BE HERE
THIS YEAR AND I WILL CONTINUE
TO BE AFTER. ANYTHING RELATED
TO THE PANDEMIC SO ONCE AGAIN
FIFTEEN THAT- SO MANY OF US
INCLUDING. MYSELF HAVE KNOWN
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TAKEN THEIR
LIVES THIS IS SOMETHING THAT I
HOPE THAT WE CAN JUST. YOU KNOW
PUSH FORWARD AND FOCUS ON THE
NEED. FOR IT TO MOVE FORWARD
BUT ONCE AGAIN IT DIDN'T START
THIS YEAR AND I WILL NOT STOP
THIS YEAR THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DESCRIPTION OF
THE RATE ON THIS ITEM. SENIOR
NINE SENATOR HER TADO GEORGIA
CLOSE JUST WANT TO THANK
COLLEAGUES AND OF COURSE THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRAD BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AQUI THIS IS
AN ISSUE THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT IN NEAR AND DEAR TO
MANY OF US HERE IF NOT ALL AND
SO I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIFEBOAT THANK YOU. MEMBERS
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ON CALL ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THAT.
TURNING CHAIN NINE MOVE THE
CALL.
MEMBERS WHO ARE NOW
LIFTING THE CALL ON ITEM. FIFTY
FOUR. YES FOLLOWING THIRTY FOUR.
ARCHULETA I. BELL I BRADFORD.
CABRERO NO. GOD YANNI. NO
GLAZER. WAY SO. HI HER TADO.
REQUIRE I. HAN RUBIO. ROB
ROTH'S. CENTER OFF NOTAR ROSS
NOTED HI MOVE THE CALL.
OUR
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING ON NOW TO
FALL I'M FORTY ONE. AV. TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED JENNER COVER EURO
YOU'RE PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE. READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATING TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
SINNER CARRIER THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ABC TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COURT. THIS BILL REMOVES
THE SUNSET TO ENSURE THAT STATE
AGENCIES WILL CONTINUE TO
ACCOUNT FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
IN OF CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN
PLANNING BUILDING AND INVESTING
IN STATE INFRASTRUCTURE THE
CLIMATE SAFE INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKING GROUP CREATED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN SUBMITTED IS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THE REPORT PROVIDED A
NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS TO
MAKE STATE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
INFRASTRUCTURE RESILIENT AND
SUSTAINABLE TO WITHSTAND A WIDE
RANGE OF CLIMATE IMPACTS
HOWEVER THEIR WORK IS JUST
BEGINNING THAT IS WHY THE SENSE
SUNSET DATE NEEDS TO BE REMOVED
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SEEN ON
ON THE FLOOR. WE HAVE SENATOR
MORLOCK REMOTELY CAN WE GO TO
CENTER MORLOCK. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT ALL RIGHT I HAD THE
CHANCE ON ON THIS PARTICULAR
BILL TO REVIEW THE CLIMATE SAFE
INFRASTRUCTURE WORKING GROUPS.
SEPTEMBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
EXECUTIVE SUMMER SUMMARY. THE
REPORT TITLED PAYING IT FORWARD
THE PATH TOWARD CLIMATE SAFE
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY PROVIDED TO
RECOMMENDATIONS BUT I DID NOT
SEE ONE THAT WARM HOW TO AVOID
ROLLING BLACKOUTS THE MAJORITY
OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS
EMPHASIZE MORE FUNDING. FIRST
SELF PERPETUATION AND I WANT TO
I WOULDN'T VISION AND HONESTLY
NOT A CHEERLEADING SQUAD. BUT
IN TRYING TO ASSESS THE VALUE
TO THE TAXPAYERS OF THIS BRAIN
TRUST TEN DIRECTIVES WITH
PLATITUDES AND EUPHEMISMS
DOESN'T SEEM LIKE AN
UNNECESSARY EXERCISE. IF THEY
HAD A CHECK IN THE WIN COLUMN.
I MIGHT BE PLEASE BUT BECAUSE
THE FORESIGHT LONG TERM
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING SEEMS
TO BE LACKING- I YEAH I JUST
DIDN'T SEE IT SO I'M I'M-
CONCERNED ABOUT SPENDING MORE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS IN THIS REGARD
CONSEQUENTLY I'LL BE A NO VOTE
O A B. TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU IN ADDITION INSCRIPTION AND
A VERY. SENATOR DOLLAR. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO JUST MAKE A
COMMENT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE
FOR TWENTY YEARS AND YOU KNOW
WE HAVE BURNING THE HECK UP.
I'VE BEEN I CAME TO THE
LEGISLATURE IN TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE AND START TALKING ABOUT.
THIS IS BEFORE THE MEGA FIRES
THAT WE'VE SEEN. TALKING ABOUT
MET A VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THE STATE. WE
TALK WE TALK A LOT ABOUT. YOU
KNOW FINDING IN AND THE A. R.
B. DOING NASCENT TRACK.
REGULATIONS FOR THAT. BUT YOU
KNOW WE HAD A PLAN FARMERS
DON'T PLANT SEEDS IN THE- WRONG
TIME OF YEAR THEY PLAN- SO THEY
CAN HARVEST A MINUTE RIGHT
TIME. I THINK WHAT THE FOCUS
NEEDS TO BE IS NOT SO MUCH ON.
YOU KNOW. THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BUT WHERE ARE WE GOING. WHAT
WHAT IS THE OUTCOME WHAT ARE WE
DOING TO CURB THESE MASSIVE
FIRES OTHER THAN. TALKING ABOUT
YOU KNOW BATTERIES N. AND WE
HAVE ROLLING BLACKOUTS BECAUSE
WE FOCUSED ON. THE FACT THAT
WE'RE GOINGTO. CLOSE DOWN
NATURAL GAS PLANTS. IN IT YOU
KNOW AT THE END OF THE DAY THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT THE AND
THE- WORK IT ACTUALLY NEEDS TO
BE DONE ON THE GROUND IS
SOMETHING WE SHOULD FOCUS ON.
AND I THINK THAT THAT WE'VE
BEEN JUST MISGUIDED FOR TWENTY
YEARS OF WHERE WERE THE
PRIORITY. IS TO SPEND THE MONEY
AND WHICH IS THE BIGGEST.
OUTPUT OF CARBON. FOREST FIRE
NUMBER ONE BY FAR WORSE
EVERYTHING ELSE. BUT NO WE KEEP
CONTINUE TO. PUT MONEY INTO
TRAINS WE KEEP CONTINUE TO PUT
MONEY INTO. SOLAR WHICH WHICH
WE HAVE TOO MUCH OF IT AT THE
ROCK WRONG TIMES A DAY. I THINK
WE JUST NEED TO DO SOME
PLANNING SOME SERIOUS LIKE HEY
WHAT IS IT WHAT IS THE FUTURE
LOOK LIKE. AND WHAT WE DO IS WE
JUST KEEP TAXING PEOPLE.
RUNNING BUSINESSES OUT OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE'RE WE'RE
GETTING MORE OF THE SAME SO FOR
THOSE REASONS. I OPPOSE THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AS WELL.
THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. HERE IN JINAN
SOONER COPIER WHICH OUGHT TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS THANK
YOU FOR OUR SEARCH CENTER
PROBABLY AREN'T WE HAVE. CENTER
BAIT SHE WANTS TO COMMENT ON
THIS ISSUE SENATOR BATES.
SURVEY TERM YOU. YEAH I AM I AM
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS I HAVE
SUPPORTED ON MANY OF THE
CLIMATE CHANGE- BILLS
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE OF WHAT WE
SEE IN OUR COASTAL COMMUNITIES
OF C. RICE BUT I'M HOPING THAT
THE INFRASTRUCTURE WORKING
GROUP WILL HAVE SOME INFLUENCE
ON THE COASTAL COMMISSION WHO
HAVE ADOPTED A MANAGED RETREAT
OUR PHILOSOPHY AND WITH THAT WE
ARE SEEING ALONG OUR COAST
STRETCHING THROUGH ORANGE
COUNTY AND SAN DIEGO CRUMBLING
OF EROSION CRUMBLING OUR- OUR-
ONTO OUR BEACHES SAW LIVES WERE
LOST IN ENCINITAS IN MY
DISTRICT AND- WE HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO GET THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THAT WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
WELL WE NEED SOME REMEDY TO
ENSURE THAT OUR BLESSED WILL
STAY STABLE WE WILL HAVE SAND
ON THE BEACH EVEN WITH THE RISE
AND THEY HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE INCLUDING OUR
HIGHWAYS CLOSED HIGHWAY OR REAL
LINES ARE THOSE THAT READ TO
JOHN MAHER WILL BE PROTECTED SO
I SUPPORT THEIR SENTENCE
MICHAEL BADLY INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKING GROUP WILL START TAKING
A LOOK AT. WHAT IS GOING ON
NOW- WE SOME OF THESE POLICIES
THAT REALLY PUT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND CERTAINLY OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND GREAT RISK
AS. WE DO SEE ALL THE RISING
SEA. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
ADDITIONAL HANDS UP REMARKS
APPEAR OR REMOTELY CENTER W. OR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT AND
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FROM
ALL OVER THE STATE REALLY- THIS.
IS A SUNSET AND THERE'S NO
QUESTION THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
CONTINUES TO PLAGUE OUR WORLD
AND WE NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT
WHAT WE CAN DO TO MAKE SURE
THAT OUR INFRASTRUCTURE. IS
RESILIENT IT INCLUDES FOUR
ENGINEER SIGN ARCHITECTS. AND
EXPERTS WITH EXPERTISE- IN IN
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING AND-
MAYBE THE NEXT BILL THAT WE
SHOULD DO SHOULD BE TO INCLUDE
SOME OF THE ISSUES THAT WERE
RAISED- THAT ARE ABSOLUTELY IN
IMPERATIVE WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO STRENGTHEN OUR
ENERGY- GREAT WE'VE GOT TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT KIND OF. OF A
LAND MANAGEMENT CHANGES THAT WE
NEED TO MAKE IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THE VIRULENCE OF THESE FIRES
THERE'S ABSOLUTELY NO QUESTION
BUT TODAY THE BILL ALL IT DOES
IS- IT COULD TAKE OUT. OR
ELIMINATE THE SUNSET AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON A B. TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I AT KINS I FELL. BRADFORD I
COULD BUY A FIVE DOT. HI DURAZO
HI KALYANI HI GLAZER GONZALEZ
FIVE HURTS BERG. HI PHIL I WAS
SO HI HER TADO. HI LLEVA I
REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL. HI MY
NAME I NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
FOURTEEN TINA. FIVE ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERN.
NUMBER HI HI WACO SKI FIVE
WINNER. HI. SECATEURS CAN WE
NOW GO TO A REMOTE VOTING
SENATORS ON ITEM FORTY ONE AV
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED. BASICS
ACV TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED HIGH
BASE HI FORTUS OR JUST BABY
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED NO FOR
JUST NO CHANG THANK A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED I SANG HI
SALLY. DAWALY A. B. TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED NO DALLY NO. ROVE
GROSS AT TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
NO GROVE NO MELINDA'S WHEN
THERE'S A B. TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. K. B. TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
A. B. TWENTY HUNDRED NO MORALE
NO WELL. WE'LL AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED HI WELL HI. NIELSEN NO.
SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES TO CALL.
NOW MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM.
FORTY TWO. AV. THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX SENATOR MINING HE IS
PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY YOU
MAY RE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORREO AN ACT
RELATING TO FOOD IN FLORIDA
YOURS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY
SIX PROVIDES BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AGAINST FOOD
CONTAMINATION FROM READY TO EAT
DELIVERY SERVICES BY
ESTABLISHING PRINCIPLE
SAFEGUARDS. A. B. THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX PROTECTS THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH BY ENSURING
THAT READY TO EAT FOOD IS NOT
TAMPERED WITH THE NO BREAK SEAL
OR OTHER METHOD OF CLOSURE AND
IS DELIVERED BEFORE IT CAN
BECOME SPOILED. READY TO EAT
FOOD DELIVERY DRIVERS AND
RESTAURANT WORKERS HAVE BECOME
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AMID COVERT
NINETEEN AND THEY RISK THEIR
LIVES EVERY DAY TO FEED
CALIFORNIANS THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY LOCAL HEALTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND RESTAURANT
FACILITIES THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION. URGED
HERE I VOTE THANK YOU. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE I SEE
SENATOR MELINDA US. WE HAVE
CENTER MELINDA'S. THERE WE GO
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN I AM SPEAKING IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL ARE YOU
KNOW. PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
DELIVERING FOOD TO CONSUMERS
FOR A VERY LONG TIME AND WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY PROBLEM SADLY
BECAUSE OF CODE RED NOW- THERE
IS THIS PROBLEM WITH FOOD BEING
TAMPERED WITH OR I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE BUT THIS
IS THIS IS A SOLUTION IN SEARCH
OF A PROBLEM AS FAR AS I CAN
TELL BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T. EVEN
HAD ANY PROBLEMS IN FACT THE
OTHER COULDN'T EVEN REALLY
POINT ANY OUT WHERE SOMEONE WAS
BEING HARMED BECAUSE OF FOOD
THAT WAS TAMPERED WITH THAT WAS
DELIVERED TO THEM SO I DON'T
KNOW THAT AT THIS. TIME
CONSIDERING RESTAURANTS ARE
LUCKY IF THEY'RE STILL
OPERATING IF THIS IS A TIME
WHERE WE NEED TO PUT MORE
BURDENS ON THEM I WILL ALSO
TELL YOU THAT- THERE ARE
BUSINESSES THAT ARE CURRENTLY
ACTUALLY ALREADY DOING THIS
WITHOUT THE HEAVY HAND OF
GOVERNMENT COMING IN AND
TELLING THEM THAT THEY MUST DO
IT. THERE'S SOME PERHAPS-
BECAUSE OF THEIR CUSTOMERS
ASKING FOR IT THEY HAVE CHOSEN
TO PUT THESE MEASURES IN PLACE
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THE
GOVERNMENT NEEDS TO STEP DOWN
AS FAR AS I CAN TELL I HAVEN'T
SEEN WHAT MAJOR PROBLEM THERE
IS TO. RESUSCITATE THIS BILL SO
I WOULD ASK FOR NOW BUT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. DR BEN. THANK YOU AND-
MATT OF MR PRESIDENT- CENTERS I
JUST AS A POINT OF FACT
ACTUALLY- SO I MENTIONED THAT
WE HAVE THREE MILLION CASES OF-
ILLNESSES EACH YEAR FROM FOOD
POISONING NOW NOT ALL THAT SOME
DELIVERY BUT I WOULD SAY THAT'S
NOT AN INSIGNIFICANT PROBLEM.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE INSPECTORS
THAT'S WHY THEY WANT- THIS-
LEGISLATION AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE PROTECT THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA FROM
SOMETHING THAT'S ACTUALLY QUITE
PREVALENT UNFORTUNATELY- NOT
ONLY IN OUR STATE BUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY I OR TONIGHT BUT
THANK YOU. THANK SENTOR PAN
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. EARNING
CHAIN NINE CENTER MINING YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I WOULD JUST
COMMENT ON THE CONCERNS THAT
WERE RAISED. THIS MEASURE
ACTUALLY PROTECTS RESTAURANT
OWNERS AS WELL AS DRIVERS FROM
POTENTIAL LIABILITY IT'S WHY
THE RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION HAS
BEEN ENGAGED IN THERE'S NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION- I WOULD
URGE YOU NOT TO VOTE. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. WELL BRADFORD I HAVE
ITEM I DON. HI THE RUSSELL I
CALLED ANI FIVE LASER. GONZALEZ
I HURTS BERG. HELLO I WAS SO.
BY HER TADO HI JACKSON I LABOR.
HI WIRE FIVE MITCHELL. HI
MORNING FIVE NIELSEN. NO HAN
I'VE FOURTEEN TINA. HI ROB. I
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN.
AMBERG I WACO SKI FIVE WINNER I.
ZURCHER CAN YOU CALL OUR REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS AT THIS TIME ON
AN- ITEM. FORTY TWO A. B.
THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX. BATES
AB THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX NO.
EIGHT NOW FOR JUST. WE'RE JUST
A BABY THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX
NOW FOR JUST NO CHANG. THANK A.
B. THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX HI
JANE HI DALLI. DALLI AB THIRTY
THREE THIRTY SIX ABSTAIN.
GROWTH. ABC THIRTY THREE THIRTY
SIX NOW GROVE NO MELINDA'S BUT
WHEN THERE'S A B. THIRTY THREE
THIRTY SIX NO MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. WE'RE LIKE A BEACH THREE
THREE THREE SIX ABSTAIN. MORO.
WELL EIGHTY THREE THREE THREE
SIX NOW MORALE NO WILKE. WILL
AT THIRTY THREE THIRTY SIX HI.
WELCOME HI. SURE MONEY MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS WERE NOW MOVING
ON TO FALL I DON'T FORTY THREE.
AV. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY BY DR
QUIRK GENERALITY PREPARED FOR
THAT MATTER. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATING TO WATER QUALITY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
THAT THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
STATE WATER BOARD OPPOSED THE
PROPOSED NOTIFICATION LEVEL AND
PROPOSED RESPONSE LEVEL ON
THEIR WEBSITE- WELL THE
NOTIFICATION I WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR NOT REGULATORY STANDARDS
THEY DO HAVE IMPACTS FOR WATER
AGENCIES ONCE OR SAD. THE BILL
ALSO ADDS GREATER TRANSPARENCY
IN THE WATER BOARD'S PROCESS
AND GETTING THESE DRINKING
WATER LEVELS IN ORDER FOR
AGENCIES TO BETTER INFORM THEIR
pOPPOSITION DEVELOP. RESPECT
RESTAURANT. TAKING ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
HEARING CHAIN NINE MEMBERS THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ON
CALL ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THAT AT THIS
TIME. HEARING SAYING ON. THE
MEASURES ON CALL. MEMBERS WERE
NOW MOVING ON TO ITEM. FORTY
FOUR. SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT. AV TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY MEMORY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CORIO AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILD SUPPORT. THE
FLOOR IS YOURS SENATOR. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT SORRY FOR THE
DELAY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF A
FAMILY MEMBER CORREO. AT TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE SUSPENSI
PARENTS OBLIGATIONS TO PAY
CHILD SUPPORT WHILE
INCARCERATED OR INVOLUNTARILY
HELD IN AN INSTITUTION FOR MORE
THAN NINETY DAYS UNLESS THE
PARENT HAS THE MEANS TO PAY
THIS BILL IS VITAL TO ENSURE
INCARCERATED PARENTS HAVE
SUCCESSFUL REENTRY AND
REUNIFICATION WITH THEIR
CHILDREN WITHOUT THIS BILL
PARENTS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO GET
BACK ON THEIR FEET AND PROVIDE
THE PROPER SUPPORT AND PAYMENTS
TO THE CHILDREN. WHICH THEY
WILL NEED THE BILL PASSED IN
THE SENATE COMMITTEE WITH
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IDOL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
DESCRIPTION OF A ON THE SIDE
OF. CENTER WHERE COFFEE. I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND JUDICIARY
I DID POINT OUT THAT. FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCARCERATED FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE THEY DO NOT
GET THIS A SUSPENSION OF THEIR
PAYMENTS AND IT'S ONE OF THESE
THINGS PEOPLE LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT BUT- IN VIOLENCE AGAINST
ANYBODY IS NOT TO BE CONDONED
HERE BUT IT'S ONE OF THE THINGS
I'LL BE GOING UP ON THE- ON THE
BILL I URGE ADVOCATES IN THIS
ARENA WHO ARE LOOKING. AT THE
CHALLENGES THE PEOPLE HAVE
THERE ARE TWO CARS FOR YOU TO
GO BACK IN AND DO A FOLLOW UP
BILL FOR THAT WE WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NEVER GOING IN COURAGE
PEOPLE TO BEAT UP THEIR
NEIGHBOR BEAT UP THEIR SPOUSE
OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT BUT- I'M-
I THINK IT NEEDS MORE ATTENTION
IN THIS AREA. I STILL OR SHOULD
I VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS ON THIS I DON'T.
FIFTY NINE SENATOR RUBIO TAUGHT
CLOSE. THANK YOU I JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON A B.
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE. KNOWS
THE CHECK IN WITH A CHECK ON
THE. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I FELT. BRADFORD ON FIVE
BY ADAM. DOT HI THE RISER. I
GOT JOHNNY. GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG I STILL HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON. JACKSON
HI LLEVA I REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL
FIVE MINING. HI NIELSEN. HI PAM.
HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH. FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN.
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY. WHITE HOUSE
K. FIVE WINNER. FIVE MA'AM
SECTOR CAN WE NOW CALL OUR
REMOTE VOTING SENATORS ON A-
ITEM TWENTY TWELVE ITEM FORTY
FOUR A. B. TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FIVE. FAITH EIGHT ABC TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE ON FAITH HI
GORGEOUS. FORGES AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE I LIVE FOR
JUST FIVE. CHANG CHANG AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE I.
TRYING HI DALLI DALLI AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE HI SALLY I
GROW. ABC TWENTY THREE AT
TWENTY FIVE I DROVE HI.
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE NOW MELINDA'S
NO MORE LOCK. A. B. TWO THREE
TWO FIVE HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
MAYBE TWENTY THREE TWENTY FIVE
OF ST. WELL. IT WILKE AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FIVE I WILL HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL NEXT UP IS
FALL ITEM FORTY FIVE AV ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR SENATOR PORN TEEN
ARE YOU PREPARED FOR THIS ITEM.
HE IS MADAM SECRETARY YOU EVERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MAIN
SHINE AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
CARE SERVICE PLANS IN FLOOR
GEORGE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A
B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR WHICH
REPRESENTS AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO CONTAIN
SKYROCKETING HEALTH CARE COSTS
EMPLOYERS TO PROVIDE HEALTH
CARE BENEFITS TO THEIR
EMPLOYEES STRUGGLE TO CONTAIN
THEIR COSTS. AND OBTAIN THE
BEST QUALITY OF CARE AT THE
SAME TIME THE BILL THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE TWO PILOT
PROGRAMS THAT WOULD INCLUDE
BRIDGE BEARING PROVIDERS THAT
ARE MONITORED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTH CARE FOR
FINANCIAL SOLVENCY AND
OPERATIONS SELF FUNDED EMPLOYER
PLANS WOULD USE RISK BASED. AIM
AT MARK MECHANISMS WITH HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS FOR THEIR
SERVICE. RATHER THAN THE PURE
FEE FOR SERVICE. COMPENSATION A
STUDY BY UC BERKELEY SCHOOL OF
PUBLIC HEALTH PREDICTED THAT
THIS TYPE OF MODEL. COULD
REDUCE HEALTH CARE EXPENDITURES
BY AN ESTIMATED A HUNDRED AND
TEN BILLION DOLLARS OVER TEN
YEARS. COMBATING THE RISING
COSTS OF HEALTH CARE REQUIRES A
NEW WAY OF THINKING THE PILOT
PROJECT AUTHORIZED BY THIS BILL
CAN CHANGE THE WAY WE APPROACH
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY. A SIMILAR
BILL TO THIS PAST OFF THE FLOOR
LAST YEAR WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. BUT WAS VETOED BY THE
GOVERNOR SINCE THEN THE AUTHORS
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF ADMINISTRATION TO
ADDRESS CONCERNS HOW
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I WILL.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM. SEE NO
MIKE'S UP ON THE FLOOR. SEEING
REMOTE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FELL.
BRADFORD MICROBIOTA HI DOUG HI
DURAZO. I GOT JOHNNY. FIVE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE KURTZ
BERG. HI HELLO I WAS SO. HI HER
TADO. HI JACKSON HI LLEVA. HI
WIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME.
HI NIELSEN. NO HAND HI FORTUNE
TINO HI HI RALPH HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI STERN AMBERG HI
WACO SKI HI WINNER. HI. I'M
SECTOR NOW WE'RE GONNA GO TO A
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS ON FILE I
AM FORTY FIVE AV. ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR. BASICS H. A. B. O. LEVIN
TWENTY FOUR OF ST. GORGEOUS
ORDERS MAY BE ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR I'M STAYING. CHANG. TANG
AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR NOW CHANG
NO DALLY. GOLLY AB ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR A STATE. GROSS.
GROSSING AB ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
NO GROVE NO MELINDA'S. WHEN
DOES A. B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR
AM STAYING. MORLOCK WARLORD G.
B. ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR NO MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. AND MORALE AT
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR YEAH. MORALE
NO WELL. WELL AT ELEVEN TWENTY
FOUR NO WILKE NO REMOVE THE
CALL NEXT UP IS FALLING FORTY
SEVEN BUT I DON'T SEE SENATOR
MCGUIRE. WE WILL CRASH
TEMPORARILY MOVE ON TO FALL
ITEM FORTY EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO
SHE IS PREPARED MANNEQUIN ERA
SECRETARY CAN YOU READ THE
FOLLOWING FORTY EIGHT. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC UTILITIES.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR GEORGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AT TWO SEVEN EIGHT WITH
FURTHER WHICH FURTHER PROTECTS
THE ENERGY GAS CONSUMPTION DATA
OF CALIFORNIANS WHO NOW MORE
THAN EVER DESERVE TO FEEL SAFE
AT HOME USING THE ESSENTIAL
ENERGY SERVICES PROVIDED BY
UTILITIES THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT'S TO OBTAIN A COURT
ORDER SUBPOENA. OR JUDICIAL
WARRANT AS PART OF THEIR DATA
REQUEST FREE FOR UTILITIES
INVESTIGATIONS BY THE ACLU
FOUND THAT ICE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS HAS
SUCCESSFULLY REQUESTED AND
OBTAINED OVER FOUR THOUSAND
RECORDS FROM UTILITIES THESE
DATA REQUESTS ARE SUBMITTED AND
FULFILLED WITHOUT ANY
ADDITIONAL REVIEW. MAKE NO
MISTAKE THE DATA GENERATED FROM
SMART METERS IS INCREDIBLY
SENSITIVE ACCESS TO THIS
INFORMATION REVEALS A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN THE HOUSEHOLD AND
TRENDS THAT CAN EXPOSE THE
DAILY MOVEMENTS WITHIN A HOME
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT IS
SUPPORTED BY IMMIGRATION RIGHTS
GROUPS REPAIR ADVOCATES AND HAS
RECEIVED NO VOTES AND NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
UNCLE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENIOR HEARING NAINA
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MAYBE TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS I FELL. BRADFORD I KERR
BY ADAM I DON. HI THE RUSSELL.
HI GIRL JOHNNY HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HERZ BERG HI HELLO
HI WITH SO. I HER TADO FIVE
JACKSON. I LABOR I REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL FIVE MINING. HI
NIELSEN I CAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO.
I. ROSS FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER
HI STERN NUMBER. HI MY CASKEY
FIVE WINNER HI. TEMPERATURES
CAN WE NOW CALL AREN'T REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT IT'S. R. A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT.
BASICS BASICALLY TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT I'M SAYING.
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS ABC TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT STAYING.
CHANG THANK A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT EXANE. DALLI DALLI
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
ABSTAIN. GROW. CENTER GROVE
YOU'RE MUTED I'M SORRY GROSS AT
AB SH TWENTY SEVEN I'M SORRY
CAN YOU TO FILE ITEM I WAS
WORKING ON SOMETHING I
APOLOGIZE. FOR MORE THAN TWENTY
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN MEATBALL
ITEM. FORTY EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT. FIRELIGHT I'M.
FORTY EIGHT EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT ABSTAIN B.
MELINDA'S. EIGHT NO WHEN
THERE'S A B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT OF STAIN. MORLOCK
K. B. TWO SEVEN EIGHT EIGHT
ABSTAIN. MORALE. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY EIGHT OF STAYING. WELL
FROM. ABC. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT HI WELCOME HI. J. REMOVE
THE CALL NOW WE'RE GONNA GO
BACK TO FOLLOWING FORTY
CHAUVINIST REQUIRES AND REQUIRE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT THAT I
DON'T. FANCY TEMPORARY AGAIN
OKAY MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
FORTY NINE. SENATOR ROS- SHE'S
PREPARED A V. TWENTY ONE OLD
FOUR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
ROUTE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
OH FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AND ACTUALLY
RELATING TO HAZARDOUS WASTE.
SENATOR ROSE REPORTS GEORGE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN THE LEAD ACID
BATTERY CLEAN THE FUND WAS
SIGNED INTO LAW BY GOVERNOR
BROWN. THIS LAW. REALLOCATED A
FEE ALREADY IMPOSED ON ALL CAR
BATTERIES TO FUND THE CLEANUP
OF CONTAMINATION CAUSED BY LEAD
ACID BATTERIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE SINCE THE BILL WAS SIGNED
INTO LAW DEPARTMENT TOXIC
SUBSTANCE CONTROL HAS BEEN
WORKING ON REGULATIONS. TO
IMPLEMENT THE CLEAN UP. OF THE
CLEAN UP PROGRAM AND TECHNICAL
PROBLEMS WERE IDENTIFIED WITH
THE OVERSIGHT PROVISIONS. WILL
EXCITE IS ON THE EDGE OF MY
DISTRICT AND OTHER COMMUNITIES
WITH HISTORIC LEAD. ACID
BATTERY MANUFACTURING PLANTS
HAVE A GREAT NEED FOR ONGOING%
FUNDING AND TO ENSURE THE-
BTTERY FEE FUND THE MONEY CAN
ONLY BE USED FOR ITS INTENDED
PURPOSE. WE MUST ALSO ENSURE
THE FUND IS USABLE BY D. T. S.
C. A B. TWENTY ONE OH FOUR HAS
NO OPPOSITION. HAS RECEIVED NO
NO VOTES AND BIPARTISAN HAS
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
THE ADDITION DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE SIDE OF. SENIOR MIKES UP
HERE ON THE FLOOR. FINO HANDS
UP. REMOTELY MEMBERS THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ON CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS ON
CALL ROLL CALL FOR THIS MEASURE.
SENIOR NINE MEASURES ON CALL.
CAN ACCEPT THIS FALL ITEM FIFTY
SENATOR SKINNER YOU PREPARE TO
PRESENT FIVE FOLLOW FIFTY AV
SEVEN NINE THREE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN ACT
RELATING TO RECYCLING THANK YOU
SO MUCH MEMBERS. EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE CENTS A MINIMUM
CONTENT STANDARD FOR RECYCLED
CONTENT OF PLASTICS THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT BILL IT WILL GREATLY
BENEFIT THE PLASTIC
MANUFACTURERS IN CALIFORNIA
MOST OF WHOM ARE EQUIPPED AND
PREPARED TO HAVE A HIGH MINIMUM
CONTENT BUT BECAUSE WE DON'T
REQUIRE IT IT PUTS THEM AT A
COMPETITIVE DISADVANTAGE TO
OTHERS. SO IT'S IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTALLY ECONOMICALLY
AND THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AND I
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM I SEEN ON
THE FLOOR SHANE NINE REMOTELY.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON AV. SEVEN NINE THREE.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD I HAVE A HI TODD.
HI DURAZO. HI CAROL CHANNING HI.
IN SOLACE. HI HURTS BERG I TELL.
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO. HI
JACKSON. HI LLEVA I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL HI MY NAME FIVE
NIELSEN. I CAN HI FORTUNE TINO
HI HI RALPH. HI RUBIO HI
SKINNER HI STERN NUMBER NINE HI
WACO SKI HI WINNER HI. THANK
YOU CAN YOU NOW GO TO OUR
REMOTE VOTING SENATORS ON FILE
ITEM FIFTY EIGHT V. SEVEN NINE
THREE. FAITH BASED AB. SEVEN
NINE THREE I'D BATES HI
GORGEOUS. ORDERS EIGHTY SEVEN
NINE THREE NOW FOR JUST NOW
CHANG. THANK A. B. SEVEN NINE
THREE I'D HANG ON A DAILY.
SENATOR ALL YOU'RE ON MUTE OUT
GALLEY EIGHT. DALLY AB SEVEN
NINE THREE HI SALLY HIGH GROWTH.
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY THREE I
GROVE HI MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
AB SEVEN NINE THREE I.
MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. MORE LIKE
EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY THREE I.
WARLOCK BY MORALE. EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY THREE I. MORALE HI.
BOROUGH NEED YOU TO STATE YOUR
NAME CENTER TOMORROW I'M SORRY.
I THOUGHT I DIDN'T BEGINNING
MORALE ABC SEVEN NINE THREE.
HIGH MORALE HI. WELK WELL
EIGHTY SEVEN NINE THREE HI
WELCOME HI. CENTER MOVES A CALL.
MOVING ON NOW TO FOLLOW ALL
RIGHT TOMB. FIFTY TWO. SENATOR
GONZALES SHE'S READY MADAM
SECRETARY WHEN YOU READ A V.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
KALRA AN ACT RELATING TO
EMPLOYMENT. SENATOR THEMSELVES
FLANDERS THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIVE EIGHT
EIGHT ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA. AB TWENTY
FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT WILL PROHIBIT
HEALTHCARE EMPLOYERS FROM
CONTINUING THE UNETHICAL
PRACTICE OF MAKING JOB
APPLICANTS PAY FOR EMPLOYER
MANDATED TRAINING WITH THAT
TRAINING IS NECESSARY FOR THEM
TO DO THEIR JOB. LAW ALREADY
PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM MAKING
EMPLOYEES PAY FOR COSTS THAT
ARE NECESSARY FOR THE EMPLOYEE
TO DO THEIR JOB. THIS IS THE
SAME TYPE OF MANDATED TRAINING
THAT AN EMPLOYER WOULD BE
REQUIRED TO PAY FOR AN EMPLOYEE
BUT BECAUSE OUR JOB APPLICANTS
AND NOT EMPLOYEES THESE ARE JOB
APPLICANTS AND EMPLOYEES THESE
EMPLOYERS HAVE TAKEN ADVANTAGE
OF THIS LOOPHOLE. HOLDING
WORKERS AND JOB APPLICANTS
FINANCIALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
EMPLOYER REQUIRED TRAININGS
TO EMPLOYMENT. AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT SIMPLY CLARIFIES
EXISTING LAW TO ENSURE EMPLOYER
MANDATED TRAININGS AND PROGRAMS
ARE COVERED. BY THE EMPLOYER
AND EXTEND THE SAME PROTECTIONS
TO DIRECT PATIENT CARE JOB
APPLICANTS. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT. THANK YOU IN ADDITION
DISCUSSION. ON THE SIDE OF THE
FLOOR SENIOR MICROPHONES. WE
HAVE CENTER GROVE REMOTELY.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
EMPLOYER MANDATED TRAININGS ARE
MANDATED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IF YOU THINK
EMPLOYERS WANT TO IMPOSE ALL OF
THESE RIDICULOUS TRAININGS AND
RIDICULOUS- SCHEDULE TRAINING
PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE TO OUR EMPLOYEES- WE
DON'T TRUST ME I DON'T KNOW ANY
EMPLOYER THAT DOESN'T THAT THAT
AND I DON'T KNOW ANY EMPLOYER
THAT DOESN'T AGREE WITH THAT
STATEMENT. WE IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
EMPLOYER MANDATED TRAINING AND-
NOW PAY FOR EXTENDED LICENSE
SEEN EXTENDED- SO IF YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR AN ELECTRICIAN AND
I REALIZE THAT THIS JUST HAS TO
IT HAS TO DO WITH HOSPITALS BUT
YOU PAY FOR THE ADDITIONAL
LICENSING WHEN THEY'RE ONLY AN
APPLICANT. SO THIS PERSON CAN
STILL APPLY YOU'RE REQUIRED TO
PAY FOR THAT LICENSE YOU DIDN'T
THEY DON'T TAKE THE JOB THAT
YOU OFFERED THAT'S AN
ADDITIONAL EXPENSE SO TO
REQUIRE AN EMPLOYER TO PAY FOR
A LICENSE WHEN THE EMPLOYEE IS
ONLY THE EMPLOYEES NOT EMPLOYEE
IT'S AN AFRICAN THERE AN
APPLICANT. SO FIFTY APPLICANTS
COME TO APPLY AND FIFTY
LICENSES HAVE TO BE ACQUIRED BY
THE EMPLOYER AND PAID FOR BY
THE EMPLOYER BEFORE A JOB OFFER
IS EVEN MADE OR ACCEPTED- I
THINK THIS IS JUST ANOTHER-
BURDEN ON EMPLOYERS- WHEN THEY
DON'T EVEN HAVE THE ABILITY TO
REAP THE BENEFITS OF HIRING AN
EMPLOYEE WITH A LICENSETHAT
THEY PAID FOR. AD BECAUSE AN
OFFER HASN'T EVEN BEEN MADE AND
THE EMPLOYEE HASN'T EVEN
ACCEPTED. IT'S POTENTIALLY JUST
BECAUSE THEY'RE AN APPLE KIDS
FOR A BUSY. ON MY WRIST ASK FOR
A NO VOTE. THANK ANY IDEA DISK
AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. TURN
CENA NO ADDITIONAL HANDS ARE MY
CLOSE UP SENATOR GONZALES WHICH
ALLOWED TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT DOES NOT INCLUDE
REQUIREMENTS FOR LICENSING
REGISTRATION OR CERTIFICATION
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO LEGALLY
PRACTICE IN THE SPECIFIC WORK
AREA AND IT DOES NOT INCLUDE
TRAINING OR EDUCATION
VOLUNTARILY TAKEN AT THE WORKER
OR JOB APPLICANTS DISCRETION-
AND FOR THOSE REASONS AND MORE-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MICHAEL.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA FIVE ATKINS. WELL
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI TODD. THE
RISER I GOT JOHNNY. I BLAZER
AND- I HURTS BERG HI HELLO. HI
WITH SO. HER TADO. FIVE JACKSON
FIVE LLEVA I REQUIRE FIVE
MITCHELL. FIVE MONEY I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN. BY HAND. BY FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO. HI
SKINNER. FIVE STERN AMBERG HI
WACO SKI FIVE WINNER. HI WE
SELL FIVE. DOT. FIVE NIELSEN I
DIDN'T KNOW. MMHM SECTOR CAN
YOU KNOW GO TO A REMOTE VOTING
SENATORS ON FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO
AV. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT.
FACE HEY IT'S AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT NO BABIES NO
BORDERS. PORGES AB TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT NOW FOR JUST NO
CHANG. HEY MAYBE TWENTY FIVE
EIGHTY EIGHT NO CHANGE NO DALLY.
DOLLY AT TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT NO DALLY NO GROWTH. THE
EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT
NO GROWTH NO MELINDA'S. AND
IT'S A B. TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE
LOCK. WHAT GAVE ME TWO FIVE
EIGHT EIGHT NO MORE LOCK NO
MORAL. WELL EIGHTY TWO FIVE
EIGHT EIGHT NOW MORALE NO WELL.
WELL EIGHTY TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
EIGHT NO WELL NOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR MOVES A CALL. WE WILL
NOW TO FILE ITEM FIFTY THREE
CENTER ON BURGER YOU PREPARED
HE IS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE AN
ACT RELATING TO MOBILE HOMES.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR GEORGE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I RISE TO PRESENT AT TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STONE- AS YOU
KNOW MOBILE HOME RESIDENTS ARE
PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
POSITION PARTICULARLY DURING
THE CALL THE CRISIS- AB TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY TWO REQUIRES PARK
MANAGEMENT TO GIVE HOMEOWNERS
AT LEAST SIXTY DAYS CURRENTLY
FIFTEEN DAYS IS THE SPORT
STANDARD. WRITTEN NOTICE THAT
MANAGEMENT WILL BE APPEARING
BEFORE LOCAL GOVERNMENT BOARD
COMMISSIONER BODY TO ATTEMPT TO
OBTAIN LOCAL APPROVAL FOR
INTENDED CHANGE OF USE OF THE
MOBILE HOME PARK. THIS BILL
CLARIFIES THE POWER OF LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO PROTECT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BY REQUIRING
A FINDING OF APPROVAL NOR TO
CONVERT PARKS THE CONTAIN LOW
INCOME AFFORDABLE MOBILE HOMES-
THIS BILL ALSO PROVIDES THAT
SHOULD BE- PARK BE CONVERTED
THAT THE RESIDENTS OF THE PARK
WOULD BE. ENTITLED TO
COMPENSATION. ABC TWENTY
SEVENTY TWO WOULD ALSO RESTORE
THE POWER OF LOCALS TO ENACT
LOCAL RENT STABILIZATION
ORDINANCES FOR RESIDENTS IN
OTHER WORDS. IT LEVELS THE
PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN MOBILE
HOME RESIDENTS AND THOSE THAT
LIVE IN STICK BUILT HOUSING- I
URGE YOUR BIBLE. THANK YOU
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS OR
DEBATES GOING ON ON THE FLOOR
SENATOR GIRL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL YOU KNOW A
PERSONAL STORY WE WERE IN AT
CURRENT COUNTY. WIN IN KERN
COUNTY- WE HAVE A MOBILE HOME
PARK THAT WAS- TAKING OVER AS
AN OPPORTUNITY ZONE BASICALLY
TYPE ENVIRONMENT TO AN
ENTERPRISE ZONE OR AT A PLACE
WHERE NEW INVESTORS WOULD COME
AND INVEST IN THIS AND IMPROVE
THE QUALITY OF LIFE OF
INDIVIDUALS THAT WERE THERE
INCLUDING ALL THE CHILDREN-
PREDOMINATELY THAT THE MOBILE
HOME PARK WAS- THAT TRADERS
WERE OCCUPIED BY INDIVIDUALS
THAT- DID NOT- DESIRE THAT TO
HAPPEN THEY WERE ACTUALLY.
BREAKING THE LAW STEALING AND
SPLITTING- P. JEANNIE WIRES SO-
THEY HAD SPLICED THAT P. G.
NEAR THE POWER WIRES TO THE
POINT WHERE THREE OR FOUR
HOUSES WERE OPERATING ON ONE
PARTICULAR- UNIT. THEY HAD-
DAMAGED- SO MUCH OF THAT THE
MOBILE HOME PARK- PUT THE PART
OF THE POOL WAS FULL OF DEBRIS-
IT WAS JUST HORRIFIC AND EVERY
TIME THE OWNER TRIED TO GO IN
AND CLEAN IT UP HE WASN'T
ALLOWED TO DO SO AND IT OR IT
WHEN HE WAS ABLE TO IT WAS SAID
JUST A CONSIDERED A RE DONE.
THEY WOULD STILL ATTACKED THE
PARK AND- BECAUSE- DAMAGE TO
THE PARK AGAIN SO THEY ARE
FINALLY GAVE UP SOLD IT TO THE
NEW GUYS COME IN THINKING THEY
COULD CLEAN IT UP AND THEY RAN
INTO THE SAME PROBLEMS AND IT
MADE IT UNSAFE FOR ALL THE
CHILDREN THEIR CHILDREN OR
POINT PLANE AND DEBRIS PILES.
AND SO TO RESTRICT PEOPLE'S
ABILITY AND I'M NOT SAYING
EVERY MOBILE HOME PARK IS LIKE
THIS AT ALL IN ANY WAY SHAPE OR
FORM BUT TO RESTRICT AN OWNER'S
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO MAKE
CHANGES AND- AND IN A CHANGE OF
OWNERSHIP AND ALSO- YOU KNOW
HAVING TO GIVE THIS NOTICE
REQUIREMENT. I CAN'T EVEN
IMAGINE THE STRUGGLES OF HIS
OWNERSHIP HAD CONTACTED MY
OFFICE THAT WE TRIED TO WORK
THROUGH- WITH ED THE MOBILE
HOME PARK OF ORGANIZATION- TO
FIX AND IT WAS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE SO MONTHS AND MONTHS
HAD GONE BY BEFORE ANY
TRANSITION COULD. BE DONE WITH
THIS PARTICULAR MOBILE HOME SO
I THINK WE SHOULD. NOW IS JUST.
A AND YOU PASS THIS BILL IS
JUST TO. WAY RESTRICT PEOPLE
FROM MAKING A BETTER CLIMATE
FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE IN
ESPECIALLY IF YOU HAVE LOW-
SOCIO ECONOMIC DISADVANTAGE. OF
PARENTS THAT HAVE CHILDREN THAT
ARE IN THESE VERSES IN THESE
LOCAL HOME PARKS AND THE
ELDERLY AS WELL. SO I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. HEARING INSANE NINE
SENATOR UMBERG WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE- YES THANK YOU- I'M
SORRY TO HEAR THAT THAT IT
LEADS TO MORE MOBILE HOME PARK
THERE'S SOME FOLKS WHO ARE A
LAW ABIDING CITIZENS BUT
OVERWHELMINGLY THOSE WHO DO
LIVE IN MOBILE HOME PARKS ARE
SENIORS AND THEY ARE LAW
ABIDING- THIS BILL DOESN'T.
RESTRICT IN OWNERS ABILITY TO
CONVERT THE PARK IT SIMPLY
GIVES THE RESIDENTS MORE TIME
TO- ONE DEAL WITH THE LOCAL
AUTHORITY IN TERMS OF THE
CONVERSION INTO S. I THINK MOST
OF US KNOW MOBILE HOMES ARE NOT
REALLY MOBILE HOMES THEIR HOMES
THAT ARE MANUFACTURED THAT ARE.
THAT ARE OWNED ON A RENTAL
SPACE YOU CAN'T REALLY MOVE
THEM AND SO THEY'RE IN A UNIQUE
POSITION AND DO REQUIRE MORE
TIME. ORIGINAL VOTE. GREAT MMHM
SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE
ACTIONS. WELL BRADFORD ONLY
FIVE CABRERA FIVE DOT. HI
TORONTO I GOT JOHNNY FIVE LASER
GONZALEZ FIVE HURTS BERG. HELLO
FIVE WITH SO. HI HER TADO. I
JACKSON. FIVE LLEVA. I REQUIRE
HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. FIVE
NIELSEN NO CAN HI FOURTEEN TINA
FIVE ROTH. FIVE RUBIO I SKINNER
HI STERN. AMBERG HI BY CAL SKI
I WINNER. I. HOME SECURITY WE
NOW GO TO OUR REMOTE VOTING
MEMBERS ON FILE I'M FIFTY THREE
A. B. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO.
FAITH H. A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO NO BATES NO FOR JUST.
OR JUST GAVE ME TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO NOW FOR JUST NO
CHANG. THANK A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO NOW. CHANG NO DALLI
DALLI AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO NO ALLEY NO GROWTH. THE
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO
NO GROWTH NO MELINDA'S. THE
WIND IS A B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO NOW MELINDA'S NO
MORE LOCK. D. B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY TWO NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE WELL EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN
YOU KNOW. MORALE NO WELK. WELL
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWO NO
WELK NO. SINGER MOVED SOONER
MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON NOW. TO
FILE ITEM. FIFTY SIX. SENATOR
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED FOR
THAT ITEM SHE IS MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN BY A FAMILY
MEMBER TO AN ACTUAL RELATING TO
HEALTH AND CLICK CARE
FACILITIES THE NEW SCANNER
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
BOARD AND CARE HOMES AND OTHER
ADULTS SO RESIDENTIAL ARE
CENTRAL HOUSING FOR MANY
DISABLED FORMERLY HOMELESS AND
OTHER ADULTS HOWEVER WE ARE
LOSING SUCH FACILITIES AT AN
ALARMING RATE. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN HELPS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RETAIN SUCH
FACILITIES BY PROVIDING A SIX
MONTH NOTICE BEFORE CLOSURE
ENSURING THAT THERE'S A
RELOCATION PLAN FOR THE
RESIDENTS AND GIVING THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE FIRST RIGHT OF
REFUSAL TO PURCHASE SUCH
FACILITIES THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SEEN ON THE FLOOR. WE
HAVE SENATOR GROW REMOTELY SIR
GIRL. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BUT I'D LIKE TO REMIND ALL MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE AISLE THAT THE R. F. AND
THE RCF FEES ARE CLOSING
BECAUSE OF THE- DATE THAT WE'RE
LOSING OUT LIKE THE AUTHOR SAID
OR THE GYM FLOOR JACKIE SAID AT
AN ALARMING RATE IT'S BECAUSE
THE LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED
THREE YEARS AGO OR TWO YEARS
AGO- AND FOUR YEARS AGO IT WAS
A COMPLETE REVAMP. SO ALL OF
THESE FACILITIES THESE LIKE YOU
WOULD CONSIDER THEM SIXPENCE
FACILITIES OR FACILITIES THAT
WE'RE TAKING CARE OF OUR
ELDERLY AND THOSE ON FIXED
INCOMES THEY'RE CLOSING BECAUSE
OF THAT BILL PACKAGE THAT WENT
THROUGH THIS BUILDING AND- SO I
JUST WANT YOU TO RECOGNIZE
THAT. YOU KNOW WHEN BILLS
PASSED IF WE DON'T THINK ABOUT
THE RAMIFICATIONS OF
POTENTIALLY LEGISLATING PEOPLE
OUT OF BUSINESS- AND THEN
HAVING THE AFTERMATH OF HAVING
TO DEAL WITH ELDERLY AND IN
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE LOSING
THOSE CARE FACILITIES FOR THEIR
CARE AS THEY GET OLDER OR
THEY'RE DISABLED- WE SHOULDN'T
REALLY BE LOOKING AT THINGS
LIKE THAT- SO I ALTHOUGH I
SUPPORT THE BILL I'D LIKE TO
JUST REMIND EVERYBODY THAT.
YOUR POLICIES ARE WHAT CAUSED
THE SITUATION TO ATTACK
HAPPENED IN THE FIRST PLACE-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS IT'S BASED
ON THIS ITEM. HEARING SHEENA
AND SOONER. WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU URGENT I WROTE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I ACTON'S I FELL
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I
THOUGHT HI THE RUSSELL. I
CALLED JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER
GONZALEZ FIVE HURTS BERG. HELLO
I WISH SO. BY HER TADO FIVE
JACKSON. FIVE LATER HI WIRE I
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME HI NIELSEN
I PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. I.
ROSS. I RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN AMBERG I WAKE COUNTY HI
WINNER HI. ZURCHER CAN WE NOW
CALL A REMOTE MEMBERS FOR FIVE
IN FIFTY SIX A. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY SEVEN. FAITH H. A. B.
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN A
HIGH STAKES HI GORGEOUS.
PORCHES AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN HI FOR JUST BY CHANG.
TANG AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
SEVEN HI JANE HI DALLI DALLI AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN HI
DALLY HI GROWTH. GROVE AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN I
GROW BY MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S AB
WONDERS HI MORLOCK OR LIKE
EIGHTY TWO THREE SEVEN SEVEN HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE NO WAY ABC
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN HI
MORALE HI WILKE. ABC TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN HI WELK HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL NOW WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM FIFTY
EIGHT SENATOR RUBIO PAIRED.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT AV TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SERVAN TESTS AN
ACT RELATING TO EMERGENCY-SERVICES. SENATOR FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE AND TO PRESENT BILL TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ON BEHALF OF A
SEVENTY MEMBER SERVE ON TESTS
THERE IS EMERGENCIES CAN
OVERWHELM A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
AND DELAYS OF MERE MINUTES IN
RESPONDING TO A DISASTER MIGHT
MEAN THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
LIFE OR DEATH. TO MINIMIZE THE
RISK AND THE POTENTIAL LOSS OF
LIFE IT IS CRITICAL THAT LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WORK TOGETHER TO
ENSURE THEY ARE. READY AND
COORDINATE RESOURCES DURING A
DISASTER ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY WELL HOW
ACCOMPLISH THIS BY REQUIRING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND AGENCIES
TO WORK TOGETHER TO SHARE
LOGISTICAL RESOURCES SUCH AS
PARA TRANSIT VEHICLES DRIVERS
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT AND THE LIKES
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY. AND IN THE SENATE
THUS FAR COLLEAGUES ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU. HE ADDITIONAL
DESCRIPTION GREAT HERE ON THE
FLOOR. SENIOR IN NINE WE'RE
MOVING TO CENTER GROVE REMOTELY.
I AM THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
ALL OF YOU KNOW AND I THINK YOU
FOR THE COMMENTS THAT YOU SENT
ME ON MY TEXT MESSAGES- WHEN WE
HAVE THOSE EARTHQUAKES-
HAPPENING IN RIDGECREST IN THE
RIDGECREST AREA YOU KNOW WHAT
WAS REALLY INTERESTING TO SEE
IS THAT EVEN BEFORE THIS A
PIECE OF LEGISLATION HAD PASSED
THE COUNTIES. AROUND THAT AREA
HAD WORKED TOGETHER- IT AND
TRUTHFULLY FROM ALL OVER THE
STATE TO COME TO THE RESCUE OF
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT WERE
TAKING PLACE IN RIDGECREST WITH
MAGNITUDE MAGNITUDE SIX POINT-
YOU KNOW PLUS EARTHQUAKE AT
SEVERAL OF THEM IN A ROW AND SO
I JUST- I APPLAUD THE LAUGHTER
FOR BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD
IT WAS REALLY GREAT THAT- WE
DIDN'T NEED IT THAT PEOPLE
AUTOMATICALLY AT THE GOODNESS
OF THEIR HEART AND COUNTY
SHARED RESOURCES AMBULANCES. TO
TRANSPORT PEOPLE OUT OF THE
HOSPITAL AND FROM DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND THINGS LIKE THAT A
HELICOPTER WAS EVEN PROVIDED
FROM A DIFFERENT COUNTY AND SO-
WE NEED IT BUT IT IS IT THAT
JUST SHOWS GOOD CHARACTER OF
INDIVIDUALS AND PEOPLE THAT ARE
WILLING TO HELP AND BUT THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WOULD
ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN ON A MORE
NATURAL BASIS SO I SUPPORT THE
LEGISLATION AND APPLY THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS. QUESTIONS OR DEBATE
ON THE SIDE OF. HEARING AND
SEEING NINE TO REVEAL WHICH
ALLOWED TO CLOSE. JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUTPUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY. THIS ITEM IS.
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ON CALL
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL.
SENIOR NO OBJECTION THE
MEASURES ON CALL THANK YOU.
WELL TO FILE ITEM FIFTY NINE
ABC TWENTY TWO THIRTEEN
SURJECTION SHE IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LET
ALONE AN ACT RELATING TO
EMERGENCY SERVICES.
INTERJECTION THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA IS THREATENED YOU
AROUND BY THE POSSIBILITY OF
MASSIVE WILDFIRES AND OTHER
NATURAL DISASTERS AB TWENTY TWO
THIRTEEN ASSISTS LOCAL AND
STATE AUTHORITIES IN RESPONDING
TO DISASTER EMERGENCIES. AND
ENSURES THE SAFETY OF AFFECTED
RESIDENTS ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
HAVE FUNCTIONAL AND ACCESS
NEEDS. THE MEASURE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES AND CAL
VOLUNTEERS TO DEVELOP PLANNING
GUIDANCE TO IDENTIFY VOLUNTEERS
AND DONATIONS MANAGEMENT
SERVICES THAT COULD ASSIST IN
RESPONDING TO OR RECOVERING
FROM THESE DISASTERS. IT ALSO
EXPANDS CALIFORNIA'S OPT OUT
EMERGENCY NOTIFICATION PROGRAM
TO INCLUDE CITIES AND
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS
CLARIFYING THAT ALERTING
AUTHORITIES MAY USE WIRELESS
TELEPHONE SUBSCRIBER DATA TO
ENROLL RESIDENTS IN THESE LOCAL
ALERTING SYSTEMS. THOROUGHLY
BEING ABLE TO REACH VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS DURING AN EMERGENCY
IT IS CRITICAL TO ENSURING
THEIR SAFETY IN THE VET
INVENTIVE A DISASTER. THE
MEASURE WILL ALLOW LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND INDIVIDUALS TO
BE BETTER PREPARED WHEN OUR
NEXT EMERGENCY HAPPENS WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. VOTE. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER AND DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SHINO MIKE'S UP ON THE FLOOR
SEEING NO HANDS UP REMOTELY.
CAN'T MEMBERS THIS IS ALSO A
CANDIDATE. FOR UNANIMOUS ON
CALL ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY OF
WOULD USING UNANIMOUS ON CALL
ROLL CALL. SHE NO OBJECTIONS.
THE MEASURES ON CALL. THEY'RE
MOVING ON MEMBERS TO FILE.
SENATOR RUBIO SHE'S THERE MADAM
SECRETARY AV NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE POLICE RAID ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AN
ACT RELATING TO SECOND HAND
GOODS. SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO PRESENT AT NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BLANCA RUBIO ABC NINETEEN SIXTY
NINE IS A SIMPLE STEP THAT ILL
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES FROM
ENTITIES THAT ARE NOT USING THE
CAP SYSTEM AS INTENDED WITHOUT
PLACING UNDUE STRESS ON LAW
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATIONS
AMENDMENTS TAKEN ON THE SENATE
FLOOR DELAY IMPLEMENTATION AT
THE REQUEST OF THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO ALLOW SAFE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS SIMPLE
ADJUSTMENT. HAS KOBE CONTINUES
TO DISRUPT OUR WAY OF LIFE SOME
OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE STRUGGLING TO
MAKE ENDS MEET SINCE THE ONSET
OF THIS PANDEMIC THE LATINO
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD BY THE VIRUS
THIS ECONOMIC IMPACT THIS%
MEASURE WILL HELP OR LATINO
POPULATION INCLUDING MEXICAN
NATIONALS THREE RESIDING IN
CALIFORNIA WHO ARE RELYING ON
PAWN BROKERS FOR FISCAL RELIEF
ON A PERSONAL NOTE IT IS MY
PRIVILEGE TO BE PRESENTING THIS
BILL TODAY. THIS IS THE LAST
MEASURE THE FORMER MEMBER BUILT
A PC WORKED ON BEFORE HIS
PASSING MR DEPLETES HE WAS
PASSIONATE IN HIS SERVICE BOTH
INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE BUILDING
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR YOUR RIFLE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DESCRIPTION ORDER VERY. ON THIS
ITEM ON THE FLOOR. NINETEN
NINE WE HAVE SENATOR GROWTH
REMOTELY CENTER GIRL. I AND
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I WAS
GOING TO SPEAK EXCEPT FOR- I'M
GLAD THAT THE AUTHOR I DID
MENTION THAT THIS WAS A- BILL
THAT SAYS THAT- BUILD THE PLACE
HE WORKED ON FOR A LONG TIME
AND I'M I'M SORRY HE WAS IN
HERE TO SEE IT PAST BUT I THINK
IT'S JUST A GREAT HONOR TO HIM
THAT THIS BILL WILL PASS AND
HOPEFULLY BE SIGNED BY THE
GOVERNOR. THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION VERY. HEARING CHAIN
NINE SENATOR RUBIO'S T. OF
CLOSE THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.%
VOTE GOT IT WHO TRULY NOTED
SHOW MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ON A B. TWENTY
ONE NINETEEN ANNOUNCER.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I FELL.
BRADFORD HI I HAVE A I DON'T. I
DON. THE RYZEN. I GOT JOHNNY
FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ I HURTS
BERG I STILL I WAS SO. BY HER
TADO HI JACKSON. I LLEVA I
REQUIRE. I MITCHELL FIVE
MORNING HI NIELSEN I CAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO. FIVE ROTH. HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER HI STERN.
NUMBER FIVE WACO SKI HI WINNER
HI. MMHM SIGNATURE CAN WE NOW
MOVED TO A REMOTE VOTING
SENATORS FOR FILE ITEM SIXTY
ONE AB. NINETEEN SIXTY NINE.
FAITH B. H. A. B. NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS
FORGES AB NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
NO FOR JUST NO TANG. THANK AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE I HANG ON
DALLY. VALLEY A. B. NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE NO DALLY NO ROSE.
GROVE AB NINETEEN SIXTY NINE I
GROVE FIVE MELINDA'S. THE LAND
IS A B. NINETEEN SIXTY NINE NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. YOU'RE
LUCKY THE NINETEEN SIXTY NINE
NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE. L. A.
B. NINETEEN SIXTY NINE L.
MORALE NO WELK. WILKE AB
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE HI WILKE HI.
REMOVE THE CALL. MOVING ON NOW
TO FOLLOW ITEM SIXTY TWO
SENATOR GLAZER YOU'RE PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER NEWS
ARIAN AN ACT RELATING TO
FLOORS WERE. THIS LEGISLATION
EXTENDS A SUNSET HAS SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES ASKED FOR AND I
DON'T. THANK YOU BREVITY. IS
THERE ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM I
VENTURE TO SAY THERE'S NOT.
MADAM SECRETARY THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ON CALL
ROLL CALL. IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING THE
ANONYMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL.
OUR. MANCHESTER CALL GIRL. WELL
OKAY SO NO OBJECTION TO USING
AN ARMS ROLL CALL. HEARING TINA
THE CALL. IRATE MEMBERS NOW
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ITEM.
SIXTY THREE. SENATOR HER TADO
SHE IS PREPARED MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE ROUTE. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL AN ACT
RELATING TO HOMELESSNESS SOONER
TOMORROW THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I AM PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT A
B. TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CABLE A BILL
THAT INTEREST WRONG
ACCOUNTABILITY AND REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR STATE FUNDED
HOMELESS PROGRAM STRUCTURE
CALIFORNIA IS DOING ALL IT CAN
TO ADDRESS OUR HOMELESS CRISIS.
DESPITE SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENTS
IN RECENT YEARS REDUCE
HOMELESSNESS FROM LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS HOMELESSNESS
STILL INCREASED IN MANY AREAS
OF OUR STATE. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE UNIFORM
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS ACROSS A
BROAD SET OF HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAMS SO THAT WE CAN COMPARE
AND ANALYZE THEIR EFFECTIVENESS.
R. A. B. AT TWENTY SEVEN FORTY
SIX PASSED THROUGH TE SENATE
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WITH A
UNANIMOUS BOW AND THIS. HAS A
BI PARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. I SEE NO
MIKE'S UP. I SEE NO HANDS
REMOTELY. THIS IS KAREN IS A
CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS ON CALL
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ON CALL ROLL CALL. SEE NO
OBJECTION MOVE THE CALL. ON TO
FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR SENATOR
GONZALO'S AV. SIX EIGHT FIVE.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY FIVE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAN AS AN ACT
RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY.
CENTERED IN DOLLARS WHEN YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE
AUTHORED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY.
WHICH WILL PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES AND CONSTITUENTS BY
LOWERING EXPOSURE TO COVERT
NINETEEN IN THE WORKPLACE
CURRENTLY THERE IS NO
COMPREHENSIVE MANDATE TO
PUBLICLY REPORT CODE NINETEEN
EXPOSURES IN CASES FOR TRACKING
PURPOSES. EXISTING LAW REQUIRES
EMPLOYERS REPORT FATALITIES AND
SERIOUS INCIDENTS IN THE
WORKPLACE BUT ONLY RECOMMENDS
THAT EMPLOYERS REPORT INSTANCES
OF COVER NINETEEN INFECTIONS.
SIX EIGHTY FIVE WILL ESTABLISH
CLEAR AND SIMPLE GUIDELINES FOR
WHAT AN EMPLOYER SHOULD DO WHEN
THEY ARE INFORMED THAT SOMEONE
AT THE WORK SITE HAS TESTED
POSITIVE OR BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
COPD NINETEEN. THE MEASURE WILL
ALLOW EMPLOYERS ONE BUSINESS
DAY TO NOTIFY WORKERS WHO ARE
ON THE PREMISES WITH THE PERSON
WHO TESTED POSITIVE AND WILL
REQUIRE THE NOTICE TO INCLUDE
INFORMATION ON WHAT TYPE OF
SICK LEAVE THEY MAY BE ELIGIBLE
FOR AND THE DISINFECTION
PLANNED. FOR THE SITE. AT SIX
EIGHTY FIVE ADDITIONALLY
REQUIRES IT OF THREE WORKERS
TEST POSITIVE WITHIN FOURTEEN
DAYS WHICH IS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
DEFINITION OF AN OUTBREAK. THE
EMPLOYER MUST REPORT THIS TO
THE LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THESE COMMON SENSE
REQUIREMENTS ARE THE EXTENT OF
THE EMPLOYER'S OBLIGATIONS.
INCLUDING THE AUTHOR HAS ASKED
ME TO SHARE THAT SHE HAS MET.
AND NEGOTIATED IN GOOD FAITH
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS TO
ADDRESS THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS FOR THAT AND- THE BILL
HAS BEEN SUBSTANTIALLY AMENDED
TO SIMPLIFY NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS. REMOVE
DUPLICATIVE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS REMOVE THE PENALTY
REMOVED REBUTTABLE PRESUMPTION.
EXEMPT MOST HEALTH CARE
EMPLOYERS AND ADD IT TO YOUR
SUNSET. AND SHE IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS IN
JANUARY AND HAS COMMITTED TO
WRITING A LETTER IN THE JOURNAL
FOR FURTHER CLARITY- FOR ALL
THIS AND ENSURING THAT WE
PROTECT OUR- ESSENTIAL
WORKFORCE IN THIS VERY.%
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BILLS.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR CENTER DRAWS A. SENATOR
ROGER MARKS NOT ON YOU KNOW
HELLO OKAY YEAH AS VICE CHAIR
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A. B. SIX EIGHTY
FIVE. IT'S A PRIORITY BECAUSE
CORBIN NINETEEN AFFECTIONS AND
DEATHS HAVE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTED THE LATINO COMMUNITY
IT IS CRITICAL THAT WE ACT
SWIFTLY TO PROTECT THE HEALTH
OF THE WORKERS. AND MINIMIZE.
CORBETT NINETY NOW BREAKS BY
REQUIRING ACCURATE AND TIMELY
COVERED NINETEEN EXPOSURE DATA.
AS REPORTED BY EMPLOYERS THIS
INFORMATION CAN SURE ABLE TO
FULLY REOPEN OUR ECONOMY WEALTH
SAFELY FOR MINIMIZING CARBON
NINETEEN FACTION AND
TRANSMISSION RISKS ASPIRIN I
WILL. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SENATOR
PEROT. SO THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT- HIGH RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY
FIVE THIS CRISIS IS UNDOUBTEDLY
A BROUGHT ABOUT NEW CHALLENGES
AND HURDLES THAT WILL HAVE TO
OVERCOME BUT REACTIONS TO THE
CRISIS LIKE THIS HAVE TO BE-
WELL THOUGHT OUT AND NOT YOUR
RATIONAL IN THIS BILL IS
COMPLETELY IRRATIONAL THE BILL
IS AN ATTACK ON OUR PLAYERS AND
OUR JOB CREATORS MAKES
COMPLIANCE EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
IF NOT IMPOSSIBLE. WITH THE
BROAD AND VAGUE LANGUAGE IT'S
NOT ONLY SO POORLY THOUGHT OUT
BUT POORLY WRITTEN AND IT HAS
HEAVY PENALTIES FOR BUSINESSES
AT TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IF IT
IF IT EVEN THOUGH IT FAILS TO
CLEARLY NOT OUTLINED WHAT IT
KIND OF CUTS TO USE AND
EXPOSURE ADDITIONALLY IT
IMPOSES RIDICULOUS AND
BURDENSOME REQUIREMENTS ON
EMPLOYERS WE HAVE TO REPORT
CODE EXPOSURES ON THEIR
EMPLOYEES IN THEIR OWN HOME- I
DON'T KNOW HOW AN EMPLOYER
WOULD COMPLY WITH THAT IF
EMPLOYEE GOT COATED IN THEIR
OWN HOME OR OUTSIDE OF THE
WORKPLACE. AND THE EMPLOYEE
DIDN'T SELF IDENTIFY YOURSELF
EXPOSE THAT HOW WOULD THE
EMPLOYER HAD THE ABILITY TO
EVEN- MAKE THAT A REPORTING I
MEAN HOW CAN YOU MAKE IT
REPORTED A FIRE BUT WHEN THE
EMPLOYEE ISN'T EVEN REQUIRED
SIMPLY TO THAT REPORTED TO THE
EMPLOYER THE BILL PROVIDES THE
CALIFORNIA DIVISION OF
OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH OSHA WITH
YOUR STORY TO WALK INTO A
BUSINESS IS BUSINESS AND
BASICALLY JUST SHUT THEM DOWN-
WITHOUT ANY DUE PROCESS AND
THAT'S COMPLETELY UNACCEPTABLE.
DOZENS OF ASSOCIATIONS ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AND FOR
GOOD REASON I ACTUALLY CONSIDER
THE SEVERE RAMIFICATIONS A
STILL HAVE- INUSE YOUR LOGIC
INTO DENYING THIS PREMATURE
BILL AGAIN- I DON'T KNOW HOW
ANY EMPLOYER IS GOING TO BE
ABLE TO IDENTIFY AND REPORT AN
EMPLOYEE GETTING INFECTED IN
THEIR OWN HOME OR IN THEIR OWN
FAMILY GATHERING OR OUTSIDE THE
SCOPE F EMPLOYMENT I
RESPECTFULLY. ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER THIS. OR
DEBATE ON THIS. WE HAVE.
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU MY
COLLEAGUE MENTIONED SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS IMPORTANT. THAT
THIS BILL DOES NOT APPEAR TO
ADDRESS IS WHETHER OR NOT THERE
IS A REQUIREMENT THAT THE
EMPLOYEES HAVE AN OBLIGATION TO
DISCLOSE. BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THE
WAY THAT I UNDERSTAND IT. THE
ENTIRE ONUS IS ON THE BUSINESS
OWNER BUT THAT BUSINESS OWNER
DOES NOT HAVE FULL ACCESS. TO
INFORMATION IN THE EMPLOYEE
HOUSEHOLD IN FRANKLIN I IMAGINE
THERE'S SOME PRIVACY EFFORTS.
AND PROTECTIONS IN PLACE THAT
MAY ACTUALLY KEEP THE EMPLOYEE
FROM HAVING TO DISCLOSE. SO
THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER ONE IS THAT
THIS IS NOT SUFFICIENTLY
TAILORED AND REFINED. INTO A
WORKABLE FORM THE SECOND IS
THAT IT IS AN AUTHORIZATION
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE. BUT
THE ENTIRE FOCUS OF THE
LEGISLATION IS WITHIN THE
CONTEXT OF CODE. WE DON'T KNOW
IF KOBE IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE THE THREAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
TO TWENTY THREE AS IT IS TODAY.
SO I WOLD THINK THAT AT LEAST
IT WOULD BE REFINED TO THE
STATES DECLARED STATE OF
EMERGENCY WHICH IN THE SPECIFIC
AUTHORIZATIONS INVOLVING KOBE.
SO I GUESS IN SHORT. I WANT TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT BUSINESSES
OPERATE FAIRLY AND RESPONSIBLY.
AND I WANT TO MAKE CERTAIN
EMPLOYEES- DISCLOSE INFORMATION
GOD THAT IS IN THE PUBLIC'S
WELFARE IN INTEREST BUT THE WAY
THIS IS DRAFTED THERE ARE SO
MANY. OF AREAS WHERE. FACT AND
CIRCUMSTANCE AND LAWFUL THROUGH
THE CRACKS I DON'T KNOW HOW
THIS CAN BE SUPPORTED IN I
THINK THE INTENT IS GOOD. BUT
THIS WOULD DO MUCH BETTER IF
THIS WERE BROUGHT BACK. IN
JANUARY IN REFINED FURTHER I
THINK WOULD BE FAR MORE
EFFECTIVE IT WOULD PROBABLY
MEET WITH OUR- SIGNIFICANT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT INSTEAD
ITS CURRENT FORM IT'S JUST NOT
DRAFTED WELL ENOUGH IN MY
OPINION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR MELINDA S. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MY COLLEAGUES FROM
FRESNO AND BAKERSFIELD COVERED
MANY OF THE CONCERNS THAT I WAS
GOING TO RACE I JUST WOULD LIKE
TO ASK THE ASK FOR MANAGER
QUESTION IF I MAY. SOONER THAN
THOSE WHICH MAKES UP THE
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY THE CHAIR
SENATOR MELINDA THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT RIGHT JUST I KNOW
THAT YOU MENTIONED THAT A
NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN
IN ORDER TO SATISFY SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION. SO WERE- ANY OF THE
GROUPS INDIVIDUAL AS OPPOSED TO
THE ORIGINAL FORM OF THE BILL
HAVE ANY OF THEM COME OFF OF
OPPOSITION. I'M THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW IF
ANYBODY HAS GONE OFF
SPECIFICALLY BUT I CAN SAY THAT
THE AMENDMENTS- FROM THE
ORIGINAL BILL. REMOVED A
PENALTY SO THERE'S NO NO NO
PENALTY THERE'S NO PRESUMPTION
OF RETALIATION- HEALTH
FACILITIES EXEMPTED FROM
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS- NOTICE
ONLY GOES TO WORKERS WHO WERE
AT THE SAME WORKSITE- NO LONGER
INCLUDES- INSTRUCTIONS FOR
TESTING QUARANTINE THERE'S A
NUMBER IN. AND ALSO INCLUDES A
TWO YEAR SUNSET WHICH I THINK
IS PRETTY SIGNIFICANT FROM
WHERE THE BILL WAS ORIGINALLY.
OKAY AND THANK YOU FOR THAT I
JUST WONDER IF THAT WAS ENOUGH
TO SATISFY THE MANY CONCERNS
THAT THE OPPOSITION HAD- THERE
WERE A NUMBER OF GROUPS AROUND
WERE IN OPPOSITION SO I. I
JUST- IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
WHETHER NOT DISSATISFIED
THERE'S BEEN CONCERNS IF. BY
SOME CHANCE SOMEONE CAN SLIT
THE THAT INFORMATION MAYBE
SOMEONE ON YOUR STOCK LET YOU
KNOW IF ANY OPPOSITION HAD.
PULLED THEIR OPPOSITION BEFORE
YOU CLOSE. ON THE BILL THAT
WOULD BE APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS
REMEMBERS. HEARING SHE NINE
SYRIANS ALL THOSE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YES AGAIN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I VOTE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE
FOR ESSENTIAL WORKERS WHO ARE
OFTEN AND IN WORK PLACES THAT-
HAPPEN THAT HAVE- PROVIDED.
EXPOSURE EXPOSURE AND THEY ALSO
NEED TO KNOW AND HAVE NEED
INFORMATION WITHIN THE
WORKPLACE. AND THERE IS
PRECEDENT THERE'S AN EXAMPLE IN
LA COUNTY WERE EMPLOYEE
EMPLOYERS ARE CURRENTLY
PROVIDING THAT DATA TO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH. DEPARTMENT AND
IT'S PROVIDING GOOD INFORMATION
FOR THE PUBLIC TO KNOW WHAT IS
GOING ON IN THIS CRISIS SO. FOR
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NIGHT BUT- THANK YOU. SENATOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON ITEM
SIXTY FOUR. AV SIX EIGHT FIVE.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELL. BRADFORD WELL I HAVE A-
HI DOUG. TORONTO FIVE KALYANI
I. GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE HURTS
BERG HI PHIL HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. JACKSON HI LAVER I
REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL MY MIND.
HI NIELSEN. NO PAN. HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH HI RUBIO.
SKINNER HI STERN. AMBERG WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WINNER. HI.
SECRETARY NOW LET US CALL OUR
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS ON FALL
ITEM SIXTY FOUR EIGHTY B. SIX
EIGHT FIVE. BASICS. EIGHT
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY FIVE NO
BABIES NO GORGEOUS. FORGES AB
SIX EIGHT FIVE NO FORTRESS NO
CHANG. HEY MAYBE SIXTY FIVE OF
SAYING. DALLY VALLEY EIGHTY SIX
EIGHT FIVE NO DALLY NO GROWTH
ROUTE EIGHTY SIX EIGHT FIVE NO
GROVE NO. MELINDA'S BUT WHEN
THERE'S A B. SIX EIGHT FIVE NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. E. SIX
EIGHT FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. YOUR L. EIGHTY SIX A.
FIVE NO. ZERO NO WILKE. ABC
FIVE NO WELL NOW. MARK SOONER
THAN DOLLARS MOVES A CALL. NOW
MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM SIXTY
FIVE SENATOR WIENER ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR THAT ITEM HE IS AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON AN ACT
RELATING TO COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WARNER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT A SUMMARY BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIBSON'S AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL I.
SIXTY INCREASE ACCESS TO
EMERGENCY CARE RESOURCES BY
AUTHORIZING COMMUNITY AND
TRIAGE PARAMEDIC SERVICES IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL IS A
CONTINUATION OF PREVIOUS
EFFORTS. YES EFFORTS TO ENSURE
COMMUNITY PARAMEDICINE AN OLD%
ALTERNATE DESTINATION PILOT
PROGRAMS ARE ABLE TO BE
IMPLEMENTED STATEWIDE- AS YOU
KNOW WE HAVE A HEALTH CARE
CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA- THIS
CRISIS IS EVIDENT WHEN PEOPLE
CALL NINE ONE ONE SEEKING HELP.
AND THEY ARE INSTEAD SENT TO AN
OVERCROWDED EMERGENCY ROOM-
WHERE THEY DON'T ALWAYS RECEIVE
THE PROMPT CARE THAT THEY NEED.
MANY NINE ONE ONE CALLERS
AREN'T ABLE TO RECEIVE TIMELY
CARE BECAUSE OUR PARAMEDICS
CANNOT TRANSPORT THEM TO
ALTERNATIVE DESTINATIONS. SUCH
AS A MENTAL HEALTH CLINIC OR A
SOBERING CENTER. INSTEAD
THEY'RE FORCED TO TAKE THEM TO
THE EMERGENCY ROOM. COMMUNITY
PARAMEDICINE ALLOWS SPECIALLY
TRAINED PARAMEDICS TO PERFORM
OUTSIDE OF THEIR TRADITIONAL
ROLE IN ORDER TO ENHANCE ACCESS
TO CARE. COMMUNITY PARAMEDICS
TO RIGOROUSLY LICENSE AND
EXTENSIVELY TRAINED. TO MAKE
CRITICAL DECISIONS IN THE FIELD
ARE REGARDING A DECISION TO
TRANSPORT- SOMEONE WHETHER IT'S
TO AN EMERGENCY ROOM. OR TO A
STROKE CENTER OR TRAUMA CENTER
OR OTHER FORMS OF SPECIALIZED
FACILITIES. TO HELP SOMEONE
WITH WHAT THEY NEED MAYBE
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR GIVES LOCAL
AGENCIES THE AUTHORITY TO
DEVELOP THESE COMMUNITY
PROGRAMS. AND REQUIRES THE
STATE OF FLORIDA. THE STATE TO
DEVELOP MINIMAL MEDICAL
STANDARDS THIS IS A THOUGHTFUL
AND BALANCED APPROACH TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE
AND I ASKED HER I GO. YOU KNOW
DO IT REPORTER. ANY ADDITIONAL
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS ON THIS
ISSUE. SHANE HEARING. NINE
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
ZERO. ALAN I ARCHULETA I CAN
SEE FIVE TELL. BRADFORD. FIVE
SEVEN ZERO FIVE DOT. DOT THERE
ARE SO FIVE GOD YANNI HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ BY GROUP HERTZBERG. HI
HELLO FIVE WITH SO. HI HER TADO.
FIVE JACKSON FIVE LIVER. HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME.
I NIELSEN. PAM FIVE FORTUNE
TINO I ROTH FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER
HI STERN UMBERG BY CAL SKI FIVE
WINNER. FIVE PLEASE CALL OUR
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS ON A B.
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR. FAITH EIGHT
ABC FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR NO FACE
NOW FOR JUST. FORGES AB FIFTEEN
FORTY FOUR UP SAYING. CHANG
ADDING EIGHTY FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR I SANG HI DALLY. DALLY AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR UPSTATE.
GROVE ABC FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR NO
GROVE NO. MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
AB FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. ABC
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR NO MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. ABC FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR NO MORALE NO WELK. WILK AB
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR I WILL HI.
CENTER MOVES A CALL. MOVING ON
NOW TO FOLLOW ITEM. SIXTY SIX
AV TWELVE SIXTY SIX. SENATOR
JACKSON'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ AT SOME
LEVEL TWELVE EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARTUCCI AN ACT
RELATING TO MOBILITY DEVICES.
INTERJECTION THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES MANY OF US
HAVE SEEN THESE DEVICES THE
SHARED MOBILITY DEVICES
SCOOTERS BIKES AND WHAT HAVE
YOU THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITIES
AND THEY HAVE MANY OF THEM HERE
IN SACRAMENTO AS WELL. THEY ARE
AN OPTION FOR CALIFORNIANS IN
MANY CITIES AND CAN BE HELPFUL-
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS THEY
SEARCH FOR ECO FRIENDLY LOW
COST OPTIONS TO SOLVE THAT LAST
MILE PROBLEM A TRANSPORTATION
PROBLEM AND CREATE ACCESS FOR
TRADITIONALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. HOWEVER IN MANY
CITIES THESE DEVICES HAVE
APPEARED OFTEN OVER NIGHT. AND
DAY LEAVE CITIES AND COUNTIES
TO CREATE POLICIES AROUND THE
ISSUE WITHOUT ANY FRAMEWORK AND
HOW TO DEAL WITH THESE MOBILITY
DEVICES OF COURSE THERE ARE
PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS FOR
WRITERS AS WELL AS THE USERS OF
THE BIKES. THIS MEASURE CREATES
A STATEWIDE MINIMUM STANDARD
REQUIRED FOR SHARED MOBILITY
DEVICES WITH THE REQUIREMENT
THAT CITIES AND COUNTIES ADOPT
AND COMPLY WITH SAFETY RULES
AND THAT THERE BE MINIMUM
INSURANCE OR I SHOULD SAY
MINIMUM INSURANCE. IN ORDER TO
PROTECT RIDERS FROM THIRD
PARTIES RECENT AMENDMENTS
SADLY. REMOVE THE WAIVER
PROVISION. THAT HAS ALLOWED
COMPANIES TO REQUIRE THAT
RIDERS WAVE A LIABILITY OF
THESE COMPANIES. BUT BY
REMOVING THAT. THE INDUSTRY HEN
ALL OPPONENTS AS I UNDERSTAND
IT HAVE REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL SO IT IS
NOT QUITE THE BILL I HAD HOPED
BUT IT DOES REQUIRE THAT WE
START ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE AND
THESE PIPES ARE THESE BIKES AND
MOBILITY DEVICES- TO AT LEAST
CREATE A BASIC FRAMEWORK FOR
THEIR USE AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. ANY ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. I SEE
NO HANDS HERE. REMOTELY WE HAVE
SENATOR GORGEOUS. THANK YOU.
WHEN THIS MATTER CAME TO
JUDICIARY I THINK MOST OF THE
AREAS OF DISCUSSION WERE ALL ON
THE WAIVER- I HAD HEARTBURN
UPON THAT- AND WE GOT OURSELVES
BACK AND FORTH ON. A NEW ONCE
LEGAL MATTER BUT ALL ULTIMATELY
EVERYONE AGREED THAT YOU CANNOT
WAIVE THROUGH A LEGAL
INSTRUMENT MANUFACTURER
LIABILITY. SO THAT THERE WERE
OTHER REASONS WHY A WAIVER WAS
SOUGHT IN ANOTHER REASON WHY
WEAVER. THERE IS A DESIRE TO
REMOVE THE WAIVER FROM THE
TRANSACTION BUT AS IT TURNS OUT
NOW THIS BILL HAS JUST BECOME A
MINIMUM INSURANCE COVERAGE- A
LOT OF POLICY ON THE SCOOTER
COMPANIES SO MY FORMER
OPPOSITION WAS BECAUSE OF THE
WAIVER AND IN ITS CURRENT FORM
I THINK IT'S ENTIRELY
SUPPORTABLE. AND IT'S CLEAR
THAT THE OPPOSITION THAT
EXISTED BEFORE AS EITHER
REMOVED OR GONE NEUTRAL SO.
I'LL BE SUPPORTIVE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. SINNER MORLOCK WE
ARE MORE LIKELY TO. SHARE MR
PRESIDENT I I'M JUST A LITTLE
CONCERNED WHEN WE ADDRESS NEW
TECHNOLOGIES OF THIS NATURE ACT
SOME MEMBER TAKING MY OLDEST
SON WHEN HE WAS TEN YEARS OLD
TO THE BASE OF HALF DOME AND
LOOK AT THE CABLE AND- I SAID
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO USE
TO GO TO THE TOP AND HE SAID NO
DAD WE'RE NOT GOING BECAUSE-
AND SO. WE GET. BETTER BUT WE
ALL KNOW THAT WHEN WE DO
CERTAIN THINGS- BECAUSE FANS
ARE ACTIVITIES ARE GONNA BE
SOME. ELEMENT OF RISK IN IT AND
IT SHOULD BE ON US IF WE'RE
GOING TO. GET ON A SCOOTER OR-
OR SOME TYPE OF VEHICLE WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE TAKING CERTAIN
RISKS I JUST THINK WE NEED TO
BE REAL CAUTIOUS. WHEN WE TAKE
ON. SOME OF THESE NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND IMPOSING A
NOVEL LEGAL STANDARD THAT IS
ONLY APPLICABLE. TO SURE. MICRO
BILITY INDUSTRY. YOU KNOW SEEMS
A LITTLE. HARSH PATEL I'M GLAD
THAT THERE'S AT LEAST SOME-
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE. HAVE KIND
OF TURNED IT DOWN SO THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT FOR LETTING ME.
SHARE. MY THOUGHTS. THANK YOU.
IN ADDITION TO. OF THE RAID ON
THE ITEM. HEARING CHAIN NINE
CENTER JACKSON GEORGIA CLOSE
YES I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THIS
ISN'T JUST ABOUT MINIMUM
INSURANCE THIS IS REQUIRING
COMMUNITIES TO ADDRESS THE FACT
THAT THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY IS
HERE AND THAT IT DOES-
POTENTIALLY SERVE A VERY
POSITIVE PURPOSE WHEN IT COMES
TO TRANSPORTATION BUT IT ALSO
DOES HAVE SOME ISSUES AND SO-
COMMUNITIES ARE. GOING TO NOW
BE REQUIRED TO CREATE SOME KIND
OF A- IF YOU WILL OF WORKING-
DIRECTIVE FOR THE USE OF THESE
BIKES- WE CAN ARGUE ABOUT THE
LIABILITY ISSUE I HAPPEN TO
THINK THAT WE JUST DON'T
SIMPLY. ASSUME EVERY RISK OF
EVERYTHING- BUT THAT ISN'T PART
OF THE BILL NOW SO WE CAN HAVE
THAT DISCUSSION SOME OTHER
TIME. THE BILL DOES HAVE VERY
POSITIVE IMPACTS IT IS A FIRST
STEP IN MY OPINION. BUT THE
AUTHOR HAS CHOSEN TO- TO
ADDRESS THE ISSUE FROM A VERY
BASIC LEVEL IT'S AN IMPORTANT
LEVEL A IT'S A START OF A VERY
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION ABOUT A
POTENTIALLY VERY POSITIVE FORM
OF TRANSPORTATION. AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. PHONE. MMHM SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA I AT KINS I FELL.
BRADFORD CABRERA I DODD FIVE
THE RUSSELL. I GOT JOHNNY.
LASER GONZALES. HERTZBERG. HI
HELLO HI I WISH SO HI HER TADO.
JACKSON HI LLEVA I REQUIRE BY
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. HI
NIELSEN. NO HAN. HI FORTINO. HI
RALPH. FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER FIVE WACO SKI FIVE
WINNER I. MMHM SECTOR WILL GO
TO A REMOTE VOTERS I'M SURE. AS
WELL AS CONSULTING WITH FIVE.
NO I WILL GO TO A REMOTE VOTING
SENATORS ON A. B. TWELVE SIXTY
SEVEN. TWELVE EIGHTY SIX. SIX
BATES AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
ABSTAIN. GORGEOUS OR JUST AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX HI. OR JUST
HI CHANG TANG AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX HI. HANG ON I DALLY. GOLLY
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX ABSTAIN.
GROWTH GROVE AB TWELVE EIGHTY
SIX ABSTAIN. MELINDA'S
BELINDA'S AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
NO ONE DOES KNOW MORE LOCK. OR
MAYBE TWELVE EIGHTY SIX
ABSTAINED. MORROW. MORAGA ON
MUTE. EIGHTY FIVE EIGHTY SIX
NOW MORALE NO WELL. AB TWELVE
EIGHTY SIX HI WELCOME HI. GROVE
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SIX ABSTAIN TO
KNOW. GROVE NO. THANK YOU
SENATOR MOVE THE CALL. WE WILL
NOW TO FALL I'M SIXTY SEVEN
SENATOR DODD HE'S PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RING AV.
FIFTEEN OH SIX. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN OH SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AN ACT
RELATING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. SENATOR DODD MR
PRESIDENT SENATORS ARRIVES THE
FLOOR MANAGER AND A PROUD
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR OF AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX THE CALIFORNIA
DEADLY FORCE ACCOUNTABILITY ACT.
CURRENTLY THERE IS ALARMING
SKEPTICISM AND A PERCEIVED
CONFLICT OF INTEREST IN THE
CURRENT IF PROCESSES FOR DEADLY
FORCE INCIDENTS PARTICULARLY
WITH LOCAL DJS INVESTIGATING
COPS THEY WORK MOST CLOSELY
WITH. AFTER SEVERAL HIGH
PROFILE CASES AROUND THE
COUNTRY AND THE STATE- WITH NO
CHARGES FILED INCLUDING A
RECENT POLICE SHOOTING IN MY
DISTRICT IT'S CLEAR. WE MUST
HAVE BEEN BETTER INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS JUSTICE MUST BE
SERVED. AB FIFTEEN OH SIX WOULD
ESTABLISH A STATE PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE POLICE OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS THAT
RESULTED IN THE DEATH OF AN
UNARMED CIVILIAN. THE STATE
PROSECUTOR'S DUTIES WOULD
INCLUDE CONDUCTING AN INVEST
INVESTIGATION GATHERING FACTS
PROVIDING WRITTEN FINDINGS IN
WHEN NECESSARY PROSECUTING THE
OFFICERS INVOLVED. LASTLY AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX INCREASES
ACCOUNTABILITY BY ALLOWING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO REQUEST
THE D. O. G. D. O. J. EXCUSE ME
TO REVIEW THEIR DEPARTMENTS
PATTERNS AND PRACTICES AND MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS. INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS ARE NOT NEW FIVE
OTHER STATES REQUIRE THEM IT'S
TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO STEP UP.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THERE BEEN ALMOST EIGHT HUNDRED
FATAL SHOOTINGS BY POLICE IT
LESS THAN FIVE INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATIONS WERE CONDUCTED.
WE'VE SEEN TOO MANY FAMILIES
GRIEVING SENSELESS KILLINGS OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR BY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THIS MUST STOP. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS THANK YOU
CENTER DOT MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR YES SENATOR NIELSEN.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
SENATE. SHOULD OTHER.
OVERREACTION THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I CONSIDER IT
OVER THE TOP TOO MUCH. THERE'S
PLENTY OF BEST TO GATING. RIGHT
NOW THE GOES ON. AND EVEN THEN
IT'S A DEAD SEVEN CITED SO
EGREGIOUS. THOSE INDIVIDUALS
ARE BEING PROSECUTED NOW. WE
HAVE THE MEANS TO DISCIPLINE.
THIS IS REALLY HEADED TOWARDS
OPEN SEASON. ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
PROFESSIONALS WHO SACRIFICED
THEIR LIVES EVERY DAY FOR US.
THEY'LL TELL YOU A STORY IS
VERY MOVING THAT DOES MAKE A
POINT. THE NERO DAM SPILLWAY
FAILED I WAS TALKING TO THE
SHERIFF OF THAT COUNTY. ELEVEN
O'CLOCK AT NIGHT. AND HE SAID I
DON'T KNOW WHAT 'M GONNA DO
I'M GETTING CONFLICTING AND
PINION SHIN THAT APARTMENT A
WATER RESOURCES AND THAT'S WHAT
COREY HERE'S WHAT YOU DO YOU
MAKE YOUR DECISION AS YOU SEE
IT. I WILL NOT BE BEHIND YOU I
WILL NOT BE BESIDE YOU. I'LL BE
IN FRONT OF THE- YOU MAKE YOUR
DECISION. THEN ANY OBSERVATION
OPTING. HE SAID JIM THEN I'M ON
THE THRESHOLD. OF ORDERING
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE. ARE THE WAY OF
TROUBLE. TO ACHIEVE THAT. I
HAVE TO ORDER MY PEOPLE. THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE IN TO
HARM'S WAY. TO DO THAT. THEY DO
PROVIDE COURAGEOUSLY THEY DON'T
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT. YES
JUSTICE WILL BE DONE. AND AS
USUAL BELIEVE FULLY EMBRACE
THESE LAW ENFORCEMENT BILLS.
DON'T BE HYPOCRITES COME. THE
DAY THAT WE CROSS THE STREET.
TO HONOR THE SLAIN OFFICERS OF
THAT YEAR BUT THE PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL. I
IMMEDIATELY TO THE WEST OF HERE.
DON'T BEARS YOURSELVES GOING IN
FRONT OF THOSE GRIEVING FAMILY
MEMBERS. THE WEEPING WIVES. THE
STANDARD STARING INTO SPACE
CHILDREN. YES. THERE IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE. ON
YOUR MIND I URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
SENATOR MITCHELL. JUSTICE HAS
NOT BEEN DONE. AND FOR THE
CONTINUED INFERENCE THAT THE
LIVES OF BLACK MEN AND WOMEN
AND BROWN MEN AND WOMEN. WHO
HAD BEEN KILLED AT THE HANDS OF
POLICE. CAN BE IGNORED
CONTINUES TO BE INSULTING. NO
ONE STANDS HERE ON THIS FLOOR
AND SAYS THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
ARE TO BE RESPECTED. AND
HONORED AND SUPPORTED I DO THAT
REGULARLY WHEN I SUPPORT BILLS
IN LABOR COMMITTEE THAT
SUPPORTS THEM. BUT IT IS NOT
OKAY. TO IGNORE. THE RISK FOUR
BLACK MEN ONE IN ONE THOUSAND
CHANCE OF BEING KILLED AT THE
HANDS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT
IS NOT OKAY TO DENY
CONTINUOUSLY THAT REALITY. AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX WOULD ESTABLISH
A STATE PROSECUTOR TO
INVESTIGATE POLICE OFFICER
INVOLVED SHOOTINGS AND THE
DEATH OF AN UN ARMED CIVILIANS.
HOW PRAY TELL IS THAT
DISRESPECTING AND NOT HONORING
LAW ENFORCEMENT I ABSOLUTELY
WILL PROBABLY CONTINUE TO GO
ACROSS THE STREET AND HONOR
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES IN
DUTY AND I WILL ALSO CONTINUE
TO STAND HERE AND SAY. THAT
THOSE WHO TAKE AN OATH TO
PROTECT AND SERVE ALL OF US
FAIRLY. IT'S FAIR AND
APPROPRIATE EXPECTATION. IT IS
NOT EITHER OR. I AGAIN WILL BE
STANDING IN SUPPORT OF A B. ONE
FIVE OH SIX IT'S AN APPROPRIATE
LEVEL OF ACCOUNTABILITY. IT
SIMPLY CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR INVESTIGATIONS TO OCCUR
BECAUSE JUSTICE HAS NOT BEEN
SERVED IN THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THE MURDER OF BLACK MEN AND
WOMEN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY
ACROSS THE STATE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF WHOM ALL OF WHOM
ARE ON ARMED AT THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL CENTER
BRADFORD. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND I TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE I CAN ASSURE YOU
IF WHITE AMERICANS WERE BEING
KILLED AT THE SAME RATE AS
AFRICAN AMERICANS AND LATINOS
ARE BEING KILLED NOT ONLY IN
THE STATE BUT ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY YOU'D BE CALLING FOR
THE DISBANDMENT OF POLICE
DEPARTMENTS ALL ACROSS THE
STATE. BUT BECAUSE IT'S BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE. ALL THAT YOU
HAVE NEVER TRULY EVER VALUE
THEIR LIVES IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT'S LIKE HOLDS. THEY MUST THE
DESERVED IT IT SHOULD BE
TELLING WHEN YOU HAVE A N. B.
A. STAR WHO PLAYED ON TV AND I
DIDN'T REALLY MATTER WHAT HIS
ROLE IS BUT TO HAVE A PLATFORM.
LIKE LEBRON JAMES HAS AND HE
SAYS AS A BLACK MAN. AS A BLACK
WOMAN AS A BLACK CHILD WE FEAR
THE POLICE. FAR TOO OFTEN YOU
SEE AFRICAN AMERICANS RUNNING
FROM THE POLICE NOT BECAUSE
THEY COMMITTED ANY CRIME.
BECAUSE THEY FEAR THE POLICE
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN OVER THE
LAST SIX MONTHS WHAT WE'VE SEEN
OVER MY LIFETIME IF THAT WOULD
HAPPEN TO YOU. YOU WOULD FEAR
THE POLICE TOO BUT IT DOESN'T
HAPPEN TO WHITE NEIGHBORHOODS
SO TO HAVE A METHOD. OF
INVESTIGATING. LAW ENFORCEMENT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE KILLED
UNARMED. CITIZENS REGARDLESS OF
THEIR COLOR SHOULD BE COMMON
SENSE AND WE SHOULD ALL
SUPPORT. I HAVE A FAMILY THAT'S
BEEN IN LAW ENFORCEMENT AS I
TOLD THE STORY I CAME CLOSE TO
BEING A POLICE OFFICER I HAVE A
FRIEND FROM. JUNIOR HIGH SCHOOL
WAY TO COLLEGE. WHO JUST
RETIRED FROM THIRTY FIVE YEARS
AS AN LAPD OFFICER AT THIRTY
FIVE YEARS HE NEVER ONCE FIRED
HIS WEAPON BUT HE TOLD ME MANY
OF THE STORIES OF THE FACT
THAT. HE KNEW WHEN ONE OF HIS
PARTNERS WAS GOING TO FIRE HIS
WEAPON BECAUSE IT WAS A BLACK
OR BROWN PERSON AND THEY
AUTOMATICALLY ASSUME THAT THEY
WERE FROM. SO THEY HAVE A
METHOD TO INVESTIGATE POLICE
OFFICERS THIS IS COMMON SENSE
THIS IS ACTUALLY SUPPORTS
POLICE THIS IS A PRO PLEASE
MEASURE BECAUSE ALL EVERYBODY
SAYS WE WANT TO GET RID OF THE
BACK OFFICE. AND HELP US GET
RID OF THE BAD COPS YOU CAN'T
GET RID OF THEM IF YOU DON'T
HAVE A METHOD OF INVESTIGATING.
THE SHOOTINGS. THIS ALL THIS
BILL REQUIRES IS ASKING FOR A
METHOD IN WHICH TO INVESTIGATE
THOSE SHOOTINGS BECAUSE- IF
YOU'RE NOT APPALLED AT WHAT WE
SAW. IN WISCONSIN THE OTHER DAY
THEN YOU HAVE NO CONSCIOUS
FEELING ABOUT A HUMAN BEING TO
GET SHOT SEVEN TIMES IN THE
BACK. AND HE'S LUCKY HE'S STILL
ALIVE. WHAT IS THREE. IN A CAR.
I'M MAD WE ALL SHOULD BE MET
BECAUSE THE CONTINUE TO SAY
THAT JUSTICE IS COLOR BLIND IS
THE BIGGEST LIE WE TELL IN THIS
COUNTRY. IT IS NOT COLOR BLIND.
SO AGAIN IT'S MEMBERS TO TALK
ABOUT DEFINING THE PLEASE WE'RE
NOT TALKING ABOUT DEFINING THE
POLICE BECAUSE WE BELIEVE. WE
DO NEED LAW ENFORCEMENT IN THIS
COUNTRY WE NEED LAW ENFORCEMENT
WORKS ON IT IT'LL BE A- MEASURE.
WELL APPLYING WAIT JUST AS IT
DOES IN THOSE ARE A FLUENT
COMMUNITY SO I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MELODRAMA PULL UP THEIR
IMAGE VICE CHAIR OF A
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THESE MEASURES
WILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR BRADFORD
CENTRE SKINNER. THANK YOU I
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
WE HEARD IT IN OUR PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. THE TESTIMONY
WAS THOROUGH THE DISCUSSION IN
THE ANALYSIS WAS THOROUGH. AND
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT WHILE I
DO NOT HAVE THE EXACT
STATISTICS FOR CALIFORNIA. WE
ARE AVERAGING IN THE UNITED
STATES OVER A THOUSAND PEOPLE
FATALLY SHOT BY POLICE ANNUALLY.
AND OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF
YEARS. ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
OFFICERS WERE CHARGED AND
THAT'S AFTER THAT'S A THOUSAND
A YEAR OF DEATHS. GET OVER
MULTIPLE YEARS ONLY A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED OFFICERS HAVE BEEN
CHARGED. AND ONLY FORTY TWO
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED AND THAT'S
ACROSS THE US IN CALIFORNIA.
AND EVEN FEWER. NOW I AM NOT
NECESSARILY ARGUING THAT
OFFICERS BE CONVICTED. WHAT I
AM ARGUING FOR IS THE ABILITY
FOR AN INVESTIGATION TO HAPPEN
AND WE FACED NOW WERE MANY MANY
SHOOTINGS OFFICER INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS HAVE NOT HAD AN
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION. AND
FAMILIES COMMUNITIES. AND
OTHERS HAVE FELT THAT THERE IS
NO ABILITY TO DETERMINE WHETHER
PROTOCOLS WERE FOLLOWED OR
WHETHER THERE WAS LEGITIMATE.
WHETHER THAT WAS A- WHETHER THE
OFFICER WAS- EXONERATED
LEGITIMATELY OR NOT AND I THINK
THIS IS ESSENTIAL FOR JUSTICE
ESSENTIAL FOR BUILDING TRUST
WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT BETWEEN
THE COMMUNITIES THEY SERVE AND
NECESSARY TO CORRECT SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN VERY WRONG FOR
YEARS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER CENTER JACKSON.
YES VERY BRIEFLY I HAD A
DISCUSSION WITH THE DA OF MY
COUNTY SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WHO
IS ALSO THE- I BELIEVE IT'S C.
PRESIDENT OF POST POLICE
OFFICER TRAININGS. AND ASKED
HER WHAT SHE THOUGHT OF THIS
BILL AND SHE SAID IT'S ABOUT
TIME. AND WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
SENATOR PORTENT TINO. THANK YOU
ADAM. PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A B. FIFTEEN OH SIX
AND ALSO ON A RISE. IN
COMPLIMENT- THE AUTHOR FROM
SACRAMENTO WHO IS BEEN SO
PASSIONATE- ON THIS ISSUE AND
DILIGENTLY WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR OF. THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE I WANT TO GIVE
A SHOUT OUT TO THE CHAIR FROM-
BERKELEY AS WELL THEY HAVE
WORKED DILIGENTLY- IN THE LAST
WEEK TO. REMOVE SOMETHING AS
SIMPLE AS THE REIMBURSEMENT
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT THAT
LITTLE PIECE. MAKES IT MORE.
PALATABLE AND MORE LIKELY THAT
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL SEE THIS
INDEPENDENT INVESTIGATION
HAPPENED AND SO I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT- THE AUTHOR. THE
CHAIR AND THE FINAL RESULT IN-
RESPECTFULLY- ASK EVERYONE TO
VOTE I AM FIFTEEN OH SIX. THANK
YOU SIR PORTENT TINO. SENATOR
RAZA. THIS WEEK I WISH I HAD
TIME TO WATCH ALL THE DIFFERENT
GAMES ON TV SPORTS THAT WERE
TAKING PLACE AND WHEN I LOOK TO
SEE WHAT I MISSED I DIDN'T MISS
ANYTHING BECAUSE THEY HAD ALL
DECIDED TO BOYCOTT BIT ALL
DECIDED TO NOT. PLAY BECAUSE
THEY'RE ALL DEMANDING THAT
THERE BE JUSTICE. EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THOSE ATHLETES AND
PLAYERS. THEY ARE SHOWING. THEY
ARE TELLING US WHAT THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY SHOULD BE TELLING
US AS WELL SO I RISE. TO
SUPPORT THIS. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS A SENATOR PAM. HANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SATURDAY TO
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS A VERY
IMPORTANT- BILL AND I STAND
WITH MY GOOD FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE- WHO REPRESENTS
SACRAMENTO AS WELL- THE AUTHOR
OF THIS BILL- SO MEMBER
MCCARTY- WE NEED TO RESTORE
TRUST. THIS IS WHAT REALLY WHAT
THIS BILL IS ABOUT YOU KNOW WE
NEED TO WE HAVE. OUR BELONG FOR
SPENT OFFICERS WHO ARE DOING
THEIR WORK BUT WE ALSO HAVE A
PROBLEM GOING ON IN OUR
COMMUNITY. WITH WITH VIOLENCE
AND POLICE BRUTALITY AND WE
NEED TO RESTORE TRUST AND
THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT. AND US TRUST AND
FAIRNESS AND SO LET'S PASS THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
MEMBERS FOR PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY I HAVE FOUR HANDS UP
SENATOR BORCHERS GROVE
MELINDA'S AND MORE LOCK WE'RE
GONNA START WITH SENATOR
BORJAS. SENATOR GORGEOUS. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THERE'S A
LOT OF PASSION IN THE ROOM AND
NO DOUBT- THERE ARE A LOT OF
GRIEVANCES HISTORICAL AND
PRESENT ON IN TERMS OF THE
RELATIONSHIP AND THE TRUST THAT
PEOPLE FEEL NEEDS TO BE
IMPROVED UPON BETWEEN THE
COMMUNITY AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
BUT I KIND OF WANT TO TAKE A
STEP BACK. AND GO TO SIFT
THROUGH THE OUTRAGE THAT IS
BEING EXPERIENCED AND FELT IN
TRYING TO GET TO THE THRUST OF
WHAT IS THIS BILL IS REALLY
ABOUT. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE AG HAS ALWAYS HAD THE
AUTHORITY. TO INITIATE AN
INVESTIGATION. INTO POLICE
MISCONDUCT. R. AND IMPROPER
INVESTIGATIONS AS WELL AS THE
CALCULATIONS THE RATIOS OF
THOSE WHO SUFFER AT THE HANDS.
OF BAD APPLES IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. AND I DON'T THINK
I FULLY UNDERSTAND WHY THIS
PARTICULAR PIECE OF LEGISLATION
IS NEEDED IF WE DEMAND IS A
COMMUNITY. THERE BE
TRANSPARENCY THAT THEY'RE BEING
INITIATION BY THE AG'S OFFICE
EITHER BY DISPATCHED ATTORNEY
OR BY THE CREATION OF A
SUBDIVISION WITHIN THE AG'S
OFFICE. HAVEN'T THEY ALWAYS HAD
THE AUTHORITY TO DO THIS SO
THAT'S WHY I'M JUST KIND OF
PUZZLED THAT IN OUR CURRENT
OUTRAGE AND DESPERATION FOR
LEGISLATION HAVE WE EVER ASKED
HOW WE HELD OUR CURRENT AG AND
THOSE BEFORE- THE CURRENT AG
ACCOUNTABLE. THAT THIS IS A
COMMUNITY DEMANDS AND MAYBE NOT
JUST AT THE STATE LEVEL BUT
ALSO AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AS
WELL IF THERE ARE FEDERAL CIVIL
RIGHTS BEING VIOLATED. SO I
GUESS. R. I WILL I WILL
PROBABLY BE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS.
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT WE
SHOULD THINK THAT. THIS IS
GRANTING POWERS THEY DIDN'T
ALREADY EXIST MAYBE WE SHOULD
BE ASKING OURSELVES WHY WEREN'T
THESE POWERS ACTED UPON.
EARLIER. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS THE CENTER GROVE. I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT- I
REALIZED AND IT'S JUSTIFIED FOR
THE PASSION ON THE SUBJECT
MATTERS THAT WE ARE DEALING
WITH- BOTH I'M FROM BOTH SIDES
IT'S SAM. I DON'T THINK ANYONE
OF US- I KNOW NO ONE IN MY
CAUCUS AND I DOUBT VERY
SERIOUSLY ANYBODY ON IT THE
SENATE FLOOR ANY ANYBODY I
KNEW. I FOR ONE MOMENT THOUGHT
THAT WATCHING SOMEBODY HAVE
THEIR KNEE ON THEM FOR A SOLID
AND EIGHT AND A HALF MINUTES OR
EIGHT MINUTES. EVER LONGER AND-
IT WAS NOT IT WAS NOT RIGHT WE
WATCHED IN THE END AND DIE
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US MURDERED
RIGHT IN FRONT OF US AND I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUES ON THAT THAT AT ALL
AND I REALIZE THAT THIS IS AN
EMOTIONALLY CHARGED ISSUE AND-
I DO WANT TO GET BACK TO THE
BILL AT HAND IF POSSIBLE THE
CONCERN AND WHY CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY IS THAT AND
DEAD THE VERSION OF THE BILL IS
ODDLY DEFINED AS AN ARMED
CIVILIAN- AND IT'S AS THE
DEFINITION OF IT IS AS CARRYING
AN UNLOADED FIREARM. I ASK YOU
TO PUT YOURSELF IN THE POSITION
OF A POLICE OFFICER AND WHO IS
THAT COMING UP ON SOMEBODY WHO
IS DATABASE THINK HAS COMMITTED
A CRIME OR IS COMMITTING A
CRIME AND DOESN'T MATTER THEIR
SKIN COLOR BUT THAT- THAT
INDIVIDUAL THAT THEY'RE COMING
IN CONTACT WITH PULLS OUT A
FIREARM AND HOW DOES THE POLICE
OFFICER EVEN KNOWN THAT THAT IS
NOT A LOADED FIREARM AND- IF
YOU MAKE THE WRONG DECISION AND
IT WAS A LOADED FIREARM- THEN
THAT COULD COST YOU YOUR LIFE
AND NOT YOU NOT BE ABLE TO GO
HOME WITH YOUR FAMILY SO. I
THINK WE REALLY NEED TO RETHINK
THIS BILL I THINK IT CAN BE-
YOU KNOW CORRECTED AND YOU'LL
GET- BIPARTISAN SUPPORT WHICH I
KNOW YOU DON'T CARE ABOUT
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT TO PUT OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT INTO A POSITION
WHERE SOMEBODY PULLS OUT A
FIREARM I'M IN THEY HAVE TO
MAKE A SPLIT SECOND DECISION TO
SEE IF THEY WERE GONNA. BE
KILLED OR NOT AND THEN TO COME
TO FIND OUT LATER AFTER THEY
TOOK IMMEDIATE ACTION ACTION.
THE THREAT IS THAT HOW IT'S
TRAIN WE GO THROUGH TRAINING
FOR YOU KNOW CCW TRAINING
EVERYTHING- IF YOU WERE TO
LEMONADE WHAT APPEARS AT THAT
MOMENT TO BE A THREAT AND THEN
FIND OUT LATER THAT IT WAS- AND
UNLOADED FIREARMS THAT'S A
PRETTY TOUGH CALL TO MAKE FOR
SOMEBODY IN A HEIGHTENED
SITUATION IN IN AN EMOTIONALLY
CHARGED SITUATION OR IN A
SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE TO
MAKE A SPLIT SECOND DECISION
AND TO NOTE TO THINK THAT YOUR
LIFE IS ON THE LINE AS WELL- SO
I THINK THAT. THAT DEFINITION
THAT SAYS- A KEY IT'S A DEFINED
AS AN UNARMED CIVILIAN AS ONE
CARRYING AN UNLOADED FIREARM
AND THAT'S A VERY BROAD AND I'M
NOT A GOOD JUST NOT A GOOD-
DESCRIPTION OF A BILL THAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND-
FIXED SO I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK REMOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE SENATOR MELINDA'S. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST VERY
BRIEFLY- WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A
VERY SERIOUS ISSUE HERE WITH
VERY. REAL AND SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES. AND I KNOW THAT.
THROUGH THE PROCESS THE AUTHOR
KNOWLEDGE THAT THERE WERE A
NUMBER OF CONCERNS THAT WERE
RAISED- ON THAT HE SAID WOULD
HAVE TO BE ADDRESSED AFTER THE
LEGISLATION PASSED. ON GIVEN
THE SERIOUSNESS OF WHAT WE'RE
DISCUSSING HERE I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT IS. THE BEST COURSE
OF ACTION TO. ADDRESS CONCERNS
OR PROBLEMS WITH THE BILL AFTER
THE LEGISLATION IS PASSED I
THINK WE OWE IT TO. LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND THOSE WHO HAVE
ENCOUNTERS WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GET THIS BILL RIGHT AND GET
IT. GET IT RIGHT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING AND NOT HAVE TO KEEP
MAKING CHANGES TO IT LATER ON-
SO I JUST PUT THAT OUT THERE
FOR. YOUR CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR MELINDA
CINDER MORLOCK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I AM VOTED FOR AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. THE KILLING OF AN
UNARMED PERSON. IT IS DESERVING
OF AN INVESTIGATION WHETHER THE
PERSON IS WHITE. BLACK BROWN
MALE FEMALE PERSON OF FAITH OR
NOT YOU KNOW ALL THE CHARACTER.
I RECENTLY LISTEN. TO CIVIL
RIGHTS ACTIVIST AND AUTHOR JOHN
PERKINS LEADER IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AUTHOR OF SEVENTEEN
BOOKS PERSONAL FRIEND CASTER
TO. PRESIDENT BILL CLINTON AND-
HE WAS DISCUSSING THE ROLE OF
FAITH AND HEALING RACIAL
DIVISIONS. AND HE REFERRED TO A
SONG. THAT I USED TO SING WHEN
I WAS A CHILD. IT GOES LIKE
THIS. JESUS LOVES ALL THE
LITTLE CHILDREN. ALL THE
CHILDREN OF THE WORLD RED AND
YELLOW BLACK AND WHITE THEY ARE
PRECIOUS IN HIS SIGHT JESUS
LOVES THE LITTLE CHILDREN OF
THE WORLD. BETTER PRESIDENT I
ENCOURAGE AND I VOTE. ON A. B.
FIFTEEN OH SIX THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER MORLOCK. US SENATOR
WILK. THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
OUT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
FIFTEEN OH SIX TODAY- I DO HAVE
SOME CONCERNS IT'S I THINK IT'S
OVERLY BANK- AS YOU MAY OR MAY
NOT KNOW EARLIER THIS YEAR- IN
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES IN MY
DISTRICT TWO DIFFERENT AFTER
AMERICAN. WERE FOUND HUNG IN
TREES WHICH SEEMS VERY ODD TO
ME AS ONE OF THE FIRST ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO CALL OUT RELATED
INVESTIGATION GOT ON THE PHONE
OVER THE WEEKEND TO ATTORNEY
GENERAL BECERRA. WHO WAS VERY
GRACIOUS AND GOT ENGAGED
IMMEDIATELY DURING THAT
CONVERSATION I TALKED ABOUT
HAVING TO DO MORE HE SAID I
DON'T HAVE THE BUDGET TO DO
MORE SO. THEY HE CAME IN HE
DIDN'T DO AN INDEPENDENT
INVESTIGATION BUT HE WAS
ALONGSIDE THE F. B. I. AND
EVERYBODY ELSE WHO WAS
INVOLVED. I WILL TELL YOU I
THOUGHT I BELIEVE THAT BROUGHT
COMFORT TO THE COMMUNITY AT
BROUGHT PEACE TO THE COMMUNITY
AND WHEN ALL THE FACTS WERE
CAME OUT. IN IN THE CONCLUSIONS
WERE DRAWN THEY BOTH ENDED. UP
BEING CONCLUDED AS SUICIDES.
PEOPLE BODY TO THOSE FINDINGS
SO I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
PERFECT BILL I'M SURE IT HAD TO
COME BACK IN AND TWEAK IT AT
SOME POINT. BUT I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE HOLD
EVERYBODY ACCOUNTABLE AND THAT
PEOPLE HAVE FAITH IN THEIR
GOVERNMENT THAT IT IS
TRANSPARENT AND IT IS
INDEPENDENT AND IS ALWAYS
LOOKING FOR THE TRUTH SO WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO BE AND I HAD
TODAY. THANK YOU CENTER WILL
SING NO FURTHER HANDS RAISED IN
SEEING NO FURTHER MICROPHONES
UP ON THE FLOOR SENATOR DODD
PLEASE CLOSE. YES MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THE DISCUSSION
HERE. WE'VE HEARD TWO WORDS
FAIRNESS AND TRUST. THEY'RE SO
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT WE'VE
GOTTEN ANSWERS ABOUT THE-
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO DOES HAVE
THE DISCRETION TO DO IT. BUT
IT'S SO UNDER RESOURCE ON THIS.
I WOULD REALLY LIKE TO
CONGRATULATE TO THAT- THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY FOR THE
HARD WORK THAT HE'S PUT IN ON
THIS BILL. AND THE TIME AND
EFFORT AND COMPROMISE. HERE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR DODD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT
KINS FIVE WELL. BRADFORD. FIVE
ZERO I DON HI DURAZO. I L. G.
ANI. HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. I HELLO HI WESTERN
R. I. HER TADO HI JACKSON HI
LLEVA FIVE REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL
HI MY NAME HI NIELSEN. NO PAM
FIVE FORTUNE TINO I ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE STERN.
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY FIVE WINNER
HI. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY ON A. B. FIFTEEN ZERO
SIX. BASICS PAGE EIGHTY FIFTEEN
OH SIX HI WAIT HI REGIS. FORGES
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX ABSTAINED.
TANG. TEN EIGHTY FIFTEEN OH SIX
SIXTEEN. DALLY. DAWALY AB FIFTY
OH SIX ABSTAIN. GROVE AT GROVE
AB FIFTEEN OH SIX AND STAYING.
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S AB FIFTEEN
OH SIX AND STAYING. WARLOCK. OR
LIVE TV FIFTEEN OH SIX HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. YOUR L. D.
B. FIFTEEN OH SIX ABSTAIN. WELL.
WILL IT BE FIFTEEN OH SIX HI
WELCOME HI SIR MUSICAL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM%
SIXTY NINE CYLINDER BRADFORD
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RAY AS
AN ACT RELATING TO CONVICTIONS
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. AB TWENTY ONE
FORTY SIX BY SOMEONE READ
SIMPLY ALLOWS FOR FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS. THAT
HAVE SUCCESSFULLY PARTICIPATED
IN AN INMATE FIREFIGHTER AZIMUT
FIREFIGHTER APPLY FOR
EXPUNGEMENT THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE VETTED BY CDC ARE STRICT
CRITERIA AND DURING WHAT HAS
BECOME AN ALMOST YEAR ROUND
FIRE SEASON. HELP HELP PROTECT
MANY OF COMMUNITY THESE IN HAVE
LOW LEVEL BECAUSE THE STATUS
GOOD BEHAVIOR AND ON THE PATH
TO REHABILITATION HOWEVER THEY
CANNOT REACH TRUE
REHABILITATION WITHOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE MEANINGFUL
AND GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT. THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO BRING ABOUT A
CHANGE IN WAR OUR RECIDIVISM
RATE WE HAVE TO ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO HAVE SERVED THEIR
SENTENCE PETER DEBT TO SOCIETY
HAVE OPPORTUNITY FOR MEANINGFUL
EMPLOYMENT. AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SIX WITH FORTY SEVEN I'M SORRY
WHAT ADD MUCH NEEDED BALANCE TO
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
ALLOW THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE. HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
EXPUNGEMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE CENTER HER TADO. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT OF
COLLEAGUES I KNOW THAT AT TIMES
I CAN BE A- TOUGH ON CRIME
DEMOCRAT. IS A SHARED VALUE
THAT APPEARED THROUGHOUT MY
DISTRICT BUT I'M ALSO A FIRM
BELIEVER IN CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM REDUCING RECIDIVISM AND
INVESTING A DISADVANTAGE YOUTH.
A COUPLE WEEKS AGO IN MY
DISTRICT I CAME ACROSS THE FIRE
CAPTAIN AND HIS TEAM COMPOSED
OF INCARCERATED FIREFIGHTERS.
THEY WERE BRIEFLY RESTING AFTER
FIGHTING A FIRE. AS CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN BATTLING THESE
HORRIFIC FIRES HIS FIREFIGHTERS
HAVE BEEN WILLING TO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE TO PROTECT
NOT ONLY OUR LIVES BUT THE
TRICK BUT PROTECT THE NATURAL
BEAUTY OF THE STATE. IF THAT IS
SUPPORT THIS BILL I DON'T KNOW
WHAT IS COLLEAGUES ASK YOU ALL
TO SUPPORT THOSE THAT HAVE
SUPPORTED US DURING THIS
DIFFICULT TIME BY AVOIDING EYE
ON A B. TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU CENTER HER TADO
SEEING NO FURTHER MIKE'S UP ON
THE FLOOR AND SEEING NO HANDS
RAISED CENTRE BRADFORD WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE IF WE
BELIEVE IN RECIDIVISM WE
BELIEVE IN ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS
TO PROVIDE FOR THEM NOT ONLY
THEMSELVES BUT THEIR FAMILY AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO'VE ALREADY.
EXPRESSED THEIR COMMITMENT TO
THE COMMUNITY BY PUTTING OUR
LIVES ON THE LINE WHILE
INCARCERATED FIGHTING THESE
HORRIBLE FIRES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR BRADFORD. THEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD I HAVE A FIVE
DOT. I ALSO I GOT JOHNNY I
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HI
HELLO HI WITH SO HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON I LIVE IN I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MOANING FIVE
NIELSEN. NIELSEN PAM I FORTINO.
HI ROB. FIVE RUBIO. SKINNER
FIVE STERN. NUMBER FIVE QUICO
SKI FIVE WINNER I. PLEASE CALL
THE MEMBERS WERE VOTING
REMOTELY ON AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN. FAITH. ACE AB MATERNAL
YOU'RE GOOD. EIGHTY EIGHTY
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN BATES
ABSTAIN. SUPPORTERS WE'RE JUST
AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
ABSTAINED. CHANG. THANK A. B.
TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN OF
STAYING. BALLY L. A. B. TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN UPSTATE. GROWTH.
THE EIGHTY TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN OF STAYING. MELINDA'S
MELINDA'S AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN ABSTAIN. MORE LAW. OR OR
ABC TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
ABSTAIN. AROUND. L. A. B.
TWENTY FOUR OR I'M SORRY TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN UPSTATE. WELL
WILK AB TWENTY ONE FORTY SEVEN
HI WILKE HI. THEN REMOVE THE
CALL MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA JUMP
AHEAD TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY FIVE
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT. AV TWENTY
THREE FORTY TWO BITES A
CINNAMON MCCARTY. AND I SERVE
AS A PROFIT CENTER BRADFORD I
APOLOGIZE THAT WAS MY FAULT
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
FORTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY AN ACT RELATING TO
PAROLE. SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU I'M HONORED TO JOIN
ASSEMBLYMAN MCCARTY OF THE PROD
ALTER OF AV TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO THIS BILL ADOPTS A NATION
WIDE BEST PRACTICES. TO IMPROVE
PAROLE IN CALIFORNIA THE BILL
GIVES PEOPLE ON PAROLE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EARN
REINTEGRATION CREDITS TO REDUCE
THEIR TERMS. ON ALL OF THAT
HERE SHE IS ON PAROLE IT IS
FOCUSED ON PEOPLE CURRENTLY ON
PAROLE SPECIFIC SPECIFICALLY
THOSE SERVING LIFE ON PAROLE.
PEOPLE WHO ARE ON PAROLE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEY ARE
READY TO REINTEGRATE INTO
SOCIETY AND OUR TEAM DID NO
LONGER BE A DANGER TO SOCIETY.
THIS BILL PROMOTES PUBLIC
SAFETY BY INCENTIVIZING PEOPLE
ON PAROLE TO PROACTIVELY ENGAGE
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WORK
BEYOND THEIR CONDITIONS OF
PAROLE. THE USE OF THE
PUNISHMENT MODEL WHICH PUNISHES
FAILURE AS OPPOSED TO
ENCOURAGING SUCCESS HAS PROVEN
INEFFECTIVE OVER THE YEARS THIS
BILL PASSED OUT OF THE SIMPLY
WITH BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
SIXTY VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR BRADFORD MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENA
MICROPHONES RAISED ON THE FLOOR
WERE GONNA GO TO A REMOTE
MEMBERS. SENATOR GORGEOUS. I
AGREE WITH THE MY COLLEAGUE
FROM GUARDIANS. THAT
REINTEGRATION CREDITS CAN BE
HELPFUL IN DEALING WITH
RECIDIVISM AND THE PROPOSAL
HERE- I WANTED TO CONFIRM IF I
MADE THROUGH THE- THROUGH YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT QUESTIONS THE
AUTHOR ASKING HIM TO CONFIRM
THAT SEX OFFENDERS ARE EXCLUDED
FROM THIS CREDIT REDUCTION.
CENTER REDFORD WE'LL TAKE A
QUESTION YES OKAY UP IN HERE HE
HAS TO GO RIGHT AHEAD YOUR SEX
OFFENDERS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
THIS. FOR IT THANK YOU IN MY
LIFE MY FINAL COMMENTS THAT-
COVETED SHOWCASED THAT. WE HAVE
A POPULATION PROBLEM WE HAVE AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PROBLEM WITHIN
THE- REHABILITATION SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA- OUR PRISONS. FOLKS
ARE GETTING OUT EARLIER THAN
THEY SHOULD BE- FOLKS ARE NOT
GOING IN IT AS THEY DID IN THE
PAST AND I THINK THAT AREN'T
ALLOWING PAROLE TO. PLAY A
LARGER ROLE IN HELPING THESE
INDIVIDUALS REINTEGRATE.
ACTUALLY SERVES A GREATER
PUBLIC POLICY GOAL UNDER THESE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES I WOULDN'T
ADMIT IT I WOULDN'T HAVE
RECOMMENDED THIS ON A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO. ONLY BECAUSE I THINK
GIVEN INDIVIDUAL COMMITTED A
CRIME HERE SHEET SHOULD SERVE
OUT THEIR COMPLETE SENSE- BUT
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WE
FIND OURSELVES IN CALIFORNIA
WHERE INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING TO
BE PUT ON PAROLE EARLIER THAN
THEY NORMALLY WOULD BE. THESE
TYPES OF CREDITS FOR GOOD
BEHAVIOR- ART OF OTHER US SMART
PATH FORWARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SENATOR PORCHES SEEING NO
FURTHER HANDS RAISED NO
ADDITIONAL MICROPHONES ON THE
FLOOR CENTER BRADFORD PLEASE
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE MEASURE TO ALLOW THOSE
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME AND DEMONSTRATED.
THAT THEY ARE PRODUCTIVE
MEMBERS OF SOCIETY TO
REINTEGRATE EARNED CREDITS TO
AGAIN BE PRODUCTIVE
CONTRIBUTING MEMBERS TO THEIR
COMMUNITY THE STATE IN THIS
COUNTRY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FELT.
BRADFORD I HAVE A YELLOW I DON.
HI TORONTO FIVE KALYANI FIVE
BLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG
HI PHIL I WAS SO. HI HER TADO.
I JACKSON. I LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. I MOANING HI NIELSEN
HI PAM HI FORTINO HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE STERN
AMBERG HI MY CASKEY. I WINNER
HI WE'RE NOT GOING TO OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SORRY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON A
B. TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO. BASE
BAYTEX AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO NOW FACE NOW OR JUST. OR
JUST A B. TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO HI PORGES HI CHANG. THANK
A. B. TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO
I'D CHANG HI DELHI. ALI A. B.
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO. NOW
SALLY NO. GROWTH AT GROVE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO NOW
GROVE NO MELINDA'S. THE LAND IS
A B. TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO NOW.
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. WELL I
GAVE THE TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO
HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. ABC
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO NOW
MORALE NO WILKE. WILKE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY TWO HI
WELCOME HI SENATOR MOVES CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SENATOR SKINNER. BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CRISTINA AN ACT
RELATING TO MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS
SENATOR SKINNER. THANK YOU I
MET PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE REQUIRES
THE DISCLOSURE OF INGREDIENTS
IN MENSTRUAL PRODUCTS AND THE
GOAL IS TO INCREASE AWARENESS
OF THOSE PRODUCTS THAT MAY HAVE
TOXIC CHEMICALS PRESENT. IT'S
TROUBLING TO LEARN THAT SOME
PRODUCTS DO YOU HAVE SUCH
THINGS AS THEY LAID BY
BIZJOURNALS AND SOME OTHER
CHEMICALS THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE
CARCINOGENIC. MANY STAKEHOLDERS
HAVE NOW BEEN MOVED TO NEUTRAL
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE- THIS
BILL WOULD BE ONE OF THE- AND-
FOR WOMEN TO BE ABLE TO. MAKE A
INFORMED CHOICE ABOUT THEIR
PRODUCTS AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVER THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER C. NO
MICROPHONES UP ON THE FLOOR AND
NO HANDS OF MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
FIVE ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD BY ADAM I DON HI
THE RUSSELL I GOT JOHNNY BY
LASER. TEN DOLLARS FIVE HURTS
BERG HI HELLO FIVE WESTERN. HI
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LLEVA. I
REQUIRE. MITCHELL I MOANING. I
NIELSEN. NIELSEN PAM FIVE
FOURTEEN TINO. HI RALPH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER FIVE STERN
NUMBER ALL RIGHT I Y. CASKEY I
WINNER I THINK YOU MOVING TO
OUR MEMBERS ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THIS IS ON A. B.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BAYTEX BAYTEX AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE ON BASE HI
GORGEOUS. FORTUS ABC NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE HI GORGEOUS HI
CHANG. EIGHTY NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE I SANG HI KELLY GHALI AT
EIGHTEEN. EIGHTY NINE HI.
SENATOR ALI THAT WAS NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE IF YOU COULD JUST
SAY THAT ONE MORE TIME PLEASE.
DALLY AB NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE.
HI THANK YOU SIR DALLY BY
GROWTH. GROWTH EIGHTY NINETEEN
EIGHTY NINE I GROW BY MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AB NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINE ON MONDAY HI MORLOCK. AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE HI WARLOCK
HIGH MORALE. A. B. ROUTE EIGHTY
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE HIGH
MORALE HI WELL. IT WILL BE
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE HI WELCOME
I DIDN'T REMOVE THE CULT
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY TWO SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
RECETA ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA AN ACT RELATING
TO LAND USE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MADAM PRESIDENT- IF YOU
FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE THOSE TWO
THINGS OFFERS THAT ENCOURAGES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO INCLUDE IN
OUR HOUSING ELEMENT AN ANALYSIS
OF GOVERNMENTAL CONSTRAINTS
UPON HOUSING FOR- INDIVIDUALS
IDENTIFIED UNDER THE ONEROUS
CIVIL RIGHTS ACT- IN ADDITION-
IT EXTENDS- THE PERIOD FOR THE
EXPIRATION OF. A HOUSING
ENTITLEMENTS- THAT HAVE NOT HAD
NOT EXPIRED BY MARCH FOURTH
TWENTY TWENTY BY EIGHTEEN
MONTHS- THIS IS A STANDARD
PROVISION THAT WE DO DURING
RECESSIONS- SO THAT-
CONSTRUCTION TEN WHICH IS BEING
PAUSE RIGHT NOW DO IT DUE TO A
LACK OF FUNDING. GIVEN THE
ECONOMIC COLLAPSE- CAN BE
DELAYED AND THEY CAN STILL HAVE
THEIR ENTITLEMENTS AND GET THAT
CONSTRUCTION GOING ONCE THINGS
HOPEFULLY GOT. BETTER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SENATOR WIENER SCENE
REMEMBER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP ON THE
FLOOR AND NO HANDS UP A
REMOTELY MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL ANY OBJECTION TO USING OUR.
ON CALL UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING HEARING. THE BILL DOES
REMAIN ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE NOW MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR
CAFIERO. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER%
RAN AS AN ACT RELATING TO
VICTIMS OF CRIME SENATE
AVAILABLE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RADIUS THIS BILL WILL
STRENGTHEN CALIFORNIA'S LAW
THAT REQUIRES LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO CERTIFY
A U. R. T. VISA FORM FOR
UNDOCUMENTED VICTIMS OF CERTAIN
CRIMES AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING.
AND THEN DOCUMENTED VICTIM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A U. FOR TV SET IF
THEY OR THEIR LOVED ONES AVE
COOPERATED WITH LAW ENFORCEMENT
IN THE INVESTIGATION OF A CRIME
IN WHICH THEY WERE A VICTIM
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THE ROLE OF
POLICE DEPARTMENTS GOVERNED BY
LOCAL SCHOOL BOARDS AND PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY AND CLOSES AN
EXISTING LOOPHOLE IN THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS WHEN AN
UNDOCUMENTED VICTIMS SEEKS TO
OBTAIN CERTIFICATION YEARS
AFTER THEY HAVE COOPERATED WITH
LAW ENFORCEMENT. AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX WILL STRENGTHEN THE
OVERALL PUBLIC SAFETY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND TO CONTINUE TO
BUILD RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THIS BILL HAS
ENJOYED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER COVER
EURO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE SEEING NO HANDS
RAISED MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS I FELT. BRADFORD
CABRERA FIVE THOUGHT. HI THE
RISER. I GOT JOHNNY HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HEARD SPURRED BY
HILL HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO.
HI JACKSON. FIVE LLEVA HI I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME
I NIELSEN. FIVE PM I PUT INTO
YOU KNOW. HI ROTH I REVERE.
SKINNER YEAH HI STERN. AMBERG
HI HI HI CASKEY FIVE WINNER I.
BRADFORD HI. THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO OUR MEMBERS WERE VOTING
REMOTELY THIS IS AB. TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX. BASED BATES AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX ABSTAIN.
GORGEOUS ORDERS A B. TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX OF STAYING.
CHANG TANG AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX I CHANG I DALLY.
KELLY AT TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX
A STATE. GROWTH THE EIGHTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX ABSTAIN.
MELINDA'S WHEN DOES AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX NOW. MELINDA'S
NO MORE LOCK. FOR WARLOCK AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX ABSTAIN
MORALE. L. A. B. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX NOW. MORALE NO. WELL
WE'LL LOOK AT TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX HI. WILKE HI SENATOR
MUSICAL MEMBERS ARE GONNA TAKE
A QUICK BREAK NOT TO LEAVE A
BREAK LIKE AS IN ONE MINUTE SO
STAND BY.
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO FILE ITEM SEVENTY FIVE
SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
SECRETARY PAST TEMPORARILY
THANK YOU MA'AM. SENATOR
MITCHELL REMOVED THE FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX SENATOR CABALLERO.
NOT AT HER DESK. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE UP SORRY THAT WASN'T THE
CORRECT ONE ANYWAY FILE ITEM
SEVENTY EIGHT SENATOR MITCHELL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE
AN ACT RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS MEASURE-
IS SPONSORED BY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER LARA AND WOULD
PROTECT DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM
BEING FORCED TO WORK IN HOUSE
CONDITIONS SUCH AS THOSE CAUSED
BY WILDFIRES. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL WOULD EXTEND EXISTING
PROTECTIONS AGAINST RETALIATION
FOR REFORM REFUSING TO WORK IN
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS TO
DOMESTIC WORKERS THE WILDFIRES
IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
DEMONSTRATED THE NEED FOR THIS
BILL AND NEWS STORIES HAVE
SHOWN US THAT MANY DOMESTIC
WORKERS. CONTINUE TO WORK IN
HAZARDOUS CONDITIONS OUT OF
FEAR THAT THEY'LL FACE ITALIAN
IF THEY REFUSED TO DO SO. THERE
IS NOTHING IN CURRENT
CALIFORNIA LABOR CODE THAT
CLEARLY AND EXPRESSLY PREVENTS
A DOMESTIC IN. FROM ORDERING A
DOMESTIC WORKER TO REMAIN IN A
MANDATORY EVACUATION SOME OF A
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER TO DO SO
IN THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT
DOMESTIC WORKERS FROM BEING
COMPELLED TO ENTER SUCH AREAS
IT'S ALSO RELEVANT NOW AS A
RESULT OF COLD IT. THEY ARE AN
INTEGRAL PART OF OUR LIVES AND
ARE WORTHY OF THE VERY SAME
PROTECTIONS WE PROVIDED TO
EVERY OTHER CALIFORNIA WORKER.
I ASKED FOR AN AIBO. THANK YOU
SENATOR MITCHELL DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE CENA MICROPHONES RAISE
ON THE FLOOR NO HANDS RAISE
FROM A REMOTE SENATORS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
FELT BRADFORD I HAVE A I
THOUGHT I THE RUSSELL. I CALLED
JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. I TELL I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO. HI JACKSON HI LLEVA I
REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL. HI MY
NAME HI NIELSEN. I CAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO I. ROSS HI RUBIO.
SKINNER FIVE STERN. HI NUMBER
ALL RIGHT I WORK CLOSELY HI
WINNER. HI WE'RE GONNA TOUR
MOVING CENTERS THIS IS A B. TWO
SIX FIVE EIGHT BEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SIX EIGHT
AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT NO.
PLEASE NO POR JUST BORJAS AB
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT NO
PORCHES NO CHANG. THANK A. B.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT HI
TURNING HI DALLY. VALLEY A. B.
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT NO.
VALLEY NO GLAZER. SORRY GROVE.
AT EIGHT TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT
OBTAINED. MELINDA'S. WHEN DOES
THE B. TWENTY SO FIFTY EIGHT
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK OR
UNLOCK A B. TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
ABC TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT NOW
MORALE NO WILKE. WELL AB TWENTY
SIX FIFTY EIGHT HI WELL HI
SENATOR. NIELSEN I DON'T KNOW
SENATOR MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS
WERE GONNA GET MOVED BACK IN
THE FILE ORDER AND WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM THIRTY
THREE SENATOR WIENER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY SEVENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WEBER AN ACT RELATING TO
JURIES SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
PROBABLY RISE TODAY. TO
PRESENTS ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
SEVENTY ON BEHALF OF DR SHIRLEY
WEBER. OUR COLLEAGUES AB THIRTY
SEVENTY WILL REDUCE ON LAWFUL
DISCRIMINATION PARTICULARLY
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN THE
EXERCISE OF PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES TO PROSPECTIVE
JURORS IN CRIMINAL CASES. I'M
CALLING TO SEE IF I MAY BE
BLUNT- THIS BILL IS ABOUT
ENDING WHAT HAS BEEN GOING ON
FOR MANY MANY YEARS IN THIS
COUNTRY- SPECIFICALLY THE
EXCLUSION. OF BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES JURIES. A PROBLEM
THAT HAS BEEN WITH US AND THAT
UNDERMINES CONFIDENCE IN THE
ENTIRE SYSTEM. WE HAVE FOCUSED
VERY JUSTIFIABLY ESPECIALLY IN
THE LAST FEW MONTHS. AND AYS
THE FEW MINUTES AGO WITH EIGHTY
FIFTEEN OH SEX. ON THE
CHALLENGES- AND A TERRIBLE
SITUATIONS THAT COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR FACE WHAT POLICING. AND
THE UNACCEPTABLE SHOOTINGS AND
MURDERS THAT WE HAVE SEEN. BUT
WE NEED TO ALSO BE CLEAR THAT
POLICING. IS STEP ONE OF OUR
BROKEN CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
A BROKEN SYSTEM THAT IS PART OF
THE STRUCTURAL RACISM THAT WE
ARE TRYING TO TEAR DOWN IN THIS
COUNTRY. ONCE YOU GET PAST THE
POLICING. ENTRY INTO THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. YOU'RE
GONNA FACE A TRIAL SYSTEM. THAT
IS A PROBLEM AND THAT LEADS TO
OVER INCARCERATION AND MASS
INCARCERATION. THAT DOESN'T
ALWAYS PROVIDE PEOPLE WITH A
FAIR TRIAL TO WHICH THEY ARE
ENTITLED. OUR SUPREME COURT IN
CALIFORNIA BAR THIS
DISCRIMINATION BARRED THE
STRIKING OF PEOPLE BASED ON
RACES FROM JURIES IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT. THE US SUPREME
COURT DID THE SAME THING IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX AND THE
BATSON DECISION. FOR THE LAST
FORTY YEARS COURTS AND LEGAL
SCHOLARS HAVE DEBATED WHETHER
THE PROCESS IN EXISTENCE. IS
ADEQUATE AT STOPPING ANGEL
DISCRIMINATION IN THE SELECTION
OF JURIES. CALLING THIS PROCESS
THE DATSUN WHEELER PROCESS HAS
FAILED. THAT IS ACROSS THE
NATION SHOW THE JURIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY WHITES
THEY'RE WHITER AND WEALTHIER
THAN THE COMMUNITY AT LARGE.
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY PUBLIC
DEFENDER TOLD THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. HE HAS DIFFICULTY
GETTING AFRICAN AMERICAN JURORS
ON JURIES IN OAKLAND TO THE
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES. AND I
KNOW EVERYONE KNOWS PROTESTING
CASE A PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE IS
ONE ATTORNEY CAN STRIKE SOMEONE
FROM A JURY. FOR PRETTY MUCH
ANY REASON. AB THIRTY SEVEN IT
DOES NOT CHANGE THE EXISTING
SUBSTANTIVE LAW BARRING
DISCRIMINATION IT'S BEEN
ILLEGAL FOR OVER FORTY YEARS
THE STRIKE SOMEONE FROM A JURY
BASED ON RACE. WHAT IT CHANGES
IS THE COURT PROCESS FOR
ASSESSING WHETHER A PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE IS BASED ON RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. IT MAKES A FEW
NEEDED CHANGES AND THE GOAL
HERE IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAD A BROADER AND FAIRER CROSS
SECTION OF OUR COMMUNITY
REPRESENTING OUR FULL
DIVERSITY. EIGHTY THREE SEVENTY
ALLOWS JUDGES TO OBJECT ON
THEIR OWN MOTION TO PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES BASED ON CONCERNS BY
THE COURT ABOUT RACIAL
DISCRIMINATION. EIGHTY THREE
SEVENTY SHIFTS THE BURDEN FROM
THE PERSON WHO IS OBJECTING. TO
A PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE. TO THE
PERSON EXERCISING THE
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGE THE PERSON
WHO EXERCISES THE CHALLENGE
WE'LL HAVE TO JUSTIFY IT AS NOT
BASED ON RACE. AT THIRTY SEVEN
CHANGES THE STANDARD. FROM
SUBJECTIVE INTENT TO OBJECT OF
ACTION. SO INSTEAD OF HAVING TO
PROVE PURPOSEFUL DISCRIMINATION
WHICH CAN BE DIFFICULT TO
IMPOSSIBLE TO PROVE THAT THE
ATTORNEY STRUCK SOMEONE BECAUSE
THE ATTORNEY INTENDED TO
DISCRIMINATE BASED ON RACE.
INSTEAD OF LOOKING AT THE
TOTALITY OF THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND WHETHER THERE IS A
SUBSTANTIAL LIKELIHOOD THAT AN
OBJECTIVELY REASONABLE PERSON
WOULD YOU RACE AS A FACTOR. IN
THE USE OF THAT PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE WE KNOW THAT DUE TO
IMPLICIT BIAS PEOPLE MAY NOT
ALWAYS BE MALICIOUSLY INTENDING
TO EXCLUDE SOMEONE BUT THE
EFFECT IS THE SAME. GUY THE
EXCLUSION WAS BASED ON RACE.
THE BILL ALSO ESTABLISHES A
NUMBER OF PRESUMPTIVELY INVALID
REASONS. FOR A PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE. FOR EXAMPLE IF
SOMEONE WHO HAS HAD MEMBERS OF
THEIR FAMILY WHO HAVE HAD
INTERACTIONS WITH THE POLICE OR
WHO HAVE SOME DEGREE OF
SKEPTICISM. OF THE POLICE
THERE'S A LAUNDRY LIST OF
FACTORS THAT ATTORNEYS HAVE
USED TO EXCLUDE PEOPLE THAT
HAVE THE EFFECT. OF BEING BASED
ON DISPROPORTIONATELY ON RACE.
THE V. THIRTY SEVENTY
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGES THE
DYNAMICS IN JUROR SELECTION TO
REDUCE RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
AND INCREASE THE DIVERSITY OF
THOSE WHO SERVE ON OUR JURIES
AND AGAIN WE HAVE TO
FUNDAMENTALLY FIX POLICING. BUT
IF WE FIX POLICING AND STOP
THERE WE HAVE FAILED. AND ONE
PIECE THAT WE HAVE TO FIX ITS
HOW WE TAKE OUR JURIES AT
THIRTY SEVENTY AS LONG OVERDUE.
WE RECEIVED A LETTER FROM THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL GOING NEUTRAL
ON THE BILL AND PROVIDING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THIS IS A
BILL THAT IS NEEDED. IT IS A IT
IS APPROPRIATE FOR THIS
LEGISLATURE TO STEP IN AND MAKE
OUR JURY SYSTEM MORE FAIR AND
MORE JUST AND I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YO SENATOR WIENER
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO GO TO
FLORIDA BAY BUT JUST SO YOU
KNOW WE'RE GONNA IX IT UP A
LITTLE AND WE'RE GONNA GO BACK
AND FORTH FROM OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING MORE
REMOTELY. BUT WE ARE GOING TO
START WITH MADAME PRO TEM. WELL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES THANKS ARRIVES TODAY
IN STRONG SO. OF A THIRTY. BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER. THIS
BILL WOULD PROVIDE A MUCH
NEEDED MECHANISM FOR
CALIFORNIA'S COURTS TO ASSESS
WHETHER A CHALLENGE TO SOMEONE
SERVING A JURY'S BASED ON
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION. LOOK
I'LL GRANT YOU MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SAN FRANCISCO MENTIONED-
ATTORNEYS AND AT. THE ACADEMIC
WORLD AND ALL OF THAT I AM
CLEARLY NOT THAT BUT- I THINK
IF THERE'S ANYTHING THAT WE
HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING ON THIS
FLOOR. IT IS RACIAL EQUITY AND
THE IMPACT. OF SYSTEMIC RACISM
IN ALL ASPECTS OF OUR SOCIETY
AND SO WHEN I SAY THIS IS A
MUCH NEEDED MECHANISM I SPEAK
AS A LAY PERSON BUT SOMEONE WHO
CLEARLY UNDERSTANDS THE IMPACT.
ON OUR COMMUNITY MEMBERS. THIS
IS A HISTORIC TIME IN OUR
NATION AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AS I'VE SAID FOR HUNDREDS OF
YEARS EXPLICIT AND IMPLICIT
BIAS OBTAINED IN OUR SYSTEMS OF
BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND ITS COURT ROOMS IN
JURIES ARE NOT IMMUNE. THE JURY
SYSTEM IS ONE OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT FRONT LINES OF DUE
PROCESS INCLUSION AND
REPRESENTATION ARE CRITICAL
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM DIVERSITY SHOULD
NOT JUST BE A CIRCUMSTANTIAL
BONUS. IT'S FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR
JURY SYSTEM MOREOVER A JURY OF
ONE'S PEERS IS FOUNDATIONAL TO
HAVING A FAIR JURY AND
OBTAINING A FAIR TRIAL. MAYBE
THIRTY SEVENTY IS A STEP
TOWARDS PREVENTING ATTORNEYS
AND JUDGES FROM UNFAIRLY
REMOVING PEOPLE FROM A JURY.
COOL BASED ON ACTUAL OR
PERCEIVED RACE ETHNICITY OR
NATIONAL ORIGIN. AND IT'S AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA TO
INTERPRET THE STRUCTURAL RACISM
THAT HAS BEEN ALLOWED TO
PERMEATE PERMEATE OUR JUSTICE
SYSTEM. EIGHTY THIRTY SEVEN IS
A CHANCE FOR US TO RIGHT THIS
WRONG WE TALKED THE TALK AND
NOW I THINK IT'S TIME FOR US TO
WALK THE WALK I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AND I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS WE'RE GOING TO
GO TO A REMOTE VOTERS I HAVE
ONE HAND UP AND THAT IS SENATOR
BORCHERS SENATOR GORGEOUS.
THANK YOU. I'M CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS BILL AND I THINK EVERYBODY
IN THE ROOM SHOULD BE BECAUSE-
ITS IMPACT IS SO. FOUNDATIONAL
THAT THIS IS NOT. YOUR EVERYDAY
TYPE OF LEGISLATION THAT COMES
ACROSS OUR DESK THIS IS THIS
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO CHANGE
VIRTUALLY EVERY ASPECT OF
COURTROOM PROCEEDINGS OFFICES
CONDUCT THEMSELVES IN THE
JUDICIAL ARM OR IN THE-
PROSECUTORIAL PROCESS. AND I
WOULDN'T WANT US TO JUMP INTO
THIS NOT AT LEAST ADDRESSING
SOME OF THE SHORTCOMINGS. I
THINK THE IDEA BEHIND IT IS TO
EQUALIZE ARE THE JURY POOL AND
ALLOW IT TO BE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE. OF THE
COMMUNITY BUT THE LEGAL
TRADITION THAT HAS DEVELOPED.
IN JURY SELECTION. HAS
BASICALLY ALLOWED THE PARTIES
TO SH TO- TO ELIMINATE ALL
POTENTIAL JURORS WITHOUT COST
WITHOUT HAVING TO EXPLAIN
THEMSELVES. AND I THINK GATHERS
AND BENEFITS THERE'S ALSO
DRAWBACKS COMMUNITY DRAWBACKS
TO THAT. BUT TO CREATE. AS A
MATTER OF LAW THAT AID
DISMISSAL OF A JUROR ON THE WAR
IT FEATURES NOT SELECTED THAT
IT MUST BE FOR COSTS AND THE
PRESUMPTION IS THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL ATTORNEY SEEKING TO
REMOVE SOMEONE FROM THE POOL
HOUSE TO PROVE UP WHY THEY'RE
DOING IT IN WAYS THAT DON'T
PERTAIN TO. ETHNICITY GENDER
SEX. NATIONALITY RELIGIOUS
AFFILIATION. I THINK IS GOING
TO CREATE AN INORDINATE AMOUNT
OF PROBLEMS THOSE I THINK CAN
BE OVERCOME IT'S THE OTHER
THINGS THAT I THINK WE NEED TO
PAY ATTENTION TO THIS BILL
SPECIFIES THAT BEING
INATTENTIVE. HAVING A
PROBLEMATIC ATTITUDE OR
PROVIDING UNINTELLIGENT OR
CONFUSED ANSWERS. ARE
PRESUMPTIVELY INVALID. UNLESS
THE TRIAL COURT IS ABLE TO
CONFIRM THAT THE ASSERTIVE
BEHAVIOR OCCURRED AND THEN ONLY
IF THE MOVING PARTY CAN PROVE
THAT THE BEHAVIOR MATTERS TO
THE CASE. THIS IS NOT JUST
REVERSING THE BONUS. THIS IS
TAKING AWAY FUNDAMENTAL.
FUNCTIONALITY OF THE JURY POOL.
THAT YOU GIVE SOMEONE CANNOT
PAY ATTENTION OR SOMEONE IS
ABSOLUTELY GET ATTENTIVE CANNOT
IS NOT PROCESSING THE
CONVEYANCE OF EVIDENCE AND
INFORMATION. DISALLOWING THAT
INDIVIDUAL TO BE RMOVED I
THINK IS. IT IT IT DEFIES LOGIC
ARIANNA I THINK THAT THIS CAN
BE REDRAFTED BUT LET'S ALSO NOT
FORGET THAT THIS IS ALSO GOING
TO APPLY TO CIVIL TRIALS IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX. WE ARE FOR
THIS BILL. ATTEMPTS TO WRITE
EVERY HISTORICAL INJUSTICE AS
MANIFESTED IN THE JURY PROCESS
AND I THINK IT IS WITH SUCH A
HEAVY HAMMER BUT THERE WILL BE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THIS
DESERVES TO BE BROUGHT BACK IN
JANUARY I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES TO
APPRECIATE THE GRAVITY OF THIS
BECAUSE THERE'S NO GOING BACK
THIS DESERVES A MORE THOROUGH
NON. COATED TRUNCATED
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE WE NEED TO GO
BACK TO THE DRAWING BOARD IN
THIS BE GIVEN THE FULL VETTING
OF ALL THE RELEVANT COMMITTEES
BECAUSE I THINK AT TIS POINT
CERTAIN FOLKS ARE. BEING ABLE
TO OPPORTUNISTIC LEAD
STREAMLINED THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS BECAUSE WE HAVE REDUCED
OUR LEGISLATIVE CYCLE TO SUCH A
DEGREE AND WE'RE LETTING
SOMETHING AS SIGNIFICANT AS
THIS PASSED THROUGH. THIS WILL
BE A PROBLEM I ENCOURAGE MY
COLLEAGUES EVEN THOSE THAT WANT
TO SUPPORT THIS. THIS DESERVES
MORE VETTING PLEASE
RESPECTFULLY ABSTAIN OR- OPPOSE
THIS WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT
IT BE BROUGHT BACK IN JANUARY.
THANK YOU SENATOR BARGES
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I WANT TO
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE PRESIDENT
PRO TEM AT LEAST 90% OF THEM.
THIS IS AN ISSUE I WANT TO
COMPLIMENT THE SIMPLY WOMAN
WEBER BECAUSE SHE HAS ADDRESSED
AN ISSUE THAT IS A PROBLEM
HISTORICALLY HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM. THIRTY YEARS AGO OR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS AGO THE U. S.
SUPREME COURT TRIED TO DRESS IN
THE- DECISION ON HIS BATS AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO POINTS OUT ISN'T
QUITE WORK THE WAY. WE WOULD
HOPE IT WOULD WORK. BUT I AGREE
WITH JUSTICE THURGOOD MARSHALL
JUSTICE MARSHALL SAID
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES WHICH
WERE THROWN OUT. IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM SOMETIME AGO ARE
INHERENTLY PROBLEMATIC BECAUSE
YOU'RE EXERCISING A PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE BASED ON BIAS YOU'RE
EXERCISING IT BASED ON YOUR
OBSERVATION OF A POTENTIAL
JUROR WHAT THEY HAVE IN THEIR
HANDS WHAT SHOES THEY'RE
WEARING WHAT THEY MIGHT BE
READING WHO THEY TALKED TO ON
THE JURY POOL THAT'S ALL YOU
HAVE TO GO ON. AND SO JUSTICE
THURGOOD MARSHALL WAS RIGHT HE
SAID WE SHOULD ELIMINATE THE
MALL AND I AGREE WITH HIM. WHAT
I'VE DONE IS I'VE STUDIED THIS
IN IN IN FACT THIS IS THE
DOCTRINAL. BASIS FOR A. B.
THIRTY SEVEN. IT'S A WORK BY UC
BERKELEY DEATH PENALTY CLINIC
ENTITLED WHITE WATCHING THE
JURY BOX. AND IT IS WELL DONE I
MAY NOT AGREE WITH ALL OF IT IS
WELL DONE. AND WHAT IT SAYS AND
WHAT ITS CONCLUSION IS THAT
THERE ARE OTHER PLACES OTHER
STATES THEY'RE DEALING WITH
THIS ISSUE. IN FACT WASHINGTON
STATE WAS FIRST AMONG THE
STATES. IN FACT BUT WITH YOUR
PERMISSION MA'AM PRO
TEMPERAMENTAL PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE TO READ WITHOUT OBJECTION
IT IT. IT QUOTES. JUSTICE
GONZALEZ IS THE FATHER OF
WHAT'S KNOWN AS GENERAL THIRTY
SEVEN WASH AND STATE. IT SAYS.
IN THE DOCUMENTS IS TIED FOR TO
SET A DECISIVE COURSE
CORRECTION BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE NOW. WE NEED LOOK
NO FURTHER THAN WASHINGTON'S
EXAMPLE TO MAKE THIS POINT
STUDIES LEADING TO THE ADOPTION
OF. G. R. THIRTY SEVEN
IDENTIFIED THE SAME INTRACTABLE
DISCRIMINATORY JURY SELECTION
PRACTICES UNDER BATS OF. THE
WASHINGTON SUPREME COURT
IMPLEMENTED A PRACTICAL
WORKABLE SOLUTION THROUGH G. R.
THIRTY SEVEN WHICH IS THE BASIS
FOR A B. THIRTY SEVENTY. BUT AT
THIRTY SEVENTY. GOES WELL
BEYOND AND IS QUITE DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WAS IMPLEMENTED IN
WASHINGTON STATE. AP THIRTY
SEVEN EXCUSE ME A. B. THIRTY
SEVENTY GOES SO FAR BEYOND THAT
THE ASSOCIATION OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN JUDICIAL OFFICERS SAID
WAIT A MINUTE. WAIT A MINUTE.
WE NEED TO STEP BACK AND LOOK
AT WHAT HAPPENED IN WASHINGTON
A COUPLE YEARS AGO. CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION SAID THERE
NEEDS TO BE AMENDMENTS AND LET
ME ILLUSTRATE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES SOME OF THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES. OF
THIS AS I MENTIONED BEFORE YOU
EXERCISE PEREMPTORIES BASED ON
JUST SOME VERY RUDIMENTARY
HELLO THAT INFORMATION UNLESS
YOU'RE WEALTH UNLESS YOU HIRE
A JURY CONSULTANT. WHO CAN LOOK
IN. PROVIDE YOU INFORMATION AS
TO WHO MIGHT BE FAVORABLE NOT
BE FAVORABLE ONLY THE WEALTHY
CAN DO THAT. BY THE WAY. BUT
LET ME GIVE YOU AN ILLUSTRATION
SO LONG TIME AGO AS FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
ORANGE COUNTY. THERE WAS A
FAMILY AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
FAMILY LIVED IN WESTMINSTER.
SKIN HAS DECIDED TO DRIVE THEM
OUT OF THEIR NEIGHBORHOOD. BY
BURNING A CROSS ON THE FRONT
LAWN. AT THAT TIME THERE WERE
NO HATE CRIME LAWS ON THE BOOKS.
WE HAD A LAW A FEDERAL LAW THAT
SAYS YOU CAN'T INTERFERE WITH
SOMEONE IN THEIR EXERCISE OF
THEIR RIGHT. TO OWN ON OCCUPIED
HOUSING. WAS A MISDEMEANOR. BUT
WE TOOK IT AND WE COMBINED WITH
A CONSPIRACY TO MAKE IT A
FELONY. NOW WE BEGIN THE TRIAL.
I LOOKED AT THE JURY POOL.
BASED ON JUST LOOKING AT THEM I
HAD TO MAKE CERTAIN ASSESSMENTS.
I SAW THAT THERE WAS NOT A
SINGLE AFRICAN AMERICAN AMONG
THEM BUT BEHIND ME IN THE
VENEER. OR TO AFRICAN AMERICANS.
AND I DESPERATELY WANTED AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN ON THE JURY.
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THEY MIGHT BE
ABLE TO EXPLAIN UNDERSTAND.
WHAT BURNING A CROSS ON
SOMEONE'S FRONT LAWN MEANT.
BECAUSE THE DEFENSE WAS THIS
WAS A PRANK THIS IS JUST A
NEIGHBORHOOD CORAL OUT OF
CONTROL BURNING A CROSS IS NOT
A PRANK IT WAS AN ACT OF
TERRORISM. AN ACT OF TERRORISM
OVERCOME THAT DEFENSE I WANTED
SOMEBODY ON THE JURY THEY COULD
EXPLAIN THAT AND SO I LOOKED AT
THE JURY POOL AND BASED ON
CLOTHING AND OTHER THINGS I
BOUNCED MEMBERS UNTIL AGAIN
AFRICAN AMERICAN JUROR ON THE
JURY POOL. IN THAT BOX SO THEY
COULD. PRESUMABLY EXPLAIN WHY
THIS WAS AN ACT OF TERROR. NOW
I KNOW YOU'RE THINKING THAT'S
JUST A SMALL EXAMPLE THAT'S
JUST ONE EXAMPLE. AND IT IS ONE
EXAMPLE. BUT THERE ARE GOING TO
BE MANY EXAMPLES WHERE FOR
EXAMPLE YOU HAVE. A BLACK
VICTIM. AND YOU HAVE A WHITE
OFFICER BECAUSE THIS WORKS BOTH
WAYS IT DOES BASICALLY
ELIMINATE THE PROSECUTION'S
RIGHT PRINTER EARLY CHALLENGE
BUT THAT HIS UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES. THAT IS
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE CASE THERE
COULD BE MUCH MORE CHALLENGING.
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST THIS BILL
IS NOT EFFECTIVE EVEN BY ITS
OWN LANGUAGE TILL TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. THAT WE DO IS TAKE A STEP
BACK AND WE SPEND SOME TIME
EXAMINING THIS VERY PROFOUND
CHANGE TO OUR TRIAL PROCEDURE.
WHEN WE COME UP PERHAPS WE DID
NOT GENERALLY THIRTY SEVEN AS A
SUGGESTED BY JUSTICE CAN
THOUSAND WATCHING STATE. BUT WE
NEED TO TAKE A STEP BACK WE
NEED TO TAKE A STEP BACK BEFORE
WE JUMP LISTEN WE CAN'T BECAUSE
IT'S NOT EFFECTIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. I URGE FOLKS TO AT
LEAST STAY OFFICE BILL SO WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO CRAFT THE
MECHANISM THAT IS FAIR TO ALL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
UMBERG SENATOR JACKSON. IS
THANK YOU. MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES IDEA HIM. STANDING
HERE IS ONE OF A FEW. WHO IS
ACTUALLY PICKED A JURY. IN A
CRIMINAL CASE IT'S A VERY
COMPLICATED PROCESS. IT IS AS
FEDERER ON BURKE SAYS OFTEN
TIMES YOU USE YOUR INTUITION.
YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT WHAT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
ARE OF THE CASE. WHAT KIND OF
INSURANCE DO YOU WANT. AND YES
WE HAVE TRIED TO PROTECT
AGAINST RACIAL BIAS IN OTHER
BIASES BY A DECISION THAT IS
THIRTY OR FORTY YEARS OLD I
BELIEVE- BACK IN THE EIGHTIES-
AND THERE IS A THERE THERE IS A
PROCESS IF THERE IS A BELIEF
THAT BIAS IS BEING EXERCISED.
AND THE JUDGE IS SUPPOSED TO A
CHALLENGE- THAT KIND OF SERIAL
DISMISSAL OF A JUROR WITHOUT
BECAUSE HE'S JUST I DON'T LIKE
THE WAY THAT JUROR LOOKS SORE I
WANT TO HAVE SOMEBODY WHO
UNDERSTANDS WHAT THE POTENTIAL
LIFE EXPERIENCES ALL OF THE
VICTIMS OR ALL OF THE
DEFENDANT. HOW THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL ARE HAS A WORKING GROUP
THAT HAS BEEN PUT TOGETHER UP
WITH EXPERTS TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THIS VERY PROBLEM BECAUSE I
CERTAINLY AGREE THAT THERE IS
BIAS IN OUR COURTS THERE IS
BIAS IN LIFE IN OUR CORE TO
REFLECTION OF LIFE AND TO GO
OUT THERE AND TO TRY IN A JURY
TRIAL TO PULL OUT IMPLICIT
BIAS. IS PROBABLY GOING TO ADD
WEEKS TO EACH JURY TRIAL. AND
AT A TIME WHEN JUSTICE IS VERY
HAS VIRTUALLY COME TO A HALT.
WE'RE LOOKING AT YEARS OF
BACKLOG EVEN TO TRY CASES EVEN
TO TRY MISDEMEANOR CASES AND I
MAY BE WRONG BUT I BELIEVE IN
WASHINGTON. THIS WAS APPLIED
FOR. CAPITAL CASES IF I'M NOT
MISTAKEN AND YET IN CALIFORNIA
WE'RE BRINGING IT DOWN TO THE
VERY BASIC. THE CASE FOR
MISDEMEANOR TRIALS THIS IS
COMPLICATED STUFF THIS IS GOING
INTO OUR COURT SYSTEM AND
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
IDENTIFY AND ROOT OUT BIAS A
VERY WORTHY CAUSE AND I COMMEND
THE AUTHOR THIS BILL FOR HER
PASSION AND HER COMMITMENT AND
RIGHTEOUSNESS. IN THIS COST.
BUT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REALLY DOES REQUIRE. THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE WELL IN THE
SYSTEM WHO UNDERSTAND WHO LEAVE
THE SYSTEM WHO ARE TRYING TO
SEE THAT JUSTICE IS DONE WORK
TOGETHER IN FACT THREE YEARS
AGO THE CHIEF JUSTICE CREATED A
PRE TRIAL DETENTION REFORM WORK
GROUP AND THE FOLLOWING YEAR
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB CAN.
REPLACING CASH BAIL. NOW WE
COULD SIT HERE AND TRY TO DO
THAT BUT WE DON'T REALLY KNOW
THE GUTS IN THE BOOK AND THE
BOLTS OF A OF THE JUDICIAL
SYSTEM WE DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
UNLESS THERE ARE PEOPLE HERE
WHO HAVE BEEN PRACTICING LONG
PICTURE REASON WHO KNOW EXACTLY
WHAT GOES ON IN THE COURTROOM
AND SO I WOULD SUGGEST IN ALL
RIGHT. YOU KNOW I KNOW
EVERYONE'S GOING TO DO WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO BUT THERE
IS ANOTHER OPTION HERE. THERE
IS THE JURY SELECTION WORK
GROUP. THAT HAS BEEN FORMED TO
STUDY THE COMPLICATED PROBLEMS
ASSOCIATED WITH BIAS IN
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES TO
PROSPECTIVE JURORS. WITH
MEMBERS WHO HAVE BEEN
APPOINTED- I WOULD NOTE THAT I
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL WENT NEUTRAL
ON THIS BILL. THEY TOOK NO
POSITION ON THIS BILL AND I
THINK THAT'S A DISTINCTION THAT
HAS TO BE DRAWN. BECAUSE THE
COURTS FREQUENTLY SAY THIS IS
NOT R. BAILEY WORK TO DECIDE
POLICY. IT IS OUR- BAILEY WE'RE
TO INTERPRET IT. AND SO I THINK
THAT WE NEED TO BE CLEAR ON
WHAT. THEY HAVE. AND WHAT THEY
HAVE NOT. DONE WITH RESPECT TO
THIS BILL- THE GOAL IS TO
ENSURE FAIRNESS OF JURY POOLS
IN THE JUDICIAL PROCESS. AND I
WOULD SUBMIT. THAT IT WOULD BE
MOST BENEFICIAL IT WOULD WORK
TO THE BENEFIT OF EVERYONE WHO
IS SEEKING. FAIRNESS AND
IMPARTIALITY IN THE COURT
SYSTEM TO LET THIS WORK GROUP
COME UP WITH ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND THEN WITH
THAT EXPERTISE AND EXPERIENCE
AND COMMITMENT FOR JUSTICE
WHICH I DO BELIEVE WE ARE
STREET WE DO SEE IN OUR
CURRENT- THE SUPREME COURT. AND
JUDICIAL COUNCIL. THEN WE CAN
MOVE AND DO IT RIGHT. AND DO IT
WELL AND DO IT EFFECTIVELY. BUT
I DO NOT BELIEVE AT THIS POINT
IN TIME. THAT WE ARE IN A
POSITION HERE TO MAKE THAT
DECISION WITH THE INFORMATION
THAT WE DO WE DO NOT HAVE. THE
JUDICIAL PROCESS IS A VERY
DELICATE ONE. IT IS A PROCESS
NOT ALWAYS. A PRODUCT. BUT WE
CAN MPROVE THEIR PROCESS AND I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT THAT IS
EXACTLY WHAT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. HAS SET UP TO DO. AND
WITH THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK. THAT WE NOT MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD TODAY. YOU CENTER
JACKSON SENATOR STERN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. YEAH I
WASN'T GOING TO GET UP AND
SPEAK A- I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO
MY HOMEWORK ON THIS LEGISLATION
AND- SHE ATE THE COMPELLING
REMARKS GIVEN- FROM THE CENTER
FROM IRVINE AND SANTA BARBARA
HERE I THINK THERE'S SOME
COMPELLING ARGUMENTS AND TO BE
HONEST I WRESTLED. MIGHTILY
WITH THIS BILL- SPECIFICALLY
BECAUSE OF SOME OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT THE CENTER
FROM IRVINE RAISED- I REPRESENT
SEAMY VALLEY. AND I'D BE REMISS
TO PASS ANY LEGISLATION. THAT
LED ANOTHER RODNEY KING VERDICT
BE MORE LIKELY. IT WAS DEEPLY
CONCERNING TO ME THAT IN SOME
WAYS WE WOULD HAND. OUR
PROSECUTORS A DIFFERENT SET OF
TOOLS SAVE IN OUR PUBLIC
DEFENDERS AND INHIBIT OUR
ABILITY TO GET MORE PEOPLE OF
COLOR- WOMEN AND OTHER
PROTECTED CLASSES ON THE JURY'S
IN THE COURSE OF THE DILIGENCE
ON THIS LEGISLATION NOW. AND
GOING THROUGH IT WHAT WHAT I
REALLY LEARNED IS THAT THIS
BILL WILL HAVE. MAJOR IMPACT ON
HOW DAZN PUBLIC DEFENDER'S DEAL
WITH THEIR BOARD HEARING IN
THESE CASES I DON'T THINK THE
SPONSORS ARE THE AUTHOR DISPUTE
THAT. BUT WHAT I EAT I'VE COME
TO THE CONCLUSION IS THAT.
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO BE MORE
CREATIVE THAN SIMPLY USING RACE
AS A FACTOR. WHEN YOU ARE DOING
THOSE PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES IF
YOU'RE PROSECUTING A HATE CRIME.
OR IF YOU'RE PROSECUTING
UNAUTHORIZED USE OF FORCE.
YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIND SOME
OTHER REASON TO BUMP THAT JUROR
OTHER THAN THE FACT THAT THEY
ARE WHITE. AND THAT'S A GOOD
THING. WE SHOULDN'T BE
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST JURORS
BECAUSE THEY'RE WHITE AND WE
ASSUME THAT THEY'RE GOING TO BE
JUST STANDING UP FOR SOMEONE
WHO WOULD PERPETRATE HATE CRIME
JUST LIKE WE SHOULD BE
DISCRIMINATED JURORS BECAUSE
THEY'RE BLACK OR THEY'RE A
WOMAN. PEOPLE HAVE THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENT JUDGMENTS. I THINK
IT IS BILL STILL AFFORDS THOSE
TOOLS OF PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES
NOT JUST THE PROSECUTION BUT
ALSO THE PUBLIC DEFENDERS NOW
MIND YOU PUBLIC DEFENDERS UNDER
THIS LEGISLATION ALSO WOULD BE
BARRED FROM USING RACE AS A
FACTOR IF THEY'RE PUSHING
FORWARD OF A PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGE. AND THAT THAT
THRESHOLD WHAT THEY CALLED THE
NOBLE REVIEW THAT'LL BE
SCRUTINIZED VERY CAREFULLY. I
THINK THE NET RESULTS MAY VERY
WELL BE- THE PRESSURE BUILDS
SUCH THAT. THE SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE AND THAT COUNCIL THAT
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT HERE TODAY.
AS A FIRE LIT UNDER THEM AND
THAT THEY THEY ACTUALLY HAVE TO
HUSTLE UP. AND DO SOME WORK
RIGHT NOW. I DON'T THINK WE CAN
WAIT TILL TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO
START MAKING JURIES MORE FAIR.
I DON'T THINK WE CAN WAIT TILL
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TO WORK
THROUGH A SET OF GUIDELINES. I
REALIZED THAT THIS BILL IS
AGGRESSIVE. AND IT'S GOING TO
FORCE CHANGE. BUT I'M I'M
REALLY COMPELLED BY THIS MOMENT.
AND REALIZING THAT THE
JUDICIARY IS AN INCREDIBLY
FUNCTIONAL IN CRITICAL BRANCH
IS NOT BROKEN BUT IT IS OUR JOB
TO STEP IN AND DECIDE THESE
TOUGH POLICY QUESTIONS. WHETHER
YOU'RE WHITE OR BLACK OR YOU'RE
A WOMAN OR A MAN. I HAPPEN TO
BE- A WHITE MAN AND I LIVE IN
YOU KNOW CALABASAS. AND YET I
STILL THINK THAT THERE ARE
FUNDAMENTAL INJUSTICES IN THIS
SYSTEM. THAT HAPPENED TO PEOPLE
EVERY DAY. SO WHEN YOU VOTE ON
THIS MEASURE NO THAT. YOU ARE
GOING TO BE CAUSING A RIPPLE
EFFECT IN OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
DELAYS WILL PROSECUTE THEIR
CASES DIFFERENTLY. AND THEY'LL
STOP. AND THINK FOR A SECOND
ABOUT HOW THEY'RE MAKING THAT
ARGUMENT. AND THERE WILL BE A
LOT OF SECOND GUESSING OF
ONESELF. AND I THINK. THAT'S A
GOOD THING. TO RECOGNIZE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE IMPLICIT BIASES.
AND IT TO REALLY WRESTLE WITH
THAT AND TO LOOK OVER YOUR
SHOULDER TO KNOW THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE IS WATCHING. TO ME
IS A CRITICAL FUNCTION AT THIS
SPOT. NOT THE JUDICIAL BRANCH
THAT INTERPRETS LAW. BUT THIS
BODY DOES THE PEOPLE'S WILL HAS
TO STEP IN AND LEAD ON. SO YOU
KNOW WITH WITH THAT MUCH
DILIGENCE AND- BUT TOUGH
DELIBERATION PROCESS HERE I'M
GONNA BE SUPPORTING THIS
MEASURE TODAY. AND I THINK
THAT. IF THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
IT DOESN'T WORK OR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL STEPS IN OR THERE IS
SOME NEW SET OF GUIDELINES. SO
BE IT THEY CAN STEP IN AND WE
CAN AMEND THIS LAW. BUT FOR
RIGHT NOW I THINK WE CAN'T
AFFORD TO WAIT YOUR AGENCY THIS
MOMENT CALLS FOR IT WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL.THANK
YOU SENATOR AND MEMBERS WERE
GONNA GO TO SENATOR MORLOCKS
SENATOR MORE LIKE EUROPE. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. MY WIFE
RECENTLY RELATED A PROFOUND AND
FUNNY QUOTE THAT SHE HAD HEARD.
AND IT WENT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
MANY PEOPLE ARE JUDGMENTAL I
CAN TELL JUST BY LOOKING AT
THEM. AND SO I KIND OF
APPRECIATE HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO PICK JURORS. YEAH I AGREE
WITH THE SENATORS FROM SANTA
SANTA ANA THE ORANGE COUNTY
SEAT AND FROM SANTA BARBARA.
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT THE
SENATOR FROM MALIBU THAT IRVINE
IS IN MY DISTRICT DON'T WANT TO.
HAVE ANY CONFUSION BUT- I
BELIEVE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
SHOULD FINISH THEIR WORK. AND I
RECOMMEND A NO VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTY SEVENTY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SENATOR
MORLOCKS SENATOR HUESO. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH AND APPRECIATE-
BECAUSE HAVING THIS DISCUSSION
HI I DIDN'T TEND TO SPEAK ON
THIS BILL. EITHER BUT- I AM
CONFLICTED ON THIS BILL AS A AS
A LATINO KNOWING THAT PEOPLE OF
COLOR GENERALLY OR ARE MORE APT
TO BE REPRESENTED IN IN PRISON.
THAN IN THE VOTING BOOTHS AND
END OF CORPORATE AMERICA AND IN
AREAS THAT- ARE. OF REFLECTIVE
OF UNEQUAL OPPORTUNITY TO SEE
YOU SUCCEED IN THIS COUNTRY. SO
I WANTED TO SPEAK JUST TO
EXPLAIN MY POSITION AND WHY I
FEEL THIS BILL REALLY DOESN'T
ADDRESS THE- I DON'T THINK EVEN
AT ALL. THIS BILL DOESN'T
GUARANTEE THAT A JURY HERE-
INTERDIGITAL THIS PROCESS WILL
BE SELECTED. THAT WILL PROVIDE
A PERSON A JURY OF- THAT WILL
WOULD BE REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
COMMUNITY WELL IT WOULD ADDRESS
HOW ONE PERSON IN PARTICULAR
COULD BE DISMISSED OR NOT IT
DOESN'T GET TO- REQUIRING THAT
A JURY SHOULD BE MADE UP OF A
JURY OF OUR PEERS AND SO IN SO
MANY CASES AND THERE AE SO
MANY FACTORS THAT LEAD TO
JURIES BEEN SELECTED THAT ARE
NOT REPRESENTATIVE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. AND SO WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE CHIEF JUSTICE
UNDERTAKING A PROGRAM THAT WILL
DO A COMPREHENSIVE CHANGE TO
MAKE SURE THIS HAPPENS. I THINK
WE'RE LOSING AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE AS A LEGISLATURE TO
INFLUENCE THAT DECISION MAKING
PROCESS. AND TO SEND A BILL TO
THE LOOK THE SUPREME COURT THAT
WILL GUIDE THAT PROCESS AND
HOPE THAT WE CAN. ADDRESS
SEVERAL ISSUES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT BUT- TO BE ADDRESSED
IN ORDER THAT THAT CAN HAPPEN.
AND THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS
THAT I HAVE THE RIGHT. IDENTIFY
THAT ARE RUCIAL BUT NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED BEFORE WE CAN GET TO
A SELECTING A JURY OF OUR PEERS
ONE OF FIRST OF ALL IS HOW THE
JURY POOL IS SELECTED- ONLY
REGISTERED VOTERS AND WE KNOW
THAT WITHIN THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO COMMUNITY THERE
ARE A LOT OF REGISTERED THERE
ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITY ARE NOT REGISTERED TO
VOTE AND THEREFORE BY PAST TO
BE PROPER TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROCESS AND WHEN YOU GO TO
A JURY A LOUNGE WHERE THE POOL
IS SELECTED FROM YOU ALREADY
SEE THAT YOU HAVE A POPULATION
TO BEGIN WITH THAT'S NOT.
REFLECTIVE OF THE COMMUNITY AND
WE NEED TO ADDRESS THAT AND
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE IN AMERICA
HAS AS A ELIGIBLE TO BE
SELECTED TO SERVE. THE OTHER
ISSUE. THAT IS VERY CRITICAL.
IS THAT WHEN. BELOW ARE
SELECTED. FULL OF COLOUR
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
TEND TO BE IN OCCUPATIONS THAT
OF PROVIDE THEM UP ON. ALL OF A
VERY HARD TIME TO BE ABLE TO
SERVE BECAUSE THEY FIND
THEMSELVES IN LOW WAGE JOBS AND
SO THEY ARE MORE APT TO SELECT
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP AS A REASON
NOT TO SERVE AND COOK OUR
CURRENT. PROCESS DOES NOT
PROVIDE ANY ANY ANY PROTECTION
OR OR COMPENSATION FOR A PEOPLE
THAT ARE OF A VERY LOW ICOME
MEANS SO ONLY REALLYIN OUR OUR
CURRENT POOL WE HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN EITHER MIDDLE CLASS
OR ABOVE MIDDLE CLASS. THERE
ARE OTHER ELIGIBLE TO SERVE IN
THAT ALSO NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED
SO YOU KNOW I APPRECIATE THAT
WE'RE WORKING IN THIS AREA IT
IS VERY IMPORTANT BUT I THINK
LIKE AS I MENTIONED BEFORE I
THINK. OTHER AREAS NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED I DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY. PEOPLE THINK THAT BY ONLY
TWEAKING THIS ONE AREA THAT YOU
YOU'RE GOING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT. AND
IT COULD POSSIBLY CREATE A
CHALLENGE IN CREATING A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION BY A
TWEAKING THIS IN PARTICULAR MAY
CREATE CHALLENGES TO.
ADDRESSING OTHER ISSUES SO.
WITH ITS WITH A HEAVY HEART
THAT I WILL I'LL STAY OFF FOR
THIS MEASURE NOW AND HOPE THAT-
THE CHIEF JUSTICE CAN CONVENE A
PROCESS THAT WILL COME UP WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS AND MANY OF
THEM MIGHT REQUIRE. LEGISLATION
TO ADOPT THEM AND MAYBE WE CAN-
SUPPORT A PROGRAM THAT WILL
GET. MORE PEOPLE ELIGIBLE TO
SERVE BY BY GIVING THEM SOME
KIND OF FINANCIAL COMPENSATION
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE PEOPLE
THAT WOULD- BE HARMED
FINANCIALLY IF THEY SERVE IN
OUR SYSTEM AND THAT'S SOMETHING
WE NEED TO ADDRESS. AND FOR
THAT HI I. AM VERY SAD NOT TO
BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS TODAY I
THINK YOU SENT AWAY SO SEEING
NO HANDS RAISED AND A FURTHER
MICROPHONES UP SENATOR WINNER
PLEASE CLOSE. I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOT A
PRESIDENT AND IT'S THIS IS A
GOOD ONE TO SHOW THAT EVERYONE
IS STILL VERY- ALERT AFTER A
LONG DAY AND PAYING ATTENTION
AND ENERGIZE AND- THAT SPEAKS
WELL OF OUR LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE FOR A VERY
THOUGHTFUL. COMMENTS AND I CAN
SAY THAT- AS A TRIAL ATTORNEY
MYSELF WE TRIED QUITE A FEW
CASES- YOU KNOW I'VE HAD MY OWN
OPINIONS ABOUT JURY SELECTION
OVER TIME- BUT I KNOW THE
FUNDAMENTALLY THIS BILL IS
ABOUT SOLVING WERE MAKING
PROGRESS IN ADDRESSING A VERY
REAL PROBLEM THAT WE FACE WHICH
IS RACIAL BIAS IN OUR JURY
SELECTION PROCESS. I WANT TO
ELECT OR ELECT I WANT TO
ADDRESS A FEW FACTUAL
STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE JUST
TO MAKE SURE WE'RE ON THE SAME
PAGE ON A VISIT AS THE CENTER
OF SANTA BARBARA MENTIONED
SHE'S CORRECT THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL SENT A LETTER SAYING
THAT IT DOES NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL. AND WHAT
THE JUDICIAL. COUNCIL SAID AT
THE END OF ITS LETTER. I WAS. I
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL HAS NO
POSITION ON A. B. THIRTY SEVEN
B. AS IT BELIEVES THAT THE
PROPOSED CHANGES TO PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES OR A POLICY CALL
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THE
LEGISLATURE. WE ARE THE POLICY
MAKING BODY FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE SET THE RULES
AND THE COURTS APPLY THOSE
RULES. AND I DON'T THINK IT IS
A SOUND ARGUMENT O SAY THAT
FOR SOMETHING AS FUNDAMENTAL AS
FUNDAMENTAL THAT PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE A FAIR JURY AND THE JURY
SELECTION SHOULD NOT BE
RACIALLY BIASED. THAT IS
ABSOLUTELY NOT JUST WITHIN THE
PURVIEW OF THE LEGISLATURE IT
IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
ADDRESS A- THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
CAME FORWARD WITH DOZENS OF
AMENDMENTS. THE SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL IN THE AUTHORS SPEND
WEEKS WORKING WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND TOOK AMENDMENTS
THEY PROVIDED TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE AND AMENDMENTS WERE
TAKEN. THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION PROVIDED NUMEROUS
AMENDMENTS AND ALL OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS EXCEPT FOR ONE WERE
TAKEN. THE AFRICAN AMERICAN
JUDGES ISSUED A NEGATIVE LETTER
AND THEN SUBSEQUENTLY WITHDREW
THAT LETTER. THIS BILL THE
IMPLEMENTATION WAS DELAYED
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO WAS ORIGINALLY
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. AND THE REASON IT WAS
DELAYED WAS BECAUSE THE JUDGES
CAME FORWARD AND SAID WE HAVE
SOME TRAINING TO DO WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE IMPLEMENT IT
WELL AND SO THE AUTHOR DR
WEBBER AGREED TO A ONE YEAR
DELAY IN IMPLEMENTATION AT THE
REQUEST OF THE JUDGES SO THAT
THEY COULD BE PROPERLY TRAINED
AND THAT WAS AN APPROPRIATE
DECISION. BUT I DON'T THINK
THAT THAT MEANS THAT WELL LET'S
NOT GO INTO EFFECT ON JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY TWO ANYWAY SO
DON'T DO THE BILL I JUST DON'T
AGREE. WITH THAT WASHINGTON
STATE AND THE SENATOR FROM
ORANGE COUNTY MENTIONED THE
WASHINGTON STATE- GENERAL
THIRTY SEVEN. AND I. WILL NOT
IT'S NOT IDENTICAL TO THIRTY
SEVENTY BUT IT HAS MANY OF THE
SAME DOCTORS. TALKING ABOUT-
WITH THAT JUROR IS INATTENTIVE
OR HAS A BAD ATTITUDE. SO
THAT'S MY REAL JUSTIFICATION.
FOR STRIKING. JUROR ALL THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS ARE IN GENERAL
RULE THIRTY SEVEN FROM
WASHINGTON STATE. WE GOT A
LETTER. FROM JUSTICE GONZALEZ
FROM THE SUPREME COURT OF
WASHINGTON AND JUST AS YOU DO.
ON A BASICALLY THANKING
CALIFORNIA FOR REACHING OUT.
AND IT ENDS BY SAYING WE HOPE
OTHER STATES WILL JOIN OUR
EFFORTS IN ADDRESSING BIAS IN
JURY SELECTION. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING MORE ABOUT
YOUR WORK THERE'S NOTHING IN
THIS LETTER THAT WAS ANYTHING
OTHER THAN POSITIVE ABOUT THE
FACT THAT CALIFORNIA. WAS GOING
TO BE JOINING WASHINGTON STATE
AND TAKING AGGRESSIVE STEPS TO
ADDRESS RACIAL DISCRIMINATION
AND THE SELECTION. OF JURIES.
WELL WE HEARD A NUMBER OF
ARGUMENTS TODAY COLLEAGUES THAT
WE SHOULD DELAY THIS. WHICH ARE
THE LATEST FOR ALL SORTS OF
REASONS AND I BET YOU CAN
WANDER AROUND THIS ROOM EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF YOU COLLEAGUE HAS
HEARD THAT ABOUT ONE OR MANY OF
YOUR BILLS. WE SHOULD ESTABLISH
A WORKING GROUP. BEFORE WE DO
YOUR BILL. WE HAVE TO HAVE A
COMPLETELY COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION THAT SOLVES EVERYTHING
OR WE CAN SOLVE ONE PIECE OF IT.
WHEN WE KNOW THAT IT IS SO RARE
THAT WE WOULD EVER HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION IT'S THE
WAY OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
YOU SOLVE PIECES OF A PROBLEM
UNTIL YOU SAW. THE WHOLE THING.
ON THAT WE SHOULD AND FROM
THREE CHALLENGES AND I AGREE
WITH THE CENTER OF OUR COUNTY
THERE'S A GOOD ARGUMENT FOR
DOING THAT AND THAT'S A BILL
THAT I WOULD BE OPEN TO
SUPPORTING. I DON'T RECALL THAT
BILL. BEING PROPOSED WHAT I DO
RECALL IS THAT THE SENATOR FROM
SANTA BARBARA. INTRODUCED A
BILL THAT I SUPPORTED THAT
REDUCED. OR EXTENDED THE
REDUCTION OF PEREMPTORY
CHALLENGES. THAT BILL WAS WORLD
WAR THREE. AND IF WE WERE TO
HAVE A BILL TO AND FROM THREE
CHALLENGES MY CONFIDENCE LEVEL
THAT THAT BILL WOULD PASS IS
SOMETHING CLOSE TO ZERO BECAUSE
EVERYONE ALL SIDES OF THE BAR
WILL COME OUT FULL GUNS BLAZING
BECAUSE THEY ALL LOVE TO HAVE
PEREMPTORY CHALLENGES. BECAUSE
IT MEANS YOU CAN GET RID OF THE
PEOPLE YOU DON'T LIKE EVEN IF
YOU HAVE IMPLICIT BIAS EVEN IF
YOU DON'T REALIZE THAT THE
REASON YOU'RE STRIKING SOMEONE
IS BECAUSE OF RACE AND THAT'S
WHY THE PART OF THIS BILL THAT
SAYS IT'S NOT ABOUT YOUR
SUBJECTIVE INTENT. YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE A BAD PERSON FOR THE
PEREMPTORY TO BE RACIALLY
BIASED IT SAYS HAS TO BE THAT
WAY OBJECTIVELY REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER YOU WERE BEING
MALICIOUS. I'M CONCERNED BASED
ON THE DEBATE TODAY BUT WHAT WE
WILL SEE IF THIS BILL WAS
REJECTED IT'S UNCLEAR THAT
ANYTHING WILL HAPPEN. I HAVEN'T
SEEN A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THE
CHIEF JUSTICE IS WORKING
WITHOUT A CRITICISM I LOVE IT
SHE JUST SAYS WHAT THE GUY WHO
I DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT'S
GOING TO TAKE IT AGAIN. THEY
ARE NOT THE LEGISLATURE. SO
THIS IS A REAL ISSUE RIGHT NOW.
COLLEGE THIS IS NOT LIKE A NEW
PROBLEM THAT'S ARISEN AND WE
HAVE TO LIKE STEP BACK. AND DO
A WORKING GROUP. AND FIGURE IT
OUT AND COME UP WITH A
COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTION. THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING
FOREVER. IT AFFECTS A CERTAIN
ASPECT OF OUR COMMUNITY
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. FAR MORE
THAN ANY OTHERS IT IS LEADING
TO AN UNFAIR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. IT IS PERPETUATING
STRUCTURAL RACISM IN OUR CRIB
JUSTICE. AND WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX IT I WILL
AND COLLEAGUES WERE TALKING
ABOUT SORT OF THE BOTTOM LINE.
YES I AGREE THIS IS VERY
DIFFERENT. THIS IS A REALLY
SIGNIFICANT CHANGE WHEN I FIRST
SAW THIS BILL BECAUSE IT CAME
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
WHEN I FIRST READ IT. I'LL BE
HONEST I HAD A REACTION LIKE
WHOA WHAT'S GOING ON HERE IS
SOMEONE WHO IS EXERCISE
PRINTERS HALOGEN PICK JURIES.
AND THAT IS BECAUSE IT IS
DIFFERENT. YES IT'S DIFFERENT
THAN LEGAL TRADITION. BUT
THAT'S A GOOD THING LEGAL
TRADITION IN THIS COUNTRY HAS
RESULTED IN A RACIST CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND WE NEED TO
EXTIRPATE THAT RACISM I'M PART
OF IT IS CHANGING HOW WE PICK
JURIES LET'S GET OUT OF OUR
COMFORT ZONE. LET'S TRY
SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE WILL
HAVE A POSITIVE IMPACT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU SAID EARLIER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN. ARCHULETA ATKINS I FELL
FIVE BRADFORD. CABRERA DOT.
YOUR BROWSER. GOD JOHNNY.
GLAZER. GONZALES I HEARD BURKE.
HELLO WESTERN. HER TADO.
JACKSON NO LLEVA I REQUIRE FIVE
MITCHELL FIVE MY NAME HI
NIELSEN. PAM FIVE FOURTEEN TINA
HI RALPH. RUBIO HI SKINNER HI
STERN HI NUMBER. BY CAL SKI.
WINNER HI. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE VOTING
REMOTELY THIS IS AB THIRTY
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BASED H. A. B. THIRTY SEVEN D.
NOT VOTING. GORGEOUS. WE'RE
JUST AB THREE ZERO SEVENS NOW
OR JUST NO CHANG. HANG A B.
THIRTY SEVENTY NOW CHANG NO
DALLY. DOLLY A. B. THREE ZERO
SEVEN ZERO NO TALLY NO. ROSE.
SEVENTY GROVE NO MELINDA'S
BELINDA'S AB THREE ZERO SEVEN
ZERO NOT VOTING. MORLOCK. A. B.
THIRTY SEVENTY NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. ABC THIRTY SEVEN A NO
MORALE NO WELL. WE GAVE ME
THIRTY SEVENTY NO WELL NOW THAT.
ALLEN HI SENATOR MUSICAL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SENATOR WAY SO. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. AT SOME
LEVEL SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAUGHTER GOT
HARDWIRED- GARCIA AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC RESOURCES IN
A WAY SO THANK YOU BEEN
PRESIDENT A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN ESTABLISHES A BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION WITHIN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION THAT WOULD LOOK INTO
FINANCIAL AND POLICY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LITHIUM
EXTRACTION EXTRACTION AT THE
SALTON SEA CURRENT AMENDMENTS
ARE CLARIFYING TECHNICAL IN
NATURE THE INSURE THAT THE BLUE
RIBBON COMMISSION HAS A MIX OF
LOCAL REPRESENTATIVES AND THE
LANGUAGE IS CLEAR. FOR THE
IMPLEMENTING AGENCY THIS BILL
DOES NOT HAVE ANY OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE THING
THE MICROPHONES UP ON THE FLOOR
SEEING NO HANDS RAISED. VENOM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA I ATKINS
I FELL. I BRADFORD. AVAILABLE
DOT. HI THERE AWESOME. KALYANI
FIVE LASER. FRIENDS ALL THIS I
HEARD BURKE. FIVE HELLO. I WAS
SO FIVE FIVE HER TADO HI
JACKSON. HI LLEVA I REQUIRE. HI
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. HI
NIELSEN. NO HAND I FORTUNE TINO.
BY ROSS HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER.
HI STERN HI I'M BURKE. HI MY
CASKEY FIVE WINNER. FIVE BEEN
TO OUR MEMBERS THAT ARE VOTING
REMOTELY THIS IS A C. B.
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
MEMBERS. EIGHT ABC AT SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN BABIES NO FACE NO
CHARGES. FORGES A B. SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN ABSTAIN. CHANG
THANK A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
ARE SANG BY DOWLING. VALLEY AB
SIXTEEN THIRTYSEVEN I DALLY
FIVE GROWTH ROUTE EIGHTY EIGHT
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN I. GROVE HI
MELINDA'S. WINDOWS EIGHTY
SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ABSTAIN.
MORLOCK DARLA K. . SIXTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN ABSTAIN MORALE
MORALE AND EIGHTY SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN YEAH. R. L. NO WELL. A.
B. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HI WILKE
HI SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS
REMOVING THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY
ONE SENATOR SKINNER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER DAILY AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING AND MAKING
AN APPROPRIATION THEREFORE
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO WE'VE
GIVEN H. C. D. MANY DIFFERENT
RENTAL HOUSING PROGRAMS TO-
ADMINISTER. AND AS A RESULT THE
PROCESS FOR FINDING- HAS BECOME
CUMBERSOME AND CONFUSING
BECAUSE- ENTITIES THAT QUALIFY
FOR MULTIPLE SOURCES OF THE
FUNDS HAVE TO INDIVIDUALLY
APPLY AT TIMES AND- FOR
DIFFERENT PARTS WHEN THEY COULD
BE APPLYING AT ONCE SO
STREAMLINING THE FUNDING AWARD
PROCESS. WILL DRASTICALLY
REDUCE TIME AND COSTS AND
THAT'S WITH A B. FOR THIRTY
FOUR DOES THE BILL IS ENJOYED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND I ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU SENATOR
SKINNER MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SEEING THE
MICROPHONES RAISING NO HANDS UP
MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ALL CALL ROLL CALL.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. SO BE THE
ORDER.
THE. MEMBERS WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO
SENATOR PAM MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE SENATOR PAM THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS EIGHTY
TWO TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN BIAS IN
OUR CAR REQUIRES HEALTH PLANS
INSURERS TO SUBMIT AGGREGATED
REPORTING FOR PLANS OFFERED IN
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETS.
THERE'S CONSIDERABLE
UNCERTAINTY AROUND HEALTHCARE
COST PROJECTIONS THE WAKE OF A
NINETEEN AND ITS EFFECT ON
HEALTH INSURANCE RATES. POLICY
MAKERS OF PURCHASERS NEED A
COMPLETE PICTURE OF OUR STATE
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETPLACE
THE SHED LIGHT ON HOW CONSUMERS
AND SMALL BUSINESSES ARE
PURCHASING HEALTHCARE COVERAGE.
SIMILAR TO LARGE GROUP MARKET
AT TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN WILL
PRODUCE AGGREGATE REPORTS ON
HOW CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PURCHASERS AND
INDIVIDUAL SMALL GROUP MARKETS
ARE RESPONDING TO THESE CHANGES
IN PREMIUM OUTS ON THE
AGGREGATE. RECOGNIZING CODE
NINETEEN HAS IMPACTED ALL
INDUSTRIES THIS BILL DELAYS
IMPLEMENTATION UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THE THREE A NEW
REPORTING PROVISIONS THAT ARE
NOT IN EXISTING RATE FILINGS SO
WHEN I TRY TO ADD ADDIIONAL
BURDEN AT THIS TIME. THIS
BALANCES WORKLOAD CONCERNS
DURING A PANDEMIC IN THE NEED
TO OBTAIN ACCESSIBLE DATA. TO
ASSESS THE STATE INSURANCE
MARKETS IN THE WAKE OF PANDEMIC
INSURE THAT WE CAN TRY TO
PEOPLE WILL RETAIN YOUR
COVERAGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AUDIT THE CENTER PANEL
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING NO MICROPHONES
RAISING NO HAY OUT WELL AND. WE
DO HAVE A HAND SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. ONE
MOMENT SIR WE DON'T HAVE YOU ON
THE SCREEN YET. WE HAVE YOU
KNOW PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT- A. B. TWO ONE
ONE EIGHT. REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
DETAILED REPORTING. OF WHAT'S
CONSIDERED NONTRADITIONAL
ACCOUNTING INFORMATION IT'S A
BIG ASSIGNMENT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE BRIEFING MATERIAL AND THE
BILL MADAM CHAIR MADAM
PRESIDENT SO I'M HOPING THAT
THE SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO CAN
ADDRESS. IN HIS CLOSING REMARKS
HOW WILL THIS REDUCE HEALTHCARE
COSTS AND IN THIS CODE NINETEEN
LOCKDOWN. WHY CAN'T THIS WAIT
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY THREE THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SENATOR MORLOCKS SEEING NO
FURTHER HANDS OR MICROPHONES UP
SENATOR PAN PLEASE CLOSE THANK
YOU- I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
FROM MY DAD CALLING FROM ORANGE
COUNTY- THAT'S WHY IN THIS BILL
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR ANY
ADDITIONAL. NEW DATA COLLECTION
BUT I WOULD ALSO POINT OUT AND
I APPRECIATE BY GOOD
COLLEAGUES- EXPERIENCES AN
ACCOUNT THAT- HEALTH CARE
INSURANCE ISN'T JUST ABOUT THE
DOLLARS AND CENTS IT'S ACTUALLY
ABOUT THE DETAILS ON THE
COVERAGE. AND ON THE HEALTHCARE
SIDE AND SO IN ORDER TO
UNDERSTAND. HOW WE'RE SPENDING
OUR MONEY THAT'S HOW WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO REDUCE OUR
HEALTHCARE COSTS SO IT'S NOT A
MATTER OF JUST THE DOLLARS AND
CENTS BUT EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
PAYING FOR. AND MY RETURN IS AN
ORDER OF WAYS WE CAN DO IT
SMARTER AND THAT'S WHAT THE
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION. WOULD
HELP US DETERMINE BUT THAT
WON'T HAPPEN UNTIL AFTER COVE
IT TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE ARE
GOING TO LOOK AT THE EXISTING
DATA. AND DO A BETTER JOB OF
TRYING TO EXAMINE THAT WITH
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
KNIGHTHOOD. THANK YOU SENATOR
PANTOMIME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KENS FIVE BELL. HI BRADFORD.
CABRERA DOT FIVE DURAZO. GOD
JOHNNY. GLAZER GONZALEZ I HURTS
BURKE. HI HELLO I WAS SO. YEAH
HI HER TADO I JACKSON. I LLEVA
FIVE REQUIRE. I MITCHELL. HI MY
NAME. HI NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
FORTUNE TINO FIVE ROSS. HI
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN.
NUMBER ALL RIGHT HI I. CASKEY
FIVE WINNER. HI. SENATOR MOVES
A CALL EXCUSE ME NOT YET SORRY
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY THIS IS
A B. TWO ONE ONE EIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FAKES DATE A B.
ONE EIGHTEEN NO EIGHT NO
PORCHES OR JUST A B. TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN NOW FOR JUST NOW CHANG.
TANG AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN NOW
HANG NO DALLI DALLI AB TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN NOW. VALLEY. YEAH
DALLY AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN NO
THANK YOU SIR DALLY NO GROWTH.
GROVE AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN NO
GROWTH NO MELINDA'S MELINDA'S
AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK.
WATCHING TV TWO ONE ONE EIGHT
NO MORE LOCK NO MORE AROUND.
EIGHTY TWO ONE ONE EIGHT VOTING
NOW. MORALE NO. WELK THESE ARE.
WILL YOU BE TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
NO. WELL NO. RIGHT BRADFORD.
FIVE UNCLE.
THE CALL. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WERE MOVING AROUND TO
FOLLOW LATER EIGHTY FOUR A. B.
NINETEEN OH SIX SENATOR DODD
JOHNNY ARE YOU PREPARED TO MAKE
THAT PRESENTATION. SHE HE IS
OKAY A MAN SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. FOR YOU TO FOR A
TEMPORARY PASS TEMPORARILY. ALL
RIGHT. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
EIGHTY SEVEN. SENATOR JACKSON.
AV. THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THREE
SIXTY FOUR BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE GOVERNMENT
INTERJECTION YES THANK YOU THIS
IS APPROPRIATELY BILL RIGHT
BEFORE DINNER- BECAUSE IT IS A-
A BILL THE CHURCH DEALS WITH
VARIOUS NON CONTROVERSIAL
CHANGES TO EXISTING LAW. TO
CLARIFY DELETE AND DELETE%
OBSOLETE REFERENCES EXTENDED
REMOVE SUNSETS. ELS HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS APPROVAL AND
ALL COMMITTEES INCLUDING THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE IS
SUPPORTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGES ASSOCIATION AMONG OTHER
GROUPS JUST TO CLEAN UP WE DO
IT EVERY YEAR TO MAKE SURE
THAT. WE HAVE MOVED AWAY FROM
PHRASES THAT WERE USED BACK IN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY. TO BE MORE
APPROPRIATE FOR TWENTY TWENTY
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS MATTER. I SEE NO MIKE'S UP
ON THE FLOOR I SEE NO HANDS UP
REMOTELY. MEMBERS THIS IS A
CANDIDATE FOR A UNANIMOUS. ON
CALL ROLL CALL ANY OBJECTION TO
USING ON CALL YOUR MOM ROLL
CALL. NO OBJECTIONS THE
MEASURES MOST. WITHOUT
OBJECTION OKAY I'M SORRY SIR
TRANSACTION RELATED OKAY WE
MOVED THE MEASURE ON CALL.
THERE WE ARE OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT MOVING ON TO FOLLOW ADAM
EIGHTY EIGHT A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY BUT SOME OF THEM IN
COURT. PRESENTED BY SENATOR
LEYVA SHE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN SEVENTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER QUIRK AN ACT
RELATING TO CANNABIS. SUGAR
LEVEL THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOOD EVENING MEMBERS I RISE 2%
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY WHICH
CLARIFIES WHAT IT MEANS TO
PROVIDE A CANNABIS PRODUCT FOR
TESTING IN ITS FINAL FORM PRIOR
TO ANY CANNABIS PRODUCT BEING
SOLD TO CONSUMERS IT IS
REQUIRED TO BE TESTED FOR
CONTENT AND FOR CONTAMINANTS BY
VARIOUS TOXICS. CURRENTLY FINAL
FORM IS DEFINED AS THE FORM IN
WHICH A CONSUMER PURCHASES A
PRODUCT FROM RETAIL LOCATION
CONDUCTING TESTS ON FULLY
SEALED AND PACKAGED PRODUCTS IS
WASTEFUL AND EXPENSIVE TO AN
INDUSTRY WAS SMALL PROFIT
MARGINS THIS CHANGE HAS NO
IMPACT ON QUALITY CONTROL OR
THE INTEGRITY OF THE PRODUCT
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AND THIS
BILL HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I
FELT. GREAT THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM SHE KNOW MIKE'S UP ON THE
FLOOR SHE NINE REMOTELY.
MEMBERS THIS CANDIDATE IS A
CANDIDATE FOR. UNANIMOUS ALONG
CALL ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTIONS TO USING NON CALL
ROBO UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. HERE
IN CHINO OBJECTION MOVE THE
CALL. NEXT UP IS FALL ITEM
EIGHTY NINE SENATOR UMBERG.
PREPARE TO PRESENT THAT.
WHILE
I REMAIN I MINUM SECTOR WHEN
YOU'RE READY YOU CAN REACH.
EIGHTY NINE WE JUST EIGHTY
EIGHT. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SIXTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AN ACT RELATING TO
CIVIL ACTIONS SENATOR UMBERG
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AT
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE WILL
PROVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE AND
OVERALL PORT EFFICIENCY BY
ALLOWING TRUCK COURSE RECOVER
THE COST OF PROVIDING
ELECTRONIC. FILING ELECTRONIC
FILING SHOULD BE THE NORM
SHOULD BE REQUIRED THE COURT
SHOULD BE PERMITTED TO RECOVER
THE COSTS THIRTY NINE VOTES.
YEAH THAT'S WHERE. THEY ARE
WHERE THEY GO. YES IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM IN NINETEEN NINE
AND ON THE FLOOR OR REMOTELY
MEMBERS THIS TOO IS A CANDIDATE
FOR UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTIONS TO
USING UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL
CALL SENIOR NINE MOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS WERE GONNA COME BACK TO
FALL ITEM EIGHTY FOUR HE B.
NINETEEN OH SIX BY SENATOR GOD
YANNI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
RATE. ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN OH
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SOLACE AN
ACT RELATING TO PEACE OFFICERS
YEAH THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN OH SIX
WOULD PROVIDE GREATER WORKPLACE
EQUITY AND SAFETY FOR PREGNANT
PEACE OFFICERS. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HUMAN RESOURCES
TO ESTABLISH A POLICY THAT
PROVIDES ALTERNATE LIGHT DUTY
ASSIGNMENTS WHILE ENSURING THAT
THE PREGNANT PEACE OFFICER
REMAINS IN THEIR CURRENT JOB
CLASSIFICATION AND RECEIVES
NORMAL PER NO PROMOTIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN PREGNANT CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS WORKING AT THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
INSTITUTION IN TEHACHAPI
TRAGICALLY LOST HER UNBORN BABY
WHILE RESPONDING TO AN
ALTERCATION BETWEEN INMATES.
PRIOR TO THIS INCIDENT THE
OFFICER HAD REQUESTED
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATIONS FOR
AN ALTERNATE LIGHT DUTY
ASSIGNMENTS AS OUR CURRENT
DUTIES WERE THOUGHT TO POSE A
POTENTIAL HARM TO HER UNBORN
BABY HER ACCOMMODATION WAS
DENIED AFTER CDC ARE
INEXPLICABLY CHANGE THEIR
POLICY IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN. TO ELIMINATE LIGHT
DUTY ASSIGNMENTS FOR PREGNANT
PEACE OFFICERS PASSING THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY WILL HELP
PREVENT TRAGIC SITUATIONS SUCH
AS THIS ONE FROM OCCURRING IN
THE FUTURE BY ENACTING FURTHER
PROTECTIONS FOR PREGNANT PEACE
OFFICERS AND THEIR UNBORN
CHILDREN THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND
HAS RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
RIVALS. THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
OR CONCERNS REGARDING THIS ITEM.
HEARING CHAIN NONE IN THE
CHAMBER NOR REMOTELY MEMBERS
AGAIN THIS IS A CANDIDATE FOR
OUR UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL CALL
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING
ARE UNANIMOUS ON CALL ROLL
CALL. SEE NO OBJECTION HEARING
NO OBJECTION. MOVE THE CALL.
IMAGE ARE YOU PREPARED TO DO
FALL ITEM SEVENTY FIVE. C. H.
R. YOU PREPARED TWO B. TWO FIVE
FOLLOW ADAM SAID THE FIVE.
ARCBEST EMPEROR OKAY.
ALL RIGHT
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
SEVENTY SIX H. C. R. NUMBER ONE
TWENTY EIGHT WE HAVE SENATOR
JOE JOHNNY MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE RATE. ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAY RELATIVE TO THE CORPORAL
RONALD SINGH MEMORIAL HIGHWAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR JOHN JOHN
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THIS RESOLUTION DESIGNATES A
PORTION OF STATE HIGHWAY ROUTE
THIRTY THREE FROM SANCHEZ ROAD
POST MALL TWENTY NINE POINT
SEVEN THREE ZERO IN MERCED
COUNTY. TO STORE ROAD POST MILE
TWO THOUSAND SIXTY AND STAFFORD
COUNTY AS THE CORPORAL RONALD
SINGH MEMORIAL HIGHWAY. AFTER
IMMIGRATING TO THE UNITED
STATES FROM THE ISLAND NATION
OF FIJI CORPORAL SAYING SETTLED
IN STAFFORD COUNTY AND BEGAN
HIS LAW ENFORCEMENT CAREER AS A
CADET WITH THE TURLOCK POLICE
DEPARTMENT. HE LATER WORKED AS
A RESERVE OFFICER WITH THE
MERCED COUNTY SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN HE JOINED THE NEWMAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT CORPORAL
SINGH WAS A WELL RESPECTED
SEVEN YEAR VETERAN OF THE
NEWMAN POLICE DEPARTMENT ANY
TRAINED CANINE OFFICER HIS
CANINE PARTNER SAM FREQUENTLY
ACCOMPANIED HIM ON DUTY.
CORPORAL SAYING POSSESSED AN
ADVENTUROUS SPIRIT AND PROVIDED
AN ADMIRABLE ROLE FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS CORPORAL SAYINGS
INNATE DESIRE TO DO WELL IN THE
WORLD BY PROVIDING COMMENDED
BOUNTIFUL INCONSEQUENTIAL
SERVICE WILL BE FOREVER
REMEMBERED. TRAGICALLY ON
DECEMBER TWENTY SIX TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN CORPORAL
SINGH WAS KILLED IN THE LINE OF
DUTY HE SWAP HE IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE ANAMIKA HIS INFANT SON
AND THE MEMBERS OF HIS EXTENDED
FAMILY IN BOTH CALIFORNIA AND
FIJI. I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT
YOU JOIN ME IN HONORING AND
RECOGNIZING CORPORAL SAYING AND.
VOTING ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. WE HAVE CENTER GROVE
REMOTELY SENATOR GIRL. AND
TAKING MATTERS ARE MISTER
PRESIDENT I. WOULD LIKE TO
JUST- ASPER RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A NIGHT OUT YOU KNOW THIS
INDIVIDUAL RADIO SCENE CAME
FROM AND CG HE IMMIGRATED HERE
LEGALLY IM HIS LIFELONG DREAM
WAS TO BE A POLICE OFFICER AND
THEY USED TO PLAY AT COPS AND
ROBBERS WITH HIS BROTHER IN AND
THE ISLAND OF FIJI AND WHEN
THEY WERE GROWING AT. AND HE
PURSUED THAT DREAM IN ORDER TO
JOIN THE POLICE FORCE AND THEN
SERVING THE NEWMAN POLICE
DEPARTMENT. WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE LOSS JUST TO NAME INCREASED
FROM IT'S A VERY VERY SMALL
DEPARTMENT SO THEY WEREN'T JUST
COLLEAGUES- PASSERS BY I MEAN
MOST OF THE PEOPLE IN THE NAME
AND POLICE DEPARTMENT ARE LIKE
BROTHERS AND SISTERS. BECAUSE
IT'S SUCH A SMALL DEPARTMENT
WENT TO THE FUNERAL OF
CORPORATE DEAL SEEN. THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE OR THEIR OVERFLOW TO
THE BALCONY IN SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ROOMS LAW ENFORCEMENT
FROM ALL OVER AT THE CANADIAN
MOUNTIES- IT WAS JUST SET A
FITTING TRIBUTE I GUESS YOU'D
SAY FOR SOMEONE WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES SO YOUNG. CORPORATE ELSE
SEEN IT WAS ONE OF THE FEW- THE
INDIAN AMERICAN INDIVIDUALS
THAT WE HAVE THAT SERVE IN OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND HE WAS VERY
VERY DEDICATED AND I WOULD ALSO
AGAIN THIS IS- LIKE TO REMIND
EVERYBODY THAT CORPORAL MISSING
DIDN'T HAVE TO DIE. WHEN HE DID
A ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP- FOR A.
D. Y. HE CAME UPON AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO. IS IN THIS
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY. HE CAME UPON
AN END OF THE WHO HAD A-
POSSESSION. AND HAD BEEN
DRINKING A DRIVING AND THAT
INDIVIDUAL SHOT AND KILLED
CORPORAL SCENE. SO TOO I
DEDICATE THIS STRETCH OF
HIGHWAY. IS AS A SMALL THING
THAT CAN BE DONE- BUT I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO REMEMBER THAT
CORPORATE NELSON DID NOT HAVE
TO DIE AND LEAVE HIS. AND HIS
YOUNG SON. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR MY BUT I'M STILL. THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
SYNDERGAARD JOHN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY DRIVE
OUT. IN Q. AMOUNT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON A C.
R. ONE TWENTY EIGHT. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I AT KINS FIVE BELL
FIVE BRADFORD BYE BYE YELLOW.
DOT FIVE THE RISER. GOD YANNI
FIVE GLAZER. HI CONSOLIDATES.
GONZALES I HURTS BERG I HELLO.
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO.
JACKSON FIVE LLEVA. I REQUIRE
FIVE MITCHELL. HI MY NAME HI
NIELSEN. I HAND FIVE FORTUNE
TINO HI RALPH. HI RUBIO.
SKINNER. FIVE STERN HI AMBERG
HI WHITE HOUSE GAME FIVE WINNER
HI. ZURCHER NOW LET'S GO TO A
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS ON ACR.
ONE TWENTY EIGHT. FACE THE H.
A. C. R. ONE TWENTY EIGHT I.
EIGHT FIVE PORCHES. GORGEOUS
EASIER ONE TO EIGHT FIVE. FOUR
JUST HI CHANG J. A. C. R. ONE
TWO EIGHT HI. NINE HI DELHI
DALLY ACR ONE TWO EIGHT HI
DALLY HIGHER GROWTH. ROVE ACR
ONE TWENTY EIGHT I GROVE HI
MELINDA'S BLEND IS A ZERO ONE
TWO EIGHT I WONDER IS WHY MOORE
LOCK. OR LIKE ACR ONE TWENTY
EIGHT HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
WORLD ABC R. ONE TWENTY EIGHT
HIGH MORALE HIGH. WELK WELL A
C. R. A C. R. ONE TWENTY EIGHT
HI WELCOME. FIVE HURTADO HI.
SENATOR MOVES- RUBIO HI. CENTER
MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS NUMBER
MORE TO FOLLOW RIGHT ON ONE OH
FOUR. A. B. THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE BUY A CINNAMON REAVIS SOON
SENATOR MINING IS PREPARED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ZERO ZERO
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROBERT
RIVAS AND ACTUALLY ADDING TO
THE LEROY ANDERSON DAM AND
RESERVOIR AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF SICK AFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. REMINDING THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START BY THANKING. THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM CALABASAS IN
HIS STAFF IN NATURAL RESOURCES
FOR THEIR TREMENDOUS. SUPPORT
AND WORK ON THIS A. B. THREE
ZERO ZERO FIVE WHICH WILL
RESOLVE THE MAJOR DISTRICT IF
YOU AN ISSUE THAT HAS REGIONAL
PUBLIC SAFETY AND WATER SUPPLY
IMPACTS AND IMPLICATIONS. THIS
LEGISLATION SEEKS TO ENACT
CHANGES IN STATE LAW CHANGES
THAT ARE NEEDED THIS YEAR TO
STREAMLINE NECESSARY SEISMIC
RETROFITS FOR THE LEROY
ANDERSON DAM BY THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT THAT WILL
DO THE FOLLOWING IT WILL
REQUIRE EXPEDITED PERMITTING BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IN THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD. WITH
ASSOCIATED COSTS COVERED BY
VALLEY WATER THE BILL WILL
AUTHORIZE BEST VALUE
CONTRACTING AN EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW FOR SEQUEL
pVALLEY WATER TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL SUBSTANTIAL
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
INCLUDING REQUIRING THE PROJECT
TO DELIVER NET ZERO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS. THE ANDERSON DAM
WAS BUILT IN NINETEEN FIFTY IT
WAS BUILT TO THE SAFETY
STANDARDS OF THAT TIME BUT AS
WE NOW KNOW THE DAM WAS
CONSTRUCTED ALONG TO EARTHQUAKE
FAULT LINES IN THE EVENT OF AN
EARTHQUAKE A BREACH OF THE DAM
AT FULL CAPACITY WOULD BE
CATASTROPHIC. IN THAT SCENARIO
IT'S PREDICTED THAT FROM THE
SITE OF THE DAM FLOODING WOULD
EXTEND TO MORE THAN FORTY MILES
FLOODING OVER A HALF DOZEN
CITIES AND TOWNS SUBMERGING THE
MAJOR TECH CENTERS OF THE
SILICON VALLEY THE DRIVE SO
MUCH OF OUR ECONOMY. AND HIGHLY
DENSE POPULATED AREAS NEAR
MORGAN HILL THIS URGENCY BILL
SEEKS TO EXPEDITE PERMITTING IN
CONTRACTING REQUIREMENTS IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE
CONSTRUCTION IMPROVEMENTS AT
ANDERSON DAM CREATING OVER.
FIVE THOUSAND WELL PAID JOBS IN
THE PROCESS MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR I VOTED
ON THIS URGENT BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IN A THE DESCRIPTION
OF CENTER NELSON. THIS PRESENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
I ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT THIS.
EXPEDITED REVIEW BUILT. IT'S A
VERY CRITICAL. NEED TO MAINTAIN
AND IMPROVE. OUR DAMS IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT CERTAINLY CAME
TO MY ATTENTION WHEN THE
ORVILLE SPELL AWAY HAD A
FAILURE. NOW THAT IS A VERY
LARGE DAM IT'S C. HEART OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT. BUT WHAT
WE DID LEARN IS OVER THE
DECADES. NOT NEAR ENOUGH
ATTENTION HAD BEEN PAID. THAT
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR AND
SUSTAINING THE SITE. NOW IN OUR
PART WE DID NOT HAVE. THE
CONCERN OF THE SAN ANDREAS
FAULT. BUT THAT IS A HUGE THERE.
AND WHEN THESE DAMS ARE
COMPROMISED. THE FAILURE CAN BE
DEVASTATING. A GOOD FRIEND THE
AUTHOR FROM THERE HAS
ACKNOWLEDGED WHAT THAT IMPACT
WOULD BE HOW FAR THAT WATER
WOULD GO HOW DESTRUCTIVE IT
WOULD LEAD TO THE ECONOMY OF
THAT VERY HEALTHY REGION. AND
ALSO THE LIVES. THAT COULD BE
COMPROMISED. OR WILL HAPPEN WE
HAD TO EVACUATE A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THIS WOULD NOT REQUIRE SUCH BUT
LET'S NOT GET TO THAT POINT.
THE POINT IS DIFFERENT
JURISDICTIONS. OVER DAMS AND
THERE IS A DEGREE STATUTE DAM
INSPECTION SYSTEMS THAT ARE ON
STATE. BUT. FOR WHAT MANY
REASONS. SOME THE INSPECTION
SOMETIMES THE REPAIRS FOUND IN
THOSE INSPECTIONS. HAS BEEN
NEGLECTED HERE I THINK IT'S
BEEN PRETTY WELL DETERMINE WHAT
NOW NEEDS TO BE DONE. AND
THEREFORE WE MUST GET A BALLOT.
FOR THOSE OF YOU IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE. WE COULDN'T ARGUE
MUCH THAT THE STATE WATER
PROJECT IN OUR BILL DOES NOT
AFFECT YOU. DOES IT DOES AFFECT
MOST OF THE STATE. THIS IS MORE
LOCALIZED BUT OF NO LESS
SIGNIFICANT. TO ALL OF THE
PEOPLE. WHO INHABIT THAT AREA.
AND BENEFIT FROM THE DROP WATER
DERIVING FROM THAT CRITICAL DAM.
I DON'T VIEW THIS IS
COMPROMISING ANY THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPERATIVES. BUT
IT CERTAINLY DOES BALANCE THOSE
WITH. THE PUBLIC SAFETY
IMPERATIVES THE NEED OF THE
CITIZENS FOR THE WATER WHATEVER
THE USE IS AN ABSOLUTE CRITICAL
NEED TO PROTECT THEM FROM A
FAILURE OF THAT. SO IF YOU LOOK
AT YOUR OWN AREA DON'T JUST SAY
WELL THAT'S THEIR PROBLEM. IT
REALLY ISN'T. THE WATER IS
NEEDED THE STATE COULD HAVE
NEVER GROWN. WITHOUT THE
IMPOUNDMENT OF WATER. AROUND
CALIFORNIA AND WE WOULD HAVE
HAD MANY JONESTOWN FLOODS. OVER
THE DECADES AND IN FACT IN
EARLIEST TIMES. MOST OF THE
SACRAMENTO AND SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEYS WERE UNDER WATER.
RADIANLAND SEIZED THE TELLER
LIKE BASIN BEING ANOTHER ONE. I
DO NOT KNOW ABOUT THIS AREA BUT
I DO KNOW HOW VALUABLE THE
WATER IS TO THEM. AND I ASKED
YOU TO SUPPORT THE BILL TO BE
OF ASSISTANCE TO THE CITIZENS
DOWN THERE TO EXPEDITE THE
PROJECT YOU'RE NOT JUST HELPING
THEM. YOU'RE HELPING YOUR WHOLE
STATE GINGIVAL. THANK YOU ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
ON THIS ITEM. SHINO HANSON
MARKS APPEAR NO HANDS REMOTELY.
CENTER MINING JULY TO CLOSE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM TO
HIM FOR HIS SUPPORT OF COMMENTS
MEMBERS OCCURRED HERE I VOTE
THIS BILL DOES NOT WAIVE ANY
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS IT
DOES PROVIDE EXPEDITED REVIEW
IN A NEGOTIATED AGREEMENT AMONG
ALL STAKEHOLDERS IN THE REGION
I URGE YOUR I VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS FIVE WELL
FIVE BRADFORD BYE BYE OTHER.
DOT FIVE THE RUSSELL. I GOT
JOHNNY. FIVE GLAZER HI GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG HI HELLO HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO FIVE JACKSON
FIVE LLEVA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME I NIELSEN
FIVE HANDS HI FORTUNE TINO HI
ROB HI RUBIO. I SKINNER FIVE-STERN HI AMBERG FIVE WACO SKI.
FIVE WINNER I. SECRETARY NOW
LET'S CALL THE ROLL ON A REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS ON THE ABC.
THREE THOUSAND FIVE. BASICS.
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND FIVE HI
SIX FIVE FOUR JUST. IT IS AB
THREE THOUSAND FIVE HI OR JUST
HI CHANG. J. A. B. THREE ZERO
ZERO FIVE HI TURNING MY DAILY.
L. A. B. THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE
HI DALLY HI GROWS. APRIL OF
EIGHTY THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE I
GROW HI MELINDA'S. WINDOWS
EIGHTY THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE
FIVE MELINDA'S BY MORE LOCK. A.
B. THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. EIGHTY
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE A HIGH
MORALE HIGH WILL. WILL HE BE
THREE ZERO ZERO FIVE HI WELCOME
HI. REMOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS
WERE MOVING BACK TO FILE I AM
TWENTY FIVE A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER THE
MON PRESENTED BY SENATOR
MCGUIRE HE'S PREPARED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND AND
ACTUALLY DOING TO INSURANCE.
CINNABAR HEY GOOD EVENING MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX IS A
GREAT DEAL BY SOME MEMBER OF
THE MONA BLOOM IT STRENGTHENS
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND
TRANSPARENCY WHEN PURCHASING OR
RENEWING HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
POLICIES HERE'S WHAT THE BILL
DOES IT REQUIRES INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO PROMINENTLY
DISCLOSE ON THE DECLARATIONS
PAGE OF OUR HOMEOWNER'S POLICY.
THAT THEIR POLICY DOES NOT
COVER THE PERIL OF FIRE INTO
GET ASSIGNED IT KNOWLEDGE MEANT
FROM THE POLICY HOLDER THAT
THEY'RE AWARE THEIR POLICY DOES
NOT COVER THE PERIL OF FIRE THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES INSURERS TO
IDENTIFY THE AMOUNTS BEING
REDUCED OR THE SPECIFIC
COVERAGE MEAN ELIMINATED I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A
VOTE. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. IN CHAIN.
NINE MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I WANT. WITH
EVERYBODY REMOTE OKAY MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN I ARCHULETA HI ACTIONS I
FELL FIVE BRADFORD I AVAILABLE.
DODD HI TORONTO. GAJI ANI.
GLAZER FIVE GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL. I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO. HI JACKSON FIVE LLEVA
FIVE REQUIRE BY MITCHELL HI MY
NAME. FIVE NIELSEN. PAM I
PERSON TINA. BY ROSS HI RUBIO.
I SCANNER. HI STERN HI AMBERG
HI MY CASKEY I WINNER. HI.
NIELSEN I. HOME SECRETARY LET'S
NOW GO TO A REMOTE MEMBERS
VOTING ON A B. TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX. BASICS H. A. B.
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI I'M
GORGEOUS. THERE IS A B. TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX OUR WORK FOR
JUST BY CHANG CHANG AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX I. CHANG HI
DALLY. SALLY AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX HI. VALLEY HI THIS
GROWTH A. B. TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX HIGH GROVE BYE MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AB TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY
SIX FINE MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK.
WARLOCK. EIGHTY TWO SEVEN FIVE
SIX FIVE MORLOCK HIGH MORALE.
WELL. EIGHTY TWO SEVEN FIVE SIX
HIGH MORALE I WILL. WELL GABY
TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX HI WELL
HI. GOD YANNI HI. YEAH THE
PROGRAM TO MEMBERS PUSH. HAVE I
EVER HI TORONTO HI. FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WHAT'S THAT ALL MEMBERS STAY ON
THE FLOOR WE WILL BE LOOKING
CALL SHORTLY.
SENATOR BREAUX
BRIDGE. I HAVE ADD I GUESS IN
THIS CASE A PARLIAMENTARY
ENQUIRING OR MAYBE JUST A
QUESTION. SO WITH THAT WITH THE
SITUATION WE FIND OURSELVES IN
AND REMOTE- PARTICIPATION HOW
WOULD ONE CALL A CAUCUS. WE CAN
DO THE CAUCUS REMOTELY WITH THE
MEMBERS BUT HOW WOULD YOU GUYS
HOW DO YOU GUYS JUST ALL IT
NORMALLY LIKE YOU NORMALLY
WOULD FOR A- TEN MINUTE CAUCUS
OR NOT. WE RESERVE YEAH. ALL
RIGHT. SENATORS GROVE IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO CALL A CAUCUS WE
CAN RECESS AND YOU CAN CALL
BECAUSE PRIVATELY WITH YOUR
MEMBERSHIP. SO AS A RESULT THE
ONLY- I'D LIKE TO RECALL A
CAUCUS IN A CAUCUS OF MY
MEMBERS FOR NOT MORE THAN TEN
MINUTES. AND. WHICH MAJORITY
LEADER FOR WHAT PURPOSE THANK
YOU LL RIGHT IN RESPONSE TO
THE REQUEST TO CAUCUS IF IT
WOULD BE ON THE CUP PERMISSIBLE
IT WOULD BE GOOD I THINK IF WE
COULD LIST THE CALLS FOR ALL
THE CALLS ARE LIFTED AND THEN
WE CAN MOVE THE BUSINESS THE
HOUSE AND THEN WE'LL DO RECESS
AND BOTH- WE CAN CARCASS AT
THAT TIME IF THAT WOULD BE IT
WORK FOR YOU IF THAT'S OKAY
WOULD BE EASIER TO MANAGE THE
OPERATIONAL HOUSE THAT THAT
WOULD BE OKAY. CENTER GROVE.
ABSOLUTELY SIR- LET'S LIFT THE
CALLS AND THEN WE'LL MOVE
FORWARD AFTER THAT THANK YOU
FOR THE SUGGESTION. MEMBERS
WERE LIFTING BECAUSE WE'RE
STARTING AT THE TOP THE LIST
FOR STERN WOULD FILE ITEM
TWELVE SP FIVE FIVE FIVE
MINUTES SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THAT SOME MEMBERS. YEAH. FOR A
LOAN ALL OUR REMOTE MEMBERS
WERE LIFTING THE CALLS IF YOU
CHOOSE TO BE RECOGNISED JUST
RAISE YOUR HAND AND WE WILL GO
TO YOU AT THAT TIME. THANK YOU.
SURE ON FILE ITEM TWELVE SP
FIVE FIVE FIVE MEMSIC TRIP
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ATKINS.
FIVE GLAZER FIVE WEST SO.
SKINNER. FIVE TURNED WELL I.
YEAH WESER HI. MM SURGERY CAN
CALL OUR REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS.
WITH IMPORTANT. OKAY GOT IT
MILLIONS ARE UP OKAY MOVING ON
TO FALL ITEM THIRTEEN AT. I'M
SORRY ICE THIRTY TWO NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES. THE MINISTER IN
THE MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FOLLOW
ITEM THIRTEEN AS V. EIGHT FIVE
FIVE MM SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE
OPTION MEMBERS. ATKINS. THANKS
BYE GLAZER. IN NO WAY SO. BY
MITCHELL. FIVE SKINNER I STERN.
HI. LOOK AT THE REMOTE MEMBERS
OKAY MARCH THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT
THE MEMBERS ARE CONCURRED IN.
OKAY. FILE ITEM FOURTEEN SP
NINE SEVEN TWO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSA MEMBERS.
WELL FIVE BLAZER. GLAZER NO WAY
SO. I STERN HI. ONE EIGHT
ELEVEN FIVE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
ELEVEN. THE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON NOW TO
FALL AND FIFTEEN US THREE NINE
SEVEN THREE. MADAM SECRETARY
POLICE CALLED OUT TO MEMBERS.
WELL. BYE GLAZER. I WHISTLE. I
STERN. HI. TWENTY NINE OF
EIGHTY FIVE TWENTY NINE KNOWS
EIGHT THAT AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN. MOVING ON NOW TO
FILE I'M SIXTEEN AS THREE TEN
FORTY FOUR. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
WHAT HAPPENED. A LOT OF.
BECAUSE THAT IS. IT MR
PRESIDENT YOU WERE RIGHT WE'RE
DOING THE RIGHT. IT HAS TO BE.
THE LADY LANCERS. CENTRELINK.
FIFTY FIVE. YEAH GOING FIFTY
FIVE YEAH
. EIGHTY EIGHT FIFTY
FIVE. MEMBERS ARE GONNA RESTATE
AGAIN WE'RE LOOKING CALLS BUT
IN ORDER FOR THIS TO WORK
EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY WE
NEED ALL MEMBERS AND THEIR SEAT
PREPARED TO VOTE IF YOU CHOOSE
TO BE ADDED ON ON THE CALL.
WINNER FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
MOTIONS OR RESOLUTIONS. CORRECT
HI MISTER. MR PRESIDENT- I'D
MOVE TO RECONSIDER- SENATE BILL
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE SO THAT A
MEMBER CAN CORRECT INFO OKAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION. THERE ANY
OBJECTIONS TO THAT. OUR MOTION
FOR RECONSIDERATION AJ. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO MOTION IS
GRANTED. MANCHESTER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. HI ARCHULETA
NEWS HI ATKINS I FELL. HI
BRADFORD ALL RIGHT HI HAVE A
YELLOW MEANS WE CAN LIVE ONE
VOTE JOB. HI DURAZO. I CALLED
JOHNNY HI GLAZER HI GONZALEZ.
HI HERTZBERG HI HELLO I WAS SO.
I HER TADO HI JACKSON. HI LLEVA
HI MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MY
NAME HI NIELSEN HI PAM HI
FORTUNE TINO. DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT RALPH. HI RUBIO I SCANNER HI
STERN HI- BURGLARY I LIKE HOW
SKI. HI WINNER. HI. MADAM
SECRETARY LOOKS CALL ARE ABSENT
REMOTE WALTERS- FOR SP EIGHT
FIVE FIVE FOLLOWING THIRTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BASICS.
INTEGRATES SO SHE WROTE. IF.
CENTER DATE JANUARY. SP EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE BASE NO. BATES NO.
GORGEOUS. THE. WHAT ARE. I
APOLOGIZE THIS THIS IS NUMBER
THIRTEEN YOU SAY. FOLLOW HIM
FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN S. B.
EIGHT FIVE FIVE. FOR. I
APOLOGIZE MR PRESIDENT ARE YOU
ARE YOU GOING THROUGH THE
ABSTENTIONS FOR THE REMOTE
VOTING. OKAY WE HAD A VOTE
RECONSIDERATION SO WE'RE DOING
A FRESH VOTE ON. FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN S. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE
WE ALL CONSIDERATION NO- FOR
JUSTICE BE EIGHT FIVE FIVE NO.
GORGEOUS NO CHANG. K. SP EIGHT
FIVE FIVE I'D CHANG HI DOLLY.
L. E. S. B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. GROW THE SP
EIGHT FIVE FIVE NO GROWTH NO.
MELINDA'S. WINDOWS XP FIVE FIVE
NOW MELINDA'S NO MORE LONG.
WARLOCK SP EIGHT FIVE FIVE
ABSTAIN. MORALE. SP EIGHT BY
FIVE NO MORALE NO WILKE. S. B.
EIGHT FIVE FIVE I WILL HI.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
OB TO MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. I
DON'T WANT THEM BLURTING OUT.
FOR FOURTEEN TINA. HI. NIELSEN
I KNOW. THERE YOU GO. FIVE
THIRTY ONE NO SEVEN. THE MOTION
AMENDMENTS ARE CONCURRED IN.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE MOVING TO NOW
FOLLOW ITEM FOURTEEN SP. NINE
SEVEN TWO. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS. IF
YOU WERE SIXTEEN OKAY I'M
SIXTEEN I'M SORRY WE'RE MOVING
TO ITEM SIXTEEN S. B. TEN FOUR
FOUR PLEASE CALL THE OB TO
MEMBERS. BELL I GOD. FIVE
GLAZER I WAS SO. HI STERN. HI.
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ZERO. ALL
EYES THIRTY NINE NO ZERO FOR.
THE MOMENT SIR CONCURRED IN. WE
WILL NOW TOO WELL I AM
SEVENTEEN AS B. TWELVE FIFTY
SEVEN AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALLER UP TO MEMBERS. ALAN. I
FELL. FIVE BLAZER. WAY SO. HI.
TWENTY EIGHT NO TEN. OR A PRICE
TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN
AMENDMENTS ARE CONQUERED AND-
MOVING ON NOW TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY. S. B. FOURTEEN OH NINE
MEN SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. WELL FIVE GLAZER. HI
WITH SO. I. AT FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEMBERS ARE
CONCURRED IN. ONE MOMENT.
ALL
RIGHT MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETEEN AS BEAT THE TWENTY
MADAM SECRETARY CALL ARE ABSENT
MEMBERS. FELL HI LASER HI WITH
SEVEN. I. NIELSEN I KNOW. THREE
FIVE SIZE THIRTY THREE MILLS
FIVE THE MOMENTS ARE CONCURRED.
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
TWO. AV. THIRTY TWO SIXTEEN
OUNCE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. FELL BY GOD
JOHNNY. GLAZER MMHM. NO WITH
SEVEN. HI SKINNER. HI. AUGUST
TWENTY SIXTH KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MARIA NOW TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN EIGHTY
ELEVEN NINETY SIX. M. SIXTY
PLEASE CALL AROUND TO MEMBERS.
SKINNER. FIVE FIVE THIRTY THREE
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE WERE GOING TO FALL ITEM.
FORTY SIX EIGHTY TWO SEVENTY
FIVE. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUR ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS
I FELL FIVE GLAZER. I NIELSEN.
HI SKINNER. I STERN. HI. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE A. B.
THREE THREE ZERO EIGHT MA'AM
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. WELL I. LASER I.
SKINNER. HI STERN HI. FIVE
THIRTY FIVE KNOWS TO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS NOW
MOVING TO WELL I'M. SIXTY
EIGHTY SIXTY NINE. M. SECTOR
PLEASE CALL OUR APPS ARE
MEMBERS. FELL. FIVE LASER I.
SKINNER FIVE STERN. FIVE WE
HAVE A REMOTE HAND UP FOR
SENATOR BORDERS. SEARCH FOR THE
MANCHURIAN KOREAN MAYBE YOU'LL
GET BACK TO ME ON THIS BUT ARE
YOU GOING TO CALL UP FIFTY. SP
FLASH WE FILE NUMBER FIFTY I
MEAN. IT'S ON OUR LIST. OKAY
THANK YOU. OUR MEMBERS MOVING
THE FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT. SURE
PRICE THIRTY ONE. NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. THAT THAT WAS A
V. SIXTY NINE. NOW WE'RE GOING
TO A. B. TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM SIXTY EIGHT MEN
SECTOR PLEASE CALLER UP TO
MEMBERS. WELL I KALYANI. GLAZER
I. MCGUIRE I NIELSEN. HI
SKINNER I STERN. FIVE AND GOD
YANNI HI. FIVE THIRTY ONE NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MEMBERS MOVING ON TO FALL ITEM
EIGHTY SIX AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY ONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUR UP TO MEMBERS.
WELL FIVE GLAZER I NIELSEN.
CHECK FIVE KINNER. YEAH HI
STERN I ALL EYES THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
WILLING TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
NINE AB. SEVENTEEN THIRTY ONE
I'M SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTIONS I. BELL FIVE YEARS
BLAZER I SKINNER. I STERN. HI
FIVE THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT ON THE
URGENCY. THIRTY NO WAY FIVE
THIRTY. THOSE EIGHT THE MEASURE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE A V.
THIRTY TO FORTY TWO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ACTIONS I BELL. HI GLAZER I
HURTS FOR. HI SKINNER. I STERN.
HI.
ALL EYES THIRTY NINE OH
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY AV
TWENTY ONE TWELVE MONTH
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. GLAZER HI SKINNER. I
STERN. HI. HIGHS THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW THE FILE FILE ITEM
FIFTY FOUR AB TEN EIGHTY ONE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUR UP TO
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT
FIVE. GLAZER HER TADO. HURTADO
NO. PAM RUBIO. SEE MY HAND
STEVE. THE CITY CENTRE DOLLAR
OKAY THANK YOU. RECOGNIZING
YOUR O. OKAY OKAY THERE- DALLY
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY NOW. DALLY NO.
ALL RIGHT FIVE TWENTY THREE
KNOWS TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES.
WE KNOW NOW TO FILE ITEM FORTY
ONE. A. B. TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT
TO MEMBERS. L. HI GLAZER I TURN.
I. FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS. SEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL
ANNOUNCE FOLLOW HIM FOR TWO AV.
THREE THIRTY SIX. INSPECTOR
PLEASE CALLER UP TO MEMBERS
ATKINS. I FELL I GLAZER I HURTS
BERG. I STERN. HI. MARCH THIRTY
ONE NO SIX MEASURE PASSES. NOW
ITEM FORTY THREE AV TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL OUR OFFICE TO MEMBERS.
FELL BY LASER I STERN HI. HIGHS
THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. I AM FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FIVE POLICE CALLED OUT
TO MEMBERS. FELL I HAVE A- I
RAJANI. I BLAZER I STERN. FIVE
HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
THE MEASURE PASSES. SOME OF THE
FOLLOWING FORTY FIVE AV ELEVEN
TWENTY FOUR MINUTES SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS. BELL
HI GLAZER I STERN. FIVE PRICE
TWENTY NINE NO SIX THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW FALL ITEM FORTY
EIGHT ABC TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE CALL OUR UP TO
MEMBERS. WELL. FIVE GLAZER I.
STERN. HI. FIVE THIRTY ONE
KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
PAUL ITEM FORTY NINE AB TWENTY
ONE OH FOUR M. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL UP TO MEMBERS. WELL HI
BLAZER FIVE STERN. HI. FIVE
THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY
FILE ITEM FIFTY EIGHT B. SEVEN
NINE THREE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL I LASER I STERN BY HOME
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUR
REMOTE VOTER SENATOR BURGE FORD
JUST. THANK YOU FOR JUST EIGHTY
SEVEN NINE THREE HI. PORGES
NOTIFY. HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT WELL I'M FIFTY TWO AV.
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT. M.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL OUT TO
MEMBERS. ATKINS I FELL. I
GLAZER. NO STERN I. HIGHS
TWENTY EIGHT MILLS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM FIFTY
THREE AV TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO. PLEASE ALLOW UP TO MEMBERS
ATKINS. I FELL HI GLAZER NO
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG I. STERN
HI. ALL RIGHTS TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY SIX
AB. TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SEVEN
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL UP TO
MEMBERS. WELL I. GLAZER HI
HURTS BERG. I STERN. FIVE YEAH
FIVE HIGHS THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
FIFTY EIGHT A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
OUR UP TO MEMBERS. WELL HI
GLAZER HI STERN. I ALL EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. MENON TO FILE
ITEM FIFTY NINE AV. TWO TWO ONE
THREE. THESE CALL THAT SOME
MEMBERS. WELL HI GLAZER HI
STERN HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IT ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE AV.
NINETEEN SIXTY NINE THEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALLER UP TO
MEMBERS. BELL HI DODD. I STERN.
FIVE FIVE THIRTY THREE KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSED ON. I'M
SORRY MILLS SENATOR NELSON.
VERY LITTLE. WE. NIELSEN I TOO
NOW DID BIG HUGE CYLINDER VASE
HAS HER HAND UP SOONER GREATS
WE RUG REGIS RECOGNIZED
STANDARDS. ABC IN NINETEEN
SIXTY NINE NO BASE NO. FAITH NO.
THIRTY FIVE THIRTY TWO. KNOWLES
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES. WELL
I'M SIXTY ONE WE CLOSE OUT.
FILE I'M SIXTY TWO ABC TWENTY
ONE NINETY NINE MEN SECTOR
PLEASE CALL OUR OFFICE TO
MEMBERS. TELL HI STERN I NUMBER.
HI ALL EYES THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE
ITEM. SIXTY THREE. ABC TWENTY
SEVEN FORTY SEVEN PLEASE CALL
THEM TO MEMBERS. THIRTY SIX I'M
SORRY TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SIX.
WELL BY STERN. I AM BERG HI.
PUBLISHED THIRTY NINE KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. GOING
TO FALL I AM. SIXTY FOUR EIGHTY
SIX EIGHT FIVE. THEN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL OUR UP TO MEMBERS.
WELL HI DODD. GLAZER. HER TADO.
RUBIO FIVE STERN HI AMBERG HI.
HIGHS TWENTY SIX. KNOWS NINE
MEASURE PASSES. FILE HIM TO
FIVE. THE V. FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR
AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUR
ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL HI. DODD.
LASER HI NIELSEN. RUBIO. FIVE
STERN. FIVE NUMBER HI ONE
MOMENT SIR. PLEASE CALL UP TO
MEMBERS WILL RETURN. GOD. FIVE
NIELSEN.
HIGHS THIRTY ONE KNOWS
FIVE THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO FILE I'M SIXTY SIX AB.
TWELVE EIGHTY SIX I'M SECTOR
PLEASE CALL UP TO MEMBERS. WELL
I BRADFORD. GOD. I LASER. I
HURTADO. RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN BURFORD ONLINE BRADFORD.
FIVE PLEASE CALL OUT TO MEMBERS
OVER TIME. OKAY ALL EYES THIRTY
TWO KNOWS FOR THE MEASURE
PASSES. BACK I'M GONNA FALL I'M
SIXTY SEVEN ABC FIFTEEN SIX
FROM SECRETARY. TELL I. LATER I.
RUBIO. FIVE STERN FIVE FIVE
PLEASE CALL OUR REMOTE VOTER
SENATOR DOLLY. DALLI DALLI AB
FIFTEEN OH SIX HI SALLY HI. WE
HAVE CENTER GROVE IN KENYA AS
WELL. GROVE. I'M SORRY IT WAS A
MISTAKE I APOLOGIZE. WE'RE
CLOSING ROLE IN THIS. PRICE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GONNA
FALL ITEM SIXTY NINE AB TWENTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN MIN SECTOR
PLEASURE IT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. WELL I GLAZER. HI.
NIELSEN. PREVIA HI STERN. I.
YEAH. THE.
YEAH. YEAH. FIVE
THIRTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. OKAY FILE ITEM EIGHTY
FIVE ABC. TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO AM SECTOR. BELL BY GLAZER I
RUBIO. FIVE STERN. HI. FIVE
THIRTY FOUR MILLS FIVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. I'M SORRY
SENATOR GROCERY OTHER HAND UP
LET'S RECOGNIZE SENATOR. YEAH
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I WAS
ACTUALLY IS ABOUT HIGHLIGHTING
EIGHTY YOU SKIPPED OVER THAT.
WE WHAT WE'RE GOING IN ORDER
THAT WE TOOK HIM UP ON THE
FLOOR SO WE WILL. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE THANK YOU CURRENT.
YEAH. WE'RE GONNA FALL I AM
SEVENTY AV NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
AFTER MEMBERS. WELL HI BRADFORD.
R. FIVE LASER I MCGUIRE. FIVE
NIELSEN. RUBIO I STERN I. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW FILE ITEM.
SEVENTY TWO. AV FIFTEEN SIXTY
ONE M. SECTOR PLEASE CALLER UP
TO MEMBERS. FELL HI LASER. I
RUBIO HI STERN. FIVE FIVE
THIRTY NINE MILLS ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW FALL ITEM
SEVENTY FOUR A. B. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY SIX MANCHESTER. WELL I.
GLAZER I. RUBIO I STERN HI.
FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS IT TOO
THE MEASURE PASSES. FILE I'M
SEVENTY EIGHT. TWENTY THREE
TWENTY SIX FIFTY EIGHT CONTACT
HER. WELL. HI GLAZER I. RUBIO.
FIVE MARCH THIRTY ONE NOSE
SEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES. I'M
CIRM SORRY WE HAVE SENATOR OVER
I'M SURE. IN. SENATOR OF. VIDEO
GROUP NO I'M AT. TWENTY SIX
FIFTY EIGHT. GROVE NO. RESTATE
THE OLONEL FALL ITEM SEVENTY
EIGHT A. B. TWENTY SIX FIFTY
EIGHT ALL EYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW
FARRO ITEM. THIRTY THREE. AV
THIRTY SEVENTY. PLEASE CALL
THAT FOR MEMBERS. ARCHULETA HI.
THIRTY SEVENTY. B.
THIRTY
SEVEN. ARCHULETA ITEM NO.
BRADFORD HI CABRERO I. DODD.
THE RISER. HI L. G. ANI. BLAZER.
HERTZBERG. HELLO WHEN A FIRM.
HER TADO. NIELSEN RALPH. AMBERG
WHITE HOUSE SKI. MY CASKEY I.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO CENTER GROVE.
OUR BASE SOME SARS CENTER DATE.
THANK YOU BASE AD THIRTY
SEVENTEEN L. SIX NO. MOVE THE
BALL. WE'RE AT FINAL ITEM
EIGHTY AV. SIXTEEN FIFTY SEVEN.
MMHM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL OUT
FOR MEMBERS. BRADFORD BYE BYE
BY ADAM. I DURAZO I LASER. I.
WE HAVE CENTER GROVE REMOTELY.
AT GROVE AND BY LATE EIGHTY
EIGHTY EIGHT SIXTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN I KNOW. GROVE I DON'T
KNOW. MARCH THIRTY TWO NOTES
FOR THE MEASURE PASSES I WANT
TO FOLLOW UP ITEM EIGHTY ONE.
AV FOUR THREE FOUR MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
MEMBERS. BRADFORD. FIVE FIVE.
CABRERA I. THE RISER. FIVE
GLAZER I. FIVE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. NOW FILE ITEM EIGHTY
TWO AB TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN
MA'AM SECTOR. CONFIRA HI THE
RISER. I GOT JOHNNY. I BLAZER.
FIVE STERN. HI. MARCH TWENTY
NINE KNOWS TEN MEASURE PASSES.
NOW MOVING TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY
SEVEN A. B. THREE THREE SIX
FOUR BROWN SECRETARY. CABRERA
HI THERE ALSO. I ALL EYES
THIRTY NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GONNA
FOLLOW MEDIATE AV FOURTEEN
SEVENTY MA'AM SECRETARY. HAVE I
EVER. FIVE YOUR BROWSER. I
HURTS BERG. I. THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES DOWN
THE FILE ITEM EIGHTY NINE AB
TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE I'M
SECTOR PLEASE CALL. YOU CAN I
ADD A- FIVE YOUR BROWSER. FIVE
HERTZBERG. HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE
KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. FILE ITEM EIGHTY FOUR
AV NINETEEN OH SIX. CONTACT HER.
CABRERA HI THERE ALSO. HI
HERTZBERG. FIVE HIGHS THIRTY
NINE KNOWS IT ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. ONE ITEM SEVENTY SIX AC
ARE ON TWENTY EIGHT MINUTES
SECTOR. HAVE I EVER. THERE ARE
SO MANY. CABRERA II DOURADO I.
HIGHS THIRTY NINE KNOWS ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBER OUR
FINAL ONE ON THE FIRST GO
THROUGH AV. THIRTY ZERO I'M A
CERT THE THIRTY ZERO FIVE FILE
ITEM ONE OF FOUR. MEN SECRETARY.
CONFIRA HI. FIVE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. ON THE
URGENCY AND THE PRICE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ON URGENCY FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE.
WERE HAVING ASSEMBLY
SECOND READING MADAM SECRETARY
THANK. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THIS MAJORITY LEADER
FOR WHAT PURPOSE. THE FIRST ONE
HUNDRED MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS- MR
PRESIDENT- AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE FILE AND
A NUMBER NINETY EIGHT B. SEVEN
SEVEN EIGHT EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW TO
THE EXACT FILE. ONE LESS BILL
TO CONSIDER AND THEN REALLY
KNOWN. I KNOW THE REPUBLICANS
WANT TO CALL THE CARCASS. WELL
BUT IN ADDITION IT'S SIX FORTY
THREE NOW. WE STILL HAVE A
NUMBER OF OTHER MATTERS THAT
ARE TIME SENSITIVE- BACK
TONIGHT IF WE CONVERT TO A
DINNER BREAK. AND HAVE
EVERYBODY BACK AT SEVEN THIRTY
SHARP. PLEASE SEVEN THIRTY
SHARP YEAH. MIKE SEVEN THIRTY
SHARP WE ARE STILL A LOT TO DO
THIS EVENING TO KEEP A FILE
MOVING SO- THE RAKE AND THEN IF
YOU TURN OVER TO THE REPUBLICAN
LEADER FOR OFFICE. SUGAR GROVE
DO YOU STILL WANT TO BE
RECOGNIZED. YES MR PRESIDENT
JUST EVERY QUEST REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS CALLING THE CONFERENCE
CALLING AS SOON AS THE FLOOR IS
IN RECESS OKAY. SO WE WILL BE
ON LUNCH RECESS UNTIL SEVEN
THIRTY MEMBERS WE- WE'LL SEE
YOU BACK AT SEVEN THIRTY ON THE
FLOOR SHARK THANK YOU.
TURN TO
THE FLOOR WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED THANK YOU.
I SEE
OKAY HERE WHEN YOU GET STARTED.
RELATED.
THE RECESSES INCLUDING
BJP WILL RETURN TO THE FLOOR
CAN RESUME OUR BUSINESS THANK
YOU.
SO WE'RE GONNA GET STARTED
SOON.
OKAY HOPE EVERYONE HAD A
GOOD RESA WILL RECESS HERE AND-
DINNER AND I'M SO WELCOME
EVERYONE BACK I JUST SO THAT
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
DOING TODAY- FOR THIS EVENING
NOW I THINK- SIR BRADFORD FURS
EXCELLENT JOB AND PRESIDING I'M
GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT IF
FOLLOWED HIS SHOES. DEFINITELY
CAN NEVER FALL IN HIS SHOES.
READ ABOUT THIS USER GUIDE SO
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE
ITEMS TWENTY SIX. TEN FORTY
SEVEN. THE NINETY TWO NINETY
THREE NINETY FOUR FOLLOWING I.
FIVE. THEN GO BACK TO FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN AND THEN
WE'LL GO TO SUPPLEMENTAL FILE
WE'RE DOING- FIRST ITEM THE SUM
OF FILE B. FILE NUMBER ONE
THIRTY SEVEN SO. YOU CAN'T
REMEMBER THAT WAS KIND OF ROLL
WITH THAT. ALL RIGHT BUT
TOTALLY DON'T GIVE AN IDEA OF
WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO AND THEN WE
HAVE A FEW ITEMS ON
SUPPLEMENTAL FILES WELL. ALL
RIGHT. SO WE'LL GO AHEAD AND
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO TWO FOUR
SEVEN AND ACTUALLY JUST CHECK
TO BE SURE WE GOT THE
REPUBLICANS HERE. ALL RIGHT SO
BE SURE TO GET OUR- REMOTE
PARTICIPANTS ON LINE HERE SO
HOPEFULLY EVERYONE KNOWS THERE
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA GO HEAD
BEGAN SO- AGAIN FILE ITEM
NUMBER. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY TWO
TWO FOUR SEVEN SEVEN REQUIRE
RATE PRESENTS US SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURKE AN ACT
RELATING TO TAXATION. THE
ACQUIRER THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS ARE RIGHT HE SAID THIS
EVENING TO PRESENT MAYBE TWENTY
TO FORTY SEVEN ABOUT ON BEHALF
OF THE HARDWORKING ISN'T OVER
MISS AUTUMN BURKE CHAIR OF THE
SIMPLY READING TAX COMMITTEE.
THIS BILL IS TAXPAYER FRIENDLY
PROPOSAL SPONSORED BY THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE FTV
RECENTLY LEARNED THAT THE
INTERNAL REVENUE SERVICE IS
STOPPED ISSUING OR NON RENEWING
INDIVIDUAL TAXPAYER
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS FOR NON
RESIDENT DEPENDENTS LIVING IN
BOTH CANADA AND MEXICO BUT THIS
HAS PREVENTED CERTAIN
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS FROM
CLAIMING THE EXISTING DEPENDENT
EXEMPTION CREDIT. FOR THEIR
OTHERWISE QUALIFYING NON
RESIDENT DEFENDANTS AT TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN WAS SIMPLY GIVE
THESE TAXPAYERS THE OPTION OF
PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE
IDENTIFICATION INFORMATION FOR
PURPOSES OF CLAIMING THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CREDIT
EARLY TESTS ON THIS IN THE
MORNING WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NINE. OKAY THANK YOU SARAH.
IS THE DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY ONES AS A-
I DON'T SEE ANY HANDS UP. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND
REQUIRE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM ALL RIGHT SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. AND WE'RE GONNA
DO ONE TIME THROUGH AND THEN
PUT THE ITEM ON CALL ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE JUST DOING ONE TIME
THROUGH AND- BUT I AM ON CALL
IF YOU MISS THAT. CALL YOU CAN.
ADD ON WE LIST THE CALL ALL
RIGHT AS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI
AT KINS. WELL I BRADFORD I HAVE
A- I DON. HI THE RUSSELL. I GOT
JOHNNY HI GLAZER GONZALEZ. HI
HERTZBERG. HI HELLO HI WITH SO
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON. I LIVE
IN. I REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI
MY NAME HI NIELSEN. PAM HI I.
FORTUNE TINO. HI ROTH FIVE
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN. AMBERG
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI WINNER I
RIGHT NOW WE'LL MOVE TO OUR-
REMOTE VOTERS VOTING MEMBERS
AGAIN THIS IS AB. TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN A SECOND PLEASE
CONTINUE THE ROLE. FAITH IT'S A
B. TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN
ABSTAIN. GORGEOUS FORGES AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN OF
STAYING. CHAIN K. A. B. TWENTY
TWO FORTY SEVEN ABSTAINED.
DALLI DALLI AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN STATE. GROSS AT KROGER AT
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN ABSTAIN.
MELINDA'S IT IS A B. TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN NOW ONE DOESN'T
KNOW MORLOCK. OR LIKE EIGHTY
TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN ABSTAIN.
ZERO A MEMORIAL EIGHT TWO TWO
FOUR SEVEN L. YEAH. MORAL. YES
I'M HERE. YEAH HE'S NOW. MORALE
NO. WELCOME WILL BE TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN ABSTAIN. OKAY. OKAY
RIGHT YES- SENSOR REQUIRE MOVES
TO CALL OUR TWENTY THREE
pLET'S NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER FORTY SEVEN PLEASE. AND
SAM WHERE ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. FOLLOW NUMBER FORTY
SEVEN ALL RIGHT A SECOND SO
THAT'S EIGHTY TWO TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX ACTUALLY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BIGELOW AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE GOVERNMENT.
CENTER MIKE WEIR. THANK YOU SO
MUCH MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO
GRATEFUL FOR THE HARD WORK THAT
THE SINGER BIGELOW PUT INTO A
SINGLE MALE TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
SIX. BUT HE'S BEEN WORKING
WITH- SOME MEMBER OF RECURRING
ON THIS CRITICAL BILL THE BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
THE ANNUAL REVIEW AT A MINIMUM
TEN LOCAL EMERGENCY PLAN
SUBMITTED TO THE OFFICE
EMERGENCY SERVICES BY CITIES
AND COUNTIES- YES WOULD THEN
DETERMINE IF A DISASTER
READINESS PLAN. MEETS OR
EXCEEDS THE FEDERAL EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AGENCY STANDARDS
THIS BILL REQUIRES- YES TO
PRIORITIZE REVIEW A PLAN
SUBMITTED FROM A COUNTY
DETERMINED TO BE AT A HIGHER
RISK OF WILDFIRE DISASTERS IN
SPECIAL EVEN SEEN THIS YEAR
THIS BILL IS CRITICAL. THAT
WOULD ASK FOR AND I VOTE THANK.
YOUS AND REQUIRES A DEBATE ON
THIS ISSUE. K. NINE THE FLOOR.
I SEE NO HANDS UP. I WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE. YES HER NAME
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA I AT KINS.
WELL FIVE BRADFORD I HAVE A- I
THOUGHT. HI TORONTO. HI GO
JOHNNY. HI LASER. GONZALEZ HI
HERZ BERG. HI HELLO I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO. HI JACKSON. HI
LLEVA I REQUIRE HI MITCHELL.
FIVE MINING. HI NIELSEN.
HAMPERED BY HIGH FORTUNE TINO.
HI ROTH HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER HI
STERN. AMBERG FIVE WACO SKI I
WINNER. HI OKAY WILL NOW MOVE
TO A REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS AND
AGAIN THIS IS A B. TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX SECRETARIES CONTINUE
THE ROLE. FAITH BATES AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX HI IT'S TIME
FOR JUST. FORGES AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY SIX OUR- REGIS HI
CHANG THANK A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY FIVE. TANG HAI DELHI. L.
A. B. TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX.
KELLY HI. GROVE SURE. MAYBE
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX I HOLD
ON CENTER GROVE EXECUTIVE
VISUAL ON THAT SO WE NEED TO
HAVE WE DO HAVE NOW IS A KEY
PLEASE REPEAT YOUR VOTE THANK
YOU GROVE AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX I THANK YOU GROVE.
HI MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S AT
TWENTY THREE SIX TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX I. MELINDA'S FIVE
MORLOCK. EIGHTY TWO THREE EIGHT
SIX HI. MORLOCK HIGH MORALE YES
ABC TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX HI
PLEASE MORALE HI. WELL WELL THE
AP TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SIX I
WILL HI RIGHT S. AND REQUIRE
PUT SNOW ON CALL RIGHT NEXT-
ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY
TWO. HERE ALL RIGHT- ACTUALLY
CENTER ATKINS IS NOT AT HER
DESK. NO. HELLO OKAY. OH SORRY
I'M MOVING TOO FAST. WE WE'LL
TAKE A QUICK. YEAH ALL RIGHT WE
WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTY SEVEN SINCE WE ARE MOVING
FASTER THAN ANTICIPATED- CENTER
SKINNER ARE YOU PREPARED. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT- SO THAT'S EIGHTY
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE SIXTY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING CENTER
SKINNER EXITED MEMBERS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AT TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE. WHICH WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS. THAT WE CAN
ACHIEVE THROUGH OUR STATE
DENSITY BONUS LAW. NOW OUR
STAGES PEOPLE TO SLOT IS A TOOL
THAT WE'VE BEEN USING FOR SOME
TIME TO PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE TO
MARKET RATE HOUSING SO THAT
THAT MARKET RATE HOUSING WILL
INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHIN THEIR
PROJECTS. HOWEVER IN MANY
JURISDICTIONS OR DENSITY BONUS
LAW HAS NOT BEEN USED SO WE
WANT TO PROVE ITS USE INCREASE
ITS USE AND THAT'S WHAT IT A.
B. TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE IS
DESIGNED. TO DO IT EXPANDS THE
DENSITY BONUS TO PROVIDE UP
250% OF ABOVE AN INCENTIVE IN
EXCHANGE FOR ADDITIONAL
AFFORDABLE UNITS IT
INCENTIVIZES THE USE OF THE
DENSITY BONUS BY REDUCING THE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS THE
MAXIMUM ANYWAY- AND IT WITHIN A
HALF MILE TRANSIT AND PROVIDES
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS DISCRETION.
TO GRANT ADDITIONAL WAIVERS FOR
PROJECTS LOCATED WITHIN HALF
MILE TRANSIT THAT ARE 100%
AFFORDABLE IT'S GOT BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND I ASK FOR YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR SKINNER.
IS OUR DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE. K.
C. NO ON THE FLOOR I SEE NO
HANDS UP. ALL RIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN.
ARCHULETA I AT KINS. BELL I
BRADFORD. I HAVE A- FIVE DODD.
HI DURAZO I GO JOHNNY HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG. HI
HELLO I WAS SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON. I LLEVA HI WIRE. HI
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. HI WILSON.
HAM HI I. FORTUNE TINO. RALPH.
HI RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. HI
STERN NUMBER. HI WACO SKIING
FIVE WINNER. FIVE RIGHT NOW
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO A REMOTE
VOTERS IT'S AGAIN AT TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE SIXTY PLEASE
CONTINUE THE ROLE. SIX SORRY
CENTER BUT YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE
YOU CAN AND MAKE YOURSELF FIRST
PLEASE THANK YOU. YEAH BATES AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE NO.
EIGHT NO. FORGES THERE IS A B.
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE AM
STAND. CHANG. J. A. B. TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE THANK. DALLI
DALLI AB TWENTY THREE FORTY
FIVE AT ST. GROVE. AT YOUR
STORE AND YOU STILL ON MUTE THE
CENTER GROVE. EIGHTY TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE AT STAYING I
DID YOU SAY YOUR NAME
BACKSTROKE CENTER GROVE AB
TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
ABSTAINING THANK YOU. YEAH WE
GOT- WE GOT HER YOU DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT. AT TWENTY
THREE FORTY FIVE NO. BELINDA'S
NO MORLOCK A. B. TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE STAIN AND YOU SAY YOUR
NAME SIR MORLOCK- WARLOCK. TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE ABSTAIN THANK
YOU. BACKGROUND MR PRESIDENT
MORALE. AB Q. FOUR TWO THREE
I'M SORRY MORALE AB TWO THREE
FOUR FIVE NO. MORALE NO WELL.
ABC TWENTY THREE FORTY FIVE
ABSTAIN AND THAT'S HOW YOU DO
IT. EXACTLY RIGHT THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER LOSE THE CALL.
ALL RIGHT AND IT'S EVERYONE CAN
STRETCH FOR ONE MINUTE AND THEN
BEFORE. WELL LET'S LET'S MOVE
THE MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
OKAY IS OUR MOTION. EXCELLENT.
OKAY ALL RIGHT. MOTIVATIONS
RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES WILL BE
PLACED ON TODAY'S SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. I AM NUMBER
ONE ONE SIX S. B. FOURTEEN
FIFTY NINE FOLLOW NUMBER ONE
ONE SEVEN S. C. R. SEVENTY
SEVEN FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE ONE
EIGHT S. B. THIRTY EIGHT FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE ONE NINE SP
FIVE TWENTY TWO. FILE UNDER
NUMBER ONE TWENTY SP FIVE
SEVENTY THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY ONE SP FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN WELL I DON'T NUMBER. ONE
TWO TWO S. B. SEVEN HELLO TO.
FOLLOW AND ONE TWO THREE S. B.
EIGHT HUNDRED FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY FOUR S. B. NINE OH
SEVEN. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE TWO
FIVE S. B. NINE OH NINE WELL
ITEM NUMBER ONE TWO SIX S. P.
NINE THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE TWO SEVEN S. B. TEN
OH THREE. FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
TWO EIGHT S. B. ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
TWO NINE S. B. ELEVEN TWENTY
THREE FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTY SP ELEVEN FORTY ONE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY ONE
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE THREE TWO S. B.
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE THIRTY THREE S. B.
TWELVE SIXTY FOUR FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY FOUR S. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY. FIVE ITEMS ONE THIRTY
FIVE S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY SIX
AND FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE THIRTY
SIX S. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO.
YEAH AND WE WILL TAKE UP THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR AT THE
END OF THE FILE. ALL RIGHT I
THINK IT IS TIME O WE CAN MOVE
NOW TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETY TWO. AND CENTER AT
KANSAS IS NOT AT HER DESK TIME
SO WE'LL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINETY THREE CENTER
WINNER YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT.
OKAY SO THAT'S EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LUZ RIVAS AN ACTIVE TRIP OF AN
ACT RELATING TO STATE
GOVERNMENT. SENATOR WIENER I
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AV
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF
OF NUMBER THERE'S THREE OF US-
ABC FORTY FIVE SIX TO CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND
COMMUNICATION THAT IS REQUIRED
NOW MORE THAN EVER. BY
ESTABLISHING A SINGLE POINT OF
CONTACT ON HOMELESSNESS AT THE
STATE LEVEL A STATE OFFICE TO
END HOMELESSNESS. THROUGH TO
THE STATE FLAG OF A CENTRALIZED
OFFICE ON HOMELESSNESS. OUR
RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS HAS BEEN
UNNECESSARILY FRAGMENTED
BECAUSE OF THIS WE'VE HAD
DIFFICULTY ACHIEVING CLEAR DATA
ON OUR HOMELESS. HOMELESSNESS
EVERY STATEWIDE SORT OF
TRACKING HOMELESSNESS RELATED
EXPENDITURES ASSESSING WHICH
PROGRAMS ARE WORKING WELL- AND-
DETERMINING WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE BETTER. THE STORE WILL BE
A CRUCIAL STEP TO HELP THE
STATE RESPOND TO OUR HOMELESS
CRISIS. AND RESPECT WELLS FROM
RIVAL. THANK YOU SIR WINNERS
OUR DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE.
SEEING NO MICROPHONES UP ON THE
FLOOR SEEING NO HANDS UP- LOOKS.
ALL RIGHT US SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. OKAY ALAN. FIVE
ARCHULETA I. ACTUALLY I'M GONNA
ASK YOU TO BUY WITH A BACKUP
CENTER BOARD YES POLITICS I DO
NOT SEE YOUR HAND UP EARLIER.
THANK YOU YES THANK YOU I JUST
SAID- THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
PRESENT I'D LIKE TO POSE A
QUESTION TO THE FIELD TO THE-
TO THE- FLOOR MANAGER. CENTER
WINNER OF THE WILLING TO ACCEPT
THE QUESTION. YEAH YES SIR
PLEASE CONTINUE CENTER BORDERS.
THANK YOU I'M MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THAT THE GOVERNOR ALREADY
HAD THROUGH A TASK FORCE
ESSENTIALLY- EIGHTY POINT
PERSON THAT WOULD BE CHARGED
WITH THE OFFICE TO END
HOMELESSNESS CAN YOU ELABORATE
ON THAT OR WAS THAT NOT. FULLY
FUNCTIONING. THROUGH THE
THROUGH THE OUR PRESIDENT ON.
SERVING AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
ADVISERS IN PEOPLE HERE POINTS
TO ADVISE HIM AND POLICY- THIS
IS CREATING A MORE FORMALIZED A
STRUCTURE BECAUSE WHAT THE
GOVERNOR DID AND I'M NOT
DISPARAGING AND ANYWAY- WAS TO
DESIGNATE PEOPLE TO PROVIDE
ADVICE TO HIM ON HOMELESSNESS
POLICY THIS IS ACTUALLY
CREATING A MORE CENTRALIZED-
OFFICE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S
VERY FRAGMENTED. IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND FRANKLY WE'VE
NEVER HAD THE KIND OF A
CENTRALIZED RESPONSE TO THIS
CRISIS THAT WE NEED. THE
RESEARCH THANK YOU THE REASON I
ASK IS THIS. THIS SEEMS TO BE
AN EXECUTIVE FUNCTION AND I'M
WONDERING IF WE'RE OVERSTEPPING
OURSELVES BY FORCIBLY CREATING.
AN EXECUTIVE POSITION FIVE WE
KNOW WHERE THE GOVERNOR STANDS
ON THIS I DO NOT KNOW WHERE THE
GOVERNOR STANDS AS I DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE STANDS ON THE VAST
MAJORITY OF BILLS- BUT I WILL
SAY THAT- THE LEGISLATURE- WE
WERE LEGISLATING CRADLES THE
AGENCIES OF STATE GOVERNMENT
ALL CREATED. TYPICALLY BY
LEGISLATION- BY THE LEGISLATURE
WE CREATE EXECUTIVE AGENCIES
AND THEN WE MAKE POLICY AND THE
GOVERNOR AND HIS AGENCY'S
EXECUTE THE POLICY. ALSO
ABSOLUTELY INAPPROPRIATE
LEGISLATIVE ENDEAVOR. TO CREATE
A NEW EXECUTIVE OFFICE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SIR BARGES
CENTER MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANT TO STAND UP BRIEFLY
IN SUPPORT OF EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE IT WAS FOUR YEARS AGO WHEN
I CARRIED AND PASSED THE
LEGISLATION SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THAT CREATED THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL IT WAS BASED ON A MODEL
AND A NUMBER OF STATES. AT THAT
POINT UNDER THE AT THE REQUEST
OF THE N. PROTEIN KEVIN DE LEON
I LET THE SENATE DELEGATION TO
UTAH TO LOOK AT THEIR HOUSING
HOMELESS COORDINATING COUNCIL
ONLY MODEL THAT BASED ON THAT.
AND SO OVER THE PAST FOUR YEARS
WE'VE SEEN WHAT WORKS IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT DOES IT AND SO.
THE FURTHER THE ROLE OF THE
COUNCIL TO REALLY COORDINATE
MULTIPLE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS IMPACTING
HOMELESSNESS. AND TO ELEVATE
THE COUNCIL SO IT'S LED BY
SECRETARY THAT'S THE POINT OF
THIS BILL BASED ON THAT
HISTORY- AND OUR COLLECTIVE
COMMITMENT AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT. HOMELESSNESS REALLY IS A
STATEWIDE ISSUE THAT SHOULD
REQUIRE EXECUTIVE LEVEL
ATTENTION. THE ELEVATION THE
COORDINATING COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. OF THE AND THE
APPOINTMENT OF THE SECRETARY
WILL DO JUST THAT SO I'M PROUD
TO LEND SUPPORT. THIS FAMILY
MEMBER IN HER BILL. THANK YOU
SIR MITCHELL SENATOR WILK.
THANK YOU SIR I'M GONNA BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY AND
FRANKLY IT IT'S LONG OVERDUE-
THE FINANCE CENTER FROM
WESTCHESTER TALKED ABOUT HER
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS FOR YEARS
AGO- I BELIEVE WAS THE
FOLLOWING YEAR MYSELF INTO SOME
IN WACKY WAS ABLE TO GET
APPROVED A REQUEST BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE OF
THE LHASA WHICH IS THE AGENCY
THAT APPROVES THAT DISTRIBUTES.
ALMOST FINDS IN LA COUNTY. OR
TO BE THE NORTHERN L. COUNTY
WAS NOT GETTING ITS FAIR SHARE
FUNDS AND LOCAL HOLD WHEN THE
STATE AUDITOR WINNIE AND-
DISCOVER THAT WAS TRUE AND
FORTUNATELY THE CHANGE- FORMULA
SO NOT EVERYBODY GETS. THE
MONEY THAT THEY- I SHOULD GET.
BUT IN IN THAT A LOT OF
REQUESTS WE ASKED. DOES STATE
AUDITOR TO COME UP WITH BEST
PRACTICES. AND WHEN SHE'S DONE
WITH THE AUDIT- MISSILE CALLED-ME AND WAS HORRIFIED. THAT THIS
STATE IS SPENDING BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ON HOMELESSNESS AND
THERE'S NO PLAN. SO I- I TOOK
THE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
AUDITOR AND RUN THAT KILLED
TWICE. TWICE SAID BILL IS BEEN
HELD UP IN THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. SO
MAYBE THAT PERSON DOESN'T CARE
ENOUGH ABOUT HOMELESSNESS I
DON'T KNOW BUT THIS ISSUE I
MEAN THIS IS THIS IS A SCOURGE
ON OUR SOCIETY- AND WE'VE GOT
TO ADDRESS IT IN THIS IS A
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD I WISH
IT'D HAPPEN SOONER. BUT IT'S
HAPPENING NOW. I STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED I GO. THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK A CENTER GROVE I
SAW YOUR HAND UP. BUT THEN IT
WENT DOWN AND UP AGAIN SO IT'S
ONE CONFIRM DID YOU WANT TO
DRESS THE CHAMBER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MR SPEAKER I DO
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY- I
JUST WANTED TO I WASN'T GOING
TO COMMENT UNTIL I HEARD SOME
OF THE COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES AND YOU KNOW IT IS
TRUE REESE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS ALLOCATED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
HOMELESSNESS AND WE'RE STILL-
50% AT THE END SHELTERED
HOMELESS LIVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- POLICIES THAT ARE
PASSED BY THIS BODY THAT
CREATES A HIGHER COST OF
HOUSING. AND JOBS THAT ARE
BEING ELIMINATED- ANY
INDIVIDUALS BEING RELEASED FROM
PRISON WITH NO PLACE TO GO- ARE
CREATING A LARGER HOMELESS
POPULATION THAN WE EVER
POSSIBLY IMAGINED WHEN I DRIVE
FROM WHERE I LIVE AT HERE AT
THE CAPITOL TO THAT CAPITAL
OFFICE I PASS- SEVERAL HOMELESS
ENCAMPMENTS SOME OF THEM- IN
THAT SEVERAL HUNDREDS- IS
SEVERAL CITY BLOCKS OF
HOMELESSNESS WHEN I CAME DOWN
TWELVE STREET AND- SO. I MEAN.
YOU KNOW WE'LL TRY THIS TO BED
YOU KNOW I DON'T SEE HOW
CREATING A SECRETARY POSITION
AFTER WE ALREADY SPEND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN HOMELESSNESS AND
THE- THE MATTER HAS GOTTEN
EXTEND YOU AND LEAVE YOU KNOW
X. IT JUST COMPLETELY WORSE.
THAN EVER- DID IT EVER WAS
BEFORE- MY OTHER COLLEAGUE-
SAID THAT SHE HAD BEEN WORKING
ON THIS FOR FOUR YEARS- IN FOUR
YEARS IT'S GOTTEN WORSE THAN IT
EVER HAS THIS IS THE LARGEST
HOMELESS POPULATION YOU'VE EVER
HAD. SPECIFICALLY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY WHERE THEY HAVE-
OUTBREAKS OF DISEASES LIKE THE
THIRD A THIRD WORLD COUNTRY. SO
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE HOW A NEW
SECRETARY POSITION IN A NEW
OFFICE AND A NEW GOVERNMENT. IS
GOING TO HELP THE SITUATION
LIKE THEM I BELIEVE IT WAS
PRESIDENT RONALD REAGAN SAID
THAT- THE WORST THING THAT YOU
CAN HEAR IS I'M FROM THE
GOVERNMENT AND I'M HERE TO HELP
YOU. BECAUSE IT HAS DEFINITELY
NOT HELPED THE HOMELESS
POPULATION SINCE THEM. WE'VE
BEEN. PUTTING FORTH POLICY. AND
MAYBE. THIS WILL CHANGE
EVERYTHING WE'LL SEE. THANK YOU
SIR GROSS DOLLAR. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I TOO ALSO. WHAT A
COMMENT I I'M GONNA SUPPORT
THIS- WE WERE SPENDING BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS ON WE HAVE THE
HIGHEST POVERTY RATE IN THE
NATION AND- YOU KNOW SOMETHING
NEED TO BE DONE AND I MENTIONED
EARLIER. ON CLIMATE CHANGE THAT
WE NEED TO PLAN A QUITE FRANKLY
WE DON'T HAVE A PLAN THE PLAN
IS JUST KEEP PUTTING MORE MONEY
TO I'M I'M ASSUMING THAT THIS
POSITION WILL THEN COORDINATE A
PLAN I WOULD BE BIRD **** AT TO
SEE WHAT THIS WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS HERE. AGAIN HELLO YOU
HAVE TO PLAN THINGS IN THE
RIGHT WAY WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT
AND HOME THIS IS NOT GOING AWAY
IT'S NOT GETTING LESS. FRANKLY
IT'S GETTING WORSE AND SO FOR
THOSE REASONS I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL- AND I'M
HOPEFUL AND I WILL BE WATCHING
OVER THE NEXT FOUR YEARS
ASSUMING I'M REELECTED IN
NOVEMBER TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A PLAN AND THAT THE MONEY
THAT WE'RE PUTTING IN ARE
ACTUALLY GOING TO. HELP THOSE
HOMELESS PEOPLE GET THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER THERE'S A AS WE
ALL KNOW TOO WELL THAT THERE
ARE MANY- THINGS THAT CAUSE
HOMELESSNESS IT'S MENTAL HEALTH
IT'S ADDICTION- I'M TRYING TO
FIND A JOB AND HOUSING THERE'S
A READERS IT'S- LOCKED AND
THERE'S ALSO A NOT A GOOD
ACCOUNTING SYSTEM TO FIND OUT
WHERE THESE PEOPLE ARE WHO THEY
ARE. AND I THINK THEY GET
COUNTED TWICE I THINK SOME-
DON'T GET COUNTED AND THAT'S
WHAT I'M HOPEFUL THAT THIS-
POSITION WILL- BRING ALL THOSE
FUNDS TOGETHER AND SOMEBODY
WILL BE ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE
RESOURCES WE ARE SPENDING. AS
AS ALL OF YOU RECALL WE GAVE
MONEY TO CITIES IN CANADA DID
YOU GET THE MONEY OUT AND
THAT'S WHAT I HOPE THIS
POSITION WILL DO SO I WILL BE
SUPPORTING IT TONIGHT IN HOPES
AND ALSO WATCHING. ALONG THE
NEXT FOUR YEARS TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT DOES WHAT. WE ALL
WANTED TO DO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER DALIAN OTHER DAY.
SAYING NONE- SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE- HELP. CENTER WE KNOW
WHICH I LIKE TO CLOSE MY EYES
FOREVER. THANK YOU SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. WELL.
BRADFORD I HAVE A HI TODD FIVE
DURAZO I GOT JOHNNY HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG. I WAS SO.
HI HER TADO I JACKSON. HI LLEVA
I REQUIRE I MITCHELL. HI MY
NAME. BY NELSON. PANNED BY FIVE
PERSONS YOU KNOW. HI ROTH HI
RUBIO HI SKINNER FIVE STERN.
NUMBER FIVE WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WINNER HI. OKAY SIR WINNER PUTS
THE BILL ON CALL. TOP STORY BUT
WHAT I'M GOING TO REMOTE
VILLAGES LET'S MOVE DOWN TO
REMOTE VOTING AGAIN THE BILL
NUMBER IS EIGHTY EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE- PLEASE CONTINUE THE ROLE
THANK YOU SIR FOR. FAITH BATES
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE BY SIX
FIVE. GORGEOUS OR JUST A B.
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE ABSTAINED.
CHANG K. EIGHT AB EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE HI TRANG I. DALLY.
DALLY AB EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE BY
DELHI HI GROSS. GROVE AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE I GROVE HI
MELINDA'S WHEN THERE'S EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE NOW ONE
DOES NO MORE LOCK. A. B.
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE HI MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. YES YOUR L. EIGHTY
EIGHTEEN FORTY FIVE NOW. MORALE
NO. WELL BILL AB EIGHTEEN FORTY
FIVE HI WELL I. THANK YOU- SIR
WINTER PLACE ISABEL ON CALL
RIGHT LET'S MOVE ON NOW TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINETY FOUR CENT
REQUIRE PREPARED TO PRESENT
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THREE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AN
ACT RELATING TO NEWSPAPERS
THANK YOU SAM MAGUIRE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MR PRESIDENT IN
GOOD EATING AGAIN THAT IS IN
GENERAL THE SENATE AND I'M
HONORED TO BE A RISE. IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE ON BEHALF OF A SOMETHING
WOMAN RUBIO WHO'S BEEN WORKING
PASSIONATELY ON THIS ISSUE.
NEWSPAPERS ARE ONE OF THE
CORNERSTONES ONE OF THE
CORNERSTONES OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
ANY ECONOMIC FALLOUT FROM THE
PANDEMIC HAS BEEN DEVASTATING
TO THE INDUSTRY. CALIFORNIA'S
NEWSPAPERS HELP HOLD OUR
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE THEY
TELL THE UNIQUE STORIES OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ALL LOVE.
NEWSPAPERS THEY INFORMED THEY
INFORM THE PEOPLE OF IMPORTANT
EVENTS THAT SHAPE OUR STATE AND
OUR NATION. NEWSPAPERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY IN
SMALL COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS WELL
THEY'RE AT RISK IN JUST THIS
YEAR ALONE DUE TO THE ECONOMIC
FALLOUT OF THE CORONAVIRUS.
FIFTEEN NEWS PUBLICATIONS HAVE
NOW CEASED OPERATIONS RIGHT
HERE IN THE GOLDEN STATE AND
MANY MORE ARE ON THE BRINK.
COMMUNITIES WITHOUT NEWSPAPERS
LOSE TOUCH WITH GOVERNMENT THEY
DON'T KEEP IN TOUCH WITH
BUSINESS OR EDUCATION OR EVEN
OUR NEIGHBORS. AND WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE ONE
YEAR EXEMPTION FOR NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS LAST YEAR WE WOULD
HAVE NEVER IMAGINED WE'D BE IN
THE DEPTHS OF THE PANDEMIC
INDUCED RECESSION ONLY TWELVE
MONTHS LATER. AND NEITHER
COULD- COMMUNITY PAPERS. THAT
HAVE WORKED VIGOROUSLY TO
IMPLEMENT EIGHTY FIVE. MAYBE
THREE TWENTY THREE WILL PROVIDE
NEWSPAPERS AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
TO COMPLY WITH EIGHTY FIVE
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE EXTENSION DOES
NOT ALLOW THE NEWSPAPERS TO BE
ABLE TO ESCAPE THE CURRENT
LIABILITY RESPONSIBILITY TO
DELIVERY DRIVERS UNDER UNDER
THE BRELO STANDARD. THE
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET DATE
FOR THE EXEMPTION FOR NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS WILL GIVE ETHNIC
COMMUNITY IN DAILY NEWSPAPERS
THE DIGITAL TIME THEY NEED TO
BE TO WORK THROUGH THE
COMPLICATED ISSUES ASSOCIATED
WITH CONVERTING. CARRIERS TO
EMPLOYEES WITH THE INVOLVEMENT
OF ALL INTERESTED PARTIES.
THROUGHOUT THE GOLDEN STATE
COMMUNITY NEWSPAPERS AND ETHNIC
NEWS PLAY A HUGE ROLE A HUGE
ROLE IN COVERING LOCAL POLITICS
THEREBY INCREASING TRANSPARENCY
AND IMPROVING THE PUBLIC'S
TRUST IN WE NEED THAT NOW MORE
THAN EVER. EIGHTY THREE TWENTY
THREE IS CRITICAL TO THE FUTURE
OF THIS INDUSTRY IT'S PROBLEM
POLICE IN THE COMMUNITIES AGAIN
THAT WE ALL LOVE TO CALL HOME
THE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU SIR I REQUIRE
AS THEIR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR.
C. CENTERED. OUR GROWTH. WE ARE
VERY. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
YOU KNOW IT WAS JUST LAST YEAR
THAT- MY REPUBLICAN COLLEAGUES
AND I INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
HELP- STOPPED AND DEVASTATING
EFFECTS THAT EIGHTY FIVE THE
EIGHTY FIVE- PRESENTED AMONG
THEM WE INTRODUCE A MINUTE FOR
NOT ONLY THE NEWSPAPER DELIVERY
PEOPLE IN THE NEWSPAPER
REPORTERS BUT ALSO AN EXEMPTION
FOR MY MUSICIANS AND OTHERS WE
ALSO INTRODUCED AN AMENDMENT TO
HELP JOURNALISTS- IN THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY'S WE
INTRODUCED AN AMENDMENT TO HELP
SUPPORT COACHES TO AVOID THE
BACKLASH OF EIGHTY FIVE A WEEK
FOR A WHILE. I MEAN CREDIBLY
PLEASED AT THE EFFORTS AND TO
INCLUDE SOME OF THESE
INDUSTRIES IN- LEGISLATION IS
MOVING FORWARD AND SPECIFICALLY
THE NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY THAT IS
JUST ASKED- IN PRACTICALLY
BEGGED. THIS LEGISLATIVE BODY
TO COME FORTH AND ADDRESS THE
DEBT. TO WITH FIVE AND WHY ON
EARTH IN A PANDEMIC WOULD WE AS
LEGISLATORS NOT ALLOWED ANYBODY
TO BE AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
SO THAT THEY COULD PUT FOOD ON
THEIR TABLE. YOU KNOW ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN THE COMMITTEE
REFERRED TO EVERYBODY BEING
UPSET BECAUSE- WE TOOK THEIR
LOLLI POPS PER SE BUT THE
BOTTOM LINE IS IT WASN'T THERE
LOLLI POPS THEY WERE UPSET
ABOUT. IT WAS ABOUT THE WAY
THAT THEY SAID THEIR FAMILY WAS
AWAKE ABOUT. THE WAY THEY MAKE
YOUR CAR PAYMENT. THESE
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR AND-
HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES EVEN
IN A PANDEMIC THEY WERE STILL
MAKING MONEY SO THAT THEY CAN
TAKE CARE OF THEIR FAMILY. AND
A FACEBOOK POST FROM ONE OF MY
CONSTITUENTS AS A SINGLE FATHER
COULD BE THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS
AND ONE NIGHT ON AN OFF NIGHT
VISITATION WHERE HIS KIDS WERE
GOING. TO SEE IS MOM THE THREE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A WEEK THAT HE
GETS ADD SUBSTANTIALLY TO HIS-
HIS SAMETIME SO EIGHTY FIVE IN
THIS INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
BILL IS A COMPLETE DISASTER. SO
I'M REALLY GLAD THAT WE'RE
FINALLY THAT YOU GUYS ARE
FINALLY SEEN THE LIGHT AND
CORRECTING A LOT OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE GOING ON WITH EIGHTY
FIVE. AND SO I HAD THE SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND HOPEFULLY THEY'LL
BE MERCH AND BILLS TO CORRECT
THAT DEVASTATING BILL THAT WAS
PASSED BY DEMOCRATS. SUPPORT
JUST LAST YEAR. THANK YOU SIR
GROSS AND HURTS FOR. THERE
BRIEFLY I WANT TO MY COM WITH-
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
REPRESENTING THE WHOLE NORTHERN
PART OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
I GET SO MANY CITIES I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO CALL IT FROM THEM.
THE GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE TO THE
TOPIC CALIFORNIA BUT I. JUST
WANT TO ADD THE FOLLOWING. YOU
KNOW. AS WE DEBATE ISSUES IN
THIS GOVERNMENT. OFTEN THE SOME
OF THE MOST DIFFICULT ONES ARE
THOSE WHERE THERE'S VRY CLOSE
COMPETING INTERESTS THINGS WE
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT. AND AS WE
FACE THIS ELEMENT OF DEMOCRACY
WHERE WE HAVE INTERNAL A. EIGHT
D. JOURNALISM WITH INTEGRITY
VERSUS WHAT WE'RE FACED WITH IN
THE INTERNET. SEEMS TO ME IN
THE BALANCE OF THINGS WE NEED
TO DO EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO
KEEP THESE. TWO FORMS OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT HAVE
JOURNALISTIC INTEGRITY ALIVE
AND SO FOR THAT I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT AND WORKING
HARD. ON BEHALF OF THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU SIR HURTS BURKE
CENTER PORCHES. IT'S HARD NOT
TO BE A LITTLE CYNICAL. AS THIS
MATTER HAS RESURRECTED BASED ON
THE EXTENSIVE DEBATE THAT WE
EXPERIENCED LAST SESSION. I
FIND IT INTERESTING THAT THE
EXAM ONE OF THE EXTENSIONS. IS
LIMITED LARGELY TO PRESS AND
COMMUNICATION OUTLETS THOSE
THAT HAVE THE POWER TO FORM
OPINIONS. THOSE THAT HAVE THE
POWER TO CALL OUT. FOR POLICY
BUT ACROSS THE BOARD WHETHER IT
BE CONVENIENCE DRIVERS WHETHER
IT BEING MUSICIANS WHETHER ME
HAIR SALON STYLIST SO AND SO
FORTH THOSE INDIVIDUALS DON'T
HAVE THE POWER TO CHANGE WITH
PRESTON'S. AND WHILE I'M
CERTAINLY GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE IT FRANKLY NEVER SHOULD
HAVE HAPPENED THIS IS JUST A
BANDAID. UNDERLYING STRUCTURAL
DEFICIENCIES THE BABY FIVE.
ONLY MANIFESTED IN THEIR TRUEST
FORMS AT A TIME WHEN PEOPLE
NEEDED TO HAVE FLEXIBILITY IN
THE WORKFORCE COLEEN HAS TAUGHT
US. HOW DESPERATE TIMES CAN GET
ANY HELP AT ALL YOUR MOVIES
PART TIME- CELL DELINEATING
SIDE JOBS OR TWO PUTTING FOOD
ON THE TABLE FOR FAMILIES. SO
I'M CERTAINLY GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THIS BUT WHETHER IT
IS THAT LAUNDRY LIST THAT WE
WENT THROUGH LAST CYCLE THE WAR
MORE DISCREET ISSUES LIKE THIS.
AP FILE HAS PROVEN. TO BE POOR
POLICY I THINK THERE IS A
NUMBER OF WAYS THAT IT COULD BE
IMPROVED UPON WITHOUT JUMPING
INTO ART A SWEEPING. SET OF
CLASSIFICATIONS OF EMPLOYEE OR
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR IN
GIVING A PREFERENCE TO THE
FORMER SO I THINK YOU KNOW
WE'RE KIND OF HAVING A YOU KNOW.
CHICKENS COMING HOME TO ROOST
MOMENT. AND I THINK IT'S SAD
BECAUSE IT'S A TESTAMENT THAT
WE JUMPED THE GUN LAST CYCLE
AND WE'RE PAYING THE PRICE NOW.
THANK YOU SIR FOR JUST A CENTER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- WHAT TALKED ABOUT A.
B. THREE TWO THREE BUT. THIS
LAST YEAR HAS BEEN PRETTY
DIFFICULT FOR A LOT OF US IS.
LEGISLATORS HAVING TO TAKE
PHONE CALLS- TAKE MEETINGS-
TAKE. GOOD BYE LETTERS FROM
BUSINESSES- AT ONE PUBLISHER
THAT JUST ACTUALLY LEFT ORANGE
COUNTY MOVED TO ARIZONA OVER
EIGHTY FIVE. EIGHTY FIVE WAS A
LOUSY INCOME TAX LAW AND THE
TIMING COULD NOT HAVE BEEN
WORSE. CARVE OUTS. ONLY PROVE
THAT EIGHTY FIVE IS POORLY
CONSTRUCTED LEGISLATION. I'LL
RELUCTANTLY VOTE FOR A. B.
THREE TWO THREE BUT- AS THE
SENATOR FROM PRESIDENT POINTED
OUT. THE LINE OF OTHER
INDUSTRIES WANTING A CAR ABOUT
NEEDS OUR ATTENTION AS WELL BUT
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO PURCHASE
INK BY THE BARREL. TAKING
JOURNALISM TO ITS PROVERBIAL
NEEDS. THROUGH AB FIVE SHOULD
MAKE OUR BODY THE MORE
DELIBERATIVE ABOUT CHANGING
SOMETHING THAT WAS NOT REALLY
BROKEN DYNAMAX WAS BROKEN. BUT
NOT THE WHOLE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR VERSUS COMMON LAW
EMPLOYEE ISSUE THAT WAS ALREADY
BEING DEALT WITH RATHER
SATISFACTORY BY THE INTERNAL
REVENUE SERVICE. SO WITH THAT
WE'VE GOT TO BE CAREFUL IN THE
FUTURE WITH BROAD BRUSHES.
WHICH ARE DANGEROUS AND PERHAPS
RECKLESS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR MARK I
JUST TO WANT TO RESPECTFULLY
REMIND PEOPLE TO FOCUS ON THE
ACTUAL MATTER HAND WHICH IS
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE-
SETTER. UPDATES YOUR NETFLIX
MISTER PRESIDENT YES SIR MORE
LIKE YES I COULD YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE YOUR CLARIFICATION
BUT WE WOULDN'T HAVE A. B.
THREE TWO THREE IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE MAYBE FIVE. SO THERE ARE
THERE RELATED CHOICE IT I DON'T
I DON'T APPRECIATE THAT KIND OF
A- REBUKE I JUST WANNA PUT ON
THE RECORD THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SIR MORE
LOCK- CENTER BATES. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT I DO HAVE A LOT OF
MEN INSIDE AT THE DESK. ALL
RIGHT CENTER BATES. AND YOU
HAVE AMENDMENTS AT THE DESK-
SECRETARY DO YOU READ THE SET
OF AMENDMENTS. AMENDMENTS BY
SENATOR BATES THAT ONE. RIGHT
CELEBRATES WITH JEWISH TO
PRESENT ON THE AMENDMENTS. YES
THESE SHOULD BE FOR THE
NEWSPAPER CARRIERS AND- I JUST
LIKE TO SAY WHY WE ARE IN THE
MIDST OF THE GLOBAL PANDEMIC
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE DO RELY
ON OUR LOCAL JOURNALISM AND I
BELIEVE THAT THE- FLOOR- THAT
WAS MENTIONED ON THE FLOOR WE
BEGAN. THAT FOR DECADES- WE'VE
HAD A DELIVERY SYSTEM THAT IS
ENSURING THAT WE GOT THAT NEWS
DELIVERED TO. OUR FRONT DOOR
SAYING I CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE
WHAT IT WOULD BE LIKE WITHOUT
THAT. SO AB THREE TWO THREE SIX
SIX AND THE EXEMPTION DATE FOR
NEWSPAPER DISTRIBUTORS AND
CARRIERS TO JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. I HAVE SO WE
REMOVED THE SUNSET DATE AND
ACCEPT THIS INDUSTRY
INDEFINITELY FROM THE EFFECTS
OF ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE. WE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SURVEY IT SAYS
SENATOR HERTZBERGTHANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR PRESIDENT THE
MAJORITY LEADER OF MODE MOVED
TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE. OKAY SO THERE'S A MOTION
TO LATE AND THEN IT'S ON THE
TABLE THAT. SO WE WERE TAKING
DEBT THAT WE HAVE A MOTION THIS-MOTION IS NOT DEBATABLE SO
CENTER HERTZBERG'S MOSHING TO
LAY ON THE TABLE THE MAJORITY
LEADER RECOMMENDS AND I VOTE
AND I SINCE CENTER BATES.
RECOMMENDS A NO VOTE SO
SEPARATE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON THE MOTION. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS. WELL
BRADFORD I COME BY ADAM I DON
HI DURAZO I GOT JOHNNY HI
GLAZER GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG
HI HELLO FIVE WAYS SO. FIVE HER
TADO FIVE JACKSON I LLEVA I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME.
FIVE NIELSEN. NO PAN HI HI
FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS HI RUBIO
HI SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER
RIGHT I Y. CASKEY FIVE WINNER.
HI LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE OUR
REMOTE PARTICIPATING MEMBERS-
PLEASE CONTINUE THE ROLE
SECRETARY AGAIN THE MOTION IS
TO LAY ON THE TABLE. EIGHT NO I
MOTION TO LAY ON THE TABLE.
FAITH NO. GORGEOUS GORGEOUS
NODE TO LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON
THE TABLE GORGEOUS NO CHANG. I
KNOW ON THE MENACE TO LAY ON.
CHANG NO DALLY. GOT A NOTE
TODAY THE MINUTES ON THE TABLE
DALLY NO GROWTH. NOTE TO LADY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE GROVE
NO MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S NOTE TO
LAY THE AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE
MELINDA'S NO MORE LOCK. WE'RE
LIKE A CLOSE TO LANEY
AMENDMENTS ON THE TABLE. MORE
LOCK NO MORALE BRAND NAME TO
LAY IN THE AMENDMENTS ON THE
TABLE AND MORALE NO. WELL WELL
NO REGARDING LAYING THERE AND
THEN IT'S ON THE TABLE WELL NOW.
THE EYES ARE TWENTY FIVE
WINDOWS OR TEN THE MOTION IS
PASSED TO LAY THEM AND IT'S ON
THE TABLE. LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO
CENTRE DOLLY BACK TO THE TO THE
BILL ITSELF. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I ALSO WANT TO. I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE- FROM
THE NORTH IT WHEN YOU REPRESENT
VERY SMALL RURAL COUNTIES AS A-
SENATOR FROM THE SECOND SENATE
DISTRICT MYSELF DO. PAPERS ARE
ONE OF THE ONLY- AVENUES FOR
GETTING INFORMATION OUT TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AS HE EXPLAINED IT
VERY ELOQUENTLY- AND ALL THOSE
PLACES DON'T HAVE THE-
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR BROADBAND
AND THE LIKES TO EVEN GET A
GOOD CELL SERVICE WHERE WE CAN.
BE ABLE TO. GET GOOD
INFORMATION INTO THAT AND THE
NORTHERN PART OF STATE FOR
SURE. SO I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
A. B. THREE TWO THREE ALSO WANT
TO SHARE THAT. YOU KNOW THIS IS
KIND OF AN AREA WHERE WE HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY WHERE PEOPLE
CAN PRINT AND THEY THEY'RE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY. THE SALES OF
THEIR PAPER IN THEIR OPINIONS
WE'VE SEEN THAT- INFORMATION
DISTRIBUTED THROUGH FACEBOOK
AND INTERNET AND OTHER. SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS ARE TAKING
PEOPLE OFF OF THOSE AND NOT AND
NOT ALLOWING US TO HAVE THE
FREEDOM OF SPEECH THAT WE'VE
SEEN. OVER DECADES OF PRINT AND
SO I THINK THAT THE I'M WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE SUNSET COME OFF
COME OFF OF THIS AS WELL. I
JUST MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
OTHER OPPORTUNITIES TO SEE- TO
GET INFORMATION THAT'S UNBIASED
OR OR MAYBE NOT SHUT DOWN BY
SOME OTHER- BILLION BILL TO
TAKE PEOPLE OFF OF. THEIR
SOCIAL MEDIA AND NOT A LOT
THERE ALLOW THEIR VOICES TO BE
HEARD EVEN THOUGH SOMETIMES WE
DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT. ARE WE
TO DIFFERENT OPINION OF OURS
AND STILL NEED TO BE SAID. AND
I THINK THAT SAYS. SOMETHING IS
HAPPENING IN AMERICA RIGHT NOW
THAT'S CHANGING AND IT'S
UNFORTUNATE. SO FOR THAT REASON
AND MANY OTHER REASONS ALONG
WITH THE I AGREE WITH WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE SAID ABOUT THE
POLICIES THAT AB FIVE THIS HAS
CAUSED IN OUR COUNTRY DURING. A
PANDEMIC IS UNFORTUNATE. AND WE
NEED TO LOOK AT THOSE CARVE
OUTS THAT ARE THERE. AND DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR THE PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO BE INDEPENDENT. AND TO
BE ABLE TO WORK THOSE HOURS IF
THEY WANT TO WORK AND BE ABLE
TO BE COMPENSATED AT A FAIR
RATE AND- AND HAVE FREEDOM. BUT
FRANKLY IT'S ABOUT FREEDOM AND
MORE AND MORE I SEE OUR
GOVERNMENT TAKING AWAY THOSE
FREEDOMS. BECAUSE ONE CERTAIN
OF PEOPLE WANT THEM TO BE IN
THIS BOX OR THAT BOX I DON'T
THINK IT'S FAIR TO THE
CALIFORNIA THESE. AMERICANS AND
I THINK IT'S A REALLY STIFLING
OUR FREEDOM SO FOR THOSE
REASONS I'LL BE SUPPORTING AB.
THREE TWO THREE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR. ARE
THERE ANY AND YOU DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER. A SEEING NONE-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
SYNAGOGUE YES SORRY THANK YOU
SO MUCH I'LL BE VERY BRIEF-
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS. MR
PRESIDENT JUST WANT TO SAY
AGAIN THANK YOU TO SOME WOMAN
RUBIO AND THERE ARE SEVERAL CO
AUTHORS IN THE SIMPLY WHICH
WERE INCREDIBLY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT AND THIS IS A BY PRODUCT
IS IN BIPARTISAN APPROACH LOOK
IN BIG CITIES AND SMALL
NEWSPAPERS HAVE BEEN ONE OF THE
CORNERSTONES OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
WE'RE ABLE TO SPEAK OUR MINDS
AND LETTERS THE EDITOR THEY
HIGHLIGHT THE PEOPLE THAT MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES THRIVE IN THE
HOLD ALL OF US IN THESE
CHAMBERS TONIGHT. ACCOUNTABLE
WE'RE GATEFUL TO SENATOR KABIR
ON SENATOR HERTZBERG ALSO TO
SENATOR ALLINSON ARCHULETA
CENTER DEBATE SENATOR CHANG
CENTER GOT JOHNNY CENTER GLAZER
MITCHELL ROTH RUBIO AND NUMBER
FOUR BEING CO AUTHORS WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK. FOR AND I
VOTE ON THIS BIPARTISAN
MEASURES. OKAY THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE. OKAY
SAYING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA
I AT KINS. WELL. BRADFORD I
COME BY ADAM I DON. I THE
RUSSELL. I GOT JOHNNY HI LASER
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HI HELLO.
I WHISTLE BY HER TADO. HI
JACKSON I LAVER I REQUIRE I
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME I NIELSEN
BY PAN FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH. FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER.
HI STERN NUMBER ALL RIGHT I Y.
CASKEY HI WINNER HI. NOW MOVE
ON TO A REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS-
SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE THE ROLL
ON AGAIN THIS IS EIGHTY THREE
TO THREE THANK YOU. FAITH.
EIGHT EIGHTY THREE TWO THREE HI
BASED ON REGIS WE'RE JUST
EIGHTY THREE TWO THREE I OR
JUST HI CHANG. THANK A. B.
THREE TWO THREE I TRAINED HI
DALLI DALLI AB THREE TWO THREE
FIVE. BALLY HI GROSS. SANDRA
YOU'RE STILL ON MUTE. I
APOLOGIZE MISTER PRESIDENT
GROUP AB THREE TWO THREE HI
GROVE HI MELINDA'S. BELINDA'S
AB THREE TWO THREE FIVE
MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. THREE TWO
THREE RELUCTANT HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. EIGHTY THREE TO THREE
HIGH MORALE HI WELK. WE'LL LOOK
AT THREE TWO THREE HI WILKE HI.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR REQUIRE
MOVES TO CALL. LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO- I FELL AND I'M NUMBER
FIVE MR GONZALEZ ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT NINETY I
MEAN AT THE FOLLOWING NUMBER
NINETY FIVE SORRY POLITICS.
APRESENTA SEXUALLY PLEASE READ
THIS IS A. B. THREE ONE EIGHT
TWO. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
TING AN ACT RELATING TO HOUSING.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A B.
THREE ONE EIGHT TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM. DUE TO A
LOOPHOLE IN STATE LAW H. AWAY
IS ANOTHER COMMON INTEREST
DEVELOPMENTS ARE ALLOWED TO
PROHIBIT OR LIMIT HOMEOWNERS
FROM RENTING OUT THEIR HOMES.
H. O. IS GOVERNED 25% OF
EXISTING HOUSING AND THIRTEEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVE IN AN H. AWAY
ALLOWING FOR RENTAL PROVISIONS
FOR UNREASONABLE RENTAL
RESTRICTIONS MEANS CALIFORNIA
ISN'T TAKING FULL ADVANTAGE OF
THE AVAILABLE HOUSING STOCK AT
A TIME WHEN WE NEED IT THE
MOST. BY ALLOWING RENTAL
RESTRICTIONS THESE COMMUNITIES
CAN ALSO BAN THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NATURALLY AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TYPES SUCH AS ACCESSORY
DWELLING UNITS. EIGHTY THREE
MONEY TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE BY
PROHIBITING HOAS FROM BANNING
OR EFFECTIVELY PROHIBITING
THESE RENTALS BASED ON THE
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
THE HIGH RATES OF RENTALS CAN
LEAD TO HOAS OR INDIVIDUALS-
HOMEOWNERS RECEIVING INFERIOR
LENDING TERMS FROM THE FEDERAL
HOUSING ADMINISTRATION OR THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
THE AUTHOR RECENTLY AMENDED THE
BILL TO ALLOW HOAS TO CAP
RENTALS AT 25% OF THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF HOMES IN THE
ASSOCIATION. EIGHTY THREE ONE
EIGHT TWO ALSO CLOSES AN
IMPORTANT LOOPHOLE ALL MAKE NEW
AND EXISTING HOUSING AVAILABLE
TO MORE CALIFORNIANS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU SERRA GONZALEZ DEBATE
ON THIS MATTER CENTER CAPITAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
PRESIDENT- I RISE RELUCTANTLY
TO OPPOSE THIS BILL AND THEN
LET ME TELL YOU WHY. THE ISSUE
IN CALIFORNIA IS NOT JUST THAT
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH HOUSING
UNITS BUT THE OTHER ISSUE IS
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH.
HOMEOWNERS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THE HIGH PRICE OF OUR
HOUSING. WE HAVE THE LOWEST
HOME OWNERSHIP. IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. THEN WE'VE EVER HAD
IN OUR HISTORY INCLUDING RIGHT
B. RIGHT AT THE TIME THAT THE
GI BILL WAS INSTITUTED. AND
THAT IS THAT MEANS THAT PEOPLE
DON'T HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
GET INTO THEIR FIRST HOME. MANY
OF THE OF THE PEOPLE THAT END
UP LIVING IN HOAS MOVING TO A
CHOICE BECAUSE THERE ARE FOUR
DOUBLE. AND THEY'RE USUALLY IN
SMALLER LOT SIZES WHICH MEANS
THAT THEY'RE MUCH MORE
AFFORDABLE END TO END AND PART
OF THE REASON THEY'RE
ATTRACTIVE IS THAT THEY'RE ALL
OWNED. BY PEOPLE WHO WHO BUY
INTO THE INTO THE PROJECTS AND
WHO LIVE THERE AND ARE NOT
RENTING AND SO TO OVER RULE OR
OVER RIDE THE H. AWAY RULES
THAT SAY. THOU SHALT NOT RENT
OUT YOUR UNIT MEANS THAT WE ARE
MAKING THE DECISION HERE AT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO OVERRULE
LOCAL LOCAL DECISIONS THAT WERE
MADE ABOUTWHO WHO COULD
ACTUALLY LIVE IN IN THESE IN
THESE PROJECTS AND WHEN THESE
UNITS SELF. PAY USUALLY G VERY
QUICKLY BECAUSE THEY'RE ONE OF
THE AFFORDABLE UNITS THAT ARE
STILL LEFT ON THE MARKET SO I'M
GOING TO OPPOSE THIS BILL- I
THINK IT IT IT- THE INTENTION
WAS- IT WAS A GOOD INTENTION
BUT I THINK THE INADVERTENT
IMPACT IS GOING TO BE THAT
WE'RE GOING TO BE TAKING. AWAY
THE RIGHT OF PEOPLE TO NOT HAVE
RENTAL UNITS IN IN THEIR
PROJECTS AND- AND THAT STARTS
TO DEGRADE THE UNITS AND- THAT
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE WANT TO SEE
WE WANT TO SEE MORE HOME
OWNERSHIP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR L. AS IN ANY
FURTHER DEBATE. NINE I SEE ANY
HANDS UP- SEVENTY DOLLARS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE- I WOULD JUST
SAY THAT THIS IS A GREAT
MEASURE- ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND
WHAT- MY COLLEAGUE FROM SALINAS
IS SAYING WE ABSOLUTELY WANT
INCREASE HOMEOWNERSHIP IF
PEOPLE DO NOT HAVE THE- CAPITAL
TO. OWN A HOME OR THEY HAVE
THEIR FINANCIAL CIRCUMSTANCES
DON'T ALLOW FOR THAT THIS
ALLOWS FOR THE RENTAL MARKET TO
OPEN UP A BIT THROUGH H. AWAY
SO. WITH THAT I AM RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR TIME. THANK YOU SENATOR
GONZALES- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA. HI
ACTIONS FIVE BELL BRADFORD I
HAVE A- DOT. FIVE TERRAZZO. I
TELL JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI KURTZ BURKE. HI
HELLO HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO.
JACKSON FIVE LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. FIVE
NIELSEN. PAM HI HI FORTUNE TINO.
ROTH HE- BROUGHT. FIVE RUBIO.
SKINNER HI STERN AMBERG BY MY
COUNT SKI. FIVE WINNER FIVE.
LET'S NOW MOVE TO THE CENTERS
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY-
AGAIN THE- BILL NUMBER IS.
EIGHTY THREE ONE EIGHT TWO
SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE THE ROLE.
FAITH. EIGHT EIGHTY THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO. BATES NOW FOR JUST.
WE'RE JUST EIGHT THREE ONE
EIGHT TWO NOW OR JUST NO CHANG.
THANK EIGHT THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
TWO NOW CHANG NO DALLI DALLI AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO NO. DALLY
NO GROWTH. THE GROUP AB AT
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TWO NOW GROVE
NO MELINDA'S. WINDOWS EIGHT B.
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY TO ABSTAIN.
MORLOCKS OR IT COULD BE THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO ABSTAIN AND
MORALE. WELL IT MAY BE THIRTY
ONE EIGHTY TWO NO MORE L. NO
WELK. WE THINK AT THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO HI WELCOME HI IN THE
CENTER NIELSEN. NIELSEN NOW.
OKAY SENATORS ALWAYS PLACES THE
BILL ON CALL. SENATOR ATKINS-
THIRTY DID YOU WISH TO TAKE UP-
FILING OF NUMBER TWO NINETY TWO
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
AT THIS TIME. ALL RIGHT SO
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE IN A
FILE ITEM NUMBER NINETY TWO.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA AN ACT RELATING TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY. CENTER
ACTIONS THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES. FIVE I
APPRECIATE BEING ABLE TO
PRESENT A B. TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GLORIA A BILL THAT I BELIEVE
WILL BE TRANSFORMATIONAL FOR
THE SAN DIEGO REGION. AT ITS
CORE A B. TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE IS INTENDED TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR OUR LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCY SANDAG.
OUT WHICH IS OUR- METROPOLITAN
PLANNING ORGANIZATION TO
COLLABORATE WITH THE US NAVY ON
AN IMPORTANT REDEVELOPMENT
PROJECT. FIRST AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WILL STRENGTHEN THE
NAVY'S PRESENCE IN AMERICA'S
FINEST CITY SAN DIEGO UNLIKE
OTHER NAVY INFRASTRUCTURE THE
NAV FOR FACILITY WHICH IS
CALLED. HOUSES THE NAVY'S CYBER
SECURITY PROFESSIONALS IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE PROXIMITY TO
THE. WATER THIS BILL WILL
FACILITATE THE- OF A MOBILITY
HUB TO CONNECT DIFFERENT
TRANSIT ROUTES AT ONE PLACE
ALONG WITH TRANSIT ORIENTED
DEVELOPMENT. OF NEEDED HOUSING
WITH COMMERCIAL AND RETAIL
SPACE. MAYBE TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE WILL FACILITATE THE
CONSTRUCTION OF AN AIRPORT
CONNECTOR TO THE SAN DIEGO
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT. NO
LONGER WILL OUR AIRPORT BB ONLY
MAJOR AIRPORT WITHOUT A DIRECT
LINK TO THE REGIONAL RAIL
SYSTEM. THE NAVY IS WELL INTO
ITS ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS FOR THE REDEVELOPMENT
OF THE OLD TOWN SITE. WITH THE
HELP. OF THE SENATOR FROM SANTA
MONICA'S ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
COMMITTEE. I THE BILL INCLUDES
SEVERAL SAFEGUARDS TO ENSURE
ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW AND
REQUIRES ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
BE ACHIEVED. FOR EXAMPLE THE
BILL REQUIRES THE CENTRAL
MOBILITY HUB TO OBTAIN LEED
GOLD CERTIFICATION. AND THE
PROJECT BE GREENHOUSE GAS
NEUTRAL WITH AN EMPHASIS ON
LOCALIZED MITIGATION MEASURES.
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
REPRESENTS A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY
TO PROTECT THE EXISTING FIVE
THOUSAND NAVY JOBS FOR
RELOCATION. CREATE A TWENTY
FIRST CENTURY TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM FOR SAN DIEGO AND
PROVIDE SOME DESPERATELY NEEDED
STIMULUS TO OUR LOCAL ECONOMY
THAT SUFFERING THE EFFECTS OF
CODE NINETEEN. AND WITHOUT THE
NEED FOR STATE FUNDS SO ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER GLORIA
AND MYSELF I ASK FOR YOUR I.
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ACTIONS
IS THERE A DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE
CENTER PORTIS. THANK YOU IF I
MAY POSE A QUESTION TO THE
FLOOR MANAGER A SECOND TOO
WILLING TO ACCEPT THE QUESTION-
PLEASE CONTINUE KIND OF ORDERS.
THANK YOU. THROUGH JUDICIARY
ANOTHER- COMMITTEES AS WELL AS
FLOOR I'VE ALWAYS BEEN AN
ADVOCATE THAT SEQUEL. HAS BEEN
USED MORE AS A SORT OF DENNIS
SHIELDS ON I THINK W'VE WE'VE
LOST OUR WAY WHEN IT COMES TO
SEE WHAT BECAUSE IT IS KEPT US
FROM DOING WHAT'S IMPORTANT IN
CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S NOT TO
SAY THAT. ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
IS NOT IMPORTANT FACT I'M A BIG
ADVOCATE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW AND MANY OF YOU. ALREADY
KNOW THAT IT WAS A REPUBLICAN
THAT CREATED THIS AS GOVERNOR
BACK IN THE DAY- SO I THINK
IT'S I THINK IT'S HELPFUL
PRECEDENT SO MY QUESTION TO THE
FLOOR MANAGER IS. NEPA RUBIO IS
BEING ALLOWED TO SATISFYING
SEQUEL OBLIGATIONS IN THIS
PROCESS IS THAT CORRECT. WELL I
THINK- EIGHTY YES IN SOME
RESPECTS BECAUSE THIS PROJECT
INVOLVES THE UNITED STATES NAVY
AS WELL AND SO IT MAKES IT A
LITTLE BIT MORE COMPLEX IN
TERMS OF US SOME OF THE REVIEW
PROCESS ST. I ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW IS NOT NEGATED FROM THIS
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE ALSO
HAVE TO MEET ME BUT AS WELL. SO
IT IS YOUR QUESTION THE OLD
PRESIDIO AREA THAT WAS
DEVELOPED IN THE POINT LOMA
AREA ADJACENT TO WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT DID THAT HAVE TO
GO THROUGH SEE WHAT. I'M SORRY-
SENATOR I DON'T REMEMBER THE
HISTORY ON THAT I WOULD HAVE TO
LOOK. FOR AFRICA BY THE WAY I
AM THE- I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS FOR A COUPLE OF REASONS
ONE I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
THE STADIUM CONNIE. IN THE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN SAN DIEGO
LEADERS AND OUR MILITARY. IT
HAS A LONG HISTORY IN IN THE
SAME DAY. BUT I WANT US TO
REMEMBER THAT I SEE WHAT. IS
ONE OF THOSE THINGS WHEN THE
PRIORITY IS BIGGEST. THE
CAPITAL FINDS A WAY TO MAKE IT
WORK. AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND
FOLKS THAT WHEN OTHERS SEE WHAT
ENDEAVORS EXEMPTIONS OR
STREAMLINING EFFORTS- OR FOUGHT
TOOTH AND NAIL. I THINK IT'S
NOT ALWAYS CONSISTENT POLICY
MAKING. I'LL BE GLAD TO SUPPORT
THIS TODAY. THANK YOU SIR
BORDERS SEVERAL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- LET ME START OFF BY
SAYING THAT I'M I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS BILL I THINK IT'S
A IT'S A REALLY GOOD
INVESTMENT- IN THE COMMUNITY
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT BUT
I CAN'T I CAN'T. NOT STAND UP.
ON THIS BECAUSE I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON. TRYING TO PUT
RESOURCES INTO SOME OF OUR MORE
OF OUR POOREST COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND IN
CALIFORNIA AND THOSE ARE.
CENSUS TRACTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DESIGNATED- THAT DESIGNATED
OURSELVES IS THE POOREST CENSUS
TRACTS AND I'VE BEEN TRYING TO
GET ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IN
THEM FOR FOUR YEARS AND MY MOST
RECENT ATTEMPT WAS THOUGHT
THROUGH THIS HOUSE I WANT TO
SAY I WAS REALLY PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT WE DID VERY THANKFUL
OF MY GOOD FRIEND. SENATOR FROM
SANTA MONICA WHO HELPED ME TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE WENT THROUGH
THE MOST THE HIGHEST STANDARDS
OF C. CLUB WE BUILT A GOLD LEED
CERTIFIED WITH- I GUARANTEE
THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AS
PART OF THE OF THE PROJECT BUT
WE COULDN'T GET IT DONE AND IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND SO I'M
FRUSTRATED BECAUSE WHENEVER WE
TALK ABOUT DOING THINGS FOR
POOR PEOPLE IT SEEMS LIKE WE
JUST CAN'T. GET THE COMMITMENT
TO DO WHAT WE NEED TO DO SO I'M
I'M HERE TO SAY I'M I'M NOT
DONE I'M GONNA COME BACK- AND
MY BILL HAD THE EXACT SAME
EXPEDITED SEEKER REVIEW THAT
WE'VE GIVEN TO STADIUMS TO TWO
ARENAS PROBABLY TO THE OLYMPICS
WHEN THEY COME TO LA AND NOW TO
SAN DIEGO BUT WE NEED TO FOCUS
ON POOR PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY
DESERVE TO HAVE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AS WELL. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU SIR
CAMARILLO CENTER JACKSON. YEAH
THANK YOU I THOUGHT TIRED OF
HEARING ABOUT SICK OF BEING AT
THE PUNCHING BAG. IF WE DIDN'T
HAVE SEQUEL WOULD LOOK LIKE
MIAMI BEACH. AND IF ANY OF YOU
HAVE BEEN TO MIAMI BEACH. ARE
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING. THE
SEQUEL PROCESS WHAT HAS
PROTECTED CALIFORNIA FOR
DECADES. THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
HAVE HAD AND WE HAD A NUMBER OF
HEARINGS ON THIS SO THAT THE
FACTS ARE CLEAR AND NOT JUST.
MORE FANTASY LIKE WE SEEM TO BE
GETTING. FROM SO MANY OF OUR
FRIENDS- WHO- ARE UNWILLING TO.
TO ACCEPT WHAT IS FACTUAL. THE
PROBLEM WE HAVE IS NOT CHEAPER
THE PROBLEM WE HAVE IS
NIMBYISM. VERY DIFFERENT
ISSUES. THE SIMPLE PROCESS IS
DESIGNED SO THAT WE WILL. BE
CLEAR AND PROTECTOR OF ALL THE
COMMUNITIES AROUND WHICH THESE
DEVELOPMENTS ARE GOING ON
BECAUSE- THE DEVELOPERS WHO
WANT TO BUILD GENERALLY
SPEAKING. ARE MORE FOCUSED ON
THEIR FINANCIAL GAIN. THE
SIMPLE PROCESS REQUIRES THEM TO
CONSIDER THE COMMUNITY THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE QUALITY OF
LIFE ISSUES WHICH ARE WHAT
MAKES CALIFORNIA IS SUCH A
GREAT PLACE TO BE. THIS MEASURE
DOES HAVE A- AN EXPEDITED
JUDICIAL REVIEW PROCESS
SOMETHING WHICH I GENERALLY
OPPOSE. BUT IN THIS CASE THE
STANDARDS THAT ARE. BEING
REQUIRED HERE ARE OF THE
HIGHEST LEVELS. AND IT IS MY
HOPE THAT GOING FORWARD
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING
DEVELOPED WILL IN FACT BE MADE
OF THE HIGHEST LEVEL. AND THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF THINGS WE
CAN DO TO EXPEDITE THE SEQUEL
PROCESS WITHOUT UNDERMINING IT
AND MANY OF THEM ARE BILLS THAT
I'VE TRIED TO BRING FORWARD AND
I HOPE IN THE FUTURE. OTHERS
WILL. FOLLOW THAT EFFORT TO
STREAMLINE IT BUT NOT A RADIC
HATED AND UNFORTUNATELY THOSE
WHO ARE- BUILDERS AND
DEVELOPERS WOULD RATHER SEE IT
GO AWAY FREQUENTLY SUPER BY THE
WAY IS USED BY COMPETITORS IT
ISN'T USED BY COMMUNITIES IT'S
USED BY BUSINESSES. TO TRY TO.
CREATE OBSTACLES FOR THEIR-
OPPONENTS AND FOR THEIR
COMPETITION SO- I WANT TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY THE MAN GLORIA FOR
THIS BILL BECAUSE HE REALLY HAS
INSISTED UPON A VERY HIGH BAR.
THERE IS A REVIEW BUT I WILL
ALSO CAUTIONED THAT THIS IS NOT
ANYTHING THAT IS MANDATE THE
MANDATORY THE COURTS. WILL DO
THEIR BEST TO TRY TO MEET THAT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAY
ROOM A REVIEW. REQUIREMENT BUT
THERE ARE. FRANKLY WHEN YOU
TALKTO MANY OF THE- JUDGES ARE
EXPERT IN THE FIELD THEY TELL
YOU THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY
IMPOSSIBLE TO DO IT WITHIN TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAYS AND
THAT'S BECAUSE- BOTH SIDES.
NEED THAT ADDITIONAL TIME BUT
AGAIN LET'S BE CLEAR ON WHAT
SHE IS INNOCENT I THINK THAT'S
THE POINT HERE THIS IS A GOOD
BILL- AGAIN- THERE'S NOTHING
PERFECT IN THE WORLD IN WHICH
WE LIVE- BUT THIS IS REALLY
SOMETHING THAT DOES TRY TO
MAINTAIN THE HIGHEST OF
STANDARDS- AND HOPEFULLY WILL.
BE PART OF WHAT LEADS THE WAY
INTO TO PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES
THAT TO COMPLY WITH SECORD OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT AND
ALSO ENCOURAGE THE KIND OF
ADDITIONAL BUILDING THAT WE
NEED HERE IN THE STATE WITH
THAT I WOULD ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU SIR JACKSON
CENTER GROVE. BUT. SORRY SIR I
WAS WORKING OUT SOME
INFORMATION WITH YOUR MAJORITY
FLOOR LEADER. AND. AND I DO
APOLOGIZE AND SO ALTHOUGH I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL TONIGHT
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS GOOD THAT
WE WORK WITH THE NAVY AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE C. FOR
EXEMPTIONS THAT WE NEED TO SO
STRINGENT IN CALIFORNIA I DO-
DISAGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE IN
SANTA BARBARA THAT SEQUEL IS-
SOMETHING THAT IS FABULOUS FOR
THIS STATE IT'S ACTUALLY NOT-
WE DO EXEMPTIONS ALL THE TIME
FOR SEQUEL- WHEN IT SUITS SAID
THE MAJORITY PARTY. AND WHEN
IT- PROVIDES FOR A CONTRACT
LABOR AGREEMENT- PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS SO- ALTHOUGH YOU
KNOW LIKE I SAID I'LL SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT HAS THE
ISSUE WITH THE UNITED STATES
NAVY- THAT I THINK IS GOING TO
BE BENEFICIAL FOR THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO I WISH THAT WE WOULD
LOOK AT US HE QUIT AS A WHOLE
AND REALIZE THAT SEQUEL THAT IN
ITSELF IS AND DETRIMENTAL TO
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
YOU LOOK AT JUST PET PROJECTS
BEING APPROVED BUT NORMAL
PROCESSES WOULD TAKE YEARS TO
GET THROUGH- EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAVE BEEN MITIGATED STANDARDS
TO BE ABLE TO PROCEED. SO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME JUST-
SHARE MY THOUGHTS AND I
APOLOGIZE. FOR BEING ON THE
PHONE WITH YOUR MAJORITY FLOOR
LEADER. SO UNDERSTAND YOU TO
COMMUTE. WITH A LEADERSHIP. ALL
RIGHT A CENTER FOR CHIPS. I
CERTAINLY WAS NOT INTENDED TO
SPEAK BUT I WAS SO INSPIRED BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA'S COMMENTS. THAT IS
LONG AS WE HAVE STANDARDS THAT
ARE OF THE HIGHEST QUALITY IN
NEED BUT CERTAINLY FALLS WITHIN
THAT CATEGORY THEN ALL THE
CONCERNS INVOLVING SECRET HAVE
BEEN SATISFIED SO IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT MINE. THAT THE
CHAIR JUDICIARY AGAIN MY FRIEND
AND COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA
BARBARA- IS FINISHING UP HER
TENURE IN THE SENATE I WOULD
HAVE REALLY ENJOYED A
CONVERSATION IN THE NEXT
LEGISLATIVE CYCLE ON THE SUPER
RELATED MATTERS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR BORDERS. ANY
OTHER ADDITIONAL DEBATE SAYING
NONE ON THE FLOOR SAYING NO
HANDS UP SECRETARY. BUT WHICH
SUGGESTS THAT ACTIVITY LIKE THE
CLOTHES THANK YOU. MR
PRESIDENT- YEAH I WOULD JUST
SAY I'D THIS IS THE SECOND YEAR
IN A ROW THAT I'VE MANAGED TO
BILL FOR MY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FROM SAN DIEGO- WHICH WE GOT
INTO A ROBUST DEBATE. ABOUT
PHILOSOPHICAL ISSUES OF SEQUEL
AND OTHER THINGS SO IT MUST BE
PART OF THE PROTEINS JOB
DESCRIPTION. LET ME AT THIS
LATE HOUR ON. THAT PLEDGE MY
SUPPORT OF COURSE TO THE
SENATOR FROM SILLINESS BECAUSE
I THOUGHT THAT WAS A VERY GOOD
BILL- WORTHY OF CONSIDERATION
AND I PLEDGE MY WORK WITH HER.
ON NEXT YEAR ON THAT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND FINALLY I WOULD
SAY THE IMPORTANT THING ABOUT
THIS. HAS TO DO WITH THE
TRANSPORTATION HUB WHICH AT THE
END WILL HELP SAN DIEGO CHIEF
STATE ENVIRONMENTAL POLICIES
AND OBJECTIVES I THINK THAT'S
ONE. IN ADDITION TO THE
ECONOMIC. IMPACTS FOR SAN DIEGO
AND OF COURSE THE NAVY- THE
HIGHEST STANDARD AS POINTED OUT
BY THE CHAIR OF JUDICIARY AND
AT THE SAME TIME. THE GOALS
THAT IT WILL MEET THAT THAT ARE
ALL ABOUT. WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH- AROUND CLIMATE. AND
THEN LASTLY I WOULD SAY- IN
TERMS OF THE PROCESS THIS ARE
MEMBERS OF THIS BODY HAVE
WORKED VERY HARD ON ANOTHER
BILL THAT I HOPE TO SEE COME
BACK THAT WILL. HOPEFULLY
ADDRESS SOME OF THE OTHER.
PROJECTS AND THAT WOULD BE S.
B. NINE NINETY FIVE BUT WE'LL
HAVE ANOTHER NIGHT TO DISCUSS
THAT WITH THAT I APPRECIATE
YOUR SUPPORT YOUR- CONVERSATION
AND YOUR INPUT AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ATKINS- SECRETARY- SEE
NO OTHER DEBATE SIXTY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I FELL.
BRADFORD BY ADAM I THOUGHT. HI
TERRAZZA HI CAROL JOHNNY FIVE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG.
I TELL FIVE WESTERN. HI HER
TADO. HI JACKSON I LLEVA I
REQUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME
I NIELSEN. HI PAM HI HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI ROTH. FIVE RUBIO HI
SKINNER. HI STERN NUMBER. BY
CASKEY FIVE WINNER. HI LET'S
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR CENTERS WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THIS
IS EIGHTY TWO SEVEN THREE ONE
SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE THE ROLE.
BASICS H. A. B. TWO SEVEN THREE
ONE HIGH RATES NINE OR JUST.
WE'RE JUST EIGHTY TWO SEVEN
THREE ONE ONLINE OR JUST BY
CHANG CHENEY AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY ONE EYED CHANG HI DALLY.
KELLY ABC TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE HI DALLY HI GROSS. GROUP AB
TWO SEVEN THREE ONE HI GROVE HI
MELINDA'S. WHEN IS A B. TWO
SEVEN THREE ONE I WONDER AS I
MORLOCK. D. B. TWO SEVEN THREE
ONE ABSTAINED. MORO ABC TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE HI MORALE HI
WILKE. ABC TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE INSTITUTES WELL I OKAY
THANK YOU- CENTER ACTIONS MOVES
TO CALL ALL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
GONNA MOVE TO THE SUPPLEMENTAL
FILE IT HAS THAT- WILL FIRST
BEGIN WITH- FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE ONE THREE SP EIGHTY SIX
CENTER GARAGE SO ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT. HEY CENTER
ALSO. CHECK THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN. WE OUGHT ON- SURGERY
PLEASE READ APOLOGIZE SORRY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL EIGHTY
SIX BY SENATOR ALSO AN ACT
RELATING TO PESTICIDES SENATOR
ALSO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS B. EIGHTY SIX WILL REQUIRE
THE DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION TO SUBMIT QUARTERLY
REPORTS THAT PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON GRANULAR
CHLORPYRIFOS. THE USE OF
GRANULAR FOOTLOCKER FUSS TO
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEES AND THE
OFFICE OF THE SURGEON GENERAL
CALIFORNIA HAS A CRITICAL
INTEREST IN ENSURING THAT FARM
WORKERS AND FAMILIES ARE
PROTECTED FROM THE ADVERSE
EFFECTS OF EXPOSURE TO HARMFUL
PESTICIDES. AIRBUS IS ACUTELY
TOXIC AND ASSOCIATED WITH NEAR
DEVELOPMENTAL HARM CHILDREN.
CHILDREN CHILDREN CAN BE
EXPOSED TO CHLORPYRIFOS WHEN
THEIR PARENTS OR SIBLINGS BEING
THE PESTICIDE INTO THE HOME ON
THEIR SKIN CLOTHING AND SHOES.
S. B. EIGHTY SIX REQUIRES. THE
DPR TO PROVIDE QUARTERLY
REPORTS ON THE USE OF GRANULAR
CHLORPYRIFOS. TO BE CLEAR AS B.
EIGHTY SIX IS NOT A BAN ON
GRANULAR CHARACTER FOSS. WE DO
NEED GREATER TRANSPARENCY OVER
THE USE OF BLACK GRANULAR
CHLORPYRIFOS THIS INFORMATION
MUST BE ACCESSIBLE TO PEOPLE
LIKE FARM WORKERS FOR THESE
REASONS COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY URGE AND I BOTH.
THANK YOU SENATOR RAZA DEBATE
ON THIS ISSUE. HI SARAH
CAROLINE. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- I QUESTION THE OF
THE OF THE AUTHOR SENATOR ALSO
WE WILLING TO ACCEPT THE
QUESTION. YES PLEASE COULD YOU
ASSESS OUR COVER THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- YOU USE
THE WORD GRANULAR CLIPPER FAST
AND I WAS WONDERING I YOU KNOW
I'M I APOLOGIZE MY SCIENCE ON
THIS IS A LITTLE OLD BUT- I
BELIEVE THERE IS A GAS. AND
WELL I THINK I GET GAS THAT'S
USED IS THAT DIFFERENT THAN THE
GRANULAR I I'M SURE I'M JUST
TRYING TO GET AN UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT EXACTLY WE'RE GOING TO
BE ASKING FOR- AND HOW IT GETS
USED BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WAS A-
IT WAS USED AS AN INJECTION AS
OPPOSED TO. A GRANULAR FORM
YEAH. SO SAID ROSEN FROM ALSO-
SEND A CARRIER- I AM ALSO NOT A
SCIENCE SCIENTIST ON THIS BUT-
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THERE
IS THE AERIAL THERE'S THE SPRAY.
AND THEN THERE'S THE GRANULAR
AND OF THE AERIAL IS UP OR THE
SPRAY IS THE AUTHOR PURIFIES
VERSIONS THAT HAS BEEN BANNED
THE GRANULAR VERSION HAS NOT
BEEN BANNED AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT- CONTINUING
TO MONITOR THROUGH THESE
REPORTS. VERY MAD. I CHECKED
THE SHEET THAT- THAT
EXPLANATION- I'M GOING TO BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BECAUSE I
REALLY FEEL LIKE THAT THE MORE
INFORMATION THAT WE CAN GET THE
BETTER- AND- I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
THANK YOU A CENTER MINING.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE
IN SUPPORT I WANT TO THANK THE-
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD FOR HER WORK ON IT- IN
THE DISTRICT I REPRESENT
THERE'S BEEN. A LOT OF CONCERN
ABOUT THE NEUROTOXIC IMPACTS OF
CHLORPYRIFOS. AND I ALSO.
SUPPORT THE CONTINUED
MONITORING. THERE'S ALSO
PROCESS UNDER WAY- FOR THE
ELIMINATION OF THE USE OF.
CERTAIN FORMS OF CHLORPYRIFOS
IN CALIFORNIA. AND WE VOTED IN
THE BUDGET LAST YEAR. MONEY TO
HELP RESEARCH ALTERNATIVES. I
URGE AND I VOTE THIS IS A GOOD
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER MINING CENTER PORTIS.
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
PRESIDENT I'M HOPEFUL THAT THE
FLOOR MANAGER WILL ANSWER A
QUESTION DIRECTLY AND NOT IN
FINAL COMMENTS. WOULD IT BE
POSSIBLE TO POSE A QUESTION AND
GET A RESPONSE WELL CERTAINLY
THAT'S HER PREROGATIVE-
CENTERED AROUND SO- WOULD YOU
WILLING TO TAKE A QUESTION IT'S
TIME YES YES. PLEASE CONTINUE
CENTER OF ORDERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AGRICULTURE'S MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF DECADES ON DEALING
WITH PESTICIDES AND- THE
DANGERS BY PRODUCT THE USE OF
PESTICIDES. BUT I WANTED TO ASK
YOU THAT. THEIR PARENTS THEIR
PEERS TO BE AN IMPORTANT USE
AND I WANTED TO KNOW BASED ON
YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. ARE YOU FAMILIAR
IF THERE'S AN ALTERNATIVE TO
THE ASIAN AND I DID NOTICE I'M
I'M SO I'M LOOKING AT IT THE
ASIAN CITRUS- SOLICITED. I
THINK I'M SAYING THAT WRONG BUT
IT'S A INVOLVING AN AUNT AND
THIS PARTICULAR PRODUCT. IS
UNIQUELY SUITED TO THE A. C. P.
OUR INVESTIGATION I WANT TO
KIND OF HEAR FROM YOU. WHETHER
OR NOT THAT WAS DISCUSSED AT
LENGTH WITH THE AUTHOR OF THIS
ENDED THE CITRUS IN
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY. CENTER
ALSO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
AM NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT A
PARTICULAR CHEMICAL- THIS BILL
IS STRICTLY ON GRANULAR
CORPORATE BOSS AND THE
REPORTING OF THE USE OF
GRANULAR CLICK HERE FOR US.
SEVERAL YEARS. NO DOUBT IT IS
IT IS LIMITED TO THAT- I THINK
I WILL PROBABLY HAVE TO OPPOSE
AND FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
AGRICULTURE IN THEIR IN THEIR
DISTRICTS THIS APPARENTLY SEEMS
TO BE IN ONE PARTICULAR
PESTICIDE THAT IS ESSENTIAL IN
DEALING WITH THIS PARTICULAR-
INFESTATION THAT HAS COME IN
AND BEEN INVOLVED IN FLORIDA
TEXAS MEXICO AND BRAZIL SO I
WOULD CAUTION IS THAT EVEN
THOUGH IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
PHASE OUT OF TO THE GREATEST
DEGREE POSSIBLE- THESE
DANGEROUS PESTICIDES WITHIN THE
AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY. IN A
PANDEMIC AS WELL AS A NATIONAL
SECURITY- CONTEXT WHERE WE ARE
DESPERATE TO MAINTAIN OUR
PRODUCTION CAPACITY. THIS
SEGMENT OF AGRICULTURE IN THIS
INDUSTRY IF THERE IS NO OTHER
ALTERNATIVE AT THIS POINT IN
TIME. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DEBATE. K.
SAYING NONE CENTER ALSO WHICH
LIKE CLOTHES THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR PRESIDENT AGAIN THIS
BILL IS STRICTLY ON THE ISSUE
OF GETTING QUARTERLY REPORTS
FOR INFORMATION ON THE USE OF
GRANULAR CORPORATE FUSS IT'S
NOT ABOUT A BAND IT'S NOT A
BOTTLE ALTERNATIVE. CHEMICALS
OR PESTICIDES THIS IS ABOUT
REPORTING ON THE USE OF
GRANULAR CORPORATE BOSS AND ASK
FOR I WILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO. THAT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN I
ARCHULETA I AT KINS FIVE WELL.
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A- I
THOUGHT. I THE RYZEN. I GOT
JOHNNY HI GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
HERZ BERG. HI HELLO HI WITH SO.
HI HER TADO HI JACKSON. HI
LLEVA HI MCGUIRE. MITCHELL HI
MY NAME. I NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
FIVE FOURTEEN TINA. HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN.
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI HI
WINNER. HI OKAY I WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR CENTERS ARE
PROTESTING REMOTELY THIS IS ON
AMENDMENTS IN CONCURRENCE AT S.
B. EIGHTY SIX SECRETARY PLEASE
CONTINUE THE ROLE. BASE YES THE
EIGHTY SIX OF ST. GORGEOUS
SORRY. DID YOU HEAR TURNING
OKAY SURVEYS WE DID NOT HEAR
YOU I SAY YOUR NAME I APOLOGIZE.
BAKES SP EIGHTY SIX ABSTAINED
THANK YOU. FORTRESS BORJAS SPD
EIGHTY SIX NOW. FOR AGES NOW
CHANG. CHANGE THANK S. B.
EIGHTY SIX ABSTAINED VALLEY. L.
E. S. B. EIGHTY SIX NO DALLY NO
GROWTH. S. C. EIGHTY SIX NO
GROWTH GOT IT GROVE NO.
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S SP ONE SP
EIGHTY SIX NOW MELINDA'S NO
MORLOCK. S. P. EIGHTY SIX NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. S. P.
EIGHTY SIX NO MORALE NO WELL.
WELL S. P. EIGHTY SIX NO
WELCOME NOW. OKAY SENATOR RAZA
PLACE THE BILL ON CALL RIGHT AS
WE MOVE ON TO US THERE ARE DISK
THIS PART OF THE CALENDAR NOTE
THAT THESE ARE- CONCURRENCE IN
THE SELLING THEM IN SO JUST ASK
THAT THAT PRESENTERS FOCUSED
PRIMARILY ON THE AMENDMENT
ASSEMBLY MINUTES ARE TAKEN I
BELIEVE THE NEXT ONE UP IS-
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN CENTER
ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE
UP. SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT
CONCURRENCE AND SEMI
MAINTENANCE. RIGHT US SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL ONE
FIFTY EIGHT BY SENATOR ALLEN AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTIONS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CENTRE ALAN THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT FEW YEARS AGO
MEMBERS- WE PASSED. CENTER LAW
CENTER LARS SP NINE FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH ESTABLISHED THE COUNTY OF
LOS ANGELES REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION- FOR DRAWING THE
LINES- THEIR SUPERVISOR ALL
DISTRICTS THERE WAS A ONE ISSUE
THAT WAS WAS NOT ADDRESSED THIS
THIS IS A BILL THAT CLARIFIES
THE VOTERS WHO ARE REGISTERED
WITH NO PARTY PREFERENCE ARE
ELIGIBLE TO SERVE ON THE ON THE
COMMISSION- THIS BILL IS BACK
ON CONCURRENCE WITH SOME MINOR
AMENDMENTS AND WE- ASKED HER
ABOUT. THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN.
IS THERE DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE.
H. NO MICROPHONES UP SEEING NO
HANDS UP. SIR ALAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. AT IT IS RISKY
STRONG BIPARTISAN SUPPORT NO NO
VOTES ON THE SENATE SIDE I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR VOTE FOR
THIS. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
AND CURRENTS IN SEVENTY MINUTES.
ALAN I ARCHULETA I AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD I HAVE A- I
THOUGHT. HI DURAZO I GOT JOHNNY
FIVE LASER GONZALEZ BY HERTZ
BERG RIGHT I HELLO FIVE WAYS SO.
HI HER TADO. HI JACKSON HI
LLEVA I REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
HI MY NAME. I NIELSEN. NO PAM
BY FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH.
I REVIEW. HI SKINNER. I STERN
AMBERG BY CASKEY FIVE WINNER HI
LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
CENTERS PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
THE SUNKEN CURRENTS ASSEMBLY
MINUTES TWO S. B. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE
THE ROLE. FAKES H. SP ONE FIFTY
EIGHT HI CRITICS ARE REGIS
WE'RE JUST AS B. ONE FIVE
EIGHTY FIVE FOR JUST HI CHANG.
THANKS SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT HI
CHIANG MAI DALLY. KELLY SP ONE
FIFTY EIGHT HI SALLY HI. GROWTH
S. C. ONE FIFTY EIGHT NINE.
GROVE HI MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S
SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT I'M STAYING.
MORLOCK BROADCAST ONE FIFTY
EIGHT SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT NO.
MORE LOCK NO. ZERO YES- MORALE
SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT NOW MORALE
NO. WELL. YES P. ONE FIFTY
EIGHT HI WILL HI OKAY SIR ALAN
USED TO CALL THE NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER- FOLLOWING NUMBER
ONE FIFTEEN- CENTER HERTZBERG
WE PREPARED TO TAKE THIS UP.
RIGHT SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIX EIGHTY FOUR BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG AN ACT
RELATING TO ELECTIONS- HERZBERG
PASSED IN BERLIN OH SORRY. ALL
RIGHT BOTH WILL PASS
TEMPORARILY ON ONE FIFTEEN
LET'S MOVE DOWN TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER. ONE THIRTY SEVEN. HELLO.
OKAY CENTER HURTS BURGER TAKING
ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY SEVEN.
OKAY SO- THAT'S EIGHTY NINE
THIRTEEN OF SIXTY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE THIRTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED IRAN AN
ACT RELATING TO ELECTRICITY.
SEARCH FOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ONE OF THE MANY MANY UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF THIS- HENDE
MAKE IN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN HAS
BEEN THAT CUSTOMERSHAVE NOT
HAVE THE ABILITY TO FULLY PAY
THEIR UTILITY BILLS AND HENCE
THERE HAS BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
UNDER COLLECTION OF THOSE
BILLS. AND SO NOW WE'RE FACED
TO THE EDISON COMPANY THEY ARE
INVESTOR OWNED UTILITY IN THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA IS
FACED WITH A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE ONE THE ONE HAND YOU
RAISE RATES ARE TOO YOU COME UP
WITH A MECHANISM SEEKING
AUTHORITY THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO SMOOTH OUT THOSE
THOSE RATES THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IT DEALS WITH THE
UNDER COLLECTION- THIS A. B.
NINE THIRTEEN HE HAS A GENDER
CLASS ACTION AND CREATES THE
PROCESS IS WORKING. WITHIN THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION TO
MAKE SURE THAT ANY ALL CHARGES
WITH RESPECT TO THE UNDER
COLLECTION. ARE JUST AND
REASONABLE LAST RIVAL. THANK
YOU SIR HATS BERG IS OUR DEBATE
ON THIS MATTER. CASING ON THE
FLOOR SEEING NO HANDS UP A
SEARCH FOR WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
JUST AS RIVAL THANK YOU SO
MUCH. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I.
ACTIONS I FELT. BRADFORD I HAVE
A FIVE DOT HI TORONTO. I TELL
JOHNNY I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HURTS FOR HI PHIL I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO HI JACKSON. JACKSON.
LLEVA FIVE REQUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MY NAME. I NIELSEN. I CAN
BUY HI FORTUNE TINO. I. ROSS.
HI RUBIO. HI SKINNER. HI STERN
NUMBER WHITE HOUSE SKI. FIVE
WINNER HI BUT LET'S NOW MOVE TO
OUR CENTERS ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY THIS IS AB NINE ONE
THREE SECRETARY PLEASE CONTINUE
THE ROLE. FAKES. EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE ONE THREE ALL RIGHT BASED
ON YOUR ADDRESS OR JUST EIGHTY
NINE ONE THREE I AM BORED JUST
BY CHANG JIANG EIGHTY NINE ONE
THREE I SANG HI DELHI DELHI AB
ONE NINE THREE FIVE. NINE ONE
THREE. DALLY AB NINE ONE THREE
FIVE THANK YOU SALLY HI GROSS.
GROSS AT EIGHTY NINE ONE THREE
I'D- GROVE HI MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AB NINE ONE THREE I
MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. A. B.
NINE ONE THREE HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. EIGHTY NINE ONE THREE
HIGH MORALE HIGH WILL. WILL AB
NINE ONE THREE HI WELL HI MADE
CENTERS BROKE UP. OKAY JACKSON
HI. SEARCH BIRTH MOVES THE CALL
BY WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO BACK
TO THE REGULAR FILE STARTING
WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS S. B. THIRTEEN NO ONE
ANSWER WE SO YOU'RE PREPARED TO
BRING THIS UP- OKAY SECRETARY-
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN OH ONE BY SENATOR WAY
SO AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RESOURCES CENTER WE SELL. THANK
YOU THIRTEEN OH ONE IS BACK ON
CONCURRENCE THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE THAT- SO MUCH REGIONAL
RELIEF TO A COMMUNITY. THAT HAS
BEEN BEEN PLAGUED BY POLLUTION
AND CONTAMINATION IN THE
TIJUANA RIVER VALLEY FOR
DECADES. OF THE BILL HAS BEEN-
VERY SLIGHTLY AMENDED IN. FIRST
OF ALL THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AMENDMENTS DIRECTLY KILLED HIM
THE CAT CALIFORNIA NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY INCLUDING
THEIR SUBSIDIARY AGENCIES
SUBSIDIARY AGENCIES TO
COLLABORATE TO CREATE WATER
ACTION PLAN THEY ALSO CLARIFY
AND EXPAND THE COMPONENTS OF
THE WATER ACTION PLAN AND THE
ELIMINATE THE REQUIREMENT TO
SEEK RELEVANT INFORMATION
ADVICE BY CONDUCTING
APPROPRIATE PUBLIC OUT REGION
BY ESTABLISHING AND CONSULTING
ON AN- ADVISORY BOARD COMPOSED
OF FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES AND NON GOVERNMENTAL.
ORGANIZATIONS EITHER OF YOU
KNOW A FEW SLIGHT AMENDMENTS UP
BUT THIS BILL WILL STILL GO A
LONG WAY TO CREATE A LONG TERM
ACTION PLAN FOR THIS VERY BIG
PROBLEM I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. IN HIS EARLY
SENATE DEBATE ON CONCUR. ON
AMENDMENTS TO SP THIRTEEN OH
ONE. AND I DON'T SEE ANYONE ON
THE FLOOR DON'T SEE ANY HANDS
UP REMOTELY- SECRETARY-
ACTUALLY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE IN A WAY SO. I APPRECIATE
ALL THE SUPPORT UP UNTIL THIS
PROCESS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NO VOTE. THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN HI ARCHULETA I
AT KINS I FELL. BRADFORD HI BY
ADAM FIVE DOT. HI TORONTO I GOT
JOHNNY. BY GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HURTS BERG. HELLO HI WAY SO
FIVE HER TADO. HI JACKSON. I
LABOR. I REQUIRE. HI MITCHELL.
I MOANING I NIELSEN HI PAM ALL
RIGHT HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH
HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI STERN
NUMBER BY CAL SKI. FIVE WINNER
HI LET'S NOW MOVE TO OUR
CENTERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
THIS IS ON CONCURRENCE ASSEMBLY
MEASUREMENTS TO S. B. THIRTEEN
OH ONE SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE
THE ROLE. FAITH EIGHT HI S. B.
THIRTEEN OH ONE SIX FIVE FORGES
URGES SP THIRTEEN OH ONE HI
FORAGES BY CHANG CHANG AS THE
THIRTEEN OH ONE I. CHANG HI
DALLY. WELL YES THE THIRTEEN OH
ONE HI VALLEY HIGH GROWTH. S.
C. THIRTEEN- WHEN I'D GROVE HI
MELINDA'S. MELINDA'S SP
THIRTEEN OH ONE I. AND AS I
WARLOCK. THIS FEAT ONE THREE
ZERO ONE HI. MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. THIS FEATURE TO ONE HI
GIRL HI WELL. WE'LL LOOK AT
SPEED THIRTEEN OH ONE HI WELL
HI. THANK YOU SIR WAY SO MOVES
TO CALL THE NEXT ITEM WE'RE
GONNA BE TAKING UP THIS FILE
ITEM NUMBER THIRTY FOUR CENTER
BAITS ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. CENTER BATES BUT YOU
ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT OKAY
SECRETARY PRETTY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MASSES AN ACT
RELATING TO MEDICAL. CENTER
BATES. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
IS MY PLEASURE TO PRESENT A B.
FIVE ONE FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS CURRENT
LAW REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO CHARGE
AN INTEREST RATE OF 7% ON ANY
OVERPAYMENTS REPAYMENT PLAN.
EIGHTY FIVE ONE FIVE WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT A MEDICARE PROVIDER
IS NOT FORCED TO CLOSE THEIR
DOORS DUE TO AN OVERPAYMENT AND
HALF OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE BILL
SIMPLY ALLOWS THE PROVIDER TO
NEGOTIATE A LOWER RATE BASED ON
FACTORS SUCH AS THE IMPORTANCE
OF THE PROVIDER TO THE HEALTH
CARE SAFETY NET IN THIS
COMMUNITY. AND THE IMPACT OF
THE REPAYMENT AMOUNTS ON THE
FISCAL SOLVENCY OF THE PROVIDER
GIVEN THE CURRENT HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC CRISIS CB FIVE ONE
FIVE PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
RELIEF TO OUR PROVIDERS IN THE
FACE OF COSTLY REPAYMENT PLANS
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK
YOU SENATOR. FATES DEBATE ON
THIS MATTER. FACING NO ONE ON
THE FLOOR SEE NO HANDS UP. OKAY
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
TAKING UP OUR ON CALL ROLL CALL.
K. C. OKAY SAY NO OBJECTIONS.
CHECK WITH MY PARLIAMENTARIAN
HERE. WELL THIS OKAY SO SEE NO
DIRECTIONS- TO ARE ON CALL ROLL
CALL- THE MEASURES ON CALL
RIGHT THANK YOU LET'S MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVENTY
THREE. AND K. SIR JACKSON ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT. OKAY
US SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
AN ACT RELATING TO FIRE
PREVENTION CENTER JACKSON THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES
I'M PLEASED TO BE PRESENTING AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN YOU
KNOW MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE SUFFERED DEVASTATION DUE
TO WILDFIRES AND IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
TRY TO ADDRESS AND HARDEN OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OUR HOMES SO
THAT WE ARE. SO THAT WE ARE
ABLE TO FIGHT THESE FIRES AND
RETAIN OUR PROPERTY AND PROTECT
OUR OUR LIVES AS WELL
DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN THE EFFORT TO
SPREAD OUT TO STOP THE SPREAD
OF WILDFIRES AND PROVIDE A
SPACE FOR FIREFIGHTERS TO PUT
OUT FIRES THAT COME TO OUR
FRONT DOORS. AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR WOULD CREATE A THIRD
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ZONE CALLED AN
EMBER RESISTANCE ON CURRENT
DEFENSIBLE STATE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS HAVE A TWO ZONE
DEFENSIBLE STATE SPACE STRATEGY
ZONE ONE IS WITHIN THIRTY FEET
OF THE HOME AND SHOWN TO
EXTENDS OUTWARD FROM THAT
THIRTY FEET TWO HUNDRED FEET
FROM THE HOME THESE TRADITIONAL
SONGS ARE IMPORTANT FOR
REDUCING IGNITION FROM DIRECT
FLAME CONTACT HOWEVER EMBER
IGNITIONS ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
THE MAJORITY OF WILD FIRE FIRE.
A WILDLAND I SHOULD SAY FIRE
HOME IGNITIONS AND AMBER
RESISTANCE ZONE WHICH IS WHAT
THIS BILL CREATES WILL REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF MISSIONS
PROTECTING HOMES AND LIVES THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS FIVE FOUR
JUNE HAS BEEN VALIDATED IN LAB
TESTS NUMEROUS FIRE SCIENCE
EXPERTS SUCH AS A SCIENTIST
WITHIN THE UC DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURE AND NATURAL
RESOURCES AND OTHERS HAVE
ADVOCATED FOR THIS CRUCIAL-
SOON AS AN EFFECTIVE WAY. TO
PREVENT A STRUCTURE FIRE SHARES
THIS BILL HAS A COALITION OF
SUPPORT THAT INCLUDES FIRE
SAFETY COUNCIL'S FIRE CHIEF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS BUSINESS GROUPS UPSET
TRUCK. SO FAR THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED NO KNOWN VOTE IT IS A
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX AND ONE
THAT I HOPE THAT YOU WILL AGREE
DESERVES YOUR SUPPORT WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. PHONE. THANK
YOU SIR JACKSON DEBATE ON THIS
MATTER. YOUR DEBATE SAYING NO
ONE ON THE FLOOR AND NO HANDS
CENTER JACKSON WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. US SIMPLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN FIVE ARCHULETA I AT
KINS I FELL BRADFORD I COULD
BUY A- I DON. I THE RISER. I
TELL JOHNNY HI GLAZER GONZALEZ
FIVE HURTS BERG HI HELLO HI
WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON.
HI LAVER I REQUIRE HI MITCHELL.
HI MY NAME. HI NIELSEN I CAN
BUY HI FORTUNE TINO. HI ROB HI
RUBIO. SCANNER HI STERN. AMBERG
I LIKE HOW SKI FIVE WINNER HI
RIGHT RUBIO HI OKAY ANYONE ELSE
ON THE FLOOR OKAY LET'S NOW
MOVE ON TO OUR MEMBER CENTERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AGAIN
THIS IS AGB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE TO ROLL.
FAITH BATES AT THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR ABSTAIN. GORGEOUS AB THREE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR HI OR JUST HI
CHANG. SITTING AT THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR I. CHANG'E FIVE.
DALLI DALLI AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR I. DALLY HIGH GROWTH OVER
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR I ROVE HI
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S AT THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR I MELINDA'S HI
MORLOCK. MORE LIKE A B. THREE
ZERO SEVEN FOUR HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. SEVERAL YOU'RE STILL ON
MUTE PLEASE UNMUTE YOURSELF
FIRST. THANK YOU. THANKS THERE
WE GO COLLAGENASE GET LATE-
MORALE AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR
STATE. WELCOME WILK AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR HI WELL I. THANK
YOU LESTER JACKSON MOVES THE
CALL ALL RIGHT AND APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE I KNOW IT
ISGETTING LATE- JUST A HEADS
UP THE NEXT ITEM ON THE TAKE UP
THIS FILE LINE AND NUMBER
SEVENTY SEVEN FOLLOWED BY
EIGHTY THREE FOLLOWED BY NINETY
ONE SO MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN CENTER
FORTINO A PREPARED. RIGHTS
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AN ACT
RELATING TO FIREARMS CENTER
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING A B. TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO- AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE WOULD
BRING PEACE OFFICERS TO PARITY
BY AUTHORIZING SPECIFIC LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND STATE AGENCIES
TO PURCHASE AND CARRY FIREARMS.
THAT ARE NO LONGER ON THE DOJ
ROSTER OF HAND GUNS THE DOJ IS
REQUIRED TO KEEP THIS ROSTER OF
HANDGUNS THAT PASS SPECIFIC
SAFETY TESTS AND WHOSE
MANUFACTURERS PAYING AN ANNUAL
LISTING FEE WHICH IS IMPORTANT.
THIS BILL DOES NOT AUTHORIZE
MORE PEACE OFFICERS TO CARRY
FIREARMS AND IS NOT PUT MORE
FIREARMS IN CIRCULATION- IT
ALSO CARRIES A NUMBER OF
SAFEGUARDS AND ENSURE ADEQUATE
TRAINING OF LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
PREVENTS THESE FIREARMS FOR
GETTING IN THE HANDS OF NON
EXEMPT. PERSONS WHICH IS ALSO
IMPORTANT PROHIBITS THE SALE TO
THE NON EXEMPT PERSONS AS WELL
THIS BILL IS VERY TECHNICAL IN
NATURE YOU MIGHT SAY IT IS AND
WHEN A SPECIAL AND IT PUTS
CALIFORNIA IN LINE WITH ITS
FIREARM SAFETY GOALS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
THANK YOU CENTER PARTY NO
DEBATE ON THIS MATTER. OKAY ALL
RIGHT SAY NONE ON THE FLOOR I
DON'T SEE ANY SCANS APPS ON THE
REMOTE. SERVER PARTY NOW WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN IPHONE.
HEY THAT- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
AT KENS FIVE BELL. BRADFORD. I
HAVE I OTHER I DON. I THE
RUSSELL. I GOT JOHNNY HI GLAZER
GONZALEZ. GONZALEZ VERY.
HERTZBERG I TELL. I WAS SO. HI
HER TADO. I JACKSON. I LLEVA.
HI WIRE. HI MITCHELL. ONE OF
FIVE MORNING. HI NIELSEN. FIVE
TEN FIVE FIVE FORTUNE TINO. HI
RALPH. RUBIO HI SKINNER. HI
STERN. NUMBER I LIKE HOW SKI.
HI WINNER. HI LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO OUR CENTERS TO SEE REMOTELY
AND THIS IS A B. TWO SIX NINE
NINE SIX THREE PLEASE CONTINUE
TO ROLL. BASED. EIGHT EIGHTY
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE HI BABES
HI. IN OR JUST A B. TWENTY SIX
NINE NINE I. HOLD ON THE BUS
YES YEAH. OKAY I THINK HER NAME
OKAY I APOLOGIZE CENTER BATES-
THE CLERK ASKED IF YOU COULD
PLEASE RE CAST YOUR VOTE AGAIN.
OKAY DO I NEED A NEW. THAT
YOU'RE GONNA BE TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE BASE I. EIGHT HI
GORGEOUS. REGIS AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE I. OR JUST BY CHANG
J. A. B. TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE
HI. TANG HAI DELHI. DELHI AV
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE HI DALLY
HI GROSS. OKAY PERFECT WE'RE
WAITING FOR SIX GROWTH THE
THIRD ROW OF THE RELIGIOUS FOR
CONNECTION. MY APOLOGIES AT
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE I. GROVE.
ROAD HI. MELINDA'S MELINDA'S AB
TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE HI
MELINDA'S HI MORLOCK. D. B. TWO
SIX NINE NINE HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. A. B. TWO SIX NINE NINE
OBSCENE. WELK YOU'RE WELCOME
ABC. TWENTY SIX NINETY NINE
NINE. WELCOME HI THE REPORT TO
OKAY HOLD ON SERA. RON HI.
THERE WE GO ZERO ENERGY OF THE
VOTES CAST. WHERE IT NO WINNER
I DON'T KNOW. ROGAN OKAY SIR
FORTINO DIED AT THE TOP OF THE
PHONE CALL OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER. EIGHTY
THREE CENTER ALLEN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO BRING THIS UP. US
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BLOOM AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS. MORE
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS
I'M PRESENTING THIS ON BEHALF
OF MY- FRIEND RICHARD BLUM THIS
IS A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW AN
ACADEMIC MEDICAL CENTER
SPECIFICALLY CEDARS SINAI
CEMENT CANDIDATES FOR SPECIAL
FACULTY PERMITS DIRECTLY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL BOARD.
SPECIAL FACULTY PERMITS ALLOW
WORLD RENOWNED MEDICAL FACULTY
FROM OTHER STATES AND COUNTRIES
AND WHO DO NOT HAVE A LICENSE
TO PRACTICE IN CALIFORNIA O
COME TO THE STATE PRACTICE
MEDICINE IN AN ACADEMIC SETTING.
UNDER CURREN LAW CEDAR SINAI
MUST GO THROUGH UCLA TO
COMPLETE THE APPLICATION
PROCESS. IN A TEAM THE PROPER
PERMITS THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL. IS TO EXPEDITE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS THAT
UCLA IS RESPONSIBLE FOR IT
ALLOWS YOU TO SIGN. TO DO WHAT
IT'S ALREADY DOING WITH UCLA
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THE
OTHER PHARMACY TO TEAM. A
SPECIAL FACULTY PERMIT OR
ESTABLISH ANY NEW ENTITIES AND
MUST BE REGULATED. THE
SPECIALIZED I'VE GOT BACK TO
THE PHYSICIANS. WHO HOLD THESE
SPECIAL FACULTY PERMITS TEACH
PERFORM RESEARCH. HAS AN IMPACT
CITIZENS. RESPECT S. RIVAL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALAN SENATOR
PAN. THANK YOU- MADAM
PRESIDENT- I WANT TO THANK- SET
A CELL NUMBER BLOOM AND
SPONSORED BILLS HERE SIDE IF
POSSIBLE FOR WORKING WITH ME
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE WILL BE.
MAKING FURTHER EFFORTS AT-
ADDRESSING THIS ISSUE NEXT YEAR
AND I APPRECIATE THEIR
COMMITMENT TO DOING SO BUT
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE BILL AS
IT IS FOR THIS YEAR SESSION AND
APPRECIATE- THE PARTNERSHIP AND
MAKING THIS HAPPEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN SEEING NO
FURTHER MICROPHONES UP SEEING
NO HANDS RAISE MEMBERS THIS IS
A CANDIDATE FOR ON CALL ROLL
CALL IS THERE ANY OBJECTION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE THERE
IS AN OBJECTION. THANK YOU
SENATOR MINING MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL.
BRADFORD I HAVE A- HI DODD. HI
THERE I WASN'T. I GOT JOHNNY
FIVE LASER GONZALEZ. HI
HERTZBERG HI HELLO. FIVE
WESTERN FIVE HER TADO. HI
JACKSON. HI LLEVA I REQUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. BY
NIELSEN. FIVE PM. HI FOUR
TWENTY NINE. HI ROSS. FIVE
RUBIO. HI SKINNER. FIVE STERN.
AMBERG HI BY CAL SKI. FIVE
WINNER. HI WE WILL NOW GO TO
OUR MEMBERS FOR VOTING REMOTELY
THIS IS A B. TWO TWO SEVEN
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
EIGHT SENATOR BOETTCHER MUTE.
GET ABSTAIN LOST MY PLACE HERE
SENATE RATES CAN YOU STATE YOUR
NAME THE NUMBER AND THAT YOU'RE
ABSTAINING. I LOST MY PLACE YOU
DISLIKE ABOUT THEM DR MY PAPERS
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE WE'RE ON
THAT'S OKAY WE'RE ON FILE ITEM
EIGHTY THREE WHICH IS A B. TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE. OKAY I WAS IN
THE RIGHT PLACE YES HE B. TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE BATES HI. MA'AM
BATES HI PORGES. FORD IS A B.
TWO TWO SEVEN THREE ARE.
GORGEOUS HIGH CHANG. NINE
EIGHTY TWENTY TO SEVENTY THREE
I SHINE HI SALLY. KELLY. EIGHTY
TWO SEVEN SEVEN THREE. YEAH.
TWO TWO SEVEN THREE. ALI AB TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE I THANK OUR
VALLEY I. GROWTH A. B. TWO TWO
SEVEN THREE I'D GROVE HI
MELINDA'S. BLAINE IS A B. TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE I'D MELINDA'S
HI WARLOCK. WARLOCKS EIGHTY TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. MORALE AN EIGHTY TWO
TWO SEVEN THREE HI MORE L. I.
WELL OR WILL HE BE TWENTY TO
SEVENTY THREE HI WELCOME HI.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
NINETY ONE SENATOR RUBIO. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN EIGHTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO GAMBLING SEN RUBIO.
THANK YOU- MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE I RISE TO
PRESENT AT TEN EIGHTY TWO ON
BEHALF OF A SEVENTY MEMBER LOW
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY TWO REVISES
THE DEFINITION OF APPLICANT TO
NO LONGER INCLUDE ANY PERSON
WHO'S ABOUT TO APPLY FOR A
STATE GAMBLING LICENSE OR OTHER
LICENSEES. PERMITS OR APPROVALS
CURRENTLY THE GAMING CONTROL
ACT AN APPLICANT AS DEFINED AS
ANY PERSON WHO HAS APPLIED FOR
OR IS ABOUT TO APPLY FOR A
STATE GAMBLING LICENSE OR OTHER
LICENSE FEES OR PERMITS OR
APPROVALS AP TEN EIGHTY TWO
WOULD SIMPLY CLARIFY AND CODIFY
IN LAW THAT AN APPLICANT FOR
THE PURPOSES OF THE ACT. WILL
ONLY INCLUDE INDIVIDUALS WHO
HAVE APPLIED FOR A GAMBLING
LICENSE OR OTHER LICENSES
PERMITS OR APPROVALS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUNG PEOPLE THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP ON THE FLOOR
SEEING NO HANDS RAISED MADAM
MEMBERS THIS IS A- CANDIDATE
FOR A ON CALL ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. TO USING
THE ON CALL ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE. SUCH WILL BE THE ORDER
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE OH
FIVE SENATOR PAM. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY THREE SIXTY NINE BY
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM
AND INTERNET MEDIA. AND AN ACT
RELATING TO EMPLOYMENT AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE
THERE ARE TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY SENATOR PAM. NOT
MANY RIGHT HI THERE WE GO THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I
AM SO PLEASED TO PRESENT AT
THREE THREE SIX NINE ON BEHALF
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
AND- SPORTS FOR AND INTERNET
MEDIA. AB THREE THREE SIX NINE
AS NEEDED TO PREVENT
UNNECESSARY BURDENS PLACED ON
CHILD PERFORMERS THEIR
EMPLOYERS AND BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVES BY AN ACCIDENT
OF EXISTING LAW. EIGHTY THREE
THREE SIX NINE WAS DRAFTED WITH
INPUT FROM BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
INDUSTRIAL NATIONS IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING THE DRESS THE
INCONSISTENT THE MAN'S EARLIER
LEGISLATION ON THIS UNIQUE
SUBSET OF THE WORK FORCE. HAS
ENJOYED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT HAS ONLY BEEN ON
CONSENT THROUGHOUT THE PROCESS
AND WAS ONLY PULLED UP NEXT
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR ON
THE SENATE FLOOR NOR TO ADDRESS
THE TECHNICAL DRAFTING ERROR
WHICH HAS NOW BEEN CORRECTED.
THE CALIFORNIA ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY ESPECIALLY ITS TOP
PERFORMERS URGE SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE IT HAS BEEN ENDORSED BY
THE PART OF INDUSTRIAL NATIONS
DEPARTMENT FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING THERE'S NO FORMAL
OPPOSITION ARE STRICTLY ASPIRIN
I THOUGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP SEEING NO HANDS
RAISED. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE CLOAKS
USUALLY THIS IS A CANADA. FOR
ON CALL ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO THE ON CALL ROLL
CALL. SEEING NONE SUCH WILL BE
THE ORDER MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM ONE OF SIX SENATOR PAM. NO.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ
FILE ITEM ONE OH SIX ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOW AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALING ARTS AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE UP
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT CENTERS EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY SIX PLAYS A MEMBER LOW
ENSURE THAT NONPROFITS ARE
AUTHORIZED T PROVIDE
OPTOMETRIC SERVICES TO
COMMUNITIES WHERE ACCESS TO
VISION CARE AT NO COST TO THE
PATIENTS THIS BILL WILL
SPECIFICALLY INSURE THAT VISION
TO LEARN A NONPROFIT AS
PROVIDED HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF IBM'S AND GLASSES TO LOW
INCOME STUDENTS BASICALLY
CONTINUE TO OPERATE. WE ALL
KNOW THAT EARLY INTERVENTION IS
KEY TO TREATING VISION HEALTH
CONDITIONS THIS BILL IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING EVERY
CHILD IS ABLE TO SEE A LICENSED
OPTOMETRIST EARLY IN HER LIFE
THE BOARD OF OPTOMETRY
OFFICIALLY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
ESPECIALLY ASKED FOR AN ITEM
THANK YOU THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
HERTZBERG YEAH I JUST BRIEFLY
ONE ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
DOCTOR PAN REGIONAL EARNS GREAT
ORGANIZATION THAT IS PROVIDE
CLASSES FOR SO MANY CHILDREN
AND CHANGE THEIR LIVES. AND SO
MANY FUNDAMENTAL WAYS AS FROM
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG THING NO FURTHER
MICROPHONES UP SEEING NO HANDS
UP. MEMBERS THIS IS A CANDIDATE
FOR ON CALL ROLL CALL IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION TO THE ON CALL
ROLL CALL. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SUCH WILL BE THE ORDER
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
ONE OH SEVEN SENATOR DRAWS SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ALL YOU. ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT
TWENTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
SANTIAGO AN ACT RELATING TO
PUBLIC SOCIAL SERVICES AND
DECLARING THE URGENCY THERE OF
TO TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
BRAZO THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND- COLLEAGUES MAYBE
EIGHT TO SIX WILL PROVIDE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS OF EMERGENCY
FOOD ASSISTANCE FOR ALL LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WITH WALT
REGARD TO STATUS OVER FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ARE
UNEMPLOYED AND STRUGGLING TO
PAY FOR RENT GROCERIES AND
OTHER BASIC NECESSITIES DO THE
PANDEMIC VALLEY REGIONAL FOOD
BANK ALONE HAS SEEN A 50%
INCREASE IN PEOPLE SEEKING
ASSISTANCE SINCE THE START OF
COLBERT NINETEEN THIS BILL WILL
ASSISTANCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AND I VOTE ON THIS
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO IS STIRRED DEBATE
ON THIS MEASURE. A SCENE ON THE
FLOOR SAY NO HANDS UP. THIS
BILL IS ELIGIBLE FOR THE ON
CALL ROTA NO IT ISN'T OKAY
SORRY. ALL RIGHT- SEE NO DEBATE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE AND
DRAWS OUT. I ASK FOR I WILL.
OKAY I SEE A ROW CENTER GROVE.
N. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT DID
YOU SAY IT WAS ELIGIBLE FOR AN
ON CALL ROLL CALL BECAUSE I
CHECKED IT IS NOT VOLUNTARY AS
IT DOES IN MY ERROR WAS NOT THE
CASE THANK YOU SIR. OKAY IS
THERE ANY OTHER DEBATE. THIS
MATTER. SEEING NONE THEN LETS
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN I ARCHULETA HI
ADKINS FIVE BELL. BRADFORD I
HAVE A- I DON. HI TORONTO. I
GOT JOHNNY HI GLAZER GONZALEZ
HI HERTZBERG HI HELLO HI WITH
SO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON. I
LLEVA HI WIRE. HI MITCHELL.
FIVE MORNING. I NIELSEN. NO PAN
HI HI FORTUNE TINO. HI RALPH.
HI RUBIO. SKINNER STERN. AMBERG
FIVE WACO SKI HI WINNER. FIVE
OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
CENTERS WHO WERE PROTESTING
REMOTELY- THIS IS. EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX A SURGERY PLEASE
CONTINUE THE ROLE. FAITH. EIGHT
EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY SIX L.
BATES NOW FOR JUST. EIGHTY
EIGHT TO SIX NOW CORDIER.
THANKS FOR JUST EIGHTY EIGHT TO
SIX NOW. FOR AGES NOW CHANG
TANG AB EIGHTY SIX NOW CHANG NO
DALLY. KELLY AV EIGHT TO SIX NO.
DALLY NOW GROWTH. GRILL EIGHTY
AND EIGHTY SIX NO ROVE NO
MELINDA'S BELINDA'S EIGHTY
EIGHTY SIX NO. ONE DOES NO MORE
LOCK. EIGHTY EIGHT TO SIX NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. EIGHTY
EIGHT TO SIX NOW. I SAID ROUTE.
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT TO SIX NO
DETAILS MON MORALE NO. WELK.
WELL EIGHTY EIGHT TO SIX
ABSTAIN. OKAY CENTER ALSO MOVES
THE CALL. NEXT ITEM ON THE FILE
IS ELEVEN THIS IS A FILE NUMBER
ONE ONE TWO- SERRA CAPPIELLO.
HELLO ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. OKAY A SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING AND
OCCURRING THERE JIM'S VERA TO
TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
CEREBRAL. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT AB
THREE EIGHTY ONE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON WHICH
WILL ALLOW QUALIFIED HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT. PROJECTS TO
EFFECTIVELY USE THIS
STREAMLINED APPROACH PROCESS
ESTABLISHED BY SB THIRTY FIVE
IN. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN PANDEMIC. HOW
DOES EXACERBATE I CAN HARDLY
READ ANYMORE I'M SORRY HAS
EXACERBATED CALIFORNIA'S
ONGOING HOUSING CRISIS AS
SOARING UNEMPLOYMENT NUMBERS
LEAVE MANY AND ABLE TO AFFORD
HOUSING AND ON THE BRINK OF
EVICTION SB THIRTY FIVE WAS A
LANDMARK EFFORT TO INCREASE
HOUSING SUPPLY HOWEVER AND
AMBIGUOUS. OR AMBIGUITIES IN SB
THIRTY FIVE LANGUAGE HAVE BEEN.
EXPLOITED TO DERAIL DESPERATELY
NEEDED HOUSING PROJECTS ACROSS
THE STATE. EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY
ONE MAKE THREE CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO ADDRESS THESE
EMERGING ISSUES. IT ALLOWS THE
MODEST MODIFICATION TO AN SP
THIRTY FIVE PROJECT. AND
REFINES THE PERMITTING PROCESS
FOR CONNECTING A PROJECT TO
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE. ALSO IT
PROVIDES A TECHNICAL
CLARIFICATION TO THE TWO THIRDS
RESIDENTIAL REQUIREMENT IN SB
THIRTY FIVE WITH THESE CHANGES
A. B. EIGHT EIGHT THIRTY ONE
WILL ENSURE THAT QUALIFYING
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
CAN BE EFFECTIVELY STREAMLINED
AS INTENDED UNDER SB THIRTY
FIVE. THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BUT. THANK YOU SENATOR IS THERE
ANY DEBATE. SEEING NONE ON THE
FLOOR SEE NO HANDS UP. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. WE ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS ALL RIGHT A
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN HI ARCHULETA HI AT KINS I
FELL. BRADFORD CABRERA I DON.
HI THE RUSSELL.I GOT JOHNNY.
HI GLAZER GONZALEZ I HURTS FOR
HI HELLO HI WITH SO. HI HER
TADO. I JACKSON. LLEVA I
REQUIRE. I MITCHELL. FIVE
MORNING. HI NIELSEN. HI PAM.
ALL RIGHT HI FORTINO. ROSS ALL
RIGHT HI RUBIO. SKINNER HI
STERN. AMBERG HI BY CAL SKI.
FIVE WINNER HI AND NOW LET'S
MOVE ON TO OUR CENTERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THIS IS.
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE A
SEPARATE PLEASE CAN TO. FAITH
BATES EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
OBSCENE. GORGEOUS AB EIGHT
THREE ONE HI FOR JUST FIVE.
CHANG TANG AB EIGHT THREE ONE
HI. HANG ON DALLI DALLI EIGHTY
EIGHT THREE ONE STATE. GROSS AT
CROKE EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
ABSTAIN. MELINDA'S. MELINDA IS
EIGHTY EIGHT READ AT THE
STADIUM. MORLOCK. EIGHTY EIGHT
THREE ONE I MORLOCK HIGH MORALE
YES EIGHTY EIGHT THREE ONE
ABSTAIN. WELL. WELL AB EIGHT
THIRTY ONE AT ST. OKAY CENTER
COVER OF A WHOLE THIS CALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE GOING TO ASK
THAT ANY OF THE SENATORS WHO
ARE NOT FROM THE FLOOR TO
PLEASE RETURN TO THE FLOOR
RIGHT NOW WE'LL TAKE I GOT A
CALL A RECESS IN PLACE BECAUSE
NO ONE GO ANYWHERE AS WE WAIT
FOR REMAINING CENTERS TO GET
HERE ON THE FLOOR SO WE CAN
THEN MOVE ON TO OUR- CONSENT
CALENDAR LISTING THE CALLS. SO
I ASK THAT SO WE'LL TAKE A
BRIEF PAUSE HERE BUT ASK ANY
SENATORS WHO ARE NOT ON THE
FLOOR TO PLEASE COME TO THE
FLOOR. AS SOON AS POSSIBLE. ARE
NOW.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS TO
REGAIN TOO SO WE CAN GET
STARTED AGAIN I APPRECIATE
EVERYONE'S PATIENCE RUN PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS. I SEE A FEW
PEOPLE STILL UP AND ABOUT TAKE
YOUR SEATS. I SEE SOME HAND
WAVING OKAY DOES IT DOWN ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OUR SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE.
ITEMS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SEVENTY SEVEN SENATE BILL
THIRTY EIGHT FIVE TWENTY TWO
FIVE SEVENTY THREE.
927-028-0090 NINE OH NINE.
411-003-1117 1-123-114-0112
THIRTY TO TWELVE THIRTY FIVE.
761-380-1380 SIX AND SENATE
BILL. FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO
RIGHT ARE THERE ANY EXTRACTIONS.
SEEING NONE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS I FELL I
BRADFORD I COULD BUY A- FIVE
DOT. HI THE RUSSELL. I GOT
JOHNNY FIVE BLAZER HI
CONSOLIDATES HI HURTS BERG HI
HELLO HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO
HI JACKSON. HI LLEVA. HI WIRE
HI MITCHELL. HI MY NAME. I
NIELSEN. I CAN HI HI FORTUNE
TINO. HI RALPH FIVE RUBIO. HI
SKINNER FIVE STERN HI AMBER HI
WHITE HOUSE SKI. HI WINNER. HI
OKAY WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR
CENTERS PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
JUST WANT HER TO EVERYONE IN
THE CHAMBER PLEASE BE IN YOUR
SEATS THAT'S NOW MOVE TO OUR
MEMBERS PARTICIPATE REMOTELY ON
THE SPECIAL CONSEN CALENDAR-
SECTOR PLEASE CONTINUE THE ROLE.
FAKES H. S. V. FOURTEEN FIFTY
NINE ALL RIGHT. OKAY SURVEYS
WERE TAKING UP THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. ALL OKAY
SPECIAL CAN BE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
BASED ON. GORGEOUS WE'RE JUST
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR GET
INTO C. S. STICK HI. FOR HIGH
CHANG. THANKS SPECIAL CONSENT
HI. CHANG HI DOLLY L. A.
SPECIAL CONSENT HI DALLY I
GROWTH GROSS SPECIAL CONSENT
EYEING GROWTH ONLINE MELINDA'S
LINDA MELINDA'S SPECIAL CONSENT
HI MELINDA'S BY MORE LOCK OR
UNLOCK SPECIAL CONSENT HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. OR ELSE
TEAMS HI MORALE HIGH WELK.
WILKES CONSENT ON WILL HI GUYS
THIRTY NINE DAYS ZERO THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR IS
ADOPTED WE WILL NOW MOVE TOWARD
LIFTING THE CALLS ON ITEMS- I
WAS JUST A REMINDER FOR THOSE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY- WE AS
WE DID PREVIOUSLY IF YOU WISH
TO CHANGE YOUR VOTE OR IF HE
HAD VOTED BEFORE YOU NEED TO
VOTE PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND SO
I CAN CALL ON YOU OTHERWISE
GONNA SOON THAT- YOU'RE NOT
PLAYING TO MAKE ANY CHANGES. TO
THE RECORD- SO WITH THAT WE'RE
GONNA FIRST BEGAN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN- SECRETARY.
THANK. OKAY CORRECT PFIZER FILE
ITEM NUMBER. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TWO TWO FOUR SEVEN A SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ATKINS HI.
GLAZER I. NIELSEN. HI YEAH.
NIELSEN. NIELSEN I. RUBIO HI
STERN. HI. ACCORDING TO. THE
BILLS OUT OKAY HIGHS THIRTY
DAYS TO THE BILL IS PASSED NEXT
ITEM IS I FILE ITEM NUMBER.
FORTY SEVEN EIGHTY TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY SIX SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ATKINS HI GLAZER
I NIELSEN. HI STERN. HI OKAY
SEEING NO HANDS UP THE VOTE IS
FIVE THIRTY NINE NO DAYS THAT
BILL IS PASSED NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM THE FILE ITEM NUMBER.
578-023-4056 THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. HI ATKINS. FIVE
GLAZER NO. NIELSEN NO FORTUNE
TINO. STERN. SEEING NO HANDS
UP- THE VOTE IS ICE TWENTY SIX
DAYS FIVE THIS MEASURE IS
ADOPTED PAST- THE NEXT FILE
ITEM NUMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETY THREE EIGHTY EIGHTEEN
FORTY FIVE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ATKINS I FELL. I
GLAZER I NIELSEN. I STERN HI
THEY SAY NO HANDS UP THE VOTE
IS A NICE THIRTY SIX DAYS TO
THE MEASURE HAS PASSED NEXT
ITEM IS FIVE NUMBER OF. NINETY
FOUR EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ATKINS I FELL HI LASER. HI
STERN. FIVE OKAY AGAIN SAY NO
HANDS UP THE VOTE IS THIRTY
NINE HIGHS THIRTY NINE DAYS IS
ZERO THAT MEASURE IS PASSED
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINETY FIVE EIGHTY THIRTY ONE
EIGHTY TWO SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN. ALAN. BELL.
FIVE BY ADAM. GLAZER NO HER
TADO. FOURTEENER. RUBIO STERN.
EASTERN NOW. SAY NO HANDS UP
THE VOTE IS ICE TWENTY NINE
DAYS NINE. ON SIDE OF THE ROAD
IS ICE TWENTY THREE DAYS THE
MEASURE IS PASSED NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER. NINETY TWO
EIGHTY TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BALANCE HI BRADFORD. HI GLAZER
I. STERN HI AMBERG I. OKAY
SEEING NO HANDS UP. HIGHS
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ZERO THE
MEASURE HAS PASSED NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE
THIRTEEN SP EIGHTY SIX SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WELL I
LASER HI REQUIRE. I STERN. I AM
BERG HI. SEEING NO HANDS UP THE
VOTE IS HIGH TWENTY NINE DAYS
EIGHT ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRENT AND- NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN
SP ONE FIFTY EIGHT SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. WELL HI
GLAZER I. STERN HI NUMBER FIVE.
SEEING NO HANDS UP THE VOTE IS
FIVE THIRTY FIVE THOSE THREE ON
THE URGENCY HIGHS THIRTY FIVE
THOSE THREE ON CONCURRENCE WITH
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS NEXT ITEM
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER. ONE THIRTY
SEVEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTEEN SIX
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WELL HI BLAZER. FIVE STERN. HI
NUMBER FIVE. SAY NO HANDS UP
THE EYES THIRTY NINE DAYS IS
THIS ITEM THIS MEASURE IS THAT
FAST NEXT ITEM IS S. B. AS THE
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SP
THIRTEEN OH ONE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WELL I GLAZER HI
HERTZBERG. HI STERN HI AMBERG
HI A NO HANDS UP. THE VOTE IS
ICE THIRTY NINE THOSE DAYS IS
ZERO- SOMETHING THEN IT'S R.
CONCURRED AND NEXT ITEM IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER. THIRTY FOUR EIGHTY
FIVE ONE FIVE SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WELL HI BLAZER
HI STERN FIVE SAY NO HANDS UP
THE VOTE IS HIGHS THIRTY NINE
DAYS ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.
SEVENTY THREE EIGHTY THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. WELL. FIVE BLAZER
FIVE STERN HI. SAY NO HANDS UP
THE VOTE IS HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN
KNOWS ZERO THIS MEASURE IS
PASSED NEXT THE FOLLOWING ITEM
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER. SEVENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT TWENTY SIX
NINETY NINE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WELL. HI LASER
NO GONZALEZ. STERN HI SAY NO
HANDS UP THE VOTERS HIGHS
THIRTY FIVE DAYS TO THIS
MEASURE IS PASSED NEXT UP IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY THREE
THE EIGHTY TWENTY THREE THAT'S
RIGHT ABC. TWENTY TO SEVENTY
THREE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FELL HI LASER HI STERN HI.
THE NO HANDS UP THE PRICE
THIRTY NINE AT NO ZERO THE
MEASURE IS PASSED NEXUS FILE
ITEM NUMBER. NINETY ONE EIGHTY
TEN EIGHTY TWO SECTOR PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FELL. HI GLAZER.
HI STERN HI. ENCINO HANDS UP
THE VOTE IS HIGHS THIRTY NINE
NAYS ZERO THE MEASURE HAS
PASSED NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER. 1-058-033-6960 PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FELL HI LASER HI
RUBIO. HI STERN FIVE THEY SEE
NO HANDS UP THE VOTE IS HIGHS
THIRTY NINE DAYS IS ZERO ON
URGENCY ICE THIRTY NINE DAYS
ZERO ON THE BILL THE BILLS
PASSED- NEXT IS WELL ITEM
NUMBER. ONE OH SIX EIGHTY EIGHT
NINETY SIX SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WELL HI LASER I
RUBIO. FIVE STERN HI. SAY NO
HANDS UP IT'S FIVE THIRTY NINE
DOES THE ZERO ON THE URGENCY HI
STURDY NINER ZERO ON THE
MEASURE MEASURE IS A TOP PAST
NEXT ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER.%
ONE OH SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY SIX. SECTOR PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. BELL YOUR HI GLAZER.
I RUBIO. HI SKINNER. I STERN BY
THEY SEE NO HANDS UP THE VOTE
IS. HIGHS TWENTY NINE DAYS NINE
UNDER URGENCY HIGHS TWENTY NINE
DAYS NINE ON THE MEASURE TO
MEASURE PASSES NEXT ITEM IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER. ONE TWELVE
EIGHTY EIGHT THIRTY ONE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
WELL FIVE BRADFORD. FIVE GLAZER.
JACKSON. FORTINO RUBIO I STERN.
SAY NO HANDS UP THE LOTUS HIGHS
TWENTY NINE DAYS ZERO AND
URGENCY HIGHS TWENTY NINE DAYS
IS ZERO ON THE MEASURE TO
MEASURE PASSES FINALLY WE'RE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTY THREE. EIGHTY THIRTY
SEVENTY SIX EIGHT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GOD. KALYANI. GLAZER.
HERTZBERG. HELLO WESER. FURTADO.
NIELSEN RALPH. RALPH NO. AMBERG.
I SEE NO HANDS UP US- LEADER-
WITH WITH WHAT'S YOUR DESIRE.
RE ALL RIGHT THE VOTE IS EIGHT
HIGHS EIGHTEEN KNOWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE FAILS- THE MOTION FOR
RECONSIDERATION MR TEND TO DO
EFFECTIVE. THAT DATE. YEAH
MOTION TO REACH IS GRANTED ICE.
I THIRTY NINE DAYS SINCE. OKAY
RIGHT YEAH. OKAY THE DESK IS
CLEAR. THERE'S NO OTHER
BUSINESS CENTER RECKONS THAT'S
CLEAR. MR PRESIDENT THANK YOU
SO MUCH- AND THANK ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TONIGHT IN THE
PRESIDING OFFICERS THE STAFF
THE DESK EVERYONE WE MANAGED TO
GET THROUGH THIRTY ONE- SENATE
BILLS TODAY SIXTY SIX ASSEMBLY
BILLS WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY A
HUNDRED BILLS TOMORROW
ANTICIPATED CONSENT CALENDAR OF
A SO- WE'VE GOT WORK TOMORROW-
I HOPE YOU GO HOME AND GET A
GOOD NIGHT'S SLEEP WE WILL. BE
HERE TOMORROW MONDAY AUGUST
THIRTY FIRST AT TEN AM TEN AM
SHARP AND READY TO GO. THANK
YOU EVERYONE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU WE ARE NOW
BUT.